hello everyone welcome to this
interesting video on aws full course of
2022.
in this video we will explore various
important aspects revolving around aws
and its related concepts in depth
but before diving deep into its concepts
we will first cover the basics and have
an introduction to what is aws followed
by exploring cloud computing services
then we will explore some of the very
important services provided by aws and
various categories like compute storage
database and networking
following that we will explore and
understand the complete mechanism and
architecture of some of its
very important features related to
containers storage and security
that are aws ec2
aws s3 aws im
aws cloud formation
aws route 53 aws ecs
aws bean stock
aws vpc
aws sage maker
aws cloud front
aws auto scaling
and aws redshift after which we will
have a look at the comparison between
aws and other cloud platforms like azure
and gcp
to understand the individual identities
and how they differ from each other
based on various parameters
and we'll also see how kubernetes are
implemented on aws
and after that we will focus on how we
can adopt aws in our career and pave our
path towards becoming aws cloud
practitioner or ews solution architect
after that we will discuss the top 10
reasons why ews is a better option to go
with we will then conclude this video by
discussing the essential interview
questions and answer to help every
individual clear an interview with full
confidence by the end of this video i
can assure you that all your aws career
related queries would have been answered
for this training with me i have a
experienced aws specialist sam and rahul
together we'll walk you through the
different crucial aws keynotes
so let's start with an exciting video on
aws full course of 2022
but before we begin make sure to
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell icon and never miss an update
from simply learn
meet rob he runs an online shopping
portal
the portal started with a modest number
of users but has recently been seeing a
surge in the number of visitors on black
friday and other holidays the portal saw
so many visitors that the servers were
unable to handle the traffic and crashed
is there a way to improve performance
without having to invest in a new server
wondered rob
a way to upscale or downscale capacity
depending on the number of users
visiting the website at any given point
well there is amazon web services one of
the leaders in the cloud computing
market
before we see how aws can solve rob's
problem let's have a look at how aws
reach the position it is at now aws was
first introduced in 2002 as a means to
provide tools and services to developers
to incorporate features of amazon.com to
their website
in 2006 its first cloud services
offering was introduced in 2016 aws
surpassed its 10 billion revenue target
and now aws offers more than 100 cloud
services that span a wide range of
domains thanks to this the aws cloud
service platform is now used by more
than 45 of the global market
now let's talk about what is aws
aws or amazon web service is a secure
cloud computing platform that provides
computing power database networking
content storage and much more
the platform also works with a pay as
you go pricing model which means you
only pay for how much of the services
offered by aws you use
some of the other advantages of aws are
security aws provides a secure and
durable platform that offers end-to-end
privacy and security
experience you can benefit from the
infrastructure management practices born
from amazon's years of experience
flexible it allows users to select the
os language database and other services
easy to use users can host applications
quickly and securely
scalable
depending on user requirements
applications can be scaled up or down
aws provides a wide range of services
across various domains
what if rob wanted to create an
application for his online portal aws
provides compute services that can
support the app development process from
start to finish
from developing deploying running to
scaling the application up or down based
on the requirements
the popular services include ec2 aws
lambda amazon light cell and elastic
beanstalk
for storing website data rob could use
aws storage services that would enable
him to store access govern and analyze
data to ensure that costs are reduced
agility is improved and innovation
accelerated
popular services within this domain
include amazon s3 ebs s3 glacier and
elastic file storage
rob can also store the user data in a
database with aw services which he can
then optimize and manage
popular services in this domain include
amazon rds dynamodb and redshift
if rob's businesses took off and he
wanted to separate his cloud
infrastructure or scale up his work
requests and much more he would be able
to do so with the networking services
provided by aws
some of the popular networking services
include amazon vpc amazon route 53 and
elastic load balancing
other domains that aws provides services
in are analytics blockchain containers
machine learning internet of things and
so on
and there you go
that's aws for you in a nutshell now
before we're done let's have a look at a
quiz
which of these services are incorrectly
matched one
two
three
four
we'll be pinning the question in the
comment section comment below with your
answer and stand a chance to win an
amazon voucher
several companies around the world have
found great success with aws companies
like netflix twitch linkedin facebook
and bbc have taken advantage of the
services offered by aws to improve their
business efficiency
and thanks to their widespread usage aws
professionals are in high demand they're
highly paid and earn up to more than one
hundred and twenty seven thousand
dollars per annum once you're aws
certified you could be one of them too
hello everyone let me introduce myself
as sam a multi-platform cloud architect
and trainer and i'm so glad and i'm
equally excited to talk and walk you
through the session about what aws is
and talk to you about some services and
offerings and about how companies get
benefited by migrating their
applications and infra into aws so
what's aws let's talk about that now
before that let's talk about how life
was without any cloud provider and in
this case how life was without aws so
let's walk back and picture how things
were back in 2000 which is not so long
ago but a lot of changes a lot of
changes for better had happened since
that time now back in 2000 a request for
a new server is not an happy thing
at all because a lot of
money a lot of validations a lot of
planning are involved in getting a
server online or up and running and even
after we finally got the server it's not
all said and done a lot of optimization
that needs to be done on that server to
make it worth it and get a good return
on investment from that server and even
after we have optimized for a good
return on investment the work is still
not done there will often be a frequent
increase and decrease in the capacity
and you know even news about our website
getting popular and getting more hits
it's still an bittersweet experience
because now i need to add more servers
to the environment which means that it's
going to cost me even more but thanks to
the present day cloud technology if the
same situation were to happen today my
new server it's almost ready and it's
ready instantaneously and with the swift
tools and technologies that amazon is
providing uh in provisioning my server
instantaneously and adding any type of
workload on top of it and making my
storage and server secure you know
creating a durable storage where data
that i store in the cloud never gets
lost with all that features amazon has
got our back so let's talk about what is
aws there are a lot of definitions for
it but i'm going to put together a
simple and a precise definition as much
as possible now let me iron that out
cloud still runs on and hardware all
right and
there are certain features in that
infrastructure in that cloud
infrastructure that makes cloud cloud or
that makes aws a cloud provider now we
get all the services all the
technologies all the features and all
the benefits that we get in our local
data center like you know security and
compute capacity and databases and in
fact you know we get even more cool
features like uh content caching in
various global locations around the
planet but again out of all the features
the best part is that i get or we get
everything on a pay as we go model the
less i use the less i pay and the more i
use the less i pay per unit very
attractive isn't it right and that's not
all the applications that we provision
in aws are very reliable because they
run on a reliable infrastructure and
it's very scalable because it runs on an
on-demand infrastructure and it's very
flexible because of the designs and
because of the design options available
for me in the cloud let's talk about how
all this happened aws was launched in
2002 after the amazon we know as the
online retail store wanted to sell their
reminding or unused infrastructure as a
service or as an offering for customers
to buy and use it from them you know
sell infrastructure as a service the
idea sort of clicked and aws launched
their first product first product in
2006 that's like four years after the
idea launch and in 2012 they held a big
sized customer even to gather inputs and
concerns from customers and they were
very dedicated in making those requests
happen and that habit is still being
followed it's still being followed as a
reinvent by aws and at 2015 amazon
announced its revenue to be 4.6 billion
and in 2015 through 2016 aws launched
products and services that helped
migrate customer services into aws well
there were products even before but this
is when a lot of focus was given on
developing migrating services and in the
same year that's in 2016 amazon's
revenue was 10 billion and not but not
the least as we speak amazon has more
than 100 products and services available
for customers and get benefited from all
right let's talk about the
services that are available in amazon
let's start with this product called s3
now s3 is a great tool for internet
backup and it's it's the cheapest
storage option in the object storage
category and not only that the data that
we put in s3 is retrievable from the
internet s3 is really cool and we have
other products like migration and data
collection and data transfer products
and here we can not only collect data
seamlessly but also in a real-time way
monitor the data or analyze the data
that's being received that they're cool
products like aws data transfers
available that helps achieve that and
then we have products like ec2 elastic
compute cloud that's an recessable
computer where we can anytime anytime
after the size of the computer based on
the need or based on the forecast then
we have simple notification services
systems and tools available in amazon to
update us with notifications through
email or through sms now anything
anything can be sent through email or
through sms if you use that service it
could be alarms or it could be service
notifications if you want stuff like
that and then we have some security
tools like kms key management system
which uses aes 256 bit encryption to
encrypt our data at rest then we have
lambda a service for which we pay only
for the time in seconds seconds it takes
to execute our code and uh we're not
paying for the infrastructure here it's
just the seconds the program is going to
take to execute the code for the short
program we'll be paying in a
milliseconds if it's a bit bigger
program we'll be probably paying in 60
seconds or 120 seconds but that's not
cheap lot simple and lots cost effective
as against paying for service on an
hourly basis which a lot of other
services are well that's cheap but using
lambda is a lot cheaper than that and
then we have services like route 53 a
dns service in the cloud and now i do
not have to maintain and dns account
somewhere else and my cloud environment
with aws i can get both in the same
place all right let me talk to you about
how aws makes life easier or how
companies got benefited by using aws as
their i.t provider for their
applications or for the infrastructure
now uniliver is a company and they had a
problem right and they had a problem and
they picked aws as a solution to their
problem right now this company was sort
of spread across 190 countries and they
were relying on a lot of digital
marketing for promoting their products
and their existing environment their
legacy local environment proved not to
support their changing id demands and
they could not standardize their old
environment now they chose to move part
of their applications to aws because
they were not getting what they wanted
in their local environment and since
then you know rollouts were easy
provisioning new applications became
easy and even provisioning
infrastructure became easy and they were
able to do all that in push button
scaling and needless to talk about
backups that are safe and backups that
can be securely accessed from the cloud
as needed now that company is growing
along with aws because of their swift
speed in rolling out deployments and
being able to access secure backups from
various places and generate reports and
in fact useful reports out of it that
helps their business now on the same
lines let me also talk to you about
kellogg's and how they got benefited by
using amazon now kellogg's had a
different problem it's one of its kind
now their business model was very
dependent on an infrared that will help
to analyze data really fast right
because they were running promotions
based on the analyzed data that they get
so they being able to respond to the
analyzed data as soon as possible was
critical or vital in their environment
and luckily sap running on hana
environment is what they needed and you
know they picked that service in the
cloud and that's sort of solved the
problem now the company does not have to
deal with uh maintaining their legacy
infra and maintaining their heavy
compute capacity and maintaining their
database locally all that is now moved
to the cloud or they are using cloud as
their i.t service provider and and now
they have a greater and powerful it
environment that very much complements
their business let me start the session
with this scenario let's imagine how
life would have been without spotify for
those who are hearing about spotify for
the first time a spotify is an online
music service offering and it offers
instant access to over 16 million
licensed songs spotify now uses aws
cloud to store the data and share it
with their customers but prior to aws
they had some issues imagine using
spotify before aws let's talk about that
back then users were often getting
errors because spotify could not keep up
with the increased demand for storage
every new day and that led to users
getting upset and users cancelling the
subscription the problem spotify was
facing at that time was their users were
present globally and were accessing it
from everywhere and they had different
latency in their applications and
spotify had a demanding situation where
they need to frequently catalog the
songs released yesterday today and in
the future and this was changing every
new day and the songs coming in rate was
about 20 000 a day and back then they
could not keep up with this requirement
and needless to say they were badly
looking for a way to solve this problem
and that's when they got introduced to
aws and it was a perfect fit and match
for their problem aws offered at
dynamically increasing storage and
that's what they needed aws also offered
tools and techniques like storage life
cycle management and trusted advisor to
properly utilize the resource so we
always get the best out of the resource
used aws addressed their concerns about
easily being able to scale yes you can
scale the aws environment very easily
how easily one might ask it's just a few
button clicks and aws solved spotify's
problem let's talk about how it can help
you with your organization's problem
let's talk about what is aws first and
then let's bleed into how aws became so
successful and the different types of
services that aws provides and what's
the future of cloud and aws in specific
let's talk about that and finally we'll
talk about a use case where you will see
how easy it is to create a web
application with aws all right let's
talk about what is aws aws or amazon web
services is a secure cloud service
platform it is also pay as you go type
billing model where there is no upfront
or capital cost we'll talk about how
soon the service will be available well
the service will be available in a
matter of seconds with aws you can also
do identity and access management that
is authenticating and authorizing a user
or a program on the fly and almost all
the services are available on demand and
most of them are available
instantaneously and as we speak amazon
offers 100 plus services and this list
is growing every new week now that would
make you wonder how aws became so
successful of course it's their
customers let's talk about the list of
well-known companies that has their idea
environment in aws adobe adobe uses aws
to provide multi-terabyte operating
environments for its customers by
integrating its system with aws cloud
adobe can focus on deploying and
operating its own software instead of
trying to you know deploy and manage the
infrastructure airbnb is another company
it's an community marketplace that
allows property owners and travelers to
connect each other for the purpose of
renting unique vacation spaces around
the world and the airbnb community users
activities are conducted on the website
and through iphones and android
applications airbnb has a huge
infrastructure in aws and they're almost
using all the services in aws and are
getting benefited from it another
example would be autodesk autodesk
develops software for engineering
designing and entertainment industries
using services like amazon rds or
rational database service and amazon s3
or amazon simple storage servers
autodesk can focus on deploying or
developing its machine learning tools
instead of spending that time on
managing the infrastructure aol or
american online uses aws and using aws
they have been able to close data
centers and decommission about 14 000
in-house and co-located servers and move
mission critical workload to the cloud
and extend its global reach and save
millions of dollars on energy resources
bitdefender is an internet security
software firm and their portfolio of
softwares include antivirus and
anti-spyware products bitdefender uses
ec2 and they are currently running few
hundred instances that handle about five
terabytes of data and they also use
elastic load balancer to load balance
the connection coming in to those
instances across availability zones and
they provide seamless global delivery of
servers because of that the bmw group it
uses aws for its new connected car
application that collects sensor data
from bmw 7 series cars to give drivers
dynamically updated map information
canon's office imaging products division
benefits from faster deployment times
lower cost and global reach by using aws
to deliver cloud-based services such as
mobile print the office imaging products
division uses aws such as amazon s3 and
amazon route 53 amazon cloudfront and
amazon im for their testing development
and production services comcast it's the
world's largest cable company and the
leading provider of internet service in
the united states comcast uses aws in a
hybrid environment out of all the other
cloud providers comcast chose aws for
its flexibility and scalable hybrid
infrastructure docker is a company
that's helping redefine the way
developers build ship and run
applications this company focuses on
making use of containers for this
purpose and in aws the service called
the amazon ec2 container service is
helping them achieve it the esa or
european space agency although much of
esa's work is done by satellites some of
the programs data storage and computing
infrastructure is built on amazon web
services esa chose aws because of its
economical pay as ego system as well as
its quick startup time the guardian
newspaper uses aws and it uses a wide
range of aws services including amazon
kinesis amazon redshift that power an
analytic dashboard which editors used to
see how stories are trending in real
time financial times ft is one of the
world's largest leading business news
organization and they used amazon
redshift to perform their analysis a
funny thing happened amazon redshirt
performed so quickly that some analysis
thought it was malfunctioning they were
used to running queries overnight and
they found that the results were indeed
correct just as much faster by using
amazon redshift fd is supporting the
same business functions with costs that
are 80 age lower than what was before
general electric
ge is at the moment as we speak
migrating more than 9000 workloads
including 300 desperate erp systems to
aws while reducing its data center
footprint from 34 to 4 over the next
three years similarly howard medical
school htc imdb mcdonald's nasa
kellogg's and lot more are using the
services amazon provides and are getting
benefited from it and this huge success
and customer portfolio is just the tip
of the iceberg and if we think why so
many adapt aws and if we let aws answer
that question this is what aws would say
people are adapting aws because of the
security and durability of the data and
end-to-end privacy and encryption of the
data and storage experience we can also
rely on aws way of doing things by using
the aws tools and techniques and
suggested best practices built upon the
years of experience it has gained
flexibility there is a greater
flexibility in aws that allows us to
select the os language and database easy
to use swiftness in deploying we can
host our applications quickly in aws
beat a new application or migrating an
existing application into aws
scalability the application can be
easily scaled up or scaled down
depending on the user requirement cost
saving we only pay for the compute power
storage and other resources you use and
that too without any long-term
commitments now let's talk about the
different types of services that aws
provides the services that we talk about
fall in any of the following categories
you see like you know compute storage
database security customer engagement
desktop and streaming machine learning
developers tools stuff like that and if
you do not see the service that you're
looking for it's probably is because aws
is creating it as we speak now let's
look at some of them that are very
commonly used within computer services
we have amazon ec2 amazon elastic bean
stock amazon light sale and amazon
lambda amazon ec2 provides compute
capacity in the cloud now this capacity
is secure and it is resizable based on
the user's requirement now look at this
the requirement for the web traffic
keeps changing and behind the scenes in
the cloud ec2 can expand its environment
to three instances and during no load it
can shrink its environment to just one
resource elastic beanstalk it helps us
to scale and deploy web applications and
it's made with a number of programming
languages elastic beanstalk is also an
easy to use service for deploying and
scaling web applications and services
deployed a bit in java.net php node.js
python ruby docker and lot other
familiar services such as apache
passenger and iis we can simply upload
our code and elastic beanstalk
automatically handles the deployment
from capacity provisioning to load
balancing to auto scaling to application
health monitoring and amazon light sale
is a virtual private server which is
easy to launch and easy to manage amazon
lightsail is the easiest way to get
started with aws for developers who just
need a virtual private server lightsail
includes everything you need to launch
your project quickly on a virtual
machine like ssd based storage a virtual
machine tools for data transfer dns
management and a static ip and that too
for a very low and predictable price aws
lambda has taken cloud computing
services to a whole new level it allows
us to pay only for the compute time no
need for provisioning and managing
servers and aws lambda is a compute
service that lets us run code without
provisioning or managing service lambda
executes your code only when needed and
scales automatically from few requests
per day to thousands per second you pay
only for the compute time you consume
there is no charge when your code is not
running let's look at some storage
services that amazon provides like
amazon s3 amazon glacier amazon abs and
amazon elastic file system amazon s3 is
an object storage that can store and
retrieve data from anywhere websites
mobile apps iot sensors and so on can
easily use amazon s3 to store and
retrieve data it's an object storage
built to store and deter any amount of
data from anywhere with its features
like flexibility and managing data and
the durability it provides and the
security that it provides amazon simple
storage service or s3 is a storage for
the internet and glacier glacier is a
cloud storage service that's used for
archiving data and long term backups and
this glacier is an secure durable and
extremely low-cost cloud storage service
for data archiving and long-term backups
amazon ebs amazon elastic block store
provides block store volumes for the
instances of ec2 and this elastic block
store is highly available and a reliable
storage volume that can be attached to
any running instance that is in the same
availability zone abs volumes that are
attached to the ec2 instances are
exposed as storage volumes that
persistent independently from the
lifetime of the instance an amazon
elastic file system or efs provides an
elastic file storage which can be used
with aws cloud service and resources
that are on premises and amazon elastic
file system it's an simple it's scalable
it's an elastic file storage for use
with amazon cloud services and for
on-premises resources it's easy to use
and offers a simple interface that
allows you to create and configure file
systems quickly and easily amazon file
system is built to elastically scale on
demand without disturbing the
application growing and shrinking
automatically as you add and remove
files your application have the storage
they need and when they need it now
let's talk about databases the two major
database flavors are amazon rds and
amazon redshift amazon rds it really
eases the process involved in setting up
operating and scaling a relational
database in the cloud amazon rds
provides cost efficient and resizable
capacity while automating time consuming
administrative tasks such as hardware
provisioning database setup patching and
backups it sort of frees us from
managing the hardware and sort of helps
us to focus on the application it's also
cost effective and resizable and it's
also optimized for memory performance
and input and output operations not only
that it also automates most of the
services like taking backups you know
monitoring stuff like that it automates
most of those services amazon redshift
amazon redshift is a data warehousing
service that enables users to analyze
the data using sql and other business
intelligent tools amazon reshift is an
fast and fully managed data warehouse
that makes it simple and cost effective
and lays all your data using standard
sql and your existing business
intelligent tools it also allows you to
run complex analytic queries against
petabyte of structured data using
sophisticated query optimizations and
most of the results they generally come
back in seconds all right let's quickly
talk about some more services that aws
offers there are a lot more services
that aws provides but are we going to
look at some more services that are
widely used aws application discovery
services help enterprise customers plan
migration projects by gathering
information about their on-premises data
centers in a planning a data center
migration can involve thousands of
workloads they are often deeply
interdependent server utilization data
and dependency mapping are important
early first step in migration process
and this aws application discovery
service collects and presents
configuration usage and behavior data
from your servers to help you better
understand your workloads route 53 it's
a network and content delivery service
it's an highly available and scalable
cloud domain name system or dns service
and amazon route 53 is fully compliant
with ipv6 as well elastic load balancing
it's also a network and content delivery
service elastic load balancing
automatically distributes incoming
application traffic across multiple
targets such as amazon ec2 instance
containers and ip addresses it can
handle the varying load of your
application traffic in a single
available zones and also across
availability zones away auto scaling it
monitors your application and
automatically adjusts the capacity to
maintain steady and predictable
performance at a lowest possible cost
using aws auto scaling it's easy to set
up application scaling for multiple
resources across multiple services in
minutes auto scaling can be applied to
web services and also for db services
aws identity and access management it
enables you to manage access to aws
services and resources securely using
iam you can create and manage aws users
and groups and use permissions to allow
and deny their access to aws resources
and moreover it's a free service now
let's talk about the future of aws well
let me tell you something cloud is here
to stay here's what in store for aws in
the future as years pass by we're going
to have a variety of cloud applications
bond like iot artificial intelligence
business intelligence serverless
computing and so on cloud will also
expand into other markets like health
care banking space automated cars and so
on as i was mentioning some time back
lot or greater focus will be given to
artificial intelligence and eventually
because of the flexibility and advantage
that cloud provides we're going to see a
lot of companies moving into the cloud
all right let's now talk about how easy
it is to deploy
and web application in the cloud so the
scenario here is that our users like a
product and we need to have a mechanism
to receive input from them about their
likes and dislikes and you know give
them the appropriate product as per
their need all right though the setup
and the environment it sort of looks
complicated we don't have to worry
because aws has tools and technologies
which can help us to achieve it now
we're going to use services like route
53 services like cloudwatch ec2 s3 and
lot more and all these put together are
going to give an application that's
fully functionable and an application
that's going to receive the information
like using the services like route53
cloudwatch ec2 and s3 we're going to
create an application and that's going
to meet our need so back to our original
requirement all i want is to deploy a
web application for a product that keeps
our users updated about the happenings
and the new comings in the market and to
fulfill this requirement here is all the
services we would need ec2 here is used
for provisioning the computational power
needed for this application and ec2 has
a vast variety of family and types that
we can pick from for the types of
workloads and also for the intents of
the workloads we're also going to use s3
for storage and s3 provides any
additional storage requirement for the
resources or any additional storage
requirement for the web applications and
we are also going to use cloudwatch for
monitoring the environment and
cloudwatch monitors the application and
the environment and it uh provides
trigger for scaling in and scaling out
the infrastructure and we are also going
to use route 53 for dns and route 53
helps us to register the domain name for
our web application and with all the
tools and technologies together all of
them put together we're going to make an
application a perfect application that
caters our need all right so i'm going
to use elastic bean stock for this
project and the name of the application
is going to be as you see gsg sign up
and the environment name is gsg signup
environment 1. let me also pick a name
let me see if this name is available yes
that's available that's the domain name
so let me pick that and the application
that i have is going to run on node.js
so let me pick that platform and launch
now as you see elastic beanstalk this is
going to launch an instance it's going
to launch the monitoring setup or the
monitoring environment it's going to
create a load balancer as well and it's
going to take care of all the security
features needed for this application
all right look at that i was able to go
to that url which is what we gave and
it's now having an default page shown up
meaning all the dependencies for the
software is installed and it's just
waiting for me to upload the code or in
specific the page required so let's do
that
let me upload the code i already have
the code saved here
that's my code
and that's going to take some time all
right it has done its thing and now if i
go to the same url look at that i'm
being thrown an advertisement page all
right so if i sign up with my name email
and stuff like that you know it's going
to receive the information and it's
going to send an email to the owner
saying that somebody had subscribed to
your service that's the default feature
of this app look at that email to the
owner saying that somebody had
subscribed to your app and this is their
email address stuff like that not only
that it's also going to create an entry
in the database and dynamodb is the
service that this application uses to
store data there's my dynamodb and if i
go to tables
right and go to items i'm going to see
that a user with name samuel and email
address so and so has said okay or has
shown interest in the preview of my site
or product so this is where this is how
i collect those information right
and some more things about the
infrastructure itself is
it is running behind and load balancer
look at that it had created a load
balancer it had also created an auto
scaling group now that's the feature of
elastic load balancer that we have
chosen it has created an auto scaling
group and now let's put this url you see
this it's not a fancy url right it's an
amazon given url a dynamic url so let's
put this url behind our dns let's do
that
so go to services go to route 53
go to hosted zone and there we can find
the
dns name right so that's a dns name all
right
all right let's create an entry
and map that url to our load balancer
right
and create now technically if i
go to this url it should take me
to that application all right look at
that i went to my custom url and now
that's pointed to my application
previously my application was having a
random url and now it's having a custom
url choose from over 300 in-demand
skills and get access to 1 000 plus
hours of video content for free visit
scale up by simply learn click on the
link in the description to know more
cloud services are now available to
satisfy almost any id requirement
although cloud computing services vary
greatly
they all have some basic qualities and
benefits in common
and they can be classified into a few
basic cloud service kinds
hello everyone i am sharmly and i
welcome you all to this new video of
simply learn
on cloud computing services
let me give you an overview of the
concepts you are going to go through in
this video
first we will go through what is cloud
computing
then we will have an introduction to
cloud computing services
followed by the types of cloud computing
services
and at the end we will look into the
features and benefits of cloud computing
services
so let's not waste any more time and get
started with the video
so what is cloud computing
cloud computing is the distribution of
cloud computing services by the internet
including servers storage databases
networking software analytics
intelligence to provide faster
innovation more flexible resources and
economies of scale
you usually only pay for the cloud
services you use which helps you cut
cost run your infrastructure more
efficiently and scale as your business
grows
now that we know what cloud computing is
let's proceed with understanding
cloud computing services
cloud computing services provide users
with a variety of capabilities including
email
storage backup data retrieval app
creation testing data analysis audio
video streaming software on demand
regardless of the type of service
although cloud computing is still a
relatively new technology it is now
being used by a wide range of
organizations including large
enterprises small businesses non-profit
government agencies and even individual
consumers
so not all clouds are created equal and
not every sort of cloud computing is
appropriate for every situation
a variety of models varieties and
services have evolved to assist you find
the best option for your needs
to begin one must decide on the type of
cloud deployment or cloud computing
architecture
that will be used to implement your
cloud services
cloud services can be deployed in three
different ways public cloud private
cloud or hybrid cloud
now let's dive down deeper into cloud
computing services and explore its type
in more detail
cloud computing unlike a microprocessor
is not a single piece of technology
rather it's a system made up of three
services
infrastructure as a service
platform as a service
and software as a service
so let's have a better understanding of
each
starting with
infrastructure as a service
so what is infrastructure as a service
it is a type of cloud computing that
uses the internet to provide virtualized
computing resources
the cloud provider controls id
infrastructures such as storage server
and networking resources
and also offers them to subscribe
companies via virtual machines
accessible over the internet in ias
model
for businesses it can provide numerous
advantages including the ability to make
tasks faster easier more flexible and
less expensive
now let's have a look at the working of
iaas
users connect to resources and services
across a wide area network such as the
internet and then use the cloud provider
services to complete the application
stack
the user can for example log into the
infrastructure as a service platform to
build virtual machines
install operating systems in each vm
deploy middleware such as databases
create storage buckets for workloads and
backups
and install the enterprise workload onto
that virtual machine
customers can then track cost monitor
performance balance network traffic
solve application difficulties and
manage disaster recovery using the
provider's service
so moving ahead let's go through its
advantages and disadvantages
advantages
organizations select
infrastructure as a service because
operating a workload without having to
buy manage and support the underlying
infrastructure is frequently easier
faster and more cost effective
a company can rent or lease
infrastructure from another company
using infrastructure as a service
for workloads that are transitory
experimental or change abruptly
it is an effective cloud service
paradigm
for example if a company is creating a
new software product
hiring an ieas provider
to host and test the application may be
more cost effective
once the new software has been
thoroughly tested and refined the
company can move it away from the
iaas environment
and into a more traditional in-house
deployment
if the expenses of a long-term
commitment are lower
the organization could commit base or
software to a long-term
iaas deployment
now disadvantages
billing can be a challenge for some
firms despite its flexible pay-as-you-go
model cloud invoicing is quite detailed
and it is broken down to reflect
specific service usage
when evaluating the invoices for each
resource
and service involved in application
deployment users frequently experience
sticker shock or discover expenses that
are greater than expected
another issue
it face is lack of insight because its
providers own the infrastructure the
configuration and performance of that
infrastructure are very rarely
transparent to its con consumers
users may find it more difficult to
operate and monitor systems due to the
lack of transparency
users of infrastructure as a service are
also concerned about service
availability and reliability
the supplier has a big influence on the
workload's availability and performance
the workloads of users will be impacted
if a provider has network constraint or
any other type of internal or external
outage
furthermore because it is a multitude in
design the problem of noisy neighbors
might have an adverse effect on users
workloads
so now these are the top infrastructure
as a service providers
linode is a privately held cloud hosting
firm base in the united states that
offers virtual private servers
host winds web hosting cloud hosting and
dedicated server options are all
available from host wins
microsoft azure is a cloud computing
service operated by microsoft for
application
management via microsoft managed data
centers
digitalocean
offers developers cloud service
that make it easy to deploy and grow
programs that run on several machines at
the same time
alibaba cloud is a cloud computing firm
that serves online businesses as well as
alibaba's own e-commerce ecosystem
so the second service is platform as a
service
what is platform as a service
platform as a
which are geared towards software
development teams include computing and
storage infrastructure as well as
development platform layer that includes
web servers database management systems
and software development kits for
multiple programming languages
working of platform as a service
for software development
it does not replace an organization's
complete ip infrastructure
it's made possible by the hosted
infrastructure of a cloud service
provider
a web browser is the most common way for
users to access the offsets
platform as a service such as
application hosting and java development
can be supplied by a public private or
hybrid clouds
so
now let's look into the advantages and
disadvantages
advantages
the main advantage of platform as a
service for users is its simplicity and
convenience
much of the infrastructure and other id
services will be provided by the
platform as a service provider
which users can access from anywhere via
a web browser
the flexibility to pay on a per use
basis allows businesses to forego the
capital cost associated with on-premises
gear and software
many platform-as-a-service solutions are
aimed towards software developers
these platform provider computation and
storage infrastructures as well as text
editing version management compilation
and testing capabilities to assist
developers in swiftly and efficiently
developing your software
coming to the disadvantages platform as
a service on the other hand can cause
issues
with service availability and resilience
customers may suffer as a result of
of a service outage or other
infrastructure interruption
which might result in costly
productivity losses
its suppliers on the other hand will
typically deliver reasonably high up
times
another widespread problem is when the
lock-in which occurs when users are
unable to simply transition many of
their services and data from one
platform as a service solution to
another
when choosing a provider users
must consider the business risk of
service outages and vendor login
internal changes to a platform as a
service product could also be a problem
the impact on users might be tough and
restrictive
if a platform as a service provider
seizes supporting a programming language
or chooses to use a different set of
development tools
so let's have a look at the top platform
as a service provider
ibm cloud computing refers to a set of
cloud computing services for businesses
provided by ibm a technology corporation
red hat is a collection of tightly
integrated red hat technologies for
building cloud infrastructure and
developing cloud native apps on premises
elastic beanstalk aws elastic beanstalk
is an amazon web services application
deployment
orchestration solution
salesforce offers crm services as well
as enterprise applications for customer
service marketing
automation analytics and application
development
and software ag cloud is an open and
independent cloud platform that serves
as your one stop shop for all software
ag has to offer in the cloud
now coming to the next service which is
software as a service
so what is software as a service
customer relationship management or crm
marketing automation and business
analytics are just a few of the
application level services offered by
software as a service
companies
so how does it work
the provider gives consumers network
access to a single copy of an
application
that the provider designed expressly for
software as a service distribution
in the software on demand model
the source code for the program is the
same for all clients and new features or
functionalities are rolled out to all
the users at the same time
the data of each model's customer may be
stored locally in the cloud or both
locally in the cloud depending on the
service level agreement
coming to its advantages
customers subscribe to a software as a
service solution rather than buying and
installing software or additional gear
to support it many firms can now budget
more effectively and predictably by
converting costs to recurrent operating
expenses
you can also cancel software as a
service subscriptions at any time to
avoid incurring
recurring fees
its systems are frequently customizable
and can be connected with other
corporate applications
particularly when using software for the
same vendor
vertical scalability is a feature of
cloud services
like software as a service which allows
clients to access more or fewer services
or features on demand
disadvantages of software as a service
when providers endure
service delays impose undesirable
modifications to service offerings or
suffer a security breach
all of these things can have a
significant impact on customers
ability to use the software as a service
offering
customers should be aware of their
software as a service provider's sla and
ensure that it is followed
if the provider adopts a new version of
an application it will roll it out to
all of its clients
whether or not they want it
this may need the organization
allocating additional training time and
resources
switching vendors can be tough as it is
with any cloud service provider
customers must migrate massive volumes
of data when switching vendors
furthermore some vendors use
technologies and data types which can
make transferring client data between
cloud providers even more difficult
so coming to the top companies that
provide software as a service
adobe is a collection of
adobe incorporation programs and
services that provide user with access
to software for graphic design
video editing
web development and photography as well
as a set of mobile apps and certain
optional cloud services
sap is a platform as a service designed
by sap se for developing new application
and enhancing
existing ones in a secure cloud
computing environment managed by sap
google cloud google cloud platform is a
set of cloud computing services provided
by google that run on the same
infrastructure as google's internal
products such as google search gmail
drive and youtube
fresh works cloud platform allows users
to manage
their identities and access across all
of their freshworks products
and athelation advanced features such as
a 99.9 uptime sla unlimited storage and
premium support provide teams the
confidence to scale reliably
now that we have all the in-depth
information about different types of
cloud computing services
let's move ahead and explore its
benefits and features which makes it so
popular and convenient
first the supplier hosts and maintains
the site in their own facility
the cloud hosting provider acquires
hosts and maintains the necessary
hardware and software
users avoid the construction
expenditures and maintenance problem
that would be incurred if the service
was established on premise
second self-service using a web-based
interface
through a web interface service users
can initiate certain service functions
as well as increase or reduce
their service consumption level with
little or no intervention from the
service provider
third is you must pay to utilize the
facility
users of the service only pay for the
services they use when compared to the
typical method of building on-site id
capacities
targeted for the highest usage
situations and then having that capacity
to go unused for the most of the time
this can result in significant cost
savings
the fourth one is scalability that comes
close to being infinite cloud computing
service providers usually have the
instruct infrastructure in place to
deliver their services at a large scale
that means that cloud service consumers
can readily accommodate business
expansion or periodic surges in service
usage
well this is all about cloud computing
services hello everybody welcome to
simply learn's aws
s3 tutorial for beginners my name is
kent and today i'm going to be covering
these following points i'm going to be
covering what is
cloud computing i'm going to be
showcasing what aws is in terms of
cloud computing and i'm also going to be
covering the core fundamental service of
the simple storage service which is
a object storage service we're going to
be covering the benefits of the simple
storage service better known as s3 what
objects
and buckets are
and we're going to be seeing how things
are working in the background
and implementing that in terms of
lab assisted demonstrations in order for
you to see what those features of s3 are
and then we'll perform a wrap up of the
material we've done in a conclusion
so
let's get started
what is
cloud computing
so here is a definition of cloud
computing
but i'm going to paraphrase it
cloud computing is nothing more than you
gaining access to
infrastructure
through
web services with a pay-as-you-go model
now this is a very very different model
than where traditionally
involved in on a on-prem
data center so when i mean on-prem
i'm saying on-premise okay so you'll
hear that a lot on-prem
now when we are on on-premise data
center we have to provision lots of
infrastructure even before we get
started with
um
deploying any type of application
whether it be a mobile application a web
application etc etc
so every application needs some sort of
underlying infrastructure whether that
be
bare bone servers databases they're
obviously going to be needing some types
of storage etc etc so all this is
something that we have to kind of fight
against in order just to get started
with deploying our application so this
takes usually traditionally depending on
the size of the company about three
months to set up
so
what if
we could leverage
all this infrastructure
as a service and just through some api
call that's what the web services is all
about
we could provision a server or we could
provision a database within minutes and
then deploy any type of application that
we want to on top of that stack and also
take advantage of any storage that we
may want we may want object level
storage which is what we're going to
cover we may want
an elastic file system
right so there are different types of
storages that we're eventually going to
look at as you go down your learning
path with simply learn so cloud
computing is really about provisioning
of all these kinds of services but not
only at the infrastructure level we're
going to see how we could move up the
stack and get entire platforms as a
service or even softwares as a service
so what is aws
well aws is really a cloud computing
platform
that will offer us
many many services
through these api calls some are again
just bare infrastructure like a service
other can be
a service as a software for example
email
so here we have an example
of the public data storage this is s3
the simple storage service icon that
you're going to see over and over again
this is a representation
of an actual bucket in s3 so this will
become more clear as we
continue the slide deck and actually
reinforce this with some hands-on lab
but as you can imagine you may want to
provision a
private
software defined network in the cloud
and so we can do that in aws we can
provide load balancing we could provide
scalability in terms of auto scaling
groups that will respond to
increased demand as your application
let's say
becomes more popular you want that
infrastructure to grow elastically so
doing this on premise is traditionally
not only extremely expensive
and thus prohibited
but very difficult to implement
physically speaking as well
so by going with a cloud provider like
aws we can severely reduce the expense
and the complexity of setting all of
this up because
we're trading capital expense for
variable expense so capital expense is
about you procuring all the hardware
that you need beforehand and the budget
being approved before even getting that
hardware in through your door right and
then you have to configure it so there's
that complexity factor
whereas if you're doing this through aws
you can within minutes
just provision all of that very quickly
so you're also not paying for everything
all up front you're paying this with a
pay as you go model so very different
we are now
removing what's called undifferentiated
lifting which is everybody has to
do the same thing but it's not really
bringing any value to their end product
we all have to
buy servers and configure them and scale
them etc etc so if we remove that
element
and have aws handle that we can
concentrate on our business
which is our application and improving
that application
and responding more to our clients
request we can be more agile more
flexible so all of this leads to these
points that we see here on the slide
much easier to use much easier to get
our application to market we're actually
going to be leveraging
the physical security that aws
implements for us they have data centers
all over the world that we're going to
plug into and that physical security is
already
implemented for us there are
varying levels of security that we're
going to get into through our aws
journey
but right off the bat you know that you
have physical
security
of course we're going to be talking
about storage in this
demonstration or in this slide deck over
here but the nice thing is is we only
pay for what we use
so that's that variable expense that i
was talking about that we've traded for
capital expense we can easily set up
databases we can easily
automate our backups and have those
backups stored
in the cloud through that s3 storage
that we're going to get into okay
so lots of benefits of going through aws
here
and it's also comprehensive and simple
to use
uh comprehensive meaning that there are
hundreds and hundreds of services
um it's going to be actually quite time
consuming for you to just know what each
service does in general
but you'll get there through your
journey it's all about sticking with it
and learning something new every day
which is what simple learn is all about
over here we have infrastructure as a
service platform as a service and
software as a service so these are three
different types of distinctions we have
in the cloud industry to basically
cover what's going on here on the right
hand side so on premise you're
traditionally involved in
everything from networking which is you
for example
buying the switches the routers the
cabling everything all the way up the
stack to deploying your application and
you see everything in between there okay
so this is a very time consuming job not
only that but it costs a lot of money
because you have to buy all these
machines up front and you have to have
the
individuals with the right knowledge
to
maintain all of this stack all right so
different individuals in different teams
maintaining this whole on-premise data
center you may also have different data
centers deployed globally so you can
imagine the cost
overhead of this
so everything in green is basically
you're managing it
now we can offset that and ask aws to
handle part
of this stack over here so
on this second column over here we see
infrastructure as a service which
basically says aws i want you to handle
all the networking my software defined
network i want you to handle my storage
elasticity i want you to handle my
compute power my virtual machines i want
you to handle
even
administrating those machines at a
physical layer as well and i want you to
physically secure them so this will
allow you more time to focus on all
the green up here
of course we can move up the stack and
say i even want aws to take on more
responsibility
and that would be more of a platform as
a service where aws would also install
and maintain the operating system for
you so you can imagine things like new
versions of operating systems uh
security patches maintenance patches all
of the like and any middleware or
runtime that you have on top of that
think of something like the java a
virtual machine perhaps that needs to be
updated now you wouldn't be responsible
for maintaining all of what's in orange
over here you would only be responsible
for deploying your application and
making sure that your data is saved and
secured right so again platform as a
service is a more hands-off approach so
think of it as
you wanted to set up a
cicd deployment environment
for your development team and you want
it to be very uh involved in just
handling your application code and
making sure that it was properly
compiled built tested and deployed right
well this could be implemented as a
platform as a service
or
you could take your code as a zip file
and give it to aws's
service
called beanstalk which would
automatically deploy your code and make
sure that it's highly available scalable
and fault tolerant across all of the
orange stack over here right so more of
a hands-off approach
of course we can go all the way up the
stack and tell aws to take care of
everything for us and just ask for a
service much like a utility like
electricity or water we might want to
say we just want an email software
service and we're not
really concerned about how the
underlying operating system or servers
or network are configured for that we
just want to use the software as a
service we don't want to administrate
anything else we just want to be sort of
like an end user to it so aws will
manage everything underneath the hood so
they're varying types of services you
pick and choose whichever one makes more
sense for you and your team
so what is
s3 s3 stands for simple storage
service and it is an object
storage service in amazon what this
means is that
it doesn't matter what kind of file you
upload to s3 it will be treated as an
abstraction meaning an object so you can
upload a pdf file you can upload a jpeg
file you can upload a database backup it
doesn't really matter all that is
abstracted away
by the use of storing it within an
object we're going to talk more about
what composes an object but by doing so
what happens is s3 allows us to have
industry leading scalability so it
doesn't matter if you're going to make a
request for that database backup let's
say that object um
five times or ten thousand times that
request that demand will scale the
underlying infrastructure that is
implemented behind the scenes is handled
for you so in a sense it's kind of like
a serverless
service a storage service where you're
not
implicated in handling anything
underneath the covers you're just
uploading your objects and accessing
them later on in terms of data
availability very powerful as well
because it takes those objects and will
replicate them across at least three
availability zones of course these
availability zones have one or more data
centers attached to them so you have
lots and lots of copies of your objects
distributed globally
or at least at a regional in a regional
area
you can do this as well globally if you
enable global replication
and you will see that your level of
juror availability will skyrocket and
you're just not going to worry about
losing an s3 object
data security well we can encrypt our
data at rest our objects at rest we can
encrypt it in transit
we can also come up with security
policies at
the bucket level which we're going to
talk about what a bucket is very very
very soon
these are going to be implemented
through what's called i am policies and
you're going to be able to control who
or what has access to your objects
and of course because everything is
handled underneath the covers all the
servers all the storage nodes
are
cloud optimized for the best possible
performance
so let's continue on our journey on what
is s3
we're going to take a look at what is a
bucket and what is an object as you can
see here you have inside this bucket
which is a logical container
for an unlimited amount of objects you
could have objects of different shapes
and sizes like i said you could have
pictures database backups etc so this is
what's being represented here by
different shapes
and you can think of a bucket really as
almost like a folder where objects or
files are placed within them
so there are many ways for us to place
objects within a bucket we can do this
through the aws console which i'll be
showing you very shortly we can do this
via the command line interface or we can
do this to a software development kit at
the end of the day all those three
options go through
an api right so
it's all about picking the right method
that is best suited for whatever kind of
end user or application that needs
access to these buckets and to these
objects now
once you've got the data or objects
within this bucket
you could control pretty much how the
data is accessed how it's stored whether
you want it to be encrypted and how it's
even
managed so you can have organizations
that have specific compliance needs for
example any objects
that are placed in or perhaps some pdfs
are not to be modified or not to be
touched for 90 days let's say we can
employ
object locks if we want to
we can imply security guards we can
also for example record all
api actions
that
try to access to list to delete any kind
of api operations on those objects at
the bucket level or on the object level
we can record if that is some sort of
organizational compliance need for
auditing or for whatever internal
auditing reason that you may have
so continuing on here you can see that
there are many organizations that use s3
one in point is amazon itself s3 is so
popular and so durable that amazon
internally uses it to store its own data
you're guaranteed you know almost that
you're not going to lose any object in
there because it has what we call 11
durability now 11 9's durability
is
really an extreme amount of durability
where it's mathematically
almost impossible for you to lose an
object once you place it in s3 you're in
fact more
liable to get hit by meteorite than you
are to lose an object in s3
statistically speaking which is a pretty
incredible statistic but it's but it's
true
so if we continue here with the benefits
of s3 some of these have already
described but let's talk about the full
picture here we see the performance
scalability availability and durability
of s3 are really
you know first class in the industry
again durability we were talking about
that 11 9 so what that really means is
99.9999
in total if you count all the nines
that's 11 of those nine so um ex most
durable in the industry by far and again
because everything is handled underneath
the covers it's a serverless
service
they ensure the scalability and
availability and the performance of
the inner workings of that object level
storage now cost is of course always
important and s3 really shows up here
with first class support again
for cost it's got very very low cost we
can have object level storage for
let's say a terabyte of object level
storage for as little as a dollar
a month so again it will
depend on the kind of storage class
we're going to have a discussion
on different types of storage classes
that we might want to transition or move
over our objects from one storage class
to the next depending on how frequently
accessed that data is as you know data
over time seems to get less and less
accessed
as you know your needs shift from
one place to another we're going to talk
about that coming up very soon so we're
going to want to really focus on that to
reduce our end of the month
costs for storage with s3 of course
security is always at the forefront and
we want to make sure that we either
simply secure by encrypting everything
right off the bat
either at rest in transit or we want to
put an object lock or just maintain
security at the
bucket level maintaining let's say who
or what has access to that data because
by default no one has access to the data
unless we open up the door and also we
want to make sure that we don't give
public access
to our bucket for obvious reasons of
giving away important information by
mistake so aws makes it extremely
difficult for you to accidentally do
this and i'm going to show this in a
demonstration lab coming up very soon
and we can also query in place which is
very interesting so you can imagine you
putting let's say
a file that's in csv format or json
format or parquet format some sort of
structured format or semi-structured
format in s3 and you can actually use
sql queries on the spot to
filter that data in place at the bucket
level
you could also have other services that
may want to extract some business
intelligence
from that data
in your s3 bucket directly as well so
some other more advanced querying
operations can take place at the s3
level so this you will learn
during your journey with simply learn as
you're covering all the aws technology
stacks
and here the most widely used storage
cloud service in the industry
because of all the points that we just
covered it really is the number one
storage or object level storage solution
in the industry
let's now take a look at objects and
buckets and s3 so the objects are really
the fundamental entities that are stored
in s3 or the lowest common denominator
which means that we're not really
interested
in what kind of data is within the
object at the layer of s3 because s3
doesn't have direct access to the data
within an object like i said before it's
an abstraction of
the data so we don't know
if it's a cat's picture if it's a backup
of your database it's just treated as a
fundamental entity
aka the object now every object is
associated with metadata so data about
itself things like what's the name of
the object what's the size the time and
date that the object was uploaded things
of that nature are categorized
as metadata so s3 does have direct
access to that now the data within that
object of course is accessible by other
services
so it's not that once you've uploaded it
you've totally lost the data and it's
only can be treated as an object it's
just that at this layer
it's simply just assigned metadata and a
version id a unique version id and if
you re-upload the exact same object the
second or third time to s3 it will have
its own
version
id number so a new unique version id
number will be generated
so really what buckets are are there
logical containers to store those
objects so of course at an extremely
high level a bucket would be like your
root file system if you want to think
about it like that but that doesn't mean
you can't go into this bucket and create
separate folders
now when you create separate folders in
a bucket because you might want to
logically organize
all your objects
you might be fooled by the fact that you
think this is a hierarchical
storage system when in fact it is not
and i'll talk about that in a second
so you cannot store an object without
first storing it into a bucket so of
course the first step would be for us to
create a bucket
and then upload objects within that
bucket so an object cannot can cannot
exist without its container or its
bucket
so there's no windows explorer view like
we're used to in an operating system
because this is not a hierarchical view
no matter if you create folders within
folders within folders in fact s3's
internal architecture is a flat
hierarchy
what we do instead is we assign prefixes
which are treated as folders
in order to
logically organize our objects within
our buckets and i'm going to showcase a
prefix in one of the demonstrations
coming up very soon
so when you create or when you're
working with s3 first of all you're
working at a regional level you're gonna
have to pick a region
for example you might pick us east one
region
or usc ii region and the bucket that
you're going to be creating will be
replicated across several availability
zones but within that region
also that data those objects can be
accessed globally because
s3 uses the http protocol http protocol
is very permissive everybody knows how
to administrate it and work with it so
we just need to give access to that
object in terms of a permission policy
and give it the proper
url or
give whoever needs access to it the
proper url and they can access that via
http globally so first when you're
creating a bucket you have to select the
region
and
the object will live within that region
but that doesn't mean that it still
can't be accessed globally
so let's now take a minute go over to
the aws console and actually let me
showcase how to create
objects
and buckets
so for our first lab we're going to be
going and creating an s3 bucket and
uploading an object to it so we first
have to log into
the aws console which we have up here in
the address bar
let's click on either create free
account if it's your very first time or
as in is in my case i already have an
account we're going to sign in here
you're going to have to pass in your
im username password and your
account id of course
once you've logged in
you can search for
the simple
storage service s3 either
by coming up here in the search box and
typing s3 and you'll find it there
that's probably the easiest way or if
you want you can take a look at all the
services and it'll be under storage over
here the first one okay
so pick whichever method you see best
for yourself
once we're here we want to create
our first bucket
now i've already have a couple of
buckets here so we're gonna go on and
create a new bucket
the very first thing is you have to
specify a bucket name now this bucket
name has to be globally unique if you
take a look here at the region that
we're in
it doesn't actually select a specific
region
it selects the global
option which means that this bucket will
become globally accessible
so that is why it needs to have a unique
name much like a dns name has to be
unique for your website
right so i'm going to come up here
and pick a name that i think is going to
be unique so i'm going to say simply
learn
s3 demo
all right let's take a look at that's
going to work out of course we have to
pick a region
but it is globally accessible so you
either pick a region that's closest to
your end users or in our case since
we're just doing a demonstration we can
do whichever is closer to us right now
okay and we're going to skip these
options for now we're going to come back
to them later on we're just going to
create
the bucket
now hopefully that was a unique name and
allowed me to create that and it looks
like it did so if i scroll down you can
see
that it clearly got created over here
now we're going to click on that and
we're going to start
uploading objects to this bucket
so let me click on the upload button
and you can either select one or more
files
or you can select an entire folder so
i'm going to just go and select a
specific
cat picture that i have here
okay and again we'll go through some of
those other options later on and we'll
just click upload
now this should take no time at all
because of the fact that it's a very
small object or file that's being
uploaded so it is has succeeded we can
close this up
and we see now clearly that the object
is in our bucket if we go to properties
we can see the metadata associated with
this bucket we can see the region that
it's in we can see the arn which is the
amazon resource name which uniquely
identifies this resource this bucket
across the globe so if ever you needed
to reference this let's say
in an im policy or whatever other
service needed to communicate with s3
you would need this arn it's very
important piece of information and of
course we have the creation date so some
high level metadata so objects as we
have covered already consist of not only
the data itself
but the metadata so there's lots of
metadata and there's a lot of other
features that we can go here and enable
very easily and this will be the basis
of the future
demonstrations that i'm going to do all
right so just to
recap what we just did
we created a unique bucket
give it a name of
simply learn s3 demo and uploaded our
first object to it
so let's now take a look at
the inner workings of the amazon s3
when we upload an object into a bucket
we have to select
which one of these storage classes the
object will reside in so you see have
six storage classes here at the bottom
and each have their own characteristics
that we're going to get
into
by default
if you don't specify anything it'll get
placed in what's called the s3 standard
storage class which is the most
expensive out of all the storage classes
once your object gets colder and what i
mean by colder is your axis patterns
diminish meaning that you're accessing
that file less and less over the course
of time so it gets colder
you will transition that object from one
tier to the next all the way to for
example s3 deep archive so again deep
archive
signifies extremely cold so maybe you're
only referencing this data once a year
once every couple of years
and so you want to have the cheapest
possible storage
available so right now you can get about
one terabyte of storage per month for
about a dollar a month with s3
glazer deep archive
so you are going to be very interested
in knowing how to transition from one or
more of these storage classes over time
in order to save on your storage costs
that's really why we're doing this so
let's go through some of the storage
classes
by default like i said
whenever you upload an object you
automatically get placed into the
standard storage class so any files that
you're working on
frequently daily this is the best fit
for it you've got the highest level
of accessibility and um durability as
well not that the others don't have the
same level of durability however we'll
see how when you transition from one
storage tier to the next some
characteristics do change in order for
you to save on some cost we're going to
go through some of those
now this would be considered hot data
right data that's used all the time
maybe just by you maybe by everybody
right so that's the perfect place to
place it in the standard storage class
now over time like i said you may find
yourself working
less and less perhaps on a document that
was due by the end of the month that
document was submitted and then
afterwards you don't work on that
document anymore perhaps you're only
working on revisions based on feedback
from your colleagues that are asking you
to make some corrections or some
amendments and so only those
corrections or amendments come in
perhaps once a month and so in that case
you might find yourself
finding a justification for moving that
document from the standard tier to the
standard ia or infrequently accessed
tier
maybe any objects
not modified for more than 30 days are a
good fit for that and that's really the
criteria for ia in active access is that
s3
or aws itself recommends to only put
objects in there if they haven't been
asked access for at least 30 days so you
get a a price reduction a rebate for
putting objects that are not accessed
frequently in here of course if you
remove objects let's say before the 30
day
limit then you are charged a surcharge
for
retrieving an object that you said was
infrequently accessed but it really was
not so bear that in mind if you're going
to place objects in infrequent access
be
somewhat
reasonably assured that you're not going
to be going there and accessing them you
can still access those files no problem
just as quickly they have the same level
of
accessibility and durability however
like i said anything less than 30 days
you'll get a price thing on that
if you want to have long-term storage
we're talking about amazon glacier so
this is more
anything
over 90 days that hasn't been modified
or 180 days there's two subcategories of
amazon glacier that we're going to get
into
and this is the cheapest storage by far
and amazon glacier
doesn't really operate through the aws
console as the same as the standard and
the infrequent access you can't really
upload objects to glacier via the
console in the browser
you can only do so let's say through the
command line interface or through an sdk
the only thing you can do on the
web console with glacier is actually
create what's called a vault which is a
logical container for your archives but
then after that you have to go through
the cli or the sdk to do the rest of the
work there
if we continue on there's some gray
areas between uh the s3 standard and the
glacier one is the
one zone in frequently accessed storage
class so if we go back to the regular
standard and ia storage class all of
these objects are stored across a
minimum of three availability zones
if you want a further price reduction
you can store your objects in a one zone
ia storage class which means that
instead of taking that object and
replicating it across
three or more availability zones it will
only store it in a single availability
zone therefore
reducing
the level of availability that you have
to that object so in this case here if
that single availability zone would go
down for example you would not have
access to that object once it would come
back up of course you would the other
thing is is if there was a
an immense catastrophe where the actual
availability zone was destroyed well of
course then your object is also gone so
if that's something that doesn't worry
you
because you have already many copies of
this object maybe lying around on
premise then this is a good option for
you because it's data that you're
willing to lose or lose access to for
short periods of time if ever that
single availability zone goes down so
it's about an extra 20 off the price
from already the
normal
ia standard price
there is another one called the standard
reduced redundancy storage
this one is kind of getting phased out
as we speak because the same price
for this storage class is about the same
amount you're going to pay for the
normal ia standard class
what this does
is again is a good fit for
your objects that you're not really
worried about losing if there is some
sort of catastrophe that happens in an
availability zone there's less copies of
it
that are stored and so if that data
center and that availability goes down
then you lose your object so of course
it offered at the time the highest price
reduction
possible but now the difference between
this one and the normal ia standard
storage class is so small in terms of
price that you're probably not going to
migrate to
or navigate to this storage class but it
is still there in the documentation and
it may very well come up still
in the
certification exam so at least be aware
of that
let's now take a look at some individual
features of s3 starting off with life
cycle management so life cycle
management is very interesting because
it allows us to come up with a
predefined rule
that will help us automate the
transitioning of objects from one
storage
class to another without us having to
manually copy things over of course you
could imagine how time consuming that
would be if we had to do this manually
so we're going to see this very soon in
a lab however let me discuss how how
this works
so once we it's basically a graphical
user interface it's very very simple to
use once you come up with these
lifecycle management rules but you're
going to define two things you're going
to define the transition action and the
expiration action so the transition
action is going to be something like
well i want to transition an object
from maybe it's all objects or maybe
it's just a specific type of object in a
folder example that has a specific
prefix
from one storage class let's say
standard to standard inactive
or infrequent access
maybe only after 45 days after at least
a minimum of 30 days like we spoke of
before and then maybe after
90 days you want to transition the
objects in ia 2
right away glacier deep archive or 180
days you come up with whatever
combination you see fit okay it doesn't
have to be sequential from s3 to i8 to
one zone et cetera et cetera because
like we discussed before it depends what
kind of objects that you're interested
in putting in one zone objects that you
don't really mind losing if that one
availability zone goes down
so
you're going to be deciding those rules
it ends up that this even is not a
simple task because you have to monitor
your usage patterns to see which data is
hot which data is cold and what's the
best kind of life cycle management to
implement to reap the benefits of the
lowest cost
so you have to put somebody on this job
and
make the best informed decisions based
on your access patterns and that is
something that you need to consistently
monitor
so what we can do is we can instead opt
for something called
s3 intelligent tiering
which basically analyzes your workload
using machine learning algorithms and
after about a good 30 days of analyzing
your access patterns
will automatically be able to
transition your objects from s3 standard
to s3 standard
infrequent access okay it doesn't go
past the ia one doesn't go after the
glacier and whatnot okay so it can then
offer you
um
that
at a reduced um price overhead so there
is a monitoring fee
that is introduced in order to
implement this feature it's a very
nominal very very low monitoring fee
and the nice thing is is if ever you
take out an object out of the infrequent
axis before the 30-day limit as we spoke
of before
you will not be
charged
an overhead charge because of that why
because you're using the intelligence
tearing you're already paying an
overhead for the monitoring fee so at
least in that sense
the intelligent tearing will take the
object out of ia and put it back into
the s3 standard class if you need access
to it before the 30 days
and in that case you won't be charged at
overhead so that is something that is
very
um that is very um good to to to do in
order not to have to put somebody on
that job so yes you're paying a little
bit of overhead for that monitoring fee
but at the other side of the spectrum
you're not investing in somebody
working many hours to
monitor and put into place a system to
monitor your data access patterns so
let's take a look at how to do this
right now let's implement our own
lifecycle management rules
so let's now create a lifecycle rule
inside our bucket
first off we're going to need to go to
the management tab
in the bucket that we just created and
right on the top you see right away life
cycle rule
we're going to create lifecycle rule and
we're going to name it so i'm just going
to say something very
simple like simply
learn
life cycle rule
and we have the option of creating this
rule for every single object
in the bucket or we can limit the scope
to a certain
type of file perhaps with a prefix like
i could see one right now something like
logs so anything
that we categorize as a log file
will transition from one
storage tier to the next as per our
instructions
we're doing this because we really want
to save on costs right it's not so much
of organizing what's your older data
versus your newer data it's more about
reducing that storage cost as your
objects
get less and less used so in this case
logs are a good fit because
perhaps you're using your logs for the
first 30 days you're sifting through
them
you're trying to get insights on them
but then you
kind of
move them out of the way because they
become old data and you don't need them
anymore so we're going to see how we can
transition them to another pricing tier
another storage tier
we could also do this with object tags
which is a very powerful feature
and in the lifecycle rules action you
have to at least pick one of these
options now
since we haven't enabled versioning yet
what i'm going to do is just select
transition the current
version of the object between these
storage classes
so as a reminder of what we already
covered in the slides our storage
classes are right over here so
the one that's missing is obviously
the default standard storage class which
all objects are placed in by default so
what we're going to say is this
we want our objects that are in the
default standard storage class to go to
the standard inactive access storage
class after
30 days and that'll give us a nice
discount on those objects being stored
then we want to add another transition
and let's say we want to transition them
to glacier
after
90 days
and then
as a big finale we want to go to
glacier deep archive you can see the
rest are
grayed out would it make sense to go
back
and maybe after 180 days we want to go
there okay now there's a little bit of
a warning or
call to attention here they're saying if
you're going to store very small files
into glacier not a great idea there's an
overhead in terms of metadata that's
added and also there's an additional
cost associated with storing small files
in glacier so we're just going to
acknowledge that of course for the
demonstration that's fine in real life
you don't want to store very big tar
files or zip files that had you know one
or more log files in there okay that
would bypass that that surcharge that
you would get
and over here you have the timeline
summary of everything we selected up
above so we have here after 30 days the
standard inactive access after 90 days
glacier and after 180 days
glacier deep archive so let's go and
create that rule
all right so we see that the rule is
already enabled and at any time you
could go back and disable this if ever
you had a reason to do so we can easily
delete it as well or view the details
and and edit as well so if we go back to
our bucket now what i've done
is created that prefix with the slash
logs since we're not doing this from the
command line we're going to create a
logs folder over here that will fit that
prefix so create logs
create folder
and now we're going to upload our let's
say apache log files in here so we're
going to upload
one demonstration apache log file that
i've created with just one line in there
of course just for demonstration
purposes we're going to upload that
and now we have let's close that and now
we have our apache log file in there so
what's going to happen because we have
that
life cycle rule in place after 30 days
anything any file that has the logs
prefix or basically is placed inside
this folder will be transitioned as per
that life cycle road policy that we just
created so congratulations you just
created your first
s3 lifecycle rule policy
let's now move over to bucket policies
so bucket policies are going to
allow
or deny access to not only the bucket
itself but the objects within those
buckets to either specific
users
or other services
that are inside the aws network
now these policies fall under the
category of i am policy so im stands for
identity
and access management and this is a
whole other topic that deals with
security at large so there are no
services in aws
which are allowed to access other
services or data for example within s3
without you explicitly
allowing it through these im policies so
one of the ways we do that is by
attaching one of these policies which
are written in a json format so it's a
text file that we write
at the end of the day that's the
artifact and that's a good thing because
we can use that artifact
and we can configuration control it in
our source control and version it and
put it alongside our source code
so we deploy everything it is part of
our deployment package
so in this case here we have several
ways of doing this we can use what's
called the policy generator which is a
graphical user interface that allows us
to simply click and point and populate
certain text boxes
which will then
generate that json document that will
allow us to attach that to our s3 bucket
and that will determine like i said
which users or services have access to
whatever api actions are available for
that resource so we might say we want
certain users to be able just to
list the contents
of this bucket not necessarily be able
to delete or upload new objects into
that bucket so you can get very
fine-grained permissions
based on the kind of actions you want to
allow on this resource so in order to
really
bring this home let's go and perform our
very own lab on this
let's now see how to create an s3
bucket policy
going back to our bucket we're now going
to go into permissions
so the whole point of coming up with a
bucket policy is that we want to control
who or what the what being other
services have access to our bucket and
our objects within our bucket so there
are several ways we can go about doing
this let's edit a bucket policy
one we can go and look at a whole bunch
of pre-canned examples which is a good
thing to do
two we could
actually go in here and code the json
document ourselves which is much more
difficult of course so what we're going
to do is we're going to look at a policy
generator which is really
a form based graphical user interface
that allows us to generate
through the
answers that we're going to give here
the json document for us
first question is we've got to select
the policy type of course we're dealing
with s3 so it makes sense for us to
create an s3 bucket policy
the two options available to us are
allowing or denying
access to
our s3 bucket now in this case here we
could get really
fine grained and specify certain kinds
of services or certain kinds of users
but for the demonstration we're just
going to select star which means
anything or anybody can access
this s3 bucket all right now depending
on
also the actions that we're going to
allow so in this case here we can get
very fine-grained and we have all these
check boxes that we can check off to
give access to certain kind of api
action so we can say we want to give
access to you know just deleting the
bucket which obviously is something very
powerful
but you can get more fine grain as you
can see you have more of the getters
over here
and you have more of the
the the listing and the putting new
objects in there as well so you can get
very fine grain now for demonstration
purposes we're going to say all action
so this is a very
broad and wide
permission something that you really
should think twice about before doing
we're basically saying we want to allow
everybody
and anything any service
all api actions on this s3 bucket so
that's no
small thing
we need to specify the amazon resource
name the arn of that bucket specifically
so what we're going to do is go back to
our bucket
and you can see here
the bucket arn okay so we're just going
to copy this
paste it in this policy generator and
just say
add statement you can see here kind of a
resume of what we just did and we're
going to say generate policy
and this is where it creates for us and
make this a little bit bigger for us
it creates that json document so we're
going to take this we're going to copy
it
and we're going to paste it into
the
generator okay now of course we could
flip this and change this to a deny
right which would basically say we don't
want anybody to have access or any thing
any other service to have access to this
s3 bucket we could even say
slash star
to also encapsulate all the objects
within that bucket so if i save this
right now
you have a very ironclad
s3 bucket policy which basically denies
all access
to this bucket and the objects within of
course this is on the other side of the
spectrum very very secure so we might
want to for example
host a static website
through our s3 bucket so in this case
here allowing access would make more
sense
right so if i save changes
you see that we get an error here saying
that we don't have permissions to do
this and the reason for that is because
it realizes that this is extremely
permissive so in order to give access to
every single object within this bucket
as in the case that i was stating of a
static website being hosted on your s3
bucket it would be much better to also
at first enable that option so i'm just
going to duplicate the tab here
and once you go back to the permissions
tab
one of the first things that shows up is
this
block public access setting right right
now it's completely blocked and that's
what's stopping us from saving our
policy we would have to go in here
unblock it and save it right and it's
also kind of like a double clutch
feature you have to confirm that just so
you don't do that by accident
right so now what you've effectively
done is you've really opened up the
floodgates
to
have public access to this bucket it's
something that can't be accidentally
done
it's kind of like
having to perform these two actions
before the public access can be granted
now historically
this was something that aws was
was guilty of was making it too easy to
have public access so now we have this
double clutch now that this is enabled
or turned off we can now save
our changes here successfully
and you can see here that now it's
publicly accessible which is a big red
flag that perhaps this is not something
that you're interested in doing now if
you're hosting a public website
and you want everybody just to have read
access to every single object in your
bucket
yes this is fine however please make
sure that you
pay very close attention to this type of
access flagged over here on the console
so congratulations you just
got introduced to your first
bucket policy a permissive one but at
least now you know how to go through
that graphical user interface through
the policy generator and create them and
paste them inside your s3 bucket policy
pane
so let's continue on with data
encryption so any data that you place in
s3 bucket can be encrypted at rest very
easily
using an aes 256 encryption key so we
can have server-side encryption we could
have aws handle
all the encryption for us and the
decryption will also be handled by aws
when we request our objects later on but
we could also have client-side
encryption where we
the client that are uploading the object
have to be responsible for also passing
over our own
generated key that will eventually be
used by aws to then encrypt that object
on the bucket side of course once that
happens then the key is discarded the
client key is discarded and you have to
be very mindful that since you've
decided to handle your own encryption
client-side encryption that if ever you
lose those keys well that data is not
going to be recoverable in that bucket
on the aws network so be very careful on
that point
we can also
have a very useful feature called
versioning which will allow you to have
a history of all the changes of an
object over time so versioning sounds
exactly how it's named every time you
make a modification to a file and upload
that
new version to s3 it will have a brand
new
version id associated with that so over
time you get a sort of stack
of a history of all the file changes
over time so you can see here at the
bottom
you have an id with all these ones and
then an id with one two one two one two
so
eventually if ever you wanted to revert
back to a previous version you could do
so
by
accessing one of those previous versions
of course versioning is not an option
that's enabled by default you have to go
ahead and enable that yourself it is an
extremely simple thing to do
and so there may be a situation where
you already have objects within your
buckets
and you only then enable versioning well
versioning would only apply
to the new objects that would get
uploaded from the point that you enabled
versioning the objects that were there
before that point will not
get a specific version number attached
in fact they will have
a sort of null marker
the version number that will get
attached to them it's only after that
you
modify those objects later on and upload
a new version that they will get their
own version numbers
so right now what we're going to be
doing is
a lab on actual
versioning so let's go ahead and do that
right now
in this lab we're going to see how to
enable versioning in our buckets
enable versioning is very easy we're
simply going to click on our bucket go
into properties and there is going to be
a bucket versioning section
i'm going to click on edit and enable it
once that's done
any new objects
that are uploaded to that s3 bucket will
now benefit from
being tracked by a version number so if
you upload
objects with the same file name after
that they'll each have a different
version number so you'll have version
tracking a history of the changes for
that object
let's actually go there and upload a new
file
i'll upload one
called index.html
so we're going to simulate a situation
where
we've decided we're going to use an s3
bucket as the source of our static
website to deploy one and in this
index.html file if you take a look
right now let's take a look at what's in
there you can see that we have welcome
to my website and we're at version two
okay so if i click on this file right
now
and i go to
i can clearly see that there's some
version activity that's happening here
okay
we have here
um
at 1456 which is the latest one the
latest one is on the top the current
version we have a specific version
id and then we have a sort of history of
what's going on here
now i purposely enabled versioning
before
and then try to
delete version or disable versioning but
here's the thing with versioning you
cannot disable it fully once it's
enabled you can only
suspend it
right now suspending means
that whatever version numbers those
objects had before you decided to
suspend it
will remain so you can see i have an
older version here that has
an older version number and at this
point here i decided to suspend
versioning and so what it does instead
of disabling the entire history it puts
what's called a delete marker
okay
you could always roll back to that
version if you want
now in the demonstration when we started
it together i
enabled it again
so you can see this is
actually the brand new version number as
we did it together but you don't lose
the history of
previous versioning if ever you had
suspended before so that's something to
keep in mind right and it'll come up in
the exam where they'll ask can you
actually disable versioning once it's
enabled and the answer is no you can
only suspend it and your history is
still maintained
now we have that version there and let's
say i come to this file
and i want to up
grade this i don't know i say version
three right and now what's going to
happen
is
if i click on this version just as the
current one with version two and i open
this we should see
version two which is fine that's that's
that's expected
if we go back to
our
bucket and upload that new version file
that has version three in there
don't just modify it
we should now see
in that index.html file a brand new
version that was created
under the versions tab
and there you go
1458 just two minutes after
you can see here we have a brand new
version id
right and if i open this one
you can see version three so now you
have a way to enable versioning very
easily in your buckets and you also
have seen what happens when you want to
suspend versioning what happens to the
history of those versions files before
just to actually go back here to the
properties
where we enabled versioning the first
place if i were to go back in here and
disable it like i said you can't disable
you can only suspend and that's where
that delete marker gets placed but all
your previous versions
retained their version id
so don't forget that because that will
definitely be a question on your exam if
you're interested in taking the
certification exam so congratulations
you just learned how to
enable
versioning
let's move on
to cross region replication or crr as it
is known there will be many times when
you find yourself with objects
in a bucket and you want to share those
objects
with another bucket now that other
bucket could be within the same account
could be within another account within
the same region or could be within a
separate account
in
a different region so there's varying
levels of degree there the good thing is
is all of those
combinations are available so crr
if we're talking about cross-region
replication is really about replicating
objects across regions something that is
not enabled by default because that will
incur a replication charge because it's
syncing objects across
regions of course
you are spanning a very wide area
network in that case so there is a
surcharge for that
now
doing so is quite simple to do
but one of the things that we have to be
mindful of is to give permissions for
the source bucket which has the
originals
to allow
for this copying of objects to the
destination bucket so if we're doing
this across regions of course we would
have to come up with im policies and we
would also have to exchange credentials
in terms of
im user credentials in terms of account
ids and and such
we're going to be doing a demonstration
in the same account in the same region
but
largely this would be the same steps if
we're going to go cross region so this
is something you might find yourself
doing if you want to share data with
other
entities in your company maybe you're
multinational and you want to have all
your lock files copied over to another
bucket in another region for another
team to analyze to extract business
insights from or it might just be that
you want to aggregate data in a separate
data lake in an s3 bucket in another
region or like i said it could be even
in the same region or in the same
account so it's all about organizing
moving data around across objects across
these boundaries and let's actually go
through a demonstration and see how we
can do crr
let's now see how we can perform cross
region replication
we're going to take all the new objects
that are going to be uploaded in the
simply learn s3 demo bucket and we're
going to replicate them into a
destination bucket so what we're first
gonna do is create a new bucket
okay
and we'll just
tack on the number two here and this
will be our destination bucket where all
those objects will be replicated to
we're gonna demonstrate this within the
same account but it's the exact same
steps
when doing this across regions
one of the requirements when performing
cross region replication is to enable
versioning so if you don't do this you
can do it at a later time but it is
necessary to enable it at some point in
time before
coming up with a cross region
replication rule
all right so let me create that bucket
and now after the bucket is created i
want to go to the source bucket and i
want to configure
under the managements tab here
a replication rule
so i'm going to create a replication
rule
call it
simply learn
rep rule
and i'm going to enable this right off
the bat
the source bucket of course is the
simply learn s3 demo we could apply this
to all objects in the bucket or perform
a filter once again let's keep it simple
this time and apply to all objects in
the bucket of course caveat here this
will only now apply to any new objects
that are uploaded into this source
bucket and not the ones that are already
pre-existing there okay now in terms of
the a destination bucket we want to
select the one we just created so we can
choose a bucket in this account or if we
really want to go cross region or
another account in another region we
could specify this and put in the
account id and the bucket name and that
other account
so we're going to stay in the same
account we're going to browse and select
the newly created bucket
and we're also going to need permissions
for the source bucket to
dump those objects into the destination
bucket so we can either create the role
ahead of time or we can ask this user
interface to create a new role for us so
we'll opt for that
and we'll skip these additional
features over here that we're not going
to talk about in this demonstration i'm
just going to save this so that will
create
our replication rule that is
automatically enabled for us right now
so let's take a look at the overview
here you can see it's been enabled just
to double check the destination bucket
is the demo two we're talking about
the same region
[Music]
and again here we could opt for
additional um
parameters like different storage
classes in the destination bucket that
that object is going to be deposited in
etc etc for now we just created a simple
rule
now if we go back to
the original source bucket which we're
in right now
and we upload a new file
which will be transactions file in a csv
format
once this is uploaded
that cross region replication rule
will kick in and will eventually right
it's not immediate but will eventually
copy
the file inside the demo 2 bucket now i
know it's not there already so what i'm
going to do is pause the video and come
back in two minutes and when i click on
this the file should be in there
okay so let's now double check and make
sure that object has been replicated
and there it is been replicated as per
our rule so congratulations you just
learned how to perform your first
same account s3 bucket region
replication rule
let's now take a look at transfer
acceleration
so transfer acceleration is all about
giving your end users the best possible
experience when they're accessing
information in your bucket so you want
to give them the lowest
latency possible you can imagine if you
were serving a website
and you wanted people to have the lowest
latency possible of course that's
something that's very desirable so in
terms of traversing long distances if
you have your bucket
that is in for example
the u.s east one region in the united
states in the virginia region and you
had users let's say in london that want
to access those objects of course they
would have to traverse a longer
distance than users that were based in
the united states and so if you wanted
to bring those objects closer
to them in terms of latency then we
could take advantage of what's called
the amazon cloudfront delivery network
the cdn network which extends the aws
backbone by providing what's called
edge location so edge locations are
really data centers that are placed in
major city centers where our end users
mostly are located more densely
populated areas and your objects will be
cached in those locations so if we go
back to the example of your end users
being in london
well
they would be accessing a cached copy of
those objects that were stored in the
original bucket in the for example u.s
east one region
of course
you will get most likely a dramatic
performance
increase by enabling transfer
accelerations very simple to enable this
just bear in mind that when you do so
that you will incur
a charge for using this feature
best thing to do is to show you
how to go ahead and do this so let's do
that right now
let's now take a look at how to enable
transfer acceleration on our
simply learn s3 demo bucket
by simply going to the properties tab we
can scroll down
and look for
a heading called transfer acceleration
over here
and very simply just enable it
so what does this do
this allows us to take advantage of
what's called the content delivery
network the cdn
which extends the aws network backbone
the cdn network is
strategically placed into more densely
populated areas for example major city
centers and so if your end users
are situated in these more densely
populated areas they will reap the
benefits of having transfer acceleration
enabled because
the latency that they will experience
will be
severely decreased so their performance
is going to be enhanced if we take a
look at the speed comparison page for
transfer acceleration we can see that
once the page is finished loading it's
going to do a comparison it's going to
perform first of all what's called a
multi-part upload and it's going to see
how fast
that upload was done
with or without transfer acceleration
enabled now this is relative to where i
am running this test so right now i'm
actually running it from europe so you
can see that i'm getting very very good
results if i would enable transfer
acceleration and my users were based in
virginia so of course now i have
varying
differences in percentage
as i go closer
or further away from my
region where my bucket or my browser is
being
is being referenced so you can see here
united states i'm getting pretty good
uh percentages as i go closer to europe
it gets lower of course but still very
very good frankfurt again this is about
us probably at the worst i'm going to be
getting here since i'm situated in
europe
and of course as i go
look more towards you know the asian
regions you can see once again it kind
of scales up in terms of better
performance so of course this is an
optional feature once you enable it as i
just showed over here
this is a feature that you pay
additionally for
so bear that in mind make sure that you
take a look at the pricing page in order
to figure out
how much this is going to cost you so
that is it congratulations you just
learned how to
simply enable transfer acceleration to
lower the latency
from the end user's point of view
we're now ready to wrap things up in our
conclusion
and go over at a very high level what we
just spoke about so we talked about what
s3 is which is a core service one of the
original services published by aws in
order for us to have
unlimited object storage in a secure
scalable and durable fashion we took a
look at other aspects
of s3 in terms of the benefits we mainly
focused on the cost savings that we can
attain
in s3 by looking at different storage
classes now of course s3 is
industry recognized as one as the
cheapest object storage
services out there that has the most
features available we saw what goes into
the object storage in terms of creating
first our buckets which are our
containers
high level containers in order for us to
store our objects in again
objects are really an abstraction of the
type of data that are in there
as well as the metadata associated with
those objects
we took a look at the different storage
tiers
the default being the standard
all the way to the cheapest one which is
the glacier which are meant for long
term archived objects for example log
files that you may hold on to for a
couple of years may not need to access
routinely and we'll have the cheapest
pricing option
by far so we have many pricing tiers and
if you want to transition from one tier
to the next you would implement a life
cycle policy or use the intelligent
tiering option that can do much of this
for you we took a look at some very
interesting features
starting from the life cycle management
policies that we just talked about all
the way to
versioning cross region replication and
transfer acceleration so
with this conclusion you are now ready
to at least start working with s3 hello
everybody my name is kent and today
we're going to be covering aws
identity and access management also
known as i am
tutorial by simply learn
so these are the topics which we'll be
covering today
we'll be defining what aws security is
the different types of security in aws
what exactly is identity and access
management
the benefits of identity and access
management how
im works
its components
its features and at the end we are going
to do a great demo on i am with
multi-factor authentication and users
and groups so without any further ado
let's get started
so let's get started with what is aws
security
your organization may span
many regions or many accounts and you
may encompass hundreds if not thousands
of different types of resources that
need to be secured and therefore you're
going to need a way to secure all that
sensitive data in a consistent
way across all those accounts in your
organization while meeting any
compliancy and confidentiality standards
that have to be met so for example if
you're dealing with health care data or
credit card information or personal
identification information like
addresses
this is something that needs to be
thought out across your organization so
of course we have individual services in
aws which we will explore
in this video however in order to govern
the whole process
at an organizational level we have aws
security hub now aws security hub is
known as a cspm which stands for a cloud
security posture management tool so what
does that really mean well
it's going to encompass like i said all
these tools underneath the hood in order
to bring a streamlined
way for you to organize and adhere to
these standards across organization
it'll identify
any misconfiguration issues and
compliant risks
by continuously monitoring your cloud
infrastructure for the gaps in your
security pulse reinforcements
now why is that important
well these misconfiguration
can lead to unwanted data breaches and
also
data leakages so in order to govern this
at a very high level like i said we need
to incorporate aws security hub that
will automate and manage all these
underlying services for us in order to
perhaps take automated
action we call that remediary actions
and
you can approve these actions
manually or you can automate those
actions as you see fit across your
organization so let's delve a little bit
deeper into what is aws security and
then we'll start looking individually at
some of these services
and so
our organization has special needs
across different projects and
environments so of course
the production development test
environments all are going to have their
own unique needs however it doesn't
matter
which project or which business unit
we're talking about what are their
storage backups needs they should all be
implemented in a concise standardized
weight across your organization to meet
that compliancy we were just talking
about so we want to automate all these
tedious manual tasks that we've been
doing like ensuring that perhaps our
buckets and s3 are all encrypted or all
our ebs volumes are encrypted and we
want to have
an automated process in place in order
to
give us time
on other aspects of our business perhaps
our application development to bring
better business value and that allows to
grow and innovate the company and a way
that's best suited for it
so let's take a look at the different
types of aws security
now there are many different types of
security services out there however
we're going to concentrate primarily on
i am in this video tutorial so i like to
think of i am as
the glue between
all aws services because by default we
don't have permission for any one
service to communicate with another so
let's just take for example an ec2
instance that wants to retrieve an
object from s3 well those two services
could not
interact unless we interacted with i am
so something that's extremely important
to learn and by the end of this video
tutorial you'll be able to understand
what im is
we have amazon guard duty here which is
all about logs basically aggregates all
logs from example cloudtrail which we
still haven't talked about at the end of
this list over here but instead of
looking at cloudtrail
individually guard duty will actually
take a look at trail
cloudtrail we'll take a look at your vpc
flow logs and we'll take a look at your
dns logs and monitor that account and
your network and your data access via
machine learning algorithms and it'll id
any threat
where
you can automatically remediate the
workflow that you've approved so for
example
if you know of a malicious ip address
that's making api calls well those api
calls are registered in cloudtrail right
so
this machine learning algorithm will be
able to detect that and take action
so this is
really
governed at a higher level than you
having to you know individually inspect
all your dns locks flow logs and cloud
trails individually and take action
through some scripting fashion that that
you've come up with so guard duty
manages all that
we have amazon macy which once again
uses machine learning but also uses
pattern matching pattern matching can be
used with
matching
kind of libraries that are already in
place or you can come up with your own
pattern matching and that's used to
discover
and protect your sensitive data so for
example if you had health care data also
known as hipaa compliancy or credit card
data that's lying around well macy will
discover it and will protect it
so as your data grows across
organization that might be harder and
harder to do in your own way so macy
really facilitates uh discovering and
protecting that so you can concentrate
on other things
aws config is something that kind of
works in tandem with all the other
services it's able to continuously
monitor your resources configurations
and ensure that they match your desired
configuration so for example
maybe you state that your s3 bucket
should be encrypted by default all of
them or you want to make sure that your
im
user access keys are rotated and if
they're not then take remediary action
so a lot of these automated remediary
actions right are
basically executed via aws config so
you'll see the aws config actually used
by other services underneath the hood
and then you have cloudtrail cloudtrail
is all about logging every single type
of api call that's made so it'll
it'll always record the api call who
made it from what source ip
the parameters that were sent
with the api
the response
all that data which is really a gold
mine for you to investigate if there's
any security threat and again
this
trail over here and there can be many
and there's lots and lots of data
generated by these trails can be
analyzed by these other services
specifically guard duty here
and that automates that process so you
don't have to
so let's get to the next one which is
what is identity and access management
so what is i am
like i said im is the glue between all
aws services
it will
allow those services to communicate with
each other once you
put im into place
the other thing is is that allow us to
manage our aws users which are known as
im users and group them together in two
groups to facilitate
assigning and retrieving or removing
permissions from them
instead of doing it on an individual
scale so of course if you had
200 im users and you wanted one shot to
add a permission to
a group that contained 200 item users
well you can do that in one operation
instead of 200.
now we do have a distinction between i
am users and end users and users use
applications online or as im users
are your employees in your organization
that are interacting directly with aws
resources so for example an ec2 instance
would be a resource that let's say a
developer would be interacting with and
traditionally those are resources that
are used
full time from nine to five let's say
five days a week 365 days a year okay
now sometimes those users have to have
elevated permissions for a temporary
amount of time and that is more suited
for a role and that will eliminate the
need to create separate accounts
just for you know
type of actions that are needed for
let's say an hour a month or two hours a
week or something like that something
like backing up an ec2 instance removing
some files doing some cleanups
traditionally you don't have those
permissions as a developer
but
you can be given temporary permissions
to assume this role so it's kind of like
putting a hat on your head and
pretending you're somebody that you're
usually not for a temporary amount of
time once you take off the hat you go
back to being your old boring imuser
self which doesn't have access to
performing backups or cleanups and stuff
like that so
the roles interact with a service called
a secure token service which gives us
specific keys threes
specifically an access key a secret key
much like a username and password and
then we have a token key which only
gives you access to this role this
elevated permission for 1 to 12 hours so
we'll talk more about roles
as we go on through this video tutorial
but it's important that you at least
remember at this point even if you don't
know all the details that roles have to
do with
temporary permissions elevated
permissions
so what are the benefits of im
well
across our organization
we're going to have many accounts and
like i said hundreds if not thousands of
resources so scalability is going to be
an issue if we don't have a very high
level
uh visibility and control over the
entire security process
and once we have a tool like for example
security hub which we saw on the first
slide we can continuously monitor
and maintain a standard across our
organization so very very important to
have that visibility
and we do when we integrate with aws
security
now we also need to eliminate the human
factor right so
um
we don't want to manually
put out fires every single time of
course there will be times when
something new occurs that we've never
seen before that that you know will be
needed however
once an occurrence happens and reoccurs
we can obviously come up with a plan to
remediate the action so
once we automate we can definitely
reduce the time to fix
that reoccurring error or it could be a
new error that we don't have to interact
with because we're using machine
learning algorithm services like i was
talking about like our duty or macy
and we can really reduce the risk
of
security intrusions and data leakage and
such by using im to facilitate this of
course
you may have many compliance needs you
may be dealing
with applications that use health care
data or credit card information for
payments
or
you might be dealing with a government
agency let's say in the u.s that has
certain compliancy
requirements that needs assurances that
if their data is stored on the cloud
that you're still following the same
compliance controls that you were let's
say on premise so we have a very very
long list
of compliance requirements that each aws
service
adheres to and you can go on the um aws
documentation online and you could
figure out if for example
dynamodb is compliant with hipaa
compliancy and it is and so you can be
sure that you can use that so aws itself
has to constantly maintain these
compliancy controls in place and they
themselves have to pass all these
certifications and that gets passed on
to us so much less work for us to
implement these compliance controls we
can just inherit them by using aws a
security model by im
and last but not least we can build the
highest standards for privacy and data
security
now having
all this on our own
on-premise data center
poses security challenges especially
physical security challenges you have to
physically secure the data center you
might have
security personnel that you need to
hire
24 7 camera surveillance etc etc so just
by migrating to the cloud we can
take advantage of aws's global
infrastructure they're very very good at
building data centers that's part of
their business and securing them so of
course we have a shared security model
in place however you can rest assured
that at least as the lowest common
denominator
physical security has been put into
place for us again
as other services are used more managed
services or more higher-end services
used in aws more and more of that
security model will be aws
responsibility and less yours
we will always have a certain type of
responsibility for our applications but
we can again use these high-level
services to ensure that our ability to
encrypt the data at rest and in transit
are always maintained by coming up with
specific rules that need to be adhered
to
and if those rules are not adhered to
then we have remediary actions that take
place in order to maintain again that
cross account or organizational wide
security control okay so lots of
benefits of using i am and let's now
take a look at exactly how im works and
delve deeper into
authentication and authorization
so there are certain terms here that we
need to
know about one of them is principle now
principle is nothing more than an entity
that is trying to interact with an aws
service for example an ec2 instance or
an s3 bucket now that could be a user an
im user it could be even a service or it
could be a role so we're going to take a
look how principles need to be specified
inside i am policies
authentication
so authentication is exactly how it
sounds who are you could be something as
simple as username and password or it
could involve an email address example
if you're the root user of the account
when you're creating the account for the
very first time
other normal users will not need to log
in with their user
email it'll only be the root user that
needs that
you could also have developer type
access which needs
access let's say via command line
interface or a software development kit
also known as an sdk
now for those kind of access
points we're going to need
access keys and secret keys or public
private keys let's say if you want to
even authenticate and log in through ssh
to an ec2 instance so there are many
different types of authentication that
we could set up when creating i end
users based on what kind of access they
need do they just need access to the
console do they need access to just
services uh in terms of as a
programmatic needs
so those are different types of
authentication
and then we have the actual request now
we could make a request in aws through
various ways we're going to be exploring
that via the console the aws console
however every button you click every
drop down list you select that invokes
an api call behind the scenes so
everything goes behind a
centralized well documented api every
service has an api so if you're dealing
with
lambda let's say well lambda has an api
if you're dealing with ec2 ec2 has an
api
now you could interact with that api
like i said via the console
indirectly you can use a command line
interface you can use an sdk for your
favorite programming language like
python
so all of them get funneled through all
your requests get funneled through an
api but that doesn't mean you're allowed
to do everything just because we know
who you are and you have
access to some keys let's say to make
some api calls you have to be authorized
in order to perform certain actions so
maybe you're only authorized to
communicate with dynamodb and also maybe
you're only authorized to perform reads
and not right so we can get some very
fine-grained
authorization through some in policies
in order to control not only who has
access
to our aw resist but what they're
allowed to do so very fine grained
actions read actions right actions both
maybe just describe or list some buckets
so depending on the aws user that's
logged in we can control exactly what
actions because every api has fine
grained actions that we can control
through im
and of course many many different types
of resource
when we're coming up with these policies
all these
actions can be grouped into resources so
perhaps we can say
well this user only has access or read
only access to s3 specifically these
buckets
and
can write to
a dynamodb table but cannot
terminate or shut down an ec2 instance
so all these kind of actions can be
grouped into resources on a pro-resource
basis based on the kind of role you have
in
the projects or in the company
so now let's take a look at the
components of im
we've already seen that we can create i
am users
and that how they are different than
your normal end users
now those entities represent a person
that's working for organization that can
interact with aws services
and some of those permissions that we
assign through what's called identity
based policies to such a user will have
permissions for example that are always
necessary every time that they're logged
in so perhaps this
user tom always needs access to the
following services over here for example
an rds instance or an s3 bucket etc etc
and sometimes they will need temporary
access to other
services for example dynamodb
so in those cases there would be a
combination of normal im policies
assigned to the user
and certain
assume role calls done at runtime in
order to acquire this temporary
credential elevated permission
there is also
the root user
which is different than your
typical super user administrator access
there are some things that a root user
can do
that administrator access cannot
for example a root user
first of all logs in with their email
address
and can also have the option to change
that email address something that is
very tightly coupled
to the aws account so you cannot change
the email address with an administrator
account
the other thing your user can do is they
can change the support contract
they can also
view billing information or taxes
information that information for example
so the best thing to do the best
practice is that once you've created
your
aws account
you are obviously the root user the best
thing to do is to enable multi-factor
authentication
store away those keys in a secure
location and your first administrative
task should be to create an
administrator super user
from which that point on you will log in
as only an administrative user and you
will create other type of administrative
users and those administrative users
will create other i am users so
never log into your aws account as a
root user unless you need to access that
specific functionality
that i said that is over and above a
super user administrator account
so here we have a set of im users and
we could assign
to them directly im policies which give
them access to certain services however
the best practice is to create groups
which is just a collection of im users
and suppose we have a developer group
and a group of
security administrators of course we
could assign
different types of policies to that
group and every user that is
assigned to the developer group will
inherit those im
permissions makes it much easier to
manage
your im users this way
for
and for the fact that also you can have
users that can be
assigned to groups as you can see here
but
what's not shown here that is possible
as well is you could have a user that is
part of
two groups at the same time the thing
that you cannot have though is the
notion of sub group so i can't extend
this group and create a smaller
group of developers out of this big
group here so we don't have hierarchical
groups
but we do allow users to partake in
different
groups at the same time so they will
inherit those permissions those iem
policy permissions from for example if
user a was part of developers and user a
was part of security they would inherit
these two policy uh statements over here
now there is another type of iam policy
and that is called a resource-based
policy so resource-based policies are
not attached directly to for example
users but they're attached more to
resources like
an s3 bucket for example and so when you
have such a case a user group can't be
designated
as a principle to a group that's just
one of the restrictions however there
are other ways to get around that
as i said
when you think of an i am role i want
you to think
that these are temporary credentials
that are required at runtime
and are only good for a specific amount
of time
now an iem roll is really made up of two
components we have what's called a trust
policy
so who do you trust to assume this role
who do you would trust to even make an
api call to assume the role after that
we have an iron policy once you've been
trusted to assume the role and you get
those temporary tokens what are you
allowed to do maybe you're allowed to
have read write access
to the dynamodb
so
here we have no long-term credentials
that are connected to role you do not
assign
a role to a user the user or service
will assume the rova api call via the
secure token service sts and with those
temporary credentials we'll then be able
to access for example an ec2 instance if
the im policy attached to the item role
says that you can do so
so your users
and your applications perhaps running on
an ec2 instance and the awf aws services
themselves
don't normally have access to the aws
resources but through assuming a role
they can dynamically
attain those permissions at runtime
so it's a very flexible model
that allow you to bypass the need to
embed
security credentials
all over the place and then have to
maintain those credentials and make sure
they're rotated and they're not
acquired by anybody trying to find a
security hole in your system so from a
maintenance point of view they're really
an excellent tool to use
in your
toolbox your security toolbox
so let's take a look at the components
of i am we have the i am policy
over here which is really just a json
document
and that json document will describe
what this user
can do if it's attached directly to it
or if the iron policy is attached to the
group whatever
user is attached to that group will also
have
the same policy inherited so these are
more long-term credentials in terms of
or permissions rather that are attached
to your login for the duration of your
login whereas roles are as we've already
stated temporary and again once you've
established a trust relationship then we
can assign a policy for example a policy
that gives you only read only access to
a cloud trail to a role now it's up to
the user to assume that role either
through the console or through some
programmatic means whichever way is
performed
the user will have to make a direct or
indirect call to sts for the assume roll
call
now these permissions are examined by
aws
when a user submits a request so this
all happens at runtime dynamically so
when you change a policy it will take
effect pretty much immediately as soon
as
the user makes the next request that new
security policy whether you've just
added or removed the permission will
take immediate effect so what we're
going to do now is just really quickly
go to the aws console and actually show
you how an im policy looks like
so i've just logged into my aws
management console and if i search for
identity and access management it should
be the first one to show up i'll just
click on that and i want to show you
actually how these i am policies look
like if you go to the left hand side
here there's an entry for policies
and there are different types of
policies that we can filter out so let's
filter them out by type we have customer
managed we have aws managed and more in
line with job functions that aws managed
also so we're going to take a look at
aws manage all that means is that aws
has created
and will actually update maintain these
pre-established and already vetted
identity policies i am identity policy
so i could further down
maybe
look at all the s3 policies that are
available and we can see there are some
that allows only read only access
there are some that will give us full
access
and there are of course other types here
that we're not all going to explore but
let's just easily
kind of take a look here at the full
access you can see it's just a
json document
and of course you cannot modify it since
this is a managed
policy however you can copy it and
modify it in that case it will become a
a
your own version of it and so it'll be a
customer defined and so when you go here
and you
do a filter you can filter on your own
customer
managed policies
so over here we are simply allowing
certain actions right we talked about
actions before that were based on api so
here we have an api that starts with s3
so this is for the s3 api and instead of
filtering out exactly specifically
what api calls are there we're basically
saying all api calls so star
representing all api actions and again
there is another
category of s3 which deals with object
lambda and we are allowing
all operations on that specific api as
well
we could if this was our own customer
managed
ident
policy actually scale down on which
resource which bucket let's say or which
folder in a bucket
this would apply to but in this case
since this is a full access we're
basically
being given permission to
execute every single api action under s3
for all buckets we're going to see in
the lab where the demonstration at the
end of this
tutorial that i'm going to show you how
to scale that down okay
so that's how an im
policy looks like and if you want to
assign an im policy to a user well stay
tuned for the demonstration at the end
of the video tutorial what's not at the
end of video tutorial is really how to
create a role so i'll show you what a
role is here again there's a whole bunch
of roles already uh set up that we can
go and and take a look at here but we
can go and create our own role as well
and i might create a role
for example that gives
an ec2 let's choose choose ec2
access to s3 so if i click
ec2 and click next permissions
i can actually assign
the s3 permission
right over here just a policy just like
we took a look at
obviously assign it a tag and review it
and i'm just going to call this
my ec2 role
2s3
create the role
and because i selected
ec2
as a
service it automatically will include
that in the trust policy so now when i
go and i create an ec2 instance i can
attach this row to that ec2 instance and
that ec2 instance will automatically be
able to if we're using the linux 2mi
let's say have access to or full admin
access to any s3 bucket
in the
aws account so let's go take a look at
where we would actually attach that role
on the ec2
so when you're creating an ec2 let's
just say we go here we say launch an ec2
instance
and we'll pick this ami over here
because it'll already include the
packages necessary to perform the assume
rule call to sts4a so we won't have to
code that
and we don't have to embed any
credential keys
in order to get this running which is
really good which is the whole point of
what i'm doing because by assuming a
role i don't have to manage that
and i'm just going to pick the free
t2 micro and it is here once you you
know pick whatever you need whatever vpc
and whatnot then you come to the i am
roll and you select the roll to be
assumed dynamically now i have a whole
bunch of them here but this is the one
that
i had created here my ec2 roll to s3 and
if i go and i launched this
ec2 instance and then i had an
application let's say that i needed to
contact s3 or even if i went on the
command line of the ec2 instance i would
be able now to communicate with the s3
service because
they would use they being aws would
actually use this role to perform an
assume roll call to get those temporary
sts tokens for me which will then allow
me to
access my im policy which gives me full
access to s3 and off i go so this is a
great way like i said to avoid having to
administrate any embedded keys in this
ec2 instance and i could take this role
away at any time as well
so there you have it a little
demonstration on how to create a role
how to attach it to an ec2 instance and
also how manage and customer
managed policies
look like
in i am
of course there is also
the fact that we have multiple accounts
and so
we could assign a policy
that will also allow a user in another
account
access to our account so cross account
access is something that's very
very well needed and also is a feature
of i am so when you need to share access
to
resources from one account to another in
your organization
we are
in need of
an i am policy to facilitate that so
also roles can come into play here for
that by also assigning granular
permissions we can make sure that we
implement the
concept or the best practice of
the
least privileged access
and also
we have
secure access to aws resources because
by default again we have the principle
of least privilege
and no service can communicate with
another until
we enable it via im so very very secure
out of the box
of course if you want to add an
additional layer of authentication of
security we have multer multi-factor
authentication rather and that will
allow you to ensure through a hardware
device perhaps a
let's say a hardware token device or
your cell phone that has some software
that generates a code that will allow to
identify
you are actually the person that
is
typing the username and password and
that's somebody who's actually stolen
your username and password so at the end
of this video tutorial
we will
show you or i will show you how to
enable that
and of course identity federation is a
big thing where your users may have been
defined outside of aws you may have
thousands of users that you've already
defined let's say in an active directory
or in an ldap environment on-prem and
you don't want to recreate all those
users
again in aws as i am user so we can
tie in we could link the
users
your user database that's on-prem
or even users that have been your user
account that's been
defined let's say
uh on a social site like um
facebook or twitter or google and tie
that into your aws account and though
there is an exchange of information
there is a setup to do
but
at the end of the day it is either a
role in combination with an i am
a policy that will allow
to map what you're allowed to do once
you've been authenticated by an external
system
so
the this has to do with
perhaps
like i said ldap or
active directory and you can tie that in
with aws sso
there are many different services here
that can be leveraged to facilitate what
we call identity federation
and of course im itself
is free so it's not a service per api
request aws is very concerned to put
security first and so
i am is free
it's just the services that you use
for example if you're securing an ec2 of
course that ec2 instance falls under the
current pricing plan
so of course compliance like i mentioned
is extremely important making sure that
it's business as usual in the cloud and
so for example if you were using the
payment card industry
data security standard to make sure that
you're
storing and processing and transmitting
credit card information appropriately
in order to do your business well you
can be assured that the services you use
in aws are pci dss compliance and
there's many many other types of
compliance that aws adheres to as well
so password policies of course are
important by default we do have a
password policy in place but when you go
to the im console you are free to update
that password policy make it
more restrictive based on whatever
policy
you have at your company
so many features
and so i think we're ready now to go
into a full demonstration and i will
show you
how to
incorporate i am users groups
and also multi-factor authentication so
get ready let's do it
i'm going to demonstrate now how to
attach an s3 bucket policy via im i've
already created a bucket called simply
learn s3im demo
and what we're going to do is we're
going to attach a bucket policy
right over here we're going to have to
edit it of course
and the basis of the demonstration will
be to allow a user that has mfa so
multi-factor authentication set up to
have access to the contents
of a folder within
this bucket so of course now i have to
create a folder just simply call it
folder one
create that folder
and now i'm going to go into that folder
and upload a file
so that we can actually see
this in action so i'm going to select a
demo file that i prepared in advance
called demo file user 2 mfa
i'm going to upload that
all right and now what's going to happen
is eventually when i create our two im
users one will have access to view the
contents of this file
which
should look like something very simple
if i open this up within the console
you'll be able to see well it's pretty
small right now i'll make this a little
bit bigger of course
it says this is a demo file which user
2-mfa should only be able to have access
to so what's left to do now is to create
two users one called user one
and one called user two dash mfa and
that's what we're gonna do
right now
let's head over to i am
identity and access management
and on the left hand side here we're
going to click on users
you can see here i don't have much going
on i just got an administrator user so i
want to create two
new users we'll start with one at a time
so one called user one
now by default we have um you know the
principle of least privilege which means
this user is not allowed to do anything
unless we give them access to either the
console right over here which i will do
right now
and also if they were a kind of
programmatic user that needed access to
specific keys in order to
interact with the apis via the command
line interface or the software
development kit for example if you were
a java developer
so in this case that is not what i want
so i'm just going to assign console
access and i'm also going to create a
default password
for this user
but i will not allow them to reset it on
the first login just for demonstration
purposes
now over here we have the chance to add
the user straight to a group but i'll
only do that later on at the end of the
demonstration for now i want to show you
how to attach
to this user and i am policy which will
give them access to specific services so
if i type in s3 full access here
this is an administrative access to an
s3 bucket if you take a look at the json
document attached or representing that i
am policy you can see that it is
allowing all api actions across s3 star
and also object lambda across all
buckets and i say all buckets because
the star represents all buckets
so it is a very broad permission so be
very careful when you're actually
assigning this to one of your users to
make sure
that they deserve to have such a
permission
so i'm not going to assign any tags here
but i'm just going to review what i've
done i can see here i've just attached
an s3 full access
permission to this one user and i'm
going to create that user now
of course now is the time for me to
download the csv file which will contain
those credentials if i don't do it now i
will not have a second chance to do this
and also to send an email to this user
in order for them to have a link to the
console and also some instructions i'm
not going to bother with that i'm just
going to say close
and now i have
my user 1. you can see here
that it says none for
multi-factor authentication so i have
not set anything up right now for them
and that's what i want to do for
this second user that i want to create
called user 2
vash
mfa or mfa rather all right so now i
want to do the same exact thing as
before
i'm going to assign a custom password
and i'm going to go through the same
steps as we saw before i'm going to
attach an existing
managed policy that aws has already
vetted for us
review
create
now right now they're exactly the same
so i have to go back to user two and set
up multi-factor authentication
and to do that you have to go in the
security credentials tab
and you'll see here assigned mfa device
we have not assigned any yet so we're
going to manage that right now
and we have the option to
order and get an actual physical device
that's uniquely
made for performing multi-factor
authentication however we're going to
opt for the virtual mfa device which is
a software that we're going to install
on our cell phones let's say so i can
actually open this link just to show you
the um very many
options that we have for that right over
here i'm gonna go with google
authenticator so go to the app store on
your android device and you can download
that of course if you have an android
device if not you have other options for
iphone and other softwares for each one
of those so i'll let you do that once
you've installed that software
on your cell phone you could come here
and show the qr code now what that is
going to do is you're going to need to
go to your phone now and i'm going to my
phone right now as we speak and i'm
going to open up
that mfa software in this case the
google authenticator
and i'm going to say there's a little
plus sign at the bottom i'm going to say
scan qr code i'm going to point my phone
to this square code here this qr code
and it's going to pick it up
i'm going to say add account there's a
little button there out of count and
it's going to give me a code so i'm
going to enter that code right now
so once i've entered the code i have to
wait for a second code and that's
because this code on the screen of my
cell phone is going to expire it's only
there for about 20 to 30 seconds once
that token expires it refreshes the
display with another token so i have
another token now
that's only good for a couple of seconds
again and now i'm going to say assign
mfa what this does is it completes
the link between my personal cell phone
and
this user right now
so now that this has been set up we can
see we actually have an arn
to this device which we are going to
possibly need depending on how we write
our policies in our case here i'm going
to show you a way to kind of bypass
having to put that
so now we've got those two users one
with an mfa device and another one
without okay so now the lab is going to
be or the demonstration rather is going
to be how do we allow
user to mfa
access to
this file
in folder one and not allow
user one
the distinguishing factor will be that
user two has an mfa
set up and user one doesn't so based off
of just that condition
that'll be the determining factor if
they can view the file or not so let's
get back to s3
and actually create this i am bucket
policy
and see how it's done
so back we are in our bucket and now we
have to go to permissions in order to
set up this bucket policy
we're going to click on edit over here
and we're going to click on policy
generator to help us generate that json
file through
a user interface of course we're dealing
with an s3 bucket policy
now what we're going to do is we're
going to deny
all users and services so star
s3 is great out here because we selected
s3 up here
we want to deny all
s3 api actions we're not going to go and
selectively go down the list
the
specific
bucket and the folder so in this case
here we're missing the amazon resource
name so we have to go back here
and we have to copy the arn of our
bucket right so we're going to copy that
come back
ctrl v
and we're going to of course have to
specify the folder as well so i'm going
to just do slash
folder one
and then i'm also going to do slash
star for all the objects
in that folder okay
so
here's the mfa condition that i want to
add though because we cannot assign the
mfa condition up here we have to say add
conditions very powerful feature here
that's optional but very powerful
we want to look for a condition that
says boolean
if exist or bool if exists all right so
there's got to be a key value pair that
exists and there are many but we're
going to look for one that is
specifically
known as multi-factor authentication
present
and we want to make sure that value is
equal to false so i'm going to add that
condition and then i'm going to add that
statement and i want to generate the
policy just to show you now how that
user interface has generated this
json document for us that we're going to
attach to our s3 bucket what i want to
do is i want to take this in its
entirety copy it
and go back to our s3 bucket that's just
waiting for us to
paste our policy in here okay so let's
see what's actually going on here
we've created a policy again this policy
could have any id it's just a an id that
was given by the
user interface you could name that
whatever you want of course something
that makes total sense and then we have
one or more statements and then we only
have actually one statement and again
you can select any id here that was just
auto-generated by the ide
we're saying that all actions
on the simple storage service i say all
again because of the star
are denied
specifically on this resource which is
our bucket
and the folder named folder1 and all the
objects within that folder
under the certain conditions
so the condition is
if
you have
a
boolean value of false associated with
a key called multi-factor authentication
present and it has to exist
okay
then if that value is equal to false you
don't have access to the objects in this
folder which means that
if you do have mfa set up you will be
allowed access to the contents of this
folder so if we
assign this and apply this to all
principles which would encompass user 1
and user 2-mfa
then let me just apply this
that would mean
that user one would not be able to see
the contents
of
our object inside folder one
and user two dash mfa would so let's go
take a look and log into
let's log out first and then when we're
going to log back in we're going to log
in as the individual user1 and user2mfa
and prove this
is actually the case
so i am now logging back in as user one
that we created moments ago
and of course if i for example go see c
service like ec2
we don't have access to ec2 we've just
given ourselves access to s3 so this
makes total sense
we're just going to go see what we have
access to which is s3
should be able to list and describe all
the buckets there because we've been
giving pretty much administrative access
now if we go here to our
created bucket and go inside folder 1
and want to actually open up this
document we can see now that that's not
happening okay and that's because of
that condition
that is checking if we actually have a
value
of true for that um mfa
key that we specified okay so this is
expected and this is exactly what we
wanted
now what we're going to do
is we're going to log out once again
and we're going to do the same thing but
with user 2 dash mfa
let me log back in
and then specify the new password we
created
now of course now i have an mfa code
right because i've set that up for user
two so back on my cell phone i go
i am opening up the google authenticator
application and i have in front of me a
new amazon web services
code
that is only good for like i said maybe
20 seconds so it's a little nerve
racking if you're if you're not good
under pressure you're gonna choke
so i've just entered the code and i have
to wait for
uh
you know that to actually work now it
looks like i actually didn't check off
um
not to recreate the the password so
unfortunately
uh i must have missed that check mark so
i wanted to kind of avoid this here so
i'm gonna start
over and
create a brand new password a little
painful for
you know demonstrations but it's good
for you guys to see how that actually
looks like
so because i've set up my
mfa device properly i am able to log in
after i enter that mfa code and once
again if i go to ec2
now i haven't been given the permissions
for ec2 i've only been given the
permissions for s3 so
nothing changes here i'm going to go to
s3
and i'm going to go into folder one
of our bucket in question and i'm going
to see if i have access now to
opening up and seeing the contents and
here i have the contents this is a demo
file
which user2mfa should only be able to
have access to so that worked so now you
guys know how to create
a bucket permission policy
that is also known as a resource policy
because it's assigned to the resources
assigned to the bucket
and let me actually show it to you once
one last time here it is and that'll
only allow us to have access to the
contents of folder one if
we have multi-factor authentication set
up in our account so that's really good
the last thing i want to show you now is
how to maybe
create im users
in a better way in terms of not having
to assign over and over again
the same permissions like you saw me do
for user one and user two
of course now i cannot do anything i am
why because i'm user i'm user two i
don't have access to im so once again
i'm logging out and we're going to
actually see the best practice
in terms of how do i assign i am
policies to a group
and then assign users to that group in
order to inherit those permission
policies so let's get to it let's sign
up first
so let us go back to i am
and we're going to be creating our first
group
we're going to simply create the button
or click on the button create group and
we'll come up with a
group called testers
we have the
ability to add existing users to this
group so we will add for example user 1
only
to the testers group
and we can also add permissions
to this group so we're going to go here
and add for example the ec2
[Music]
full permissions
create group
and what's going to happen now
if we go take a look at testers we can
see we have that one user that we added
and we also have
the permissions associated with that
group so this means now that any new
users we create will automatically
inherit whatever permissions the group
has which is really good for
maintainability so
for example let's say we were to create
many new testers
so let's say user three over here now
of course i'm going to have to go in
this case through the same steps as i
did before
i'm just going to remember this time not
to forget to check uncheck that and
instead of attaching policies directly
i'm going to say well i want to inherit
the policy permissions that were
assigned to the group
so i'm going to say this user is going
to be part of the testers group and of
course i'm just going to skip through
the remaining
repetitive tasks that i've already
described
and this user 3 now
is already going to have their
permissions to access ec2
that they've gained through the group
testers
whereas if we go back to user one
this user also has
the permissions from the group but has a
unique permission added to itself
so in this case
you do have the option of doing that you
have the option of adding a permission
over and above
that is assigned to the group to
yourself directly
so this is really good
adding permissions to groups when you
have of course lots of users
in your company
in your organization
and instead of going to them and adding
permissions after permission
you can centrally access this in one or
manage this in one place so for example
if i go back to my roles
groups rather
in my
testers and let's say i forgot
to add a permission to all the users in
this group so let's say there was 20
users attached to this group okay i'm
not going to bore you with creating 20
users and we have we have two now that's
good enough to show the demonstration
and let's say now i need to add another
permission right so in this case here
i'm going to add a permission
for example let's say based on dynamodb
right so i'm going to get full access to
dynamodb i'm going to add that
permission
and what's going to happen now
is if i go back to my users for example
user 3
i'm going to see that user 3
automatically has inherited that
permission
and so has user one
all right show two more and there they
are
so in this case it really allows
for you to easily manage
a lot of users in that group because you
can simply go to one place which is the
group and add and remove policies
as you see fit and the whole team will
inherit that so it saves you lots of
work and that is the best practice so
there you have it guys
you have learned in this demonstration
how to create users
how to create groups how to
add users to groups and manage their
policies in terms of best practice and
you've also
learned
how to attach to an s3 bucket
a policy
that allows you to permit access based
off of if a user has
multi-factor authentication set up and
we showed you how to actually set that
up
when creating an im user so again
permissions tab is where this all
happens hope you enjoyed that put that
to good use
and i'll see you in the next
demonstration
so i hope you enjoyed that demonstration
we're just going to wrap things up in a
summary and kind of see what
was looked at throughout the tutorial we
first started with what is aws security
we took a look at how important it was
across our organization to maintain best
practice and also
standardize that practice across
accounts organization we took a look at
the topmost services
in which we concentrated then after on i
am and we took a look at what exactly
what i am was in terms of i am users
groups long-term credentials that are
applied as i am policies and then the
concepts of a role we took a look at the
benefits of im and the actual
terminology used with working with i am
of course principle being an entity
that is a either a user or a service
itself that can gain access to an aws
resources and we actually saw the
different types of authentication and
what we can do to implement
authorization via im policies and also
through the use of roles
so we took a look how to organize our
users into groups and what actually goes
into acquiring a role through a
demonstration we took a look at how to
actually create a role and attach that
role to an ec2 instance and then we took
a look at the high level features
of im which allowed us to either
grant access to another imuser from
another group implement multi-factor
authentication like we just did in the
demonstration
or
ensure ourselves that we are following
all the compliancy standards that have
been
adhered to by whatever project we're
working on and that aws is there to
support us
so here we're going to talk about amazon
ecs a service that's used to manage
docker containers so without any further
ado let's get started in this session we
would like to talk about some basics
about aws and then we're going to
immediately dive into why amazon ecs
and what is amazon ecs in general and
then it uses a service called docker so
we're going to understand what docker is
and there are competitive services
available for ecs i mean you could ecs
is not the on and only service to manage
docker containers but why ecs advantage
of ecs we will talk about that and the
architecture of ecs so how it functions
what are the components present in it
and
what are the functions that it does i
mean each and every component what are
all the functions that it does all those
things will be discussed in the
architecture of amazon acs and how it
works how it all connects together
that's something we will discuss and
what are the companies that are using
ecs what were the challenge and how ecs
helped to fix the challenge that's
something we will discuss and finally we
have a wonderful lab that talks about
how to deploy docker containers on an
amazon ecs so let's talk about what is
aws
amazon web service in short called as
aws is an
web service in the cloud that provides a
variety of services such as compute
power database storage content delivery
and a lot of other resources so you can
scale your business and grow not focus
more on your id needs and the rest of
the id demands rather you can focus on
your business and let amazon scale your
it or let amazon take care of your it so
what is that you can do with aws with
aws we can create deploy any application
in the cloud so it's not just deploying
you can also create your application in
the cloud it has all the tools and
services required the tools and services
that you would have installed in your
laptop or you would have installed in
your on-premises desktop machine for
your development environment you know
the same thing can be installed and used
from the cloud so you can use cloud for
creating and not only that you can use
the same cloud for deploying and making
your application available for your end
user the end user could be internal
internal users the end user could be
could be in the internet the end user
could be kind of spread all around the
world it doesn't matter so it can be
used uh to create and deploy your
applications in the cloud and like you
might have guessed now it provides
service over the internet that's how
your users worldwide would be able to
use the service that you create and
deploy right so it provides service
over the internet so that's for the end
customer and how will you access those
services that's again through the
internet it's like the extension of your
data center in the internet so it
provides all the services in the
internet it provides compute service
through the internet so in other words
you access them through the internet it
provides database service through the
internet over the internet in other
words you can securely access your
database through the internet and lot
more and the best part is this is
pay as you go or pay only for what you
use there is no long term or you know
beforehand commitment
here most of the services does not have
any commitment so there is no long-term
and beforehand commitment you only pay
exactly for what you use there's no
overage there's no overpaying right
there's no buying in advance right you
only pay for what you use let's talk
about what ecs is so before ecs before
containers right ecs is a service that
manages docker containers right it's not
a product or it's not a feature all by
itself it's a service that's dependent
on docker container so before docker
containers all the applications were
running on vm or on a host or on a
physical machine right and that's memory
bound that's latency bound the server
might have issues on and on right so
let's say this is alice and she's trying
to access her application which is
running somewhere in her on premises and
the application isn't working what could
be the reason some of the reasons could
be memory full the server is currently
down at the moment we don't have another
physical server to launch the
application a lot of other reasons so a
lot of reasons why the application
wouldn't be working in on premises some
of them are memory full issue and server
down issue very less
high availability or in fact single
point of failure and no high
availability if i if i need to tell it
correctly with easiest the services can
kind of breed free right the services
can run seamlessly now how how is that
possible those thing we will discuss in
the upcoming sessions so because of
containers and ecs managing containers
the applications can run in a high
available
mode they can run in a high available
mode meaning if something goes wrong
right there's another container that
gets spun up and
your application runs in that particular
container very less chances of your
application going down that's what i
mean this is not possible with
a physical
host this is very less possible with an
vm or at least it's going to take some
time for another vm to get spun up so
why ec is or what is ecs amazon ecs
maintains the availability of the
application and allows every user to
scale containers when necessary so it
not only meets the availability of the
application meaning one
container running your application or
one container hosting your application
should be running all the time so to
meet that high availability availability
is making sure your service is running
24 7. so container makes sure that your
services run 24 bar 7 not only that not
only that suddenly there is an increase
in demand how do you meet that demand
right let's say you have like thousand
users suddenly the next week there are
like two thousand users all right so how
do you meet that demand container makes
it very easy for you to meet that demand
in case of vm or in case of physical
host you literally will have to go buy
another physical host or
add more ram add more memory add more
cpu power to it all right or kind of
club 2 two three hosts together
clustering you would be doing a lot of
other things to meet that high
availability and also to meet that
demand but in case of uh ecs it
automatically scales the number of
containers it automatically scales the
number of containers needed and it meets
your demand for that particular r so
what is amazon
ecs the full form of ecs is elastic
container service right so it's
basically a container management service
which can quickly launch and
exit and manage docker containers on a
cluster so it's the function of ecs it
helps us to quickly launch and quickly
exit and manage docker container so it's
kind of a management service for the
docker containers you will be running in
amazon or running in the aws environment
so in addition to that it helps to
schedule the placement of container
across your cluster so it's like this
you have two physical hosts you know
joined together as a cluster and ecs
helps us to place your containers now
where should your container be placed
should it be placed in host 1 should be
placed in host 2. so that logic is
defined in ecs we can define it you can
also let ecs
take control and define that logic most
cases you will be defining it so
schedule the placement of containers
across your cluster let's say two
containers want to interact heavily you
really don't want to place them in two
different hosts right you would want to
place them in one single host so they
can interact with each other so that
logic is defined by us and these
container services you can launch
containers using aws management console
and also you can launch containers using
sdk kits available from amazon you can
launch through a java program you can
launch container using and.net program
you can launch container using an
node.js program as in when the situation
demands so there are multiple ways you
can launch containers through management
console and also programmatically and
ecs also helps to migrate application to
the cloud without changing the code so
anytime you think of migration the first
thing that comes to your mind is that
how will that environment be based on
that i'll have to alter my code what's
what's the ip what is the storage that's
being used what what are the different
parameters i'll have to include the
environment parameters of the new
environment with containers now that
worry is already taken away because we
can create and pretty exact environment
that the one that you had an on-premises
the same environment gets created in the
cloud so
no worries about changing the
application parameter no worries about
changing the code in the application
right you can be like if it ran in my
laptop a container that i was running in
my laptop it's definitely going to run
in the cloud as well because i'm going
to use the same container in the laptop
and also in the cloud in fact you're
going to ship it you're going to move
the container from your laptop to amazon
ecs and make it run there so it's like
the same the very same image the very
same container that was running in your
laptop will be running in the
cloud or production environment so what
is docker we know that it ecs helps to
quickly launch exit and manage docker
containers what is docker let's let's
answer that question what is docker now
docker is a tool
that helps to automate the development
of an application as a lightweight
container so that the application can
work efficiently in different
environments this is pretty much what we
discussed right before the slide i can
build an application in my laptop or in
on premises in a container environment
docker container environment and anytime
i want to migrate right i don't have to
kind of rewrite the code and then rerun
the code in that new environment i can
simply create an image docker image and
move that image to that production or
the new cloud environment and simply
launch it there right so no compiling
again no relaunching the application
simply pack all your code in a docker
container image and ship it to the new
environment and launch the container
there that's all so docker container is
a light weight package of software that
contains all the dependencies so because
you know when packing you'll be packing
all the dependencies you'll be packing
the code you'll be packing the framework
you'll be packing the libraries that are
required to run the application so in
the new environment you can be pretty
sure you can be guaranteed that it's
going to run because it's the very same
code it's the very same framework it's
the very same libraries that you have
shipped right there's nothing new in
that new environment it's the very same
thing that's going to run in that
container so you can be rest assured
that they are going to run in that new
environment and these docker containers
are highly scalable and they are very
efficient suddenly you wanted like 20
more
docker containers to run the application
think of adding 20 more hosts 20 more
vms right how much time would it take
and compared to that time the amount of
time that docker containers would
require to kind of scale to that amount
like 20 more containers it's very less
or it's minimal or negligible so it's an
highly scalable and it's a very
efficient uh service you can suddenly
scale number of docker containers to
meet any additional demand very short
boot up time because it takes a it's not
going to load the whole operating system
and these docker containers you know
they use the
linux kernel and features of the kernel
like c groups and name spaces to kind of
segregate the processors so they can run
independently any environment and it
takes very less time
to boot up
and the data's that are stored in the
containers are kind of reusable so you
can have an external data volume and i
can map it to the container and whatever
the
space that's occupied by the container
and the data that the container puts in
that volume they are kind of reusable
you can simply remap it to another
application you can kind of remap it to
the next successive container you can
kind of remap it to the next version of
the container next version of the
application you'll be launching and you
don't have to go through building the
data again from the scratch whatever
data the container was using previously
or the previous container was using that
data is available for the next container
as well so the volumes that the
containers users are very reusable
volumes and like i said it's isolated
application so it kind of isolates by
its nature it kind of by the way it's
designed by the way it is created it
isolates one container from another
container meaning anytime you run
applications on different containers you
can be rest assured that they are very
much isolated though they are running on
the same host though they are running on
the same laptop let's say though they
are running on the same physical machine
let's say running 10 containers 10
different applications you can be sure
that they are
well disconnected or well isolated
applications now let's talk about the
advantages of ecs the advantage of ecs
is improved security its security is
inbuilt in ecs with ecs we have
something called as a container registry
you know that's where
all your images are stored and those
images are accessed only through https
not only that those images are actually
encrypted and access to those images are
allowed and denied through identity and
access management policies iam and in
other words let's say two container
running on the same instance now one
container can have access to s3 and the
others or the rest of the others are
denied access to s3 so that kind of
granular security can be achieved
through containers when we mix and match
the other security products available in
amazon like iam encryption accessing it
using https these containers are very
cost efficient like i've already said
these are lightweight uh processes right
we can schedule multiple containers on
the same node and this actually allows
us to achieve high density on an ec2
instance
imagine an ec2 instance that that's very
less utilized that's not possible with a
container because you can actually dense
or crowd an ec2 instance with more
container in it so to best use those
resources in ec2 straightforward you can
just launch one application but with
when we use containers you can launch
like 10 different applications on the
same ec2 server that means 10 different
applications can actually feed on those
resources available and can benefit the
application and ecs not only deploys the
container it also maintains the state of
the containers and it makes sure that
the minimum a set of containers are
always running based on the requirement
that's another cost
efficient way of using it right and
anytime an application fails and that
has a direct impact on the revenue of
the company and is just make sure that
you're not losing any revenue because
your application has failed and easies
and pretty extensible services it's like
this in many organizations there are
majority of unplanned work because of
environment variation a lot of
firefighting happens when we kind of
deploy the code from one or kind of move
the core or redeploy the code uh in a
new environment a lot of firefighting
happens there right this docker
containers are pretty extensible like we
discussed already
environment is not a concern for
containers because it's going to kind of
shut itself inside a docker container
and anywhere the docker container can
run the application will run exactly the
way it performed in the past so
environment is not a concern for the
docker containers in addition to that
ecs is
easily scalable we have discussed this
already and it improves
it has improved compatibility we have
discussed this already let's talk about
the architecture of ecs like you know
now the architecture of ecs is the ecs
cluster itself that's group of servers
running the ecs service and it
integrates with docker right so we have
a docker registry docker registry is a
repository where we store all the docker
images or the container images so it's
like three components ecs is of three
components one is the ecs cluster itself
right when i say easy as itself i'm
referring to easiest cluster cluster of
servers that will run the containers and
then the repository
where the images will be stored right
the repository where the images will be
stored and the image itself so container
image is the template of instructions
which is used to create a container
right so it's like what's the os what is
the version of node that should be
running and any additional software do
we need so those question gets answered
here so it's the template template of
instructions which is used to create the
containers and then the registry is the
service where the docker images are
stored and shared so many people can
store
there and many people can access or if
there's another group that wants to
access they can access the image from
there or one person can store the image
and rest of the team can access and the
rest of the team can store image and
this one person can pick the image from
there and kind of ship it to the
customer or ship it to the production
environment all that's possible in this
container registry and amazon's version
of the container registry is ecr and
there's a third party docker itself has
a container registry that's docker hub
ecs itself which is the the group of
servers that runs those containers so
these two the container image and the
container registry they kind of handle
docker in an image format just an image
format and in ecs is where the container
gets live and then it becomes and
compute resource and starts to handle
requests you know starts to serve the
page and starts to do the batch job you
know whatever your plan is with that
container so the cluster of servers ecs
integrates well with the familiar
services like vpc vpc is known for
securing vpc is known for
isolating the whole environment from
rest of the customers or isolating the
whole environment or the whole
infrastructure from the rest of the
clients in your account or from the rest
of the applications in your account on
and on so vpc is a service that provides
or gives you the network isolation ecs
integrates well with vpc and this vpc
enables us to launch aws resources such
as amazon ec2 instance in a virtual
private network that we specified this
is basically what we just discussed now
let's take a closer look at
the ecs how does ecs work let's find
answer for this question how does ecs
work ecs has got a couple of components
within itself so these ecs servers can
run across availability zone as you can
see there are two availability zones
here they can actually run across
availability zones and ecs has got two
modes far gate mode and the ec2 mode
right here we're seeing forget mode and
then here we're seeing nothing that
means it's an ec2 mode and then it has
got different network interfaces
attached to it because they need to be
running in an isolated fashion right so
anytime you want network isolation you
need separate ip and if you want
separate ip you need separate network
interface card and that's what you have
elastic network interface card separate
elastic network interface card for all
those tasks and services and this runs
within an vpc let's talk about the far
gate service tasks are launched using
the far gate
service so we will discuss about uh task
what is forget now fargate is a compute
engine in ecs that allows users to
launch containers without having to
monitor the cluster ecs is a service
that manages the containers for you
right otherwise managing containers will
be and full-time job so easy manages it
for you and if you and you get to manage
ecs that's the basic service but if you
want amazon to manage ecs and the
containers for you we can go for fargate
so farget is a compute engine in ecs
that allows users to launch containers
without having to monitor the ecs
cluster and the tasks the tasks that we
discussed the tasks has two components
you see task right here so they have two
components we have
ecs container instance
and then the container agent
so
like you might have guessed right now
ecs container instance is actually an
ec2 instance right capable of running
containers not all ec2 instances can run
containers so these are like specific
ec2 instances that can run containers
they are ecs container instances and
then we have container agent which is
the agent that actually binds those
clusters together and it does a lot of
other housekeeping work right kind of
connects clusters makes sure that
the version
needed is present so it's all part of
that agent or it's all job of that agent
container instances container instances
is part of amazon ec2 instance which run
amazon ecs container agent pretty
straightforward definition and then a
container agent is responsible for
communication between ecs and the
instance and it also provides the status
of the running containers kind of
monitors the container monitors the
state of the container make sure that
the content is up and running and if
there's anything wrong it kind of
reports it to the appropriate service to
fix the container on and on it's a
container agent when we don't manage
container agent it it runs by itself and
you really don't have to do anything to
make the container agent better it's
already better you really won't be
configuring anything in the agent and an
elastic network interface car is a
virtual interface network that can be
connected uh to an instance in vpc so in
other words elastic network interface is
how the container interacts with another
container and that's how the container
interacts with the ec2 host and that's
how the container interacts with the
internet external world and a cluster a
cluster is a set of
ecs container instances it's not
something that's very difficult to
understand it's simply a group of ec2
instances that runs that ecs agent and
this cluster in cluster handles the
process of scheduling monitoring and
scaling the request we know that ecs can
scale the containers can scale how does
it scale that's all monitored and
managed by this ecs cluster let's talk
about the companies that are using
amazon ecs there are variety of
companies that use
ecs clusters to name a few octa users
easiest cluster and octa is a product
that use identity information to grant
people access to applications on
multiple devices at any given point of
time they make sure that they have a
very strong security protection so octa
uses amazon ecs to run their octa
application and serve their customers
and abhima abhima is an a tv channel and
they chose to use microservices and
docker containers they already had
microservices and docker containers and
when they thought about a service that
they can use
in aws ecs was the only service that
they can immediately adapt to and
because in abima tv the engineers have
already been using docker and docker
containers it was kind of easy for them
to adapt themselves to ecs and start
using it along with the benefits that
ecs provides previously they had to do a
lot of work but now ecs does it for them
all right similarly remind and ubisoft
gopro are some of the famous companies
that use amazon ecs and get benefited
from its scalability get benefited from
its cost gets benefited from its
amazon managed services get benefited
from the portability that ecs and the
migration option that ecs provides let's
talk about how to deploy a docker
container on amazon acs the way to
deploy docker container on ecs is first
we need to have an aws account and then
set up and run our first ecs cluster so
in our lab we're going to use
the launch wizard to run an ecs cluster
and run containers in them and then task
definition task definition tells the
size of the container the number of the
container and when we talk about size it
tells how much your cpu do you need how
much of memory do you need and talking
about
numbers you know it requires how many
numbers of container you're going to
launch you know is it 5 is it 10 or is
it just one running all the time now
those kind of information goes in the
task definition file and then we can do
some advanced configuration on ecs like
load balancers and you know what port
number you want to allow and you don't
want to allow you know who gets access
who shouldn't get access and what's the
ip that you want to allow and deny
requests from
on and on and
this is where we would also mention the
name of the container so to
differentiate one container from the
other and the name of the servers you
know is it an a backup job is it a web
application is it an uh data container
is it going to take care of your data
data back end and the desired number of
tasks that you want to be running all
the time those details go in when we try
to configure the ecs service right and
then you configure cluster you put in
all the security in the configure your
cluster step or configure cluster stage
and finally we will have an
instance
and bunch of containers running in that
instance all right let's do a demo so
here i have logged in to my amazon
portal and let me switch to the
appropriate region i'm going to pick not
virginia north virginia look for ecs and
it tells ecs as a service that helps to
run and manage docker containers well
and good click on it i'm in north
virginia just want to make sure that i'm
in the right region and go to clusters
and here we can create cluster this is
our far gate and this is our ec2 type
launching for linux and windows
environment but i'm going to launch
through this walkthrough portal right
this gives a lot of information here so
the different steps involved here is
creating a container definition which is
what we're going to do right now and
then a task definition and then service
and finally the cluster it's a four step
process so in container definition we
define the
image the base image we are going to use
now here i'm going to launch an uh httpd
or a simple http web page right so a
simple httpd 2.4 image is fair enough
for me and it's not a heavy application
so 0.5 gigabit of a memory is enough and
again it's not a heavy application so
0.25 virtual cpu is enough in our case
right you can edit it based on the
requirement you can always edit it and
because i'm using hdpd the port mapping
is already port 80 that's how the
container is going to receive the
request and there's no health check as
if now when we want to design critical
and complicated environments uh we can
include health check right and this is
the cpu that we have chose we can edit
it and i'm going to use some bash
commands to
create an html page right this page says
that you know amazon ecs sample app
right and then it says amazon ecs sample
app your application is running on a
container in amazon ecs so that's the
page the html page that i'm going to
create or index.html so i'm going to
create and put it in an appropriate
location so those pages can be served
from the container right if you replace
this with any of your own content then
it's going to be your own content ecs
comes with some basic
logs and these are the places where they
get stored that's not the focus as of
now all right so i was just saying that
you can edit it and customize it to your
needs we're not going to do any
customization now we're just getting
familiar with ecs now and the task
definition name of the task definition
is uh first one task definition and then
we are running it in a vpc and then this
is an far gate mode meaning the servers
are completely handled by amazon and the
task memory is 0.5 gigabit and the tar
cpu is 0.25 virtual cpu
name of the service
is it a batch job is it an you know
front end is it a back end or is it a
simple copy job what's the service name
of the service goes here again this you
can edit it and here's a security group
as of now i'm allowing 480 to the whole
world if i want to restrict to a certain
ip i can do that the default option for
load balancing is a no load balancer but
i can also choose to have a load
balancer and use port 80 to map that 480
to the container put 80 right i can do
that the default is no load balancer all
right let's do one thing let's use load
balancer let's use load balancer and
port 80 that receives information on
port 80 http uh what's going to be the
cluster name we're in the last step what
is the cluster name cluster name can be
simply learn ecs demo next we're done
and we can create so it's launching a
cluster as you can see and it's picking
the task definition file that we've
created and it's using that to launch
and service and then these are the log
groups that we discussed and it's
creating a vpc remember ecs clubs well
with the vpc it's creating a vpc and
it's creating two subnets here for high
availability it's creating that security
group port 80 allowed to the whole world
and then it's putting it behind and load
balancer it generally would take like
five to 10 minutes so we just need to be
patient and let it complete its creation
and once this is complete we can simply
access the servers using the load
balancer url and when this is running
let me actually take you to
the other products or the other services
that are integrated with the ecs it's
getting created our service is getting
created as of now ecr repository this is
where all our images are stored now as
of now i'm not pulling my image from ecr
i'm pulling it directly from the
internet docker docker hub but all
custom images all custom images they are
stored in this repository so you can
create a repository call it
app one create a repository so here's my
repository so any image that i create
locally or any docker image that i
create locally i can actually push them
push those images using these commands
right here and they get stored here and
i can make my ecs connect with ecr and
pull images from here so they would be
my custom images and as of now because
i'm using a default image it's directly
pulling it from the internet let's go to
ec2 and look for a load balancer because
we wanted to access the application from
behind a load balancer right so here is
a load balancer created for us
and anytime i put the url so cluster is
now created you see there's one service
running all right let's click on that
cluster here is the name of our
application and here is the
tasks the different containers that
we are running and if you click on it we
have an ip right ip of that container
and it says it's running it was created
at such and such time and started at
such and such time and this is the task
definition file that it this container
uses meaning the template the details to
all the version details they all come
from here and it belongs to the cluster
called
simply learn ecs demo right and you can
also get some logs container logs from
here so let's go back and there are no
ecs instances here because remember this
is forget you're not managing any ecs
instance all right so that's why you're
not seeing any ecs instance here so
let's go back to task and
go back to
the same page where we found the ip pick
that ip put it in the browser and you
have this sample html page running from
an
container so let me go back to load
balancer ec2 and then under ec2 i'll be
able to find a load balancer find that
load balancer pick that dns name put it
in the browser and now it's accessible
to the load balancer url right now this
url can be mapped to other services like
dns this url can be embedded in any of
your application if you want to make
that application connect with this
container now using ip is not all that
advisable because these containers can
die and then a new container gets
created and when a new container gets
created it gets a new ip right so a hard
coding ip is
not hardcoding dynamic ips are not
advisable so you would be using load
balancer and putting that url in that
application that you want to make it
interact with this container instance it
was a wonderful experience in walking
you through this ecs topic and in here
we learned about what aws is and why
we're using ecs
and what is easiest in general what is
docker in specific and we also learn
about the advantages of ecs the
architecture the different components of
ecs and how ecs works
when they're all connected together and
we also looked at the companies that use
ecs and their use cases and finally a
lab how we can launch ecs fargate
through the portal i'm very glad to walk
you through this lesson about route 53.
so in this section
we are going to talk about
basics of aws and then we're going to
immediately dive into
why
why we need amazon route 53 and then
we're going to expand and talk about the
details of amazon route 53 the benefits
it provides over its competitors and the
different types of routing policy it has
and some of amazon ralph 53's key
features and we're going to talk about
how to access route 53 i mean the
different ways the different methods you
can access route 53 and finally we're
going to end with an a wonderful demo in
drop 53 so let's talk about what is aws
amazon web services or aws in short is a
cloud provider that offers a variety of
services such as a variety of id
services or infrastructure services such
as a compute power database content
delivery and other resources that helps
us to scale and grow our business and
aws is hot aws is picking up aws is
being adapted by a lot of customers
that's because aws is easy to use even
for a beginner and talking about safety
the
the aws infrastructure is designed to
keep the data safe irrespective of the
size of the data with small data be it
very minimal data be it all the data
that you have in terabytes and in
petabytes amazon can keep it safe in
their environment and the wonderful
thing and the most important reason why
a lot of customers move into the cloud
is that the pay as you go pricing there
is no long-term commitment and it's very
cost effective what this means is that
you're not paying for a resource that
you're not using in on premises you do
pay for resources you're not using a lot
meaning you go and buy a server you do
the estimate for the next five years and
only after like three or four years
you'll be hitting the peak capacity but
still you would be buying that capacity
before four years right and then you
will gradually be you know utilizing it
from you know 40 days 60 days 70 80 and
then 100. so what you have done is that
even though you're not using the full
capacity you still have bought it and
are and are paying for it from day one
but in the cloud it's not like that you
only pay for the resources that you use
anytime you want more you scale up the
resource and you you pay for the scaled
up resource and anytime you want less
you scale down the resource and you pay
less for that scaled down resource let's
talk about why amazon route 53 let's
take this scenario where rachel is
trying to open her web browser and
the url that she hit isn't working a lot
of reasons behind why the url isn't
working it could be the server
utilization that went high it could be
it could be the memory usage that went
high a lot of reasons and she starts to
think is there an efficient way to scale
resources according to the user
requirements or is there an efficient
way to kind of mask all those failures
and kind of divert the traffic to the
appropriate active you know active
resource or active service that's
running our application you always want
to hide the failures right in it kind of
mask the failure and direct the customer
to another healthy service that's
running right none of your customers
would want to see a server not available
or you know none of the customers your
customers would want to see your service
not working not impressive to them and
this is tom tom is an i.t guy and he
comes up with an idea and he's answering
rachel yes we can scale resources
efficiently using amazon rod 53 in a
sense he's saying that yes we can mask
the failure and we can keep the services
up and running meaning we can provide
more high availability to our customers
with the use of route 53 and then he
goes on and explains amazon drop 53 is a
dns service that gives developers an
efficient way to connect users to
internet applications without any
downtime now downtime is the key amazon
route 53 helps us to avoid any downtime
that customers will experience you still
will have downtime in your server and
your application but
your customers will not be made aware of
it and then rachel is kind of interested
and she's like yeah that sounds
interesting i want to learn more about
it and tom goes on and explains the
important concepts of amazon rock 53
that's everything that i'm going to
explain it to you as well all right so
what is amazon rat53 amazon raw 53 is a
highly scalable dns or domain name
system web service
this service this amazon raw 53 it
functions three main things or it has
three main functions so the first thing
is if a website needs a name route 53
registers the name for the website
domain let's say you want to buy
google.com you want to buy the domain
name let's say you want to buy that
domain name you buy that through rot53
secondly a route53 is the service that
actually connects your
server which is running your application
or which is holding which is serving
your web page so that's the service that
actually route 53 is the service that
connects the user to your server when
they hit google.com in the browser or
whatever domain name that you have
purchased so you bought a domain name
and the user types in
yourdomainname.com and then roth53 is a
service that helps the user to connect
their browser to the application that's
running in an ec2 instance or any other
server that you are using to serve that
content and not only that route 53
checks health off the resource by
sending automated requests over the
internet to a resource so that's how it
identifies if there is any resource that
has failed when i say resource i'm
referring to any infrastructure failure
any application level failure so it kind
of keeps checking so it understands it
first before the customer notices it and
then it does the magic kind of shifts
the connection from a one server to the
other server we call it routing we will
talk about that as we progress so the
benefits of using route53 it's highly
scalable meaning suddenly let's say the
number of requests the number of people
trying to access your website through
that domain name that you have bought
let's say it has increased ralph 53 is
highly scalable right it can handle even
millions and millions of requests
because it's highly scalable and it's
managed by amazon the same thing it's
reliable it's a highly scalable it can
handle large queries without the users
without you interacting without the user
who bought it interact with it you don't
have to scale up you know when you're
expecting more requests it automatically
scales and it is very reliable in a
sense that
it's very consistent it has the ability
to route the users to the appropriate
application through the logic that it
has it's very easy to use when we do the
lab you're going to see that it's very
easy easy to use you buy the domain name
and then you simply map it to the
application you simply map it to the
server by putting in the ip or if you
you can simply map it to another load
balancer by putting in the load balancer
url you can simply map it to another
s3 bucket by simply putting the s3
bucket name or the sd bucket url it's
pretty straightforward easy to set up
and it's very cost effective in a way
that we only pay for the service that we
have used so no wastage of money here so
the billing is set up in such a way that
you are paying only for the amount of
requests that
you have received right the amount of
traffic the amount of requests that you
have received and couple of other things
the the number of uh
hosted zones that you have created right
and a couple of other things
it's very cost effective in such a way
that you only pay for the service that
you are using and it's secure in a way
that access to raw 53 is
integrated with identity and access
management iam so you only have
authorized users
gain access to route 53 the trainee who
just joined yesterday won't get access
and the contractor or the consultant the
third-party consultant you have given
access or who is using your environment
you can block access to that particular
person because he's not the admin or
he's not a privileged user in your
account so only privileged users and
admin gain access to route 53 through
iam now let's talk about the routing
policies so when you create a record in
in route 53 recorder is nothing but an
entry so when you do that you choose a
routing policy right routing policy is
nothing but it determines how route 53
responds to your queries how the dns
queries are being responded right that's
that's a record or that's a routing
policy so the first one is a
simple routing policy so we use simple
routing policy for a single resource in
other words simple routing allows to
configure dns with no
special route 53 routing it's kind of
one-to-one you use an single resource
that performs a given function to your
domain for example if you want to simply
map an url to a web server that's pretty
straightforward simple routing so it
routes traffic to a single resource
example web server to a website and with
simple routing multiple records with the
same name cannot be created
but multiple values can be created in
the same record the second type of
routing policy is failover routing so we
would be using failover routing when we
want to configure active passive
failover if something failed right you
want to fail over to the next resource
which was previously the backup resource
now the active resource or which was
previously the backup server now it's an
active server so you would be failing
over to that particular resource or that
particular ip if you want to do that we
use failover routing so failover routing
routes traffic to a resource when the
resource is healthy or to a different
resource when the previous resource is
unhealthy in other words anytime a
resource goes unhealthy i mean it does
all that's needed to shift the traffic
from the primary resource to the
secondary resource in other words from
the unhealthy resource to the
healthy resource and this records can
route traffic to anything from an
amazon
s3 bucket or you can also configure a
complex tree of records now when we
configure the records it will be more
clear to you so as of now just
understand that route 53 can route or
this routing policy the failover routing
policy can route traffic to amazon s3
bucket or
to a website that has complex
tree of
records geolocation routing policy now
geolocation routing just like the name
says it takes that routing decision
based on the geographic location of the
user in other words you know when you
want to roll traffic based on the
location of the user if that's your
primary criteria for you know sending
that request to the appropriate server
we will be using geo
location routing so it localizes the
content and presents a part or the
entire website in the language of the
user for example a user from us you
would want to direct them to an english
website and a user from german if you
want to send them to the german website
and a user from france you know you want
to send those requests or you want to
show content specific to a customer who
lives in france a french website so this
is if that's your condition this is the
routing policy we would be using and the
geographic locations are specified by
either continent or by country or by
state in the united states so only in
the united states you can actually split
it to state level and for the rest of
the countries you can do it on a country
level on a high level you can also do it
on a continent level the next type of
routing policy would be your proximity
routing geoproximity routing policy when
we want to route traffic based on the
location of our resource and optimally
shift traffic from resources in one
location to resource in another location
we would be using geoproximity routing
so geoproximity routing routes traffic
to the resources based on the geographic
location of the user and the resources
they want to access and it also has an
option to route
more traffic or less to a given resource
by specifying a value known as a bias
kind of weight but we also have weighted
routing that's different so we've chosen
different name buyers so you can send
more traffic to a particular resource by
having a bias on that particular routing
condition and a bias expands or shrinks
the size of the geographic region from
which traffic is routed to a resource
and then we have latency based routing
just like the name says we use latency
based routing if we have resources in
multiple aws regions and if you want to
route traffic to the region that
provides the best latency at any given
point of time so
let's say if one single website needs to
be installed and hosted on multiple aws
regions then latency routing policy is
what is being used it improves the
performance of the users by serving the
request from the aws region that
provides the lowest latency so at any
given point if performance is your
criteria and at any given point of time
irrespective of what happens in amazon
infrastructure irrespective of what
happens in the internet if you want to
route your users to the best performing
website best performing region then we
would be using latency based dropping
and for using latency based routing we
should create latency records for the
resources in multiple aws regions and
then the other type of
a routing policy is a multi-value
routing policy where we can make route
53 to respond to dns queries with up to
eight healthy
records selected at
random so you're not kind of loading
one particular server we can define
eight records and on a random basis
route 53 will respond to queries from
these eight records so it's not one
server that gets all the requests but
eight servers gets the request in a
random fashion so it's multi-value
routing policy and what we get by this
is that we are distributing the traffic
to many servers instead of just one
server so multi-value routing configures
rod 53 to return multiple values in
response to a single or multiple dns
queries it also checks the health of
order sources and returns the multiple
values only for the healthy resources
let's say out of the eight servers we
have define one server is not doing
healthy it will not respond to the query
with the details of the unhealthy server
right so now it's gonna treat it as only
seven servers in the list because one
server is unhealthy and it has the
ability to return multiple health
checkable ip addresses to improve
availability and
load balancing the other type of routing
policy is weighted routing policy and in
here we use
to route traffic or this is used to
route traffic to multiple resources in a
proportion that we specify so this is an
weighted routing and weighted routing
routes multiple resources to a single
domain name or a sub domain and control
the traffic that's routed to each
resources so this is very useful when
you're doing load balancing and testing
new versions of the software so when you
have a new version of the software you
really don't want to send 100 of the
traffic to it so you want to get
customers feedback about the new
software that you've launched new
version or new application that you've
launched so you would kind of send only
20 of the traffic to that application
get customer feedback and if all is good
then we would move the rest of the
traffic to that new application so any
software launches application launches
will be using weighted routing now let's
talk about the key benefits or key
features of route 53 some of the key
features of route 53 are a traffic flow
it routes end users to the endpoint that
should provide the best user experience
that's what we discussed in the routing
policies right it uses a routing policy
a latency based routing policy and jio
based routing policy and then failover
routing policy so it kind of improves
the user experience and the key feature
the other key feature of route53 is we
can buy domain names using roth53 using
route53 console we can buy it from here
and use it in rough 53. previously it
was not the case but now we can buy it
directly from amazon through route 53
and we can assign it to any resources
that we want so anybody browsing that
url the connection will be directed to
the server in aws that runs our website
a health checks it monitors health and
performance of the application so it
comes with an health check attached to
it health check are useful to make sure
that the unhealthy resources are retired
right the unhealthy resources are taken
away or your customers are not kind of
hitting the unhealthy resources and they
see an
service down page or something like that
uh we can have weighted
round robin load balancing that's
helpful in spreading
traffic between several services or
servers we are round robin algorithm so
no one server is fully hit or no one
server kind of fully absorbs all the
traffic you know you can shift you can
split and shift the traffic to different
servers based on the weight that you
would be configuring and also weighted
routing also helps with
a soft launch
soft launch of your new application or
the new version of your website there
are different ways we can access amazon
route 53 so you can access amazon route
53 through aws console you can also
access amazon route 53 using aws sdks
and we can access it using we can
configure it using the apis and we can
also do it through the command line
interface that's linux type linux flavor
aws command line interface we can also
do that using windows command line
windows powershell flavored command line
interface as well now let's look at some
of the companies that are using ros 53
so some of the famous companies that use
route 53 are
medium medium is an online publishing
platform and
it's more like a social
journalism it's kind of having hybrid
collection of
professionals people and publications or
exclusive
blogs or publishers on medium it's kind
of an blog website and that uses rot53
for the dns service a reddit is an
social news aggregation or web content
rating and discussion website that uses
route 53 so these are some websites that
that are accessed throughout the world
and they are using roth 53 and it's
highly scalable suddenly there is a new
news right their website will be
accessed a lot and
they need to keep their service up and
running all the time more availability
otherwise
customers will end up in a broken page
and
the number of customers who will be
using the website will come down so it's
very critical these sites these
companies are very critical you know
they're being highly available their
page their site being highly available
and the internet is very critical and
crucial for them and they rely and use
route 53 to meet that particular demand
and airbnb is
another company uh instacart cozara is
another company stripe is another
company that uses route53 to as their
dns uh provider for their dns service
they use route53 so their customers get
best performance they use raw 53 so
their website is highly available they
use route 53 to kind of shift to the
traffic between the resources so their
resources are properly used with all the
weighted routing the resources are
properly used now let's quickly look at
a demo i'm in my aws console and i'm in
route 53 so let me click on rot53 so in
this lab we're actually going to
simulate buying a domain name and then
we're going to create an s3 static
website and we're going to map that
website to this
dns name right so the procedure is the
same for mapping load balancer the
procedure is the same for mapping
cloudfront the procedure is the same for
mapping ec2 instances as well we're
picking s3 for simplicity right but our
focus is actually on route53 so let's go
in here and i will see if we can
we'll buy a domain name here so let's
first check the availability of a domain
name called simply learn hyphen demo
hyphen route 53 let's check its
availability it is available for 12 so
let me add it to cart and then come back
here and then once you continue it'll
ask for personal information once you
give the personal information you
finally check out and then it gets added
to your shopping list once you pay for
it amazon takes like 24 to 48 hours to
make that a dns name available so the
next stage would be contact details and
then the third stage would be
verify and purchase
so once we have bought the domain name
it will become available in our dns
portal and i do have a domain name which
i bought some time back and it's now
available for me to use so i can go to
hosted zone and simply start creating i
can go to hosted zone and then here it's
going to list all the domain names for
me right click on the domain name and
then click on the record set and here i
can actually map elastic load balancer
s3 website vpc endpoint api gateway and
cloud front elastic bean stock domain
names right all that gets mapped through
this portal quite simple like four or
five step
button clicks and then it'll be done so
i have an
domain name bot and then i'm gonna go to
s3 and i'll show you what
i've done in s3 so i've created a bucket
name called as a dns name let me clear
the content in them so i've created a
bucket and then permissions i've turned
off public access blocking and then i've
created and a bucket policy so this
bucket is now publicly accessible and
then i went on the properties and
created the static website hosting right
and i've pointed that this is the file
that's my index file that i'm going to
put or name of the file that's going to
be my index file that i'm going to put
in this s3 bucket so put the index
file.html saved it
and
we're going to create a file now we're
going to create an index file so this is
a sample code it says amazon.53 getting
started routing internet traffic to s3
bucket for your website and then a
couple of other information so save it
as an
index.html file in my desktop so let me
upload that from my desktop into this
bucket so that's index.html and it's in
capital i so let me go to properties and
go to static website hosting and make
sure that i spell it properly right it's
case sensitive and then save it so now
this means that my website should be
running through this url and it does
it's running to the static website url
we're halfway through so now let me go
back to route53 go back to route53 go
back to hosted zones go into the domain
name and then create a record set and
it's going to be an alias record and i i
see my s3 static website endpoint there
right so click on it and create it has
now created an
record that's pointing my domain name to
the s3 endpoint that i have created and
my static website is running from it so
let me test it right so let me go to the
browser put the domain name in there and
sure enough the domain name when my
browser queried for the domain name a
ros 53 returned a response saying this
domain name is actually mapped to the s3
bucket static website hosting enable s3
bucket and this is the url for that
static website hosting and then my
browser was able to connect to that s3
bucket and download the details and show
it in my browser right so it's that
simple and pretty straight forward
today's session is on aws elastic
beanstalk so what's in it for you today
we'll be discussing about what is aws
why we require aws elastic bean stock
what is aws elastic bean stock the
advantages disadvantages the components
of
mean stock along with that the
architecture and the companies that are
primarily using the aws be installed so
let's get started and first understand
what is aws aws stands for amazon web
services it's a cloud provider and that
offers a variety of services such as
compute power database storage content
delivery and many other resources so we
know that aws is the largest
cloud provider in the market and so many
services are available in the aws where
you can apply the business logics and
create the solutions using the cloud
platforms now why aws elastic bean stock
now what happened earlier and uh that
whenever the developer used to create
the software or the modules related to
the softwares it has to be joined
together to create a big application now
one developer creates a module that has
to be shared with another developer and
if the developers are geographically
separated then it has to be shared over
a medium probably an internet so that is
going to take some time uh it would be a
difficult process and in return it uh
makes the application or a software
development a lender process the
building of the software development
lend their process so there were
challenges which the developers were
facing earlier and uh to overcome that
uh we have the beanstalk as a service
available in the aws so why aws elastic
beanstalk is required uh aws elastic
being stock has made the life of the
developers quite easy
in terms of that they can share the
applications across different devices at
a shorter time duration now let's
understand what is aws elastic bean
stock
aws elastic bean stock is a service
which is used to deploy and scale web
applications by developers not only web
application any application that is
being developed by the developers this
is a simple representation of the aws
elastic bean stock now along with that
the aws elastic bean supports the
programming language the runtime
environments that are java.net php
node.js python rubygo and docker and in
case if you're looking for any other
programming language or a runtime
environment then you can make a request
with aws to arrange that for you now
what are the advantages associated with
the elastic bean stock first advantage
is that it's a highly scalable service
now when we talk about the scalability
it means that whenever we require the
resources in demand we can scale up the
resources or we can scale down the
resources so that is kind of a
flexibility we get in terms of changing
the type of resources whenever we need
it and in that case the elastic bean
stock is a highly scalable service now
that is something which is very
difficult to achieve in case of an
on-prem environments because you have to
plan for the infrastructure and in case
if you're short of the resources within
that infrastructure then you have to
procure it again the second advantage
associated with the beanstalk is that
it's a fast and simple to begin now when
we say it's fast and simple that means
that you just have to focus on the
development of an application building
an application and then you can just
deploy the application directly using
the beanstalk what the beanstalk is
going to do that every networking aspect
is being taken care by the bean stock it
deploys your application in the back end
on the servers and then you can directly
access your application using the url or
through the ip address the third
advantage is that it offers the quick
deployment that is what we discussed in
the fast and simple to begin as well so
why it offers a quick deployment you
don't have to bother about the
networking concepts you just have to
focus on the application development and
then you can just upload your
application deploy that and then you're
good to go the other advantage is that
it supports multi-tenant architecture
when we talk about tenants or
multi-tenants that means we can have a
virtual environments for separate
organizations or the divisions within
the organizations that will be virtually
isolated so likewise you can have a
virtually isolated environments created
on the bean stock and they can be
separated used as a separate entities or
a separate divisions within the
organization and we know that it's a
flexible service since it's a scalable
then it is a flexible also now coming to
the simplifies operations as an
advantage now once the application is
deployed using the bean stock then it
becomes very easy to maintain and
support that application using the
beanstalk services itself and the last
advantage that we can have from the
beanstalk is that it's a cost efficient
service the cost efficient as we know
that many of the aw services are cost
effective the cost optimization can be
better managed using the aws mean stock
as compared to if you are developing or
if you are deploying any kind of an
application or a solution on the on-prem
servers now there are some components
that are associated with the aws bean
stock and it has to be created in the
form of a sequence manner so aws elastic
bean stock consists of few important
components which are required while
developing an application now what are
these components these are four
components one is application the second
is application version the third is
environment and the fourth one is the
environment tier and we have to progress
while deploying our applications or the
softwares using the same sequence now
let's understand what are the different
components of the mean stock r the
application it refers to a unique label
which is used as a deployable code for a
web application so generally you deploy
your web application or you create your
application and that is something which
is basically uh used as a unique label
then the second component is application
versions so it resembles a folder which
stores a collection of components
such as environments versions and
environment configurations so all these
components are being stored using the
application version the third most
important component is the environment
in the environment only the current
versions of the applications runs now
remember that elastic means stock
supports multiple versions as well and
using the environment you can only run
the current version of the application
for if you wanted to have another
version of an application to be running
then you have to create an another
environment for that then comes the
environment here and in the environment
here it is basically it designates the
type of application that the environment
runs on now generally there are two
types of environment here one is the web
and the other one is the worker node and
that's something which we'll be
discussing later as well now let's
understand how does elastic beam stock
in aws works so first we have to create
an application and this is a task that
would be done by the developers and for
that you can actually select any runtime
environment or a programming language
like java docker ruby gopal or python as
well and once you select that
environment
you can
develop your application using that
runtime environments now after that once
the application is created then you have
to upload the version of an application
on the aws and after that
once the version is uploaded and then
you have to launch your environment so
just have to click on the buttons that's
it nothing more you have to do once the
environment is
launched then you can actually view that
environment using a web url or using the
ip address now what happens in that case
is when you launch an environment in the
back end the elastic bean stock runs
automatically runs an ec2 instance and
using a metadata the mean stock deploys
our application within that ec2 instance
that is something which you can look
into the ec2 dashboard as well so you
don't have to take care of the security
groups you don't have to take care of
the ip addressing and even you don't
have to login into the instance and
deploy your application it would be done
automatically by the bean stock it's
just that you just have to monitor the
environment and the statistics will be
available there itself in the beanstalk
dashboard otherwise you can view those
statistics in the
cloudwatch logs as well now in case if
you wanted to update any kind of a
version then you just upload a new
version and then just deploy that and
then monitor your environment so these
are the essentials to create a local
applications for any platform whether
it's a node.js python etc these are the
things that you have to actually take
care and this is the sequence you have
to follow while creating an environment
so you can say that it's a four steps
creation of a deployment of your
application that's it now after users
upload their versions the configuration
is automatically deployed with a load
balancer yes and with the load balancer
that means you can access the
applications using the load balancer dns
also and apart from load balancer if you
wanted to put any other feature that
includes the auto scaling for example if
you wanted to create your ec2 instances
where the application will be deployed
within the virtual private cloud or in a
particular subnet within the vpc all
those features that are available and
you can select them using the mean stock
itself you don't have to move out to the
vpc you don't have to actually go to the
ec2 dashboard and select all those
separately everything would be available
within the beanstalk dashboard so that's
what it says in the presentation that
after creating an application the deploy
service can be specifically accessed
using the url so once the environment is
created there will be a url defined now
you can put a url name also that is
something which you wanted to put for
your application you can define that you
can check for the availability of that
url and then you have to use that url to
access your application or the browser
now once it is done then in the monitor
environment it says the environment is
monitored provided capacity provisioning
load balancing auto scaling and multi
features all those features are
available there itself in the mean stock
now let's understand the architecture of
aws elastic green stock now there are
two types of environments that you have
to select you can select one is the web
server environment and the other one is
the worker environment so based on the
client requirement bean stock gives you
two different types of environment that
you have to select generally the web
server environment is the front end
facing that means the client should be
accessing this environment directly
using a url so mostly web applications
are deployed using that environment the
worker environment is the back-end
applications or on the micro apps which
are basically required to support the
running of the web applications now it
depends on the client requirement what
kind of an environment you wanted to
select now in the web server environment
it only handles the http request from
the clients so that's why we use the web
server environment mostly for the web
applications or any application which
works on the http https requests so it's
not only the http you can use the https
as well the worker environment it
process background task and minimizes
the consumption of resources so again it
is just like a kind of a micro service
or an application services that are
running in the back end to support the
web server environment now coming to the
understanding of the aws main stock so
this is how the architecture of the aws
bin stock is designed and you can refer
to that image also now in the web server
environment let's say if we select a web
server environment and it says that if
the application receives client request
the amazon route 53 sends this request
to the elastic load balancer now
obviously we discussed here that the web
server environment is primarily an
environment which receives the http
request it's a kind of a client-facing
environment now if the application
receives a client request amazon from
the amazon note 53 this route 53 is a
service which is primarily used for dns
mapping it's a global service and it may
route you can route the traffic from the
route 53 matching your domains towards
the load balancer and from the load
balancer you can point that traffic to
the web server environment obviously the
web server environment is nothing it's
just the ec2 instances that would be
running in the back end now here in the
diagram you can see that there are two
web server environments and they are
created in the auto scaling group that
means there is some kind of scaling
options that are defined as well and
these instances are created in an
availability zone or they can be created
in a different availability zone also
for the redundancy as well and these web
application servers are further
connected to your databases which
primarily will be in a different
security groups probably it can be an
rds database also so all these
functionalities all these features are
basically available on the elastic mean
stock dashboard itself now what happens
in that case is if the application
receives client requests amazon route 53
send these requests to the load balancer
later the load balancer shares those
requests among the ec2 instances how
does that happen it happens using a
predefined algorithm the equal
distribution of a load is distributed to
both the ec2 instances or n number of
ac2 instances running in the
availability zone now in the
availability zones every ec2 instance
would have its own security group they
can have a common security group also
they can have their own security group
as well now after the security group the
load balancer is then connected to the
amazon ec2 instance which are part of
the auto scaling group so that's
something which we have discussed
already now this auto scaling group is
would be defined from the beanstalk
itself and there will be some scaling
options that will be created it could be
a possibility that it might be the
minimum number of instances that would
be running as of now and based on the
threshold defined it may increase the
number of ec2 instance and the load
balancer will keep on distributing the
load to as many instances that will be
created inside the availability source
obviously there will be an internal
health check that the load balancer will
be first doing before distributing the
real time traffic to this instances
created by the mean stock now what does
auto scaling group does it automatically
starts the additional ec2 instance to
accommodate increasing load on your
application that's something which we
know that and also it monitors and
scales instances based on the workload
as well so depends on what kind of a
scaling threshold you have defined in
the auto scaling groups and when the
load of an application decreases the ec2
instance will also be decreased so
whenever we talk about the auto scaling
generally it comes in our mind is that
we scale up the resources that means we
it increases the ec2 instances in the
auto scaling you might have the scale
down option also scaled down policy also
created in which if the load minimizes
it can terminate the additional ec2
instances as well so that is something
which will be automatically managed all
these features can be achievable using
the elastic bean stock and with this
feature accommodated it gives you the
better cost optimization in terms of
managing your resources now it says that
elastic bean stock has a default
security group and the security group
acts as a firefall for the instances now
here in this diagram it says about the
security group auto scaling also you
might create it in a default vpc also
you might create it in your custom vpc
also where you can have the additional
level of security is also created you
can have the nacl's knuckles also
defined here before the security groups
so that would give you the additional
filtering option or the firewall option
now it says that with these groups with
these security groups it allows
establishing security groups to the
database server as well so every
database would also have its own
security group and the connection can be
created between the web servers
environment that is created by the
beanstalk to the database security
groups as well now let's discuss about
the worker environment now understanding
the worker environment what happens is
that the client the web server
environment is the client facing the
client sends a request for an access to
the web server and in this diagram the
web server further sends it to the sqs
which is a simple queue service and the
queue service sends it to the worker
environment and then whatever the worker
environment is created for doing some
kind of a processing or some kind of an
application that is running in the
backend that environment initiates and
then send back the results to this sqs
and vice versa so let's understand the
architecture of aws elastic bean stock
with the worker environment so when a
worker environment here is launched aws
elastic mean stock installs the server
on every ec2 instance so that is in the
case of a web server environment also
and later the server passes the request
to the simple queue service now this
service is an asynchronous service
instead of a simple queue service you
can have other services also it is not
necessary that you need to have the sqs
also this is an example that we are
discussing about and the sqs shares
those message via a post request to the
http path over the booker environment
and there are many case studies also
with respect to this kind of an
environment that is being created that
has been done on many customers
and you can search for these kind of a
case studies available on the internet
now the worker environment executes the
task given by the sqs with the http
response after the operation is
completed now here what happens is a
quick recap the client request for an
access of an application to a web server
using an http request the web server
passes that request to the queue service
the q service shares the message with
the worker probably a worker might be
the manual worker and generally it's an
automated worker so it would be shared
via the worker environment only and the
worker sends back the response with the
http response back to the queue that
response can be viewed directly from the
queue service by the client using the
web server so this is one of the example
likewise as i said that there can be
many other examples also where you can
have the worker environments defined now
what are the companies that are using
the elastic bean stock these are few of
the companies that are primarily using
on a zillow jelly button games
then you have league of women waters
ebury
these are some of the few listed
companies
and obviously you search on the aws site
and you'll find many more organizations
that are using the elastic bean stock
primarily for deploying their
applications now the next thing is to go
with the practicals that how actually we
use the elastic bean stock so let's look
into the demo using the aws elastic bean
stock now first you have to login into
the aws console and i'm sure that you
might be having the accounts created or
you can use the im credentials as well
and then you have to select the region
also now i am in the north virginia
region likewise you can select any of
the regions that are listed here now
click on the services and you have to
search for the elastic bean stock you
can find the elastic bean stock under
the compute section so here itself
you'll find the elastic bean stock as a
service now open this service and there
it will give you an option to create an
environment you have to specifically
select an environment probably a worker
environment or a web service environment
so let's wait for the service to open so
we have the dashboard now available with
us this is how the elastic bean stock
looks and this is the symbol
representation of a bean stock now what
you have to do is we have to click on
get started and that will load and you
have to create a web app so instead of
creating a web app what we'll do we'll
create a new application so just click
on create a new application put an
application name let's say we put
something like x y z you can put any
description to your application let's
say it's a demo app and click on create
now it says you have to select an
environment
now the environment the application name
xyz is created you just have to select
an environment so click on create one
now and it is going to ask you that what
kind of an environment here you wanted
to select so as we discussed that there
are two types of environments one is the
web server and the other one is the
current one let's look into it what is
defined by the aws aw says that it has
two types of environment tiers to
support different types of web
applications web servers are standard
applications that listen for and then
process http request typically over port
number 80. workers are specialized
application that have a background
processing task that listens for message
on an amazon sqs queue workers
application post those messages to your
application by using the http response
so that's what we saw in the case of the
beanstalk slides also now the usability
of a worker environment can be anything
now we'll do a demo for creating a web
server environment so just click on
select and you we have the environment
name created now we can define our own
domain it ends with the region dot
elastic beanstalk.com let's say i look
for a domain which is xyz only that's
the environment name now i'll check for
the availability whether that domain
name is available with us or not and it
says we don't have that domain name so
probably i'll try to make it with some
other name and let's look for the
availability xyz abc and it says yes it
is available now once i deploy my
application i would be able to access
the application using this complete dns
so you can put a description
it's a demo app that we are creating and
then you have to define a platform as
well now these are the platforms that
are supported by the aws let's say i
wanted to run a node.js environment so
i'll just click on the node.js platform
the application codes is something which
is basically developed by the developers
and you can upload the app application
right now or you can do that later as
well once the environment is ready now
either you can select to create an
environment if you wanted to go with all
the default settings otherwise if you
wanted to customize it more you can
click on configure more options so let's
click on configure more options and here
you would be able to define various
different features like the type of an
instance for example what kind of an ec2
instance or a server that should be
running so that the bin stock can deploy
our applications over it if you wanted
to modify just click on a modify button
and here you can modify your instances
with respect to the storage as well now
apart from that if you wanted to do some
modification in the case of monitoring
in the case of databases in the case of
security or in the case of a capacity
let's look into the capacity so here you
can actually do the modification so in
the capacity you can select the instance
type also by default it is t2.micro but
in case if your application requires a
larger type of an instance then you can
actually go for the instance type as
well similarly you can define your emi
ids also because obviously for the
application to run you would require the
operating system also so you can select
that particular ami id for your
operating system as well let's cancel
that likewise you have many other
features
that you can actually define here from
the dashboard and you don't have to go
to the ec2 dashboard to do the
modifications now let's go and create an
environment let's assume that we are
going with the default configuration so
this is going to create our environment
the environment is being created and you
can get the environment and the logs
defined in the dashboard itself so
you'll see that the beanstalk
environment is being initiated the
environment is being started and in case
if there would be any errors or if it is
deployed correctly you'll get all the
logs here itself now the environments
are basically color coded so there are
different color codings that are defined
if you get the environment in a green
color that means everything is good to
go so here you can see that
it has created an elastic ip it has
checked the health of the environment
now it has created the security groups
and that would be an auto security
groups created by the bean stock and the
environment
creation has been started you can see
that
elastic bean stock has amazon s3 storage
bucket for your environment data as well
this is the url through which you will
be accessing the environment but right
now we cannot do that since the
environment is being created let's click
on the application name and here you can
see that it is in a gray color that
means right now the build is being done
it is being created once it will be
successfully created it should change to
the green color and then we will be able
to access our environment using the url
now if i
move to the ec2 instances and see in the
ec2 dashboard if i see whether the
instance is being created by the bean
stock or not so let's see and let's see
what are the differences in terms of
creating an instance manually and
getting it created from the bean stock
so click on the easy to let's go to the
old ec2 experience that's what we are
familiar with and let's see what's there
in the dashboard so here you can see one
running instance let's open that and the
xyz environment which was created from
the beanstalk is being initiated the
instance is being initiated and that is
something which is being done by the
mean stock itself we have not gone to
the dashboard and created it manually
now in the security groups if you see
that here the aws mean stock security
groups are defined it has the elastic
ips also defined so everything is being
created by the beanstalk itself right
now let's go back to the beanstalk and
let's look into the status of our
environment whether the color coding has
been changed from gray to green or not
and here you can see the environment is
successfully created and we have that
environment colored in green we'll
access the environment and it says it's
a web server environment its platform is
node.js running on 64-bit amazon linux
ami and it says samples app sample
application health status is okay now
the other thing is that if you do not
want to use the web console the
management console to access the main
stock then the beanstalk offers you the
elastic beanstalk cli as well so you can
install the command line interface and
then you have the command references cli
command references that you can actually
play with and get your applications
deployed using the bean stock itself so
this is one of the sample cli commands
that you can actually look into now
let's look into the environment let's
click on the environment and we'll be
represented with the url it says health
is okay
these are the logs that you have to
follow in case if there are any issues
the platform is nodejs that is what we
selected now the next thing is you just
have to upload and deploy your
applications so just click on upload and
deploy select the version label or the
name select file and wherever your
application is hosted at just select
that upload it and deploy your
application you'll see that the like
your environment is created similarly
your application will be deployed
automatically on the instance and from
this url you will be able to view the
output it is as simple as just like you
have to follow these four steps now
let's see whether the node.js
environment is running on our instance
before deploying an application so we'll
just click on this url since the
beanstalk has already opened up the
security groups or http port 80 for all
we can actually view that output
directly from the url so we have the
node.js running that's visible here and
after that you just have to upload and
deploy your application and then from
that url you can get the output now this
url you can map it with the root 53
service so using the root 53 dns
services the domain names can be pointed
to the elastic bean stock url and from
there it can be pointed to the
applications that are running on the ec2
instance whether you wanted to point it
to the url directly using the mean stock
you can do that otherwise as we saw in
the slides you can use the root 53
pointer to the load balancer and then
point it to the instances directly also
once it is created by the mean stock so
that was the demo guys with respect to
the bean stock and how we can actually
run the environments apart from that the
operational task like system operations
you can manage all these things from the
environment dashboard itself so you have
the configurations you have the logs you
can actually check the health status of
your environment you can do the
monitoring and you can actually get the
alarms and the events here so let's say
if i wanted to if i wanted to see the
logs i can request for the logs here
itself and i will be represented with
the full log report and i can now
download that log file and i can view
the locks so it's in the so we have this
bundle locks in the zip file all right
so if you want to see some kind of uh
logs with respect to elastic bean stock
activity it's in the form of a notepad
and here you can see what all
configurations the beanstalk has done on
your environment on your instance
similarly you can go for the health
monitoring alarms events and all those
things if getting your learning started
is half the battle what if you could do
that for free visit skill up by simply
learn click on the link in the
description to know more
hi
this is the fourth lesson of the aws
solutions architect course
migrating to the cloud doesn't mean that
resources become completely separated
from the local infrastructure
in fact running applications in the
cloud will be completely transparent to
your end users
aws offers a number of services to fully
and seamlessly integrate your local
resources with the cloud
one such service is the amazon virtual
private cloud
this lesson talks about creating virtual
networks that closely resemble the ones
that operate in your own data centers
but with the added benefit of being able
to take full advantage of aws
so let's get started
[Music]
in this lesson
you'll learn all about virtual private
clouds and understand their concept
you'll know the difference between
public private and elastic ip addresses
you'll learn about what a public and
private sudden there is
and you'll understand what an internet
gateway is and how it's used
you'll learn what route tables are and
when they are used
you'll understand what and that gateway
is
we'll take a look at security groups and
their importance
and we'll take a look at network acls
and how they're used in amazon vpc
we'll also review the amazon vpc best
practices
and also the costs associated with
running a bpc in the amazon cloud
welcome to the amazon virtual private
cloud and subnet section in this section
we're going to have an overview of what
amazon vpc is and how you use it
and we're also going to have a
demonstration of how to create your own
custom virtual private cloud
we're going to look at ip addresses and
the use of elastic ip addresses in aws
and finally we'll take a look at subnets
and there'll be a demonstration about
how to create your own subnets in an
amazon vpc
and here are some other terms that are
used in vpcs
there's subnets
root tables elastic ip addresses
internet gateways nat gateways network
acls and security groups
and in the next sections we're going to
take a look at each of these and build
our own custom vpc that we'll use
throughout this course
amazon defines a vpc as a virtual
private cloud that enables you to launch
aws resources into a virtual network
that you've defined
this virtual network closely resembles a
traditional network that you'd operate
in your own data center but with the
benefits of using the scalable
infrastructure of aws
a vpc is your own virtual network in the
amazon cloud which is used as the
network layer for your ec2 resources
and this is a diagram of default vpc
now there's a lot going on here so don't
worry about that what we're going to do
is break down each of the individual
items in this default vpc over the
coming lesson
but what you need to know is that a vpc
is a critical part of the exam and you
need to know all the concepts and how it
differs from your own networks
throughout this lesson we're going to
create our own vpc from scratch
which you'll need to replicate at the
end of this so you can do well in the
exam
each vpc that you create is logically
isolated from other virtual networks in
the aws cloud it's fully customizable
you can select the ip address range
create subnets configure route tables
set up network gateways define security
settings using security groups and
network access control lists
so each amazon account comes with a
default vpc that's pre-configured for
you to start using straight away so you
can launch your ec2 instances without
having to think about anything we
mentioned in the opening section a vpc
can span multiple availability zones in
a region
and here's a very basic diagram of a vpc
it isn't this simple in reality
and as we saw in the first section
here's the default amazon vpc
which looks kind of complicated
but what we need to know at this stage
is that cidr block for the default vpc
is always a 16 subnet mask so
in this example it's 172.31.0.0.16.
what that means is this vpc will provide
up to
65536 private ip addresses
so in the coming sections we'll take a
look at all of these different items
that you can see on this default vpc but
why wouldn't you just use the default
vpc
well the default vpc is great for
launching new instances when you're
testing aws
but creating a custom vpc allows you to
make things more secure and you can
customize your virtual network as you
can define your own ip address range you
can create your own subnets that are
both private and public and you can
tighten down your security settings
by default instances that you launch
into a vpc can't communicate with your
own network
so you can connect your vpcs to your
existing data center using something
called hardware vpn access
so that you can effectively extend your
data center into the cloud and create a
hybrid environment
now to do this you need a virtual
private gateway and this is the vpn
concentrator on the amazon side of the
vpn connection
then on your side in your data center
you need a customer gateway which is
either a physical device or a software
application that sits on your side of
the vpn connection
so when you create a vpn connection a
vpn tunnel comes up when traffic is
generated from your side of the
connection
vpc peering is an important concept to
understand
appearing connection can be made between
your own bpcs
or with a vpc in another aws account as
long as it's in the same region
so what that means is if you have
instances in vpca
they wouldn't be able to communicate
with instances in vpc b or c unless you
set up appearing connection
peering is a one-to-one relationship a
vpc can have multiple peering
connections to other vpcs but and this
is important transitive peering is not
supported
in other words
vpca can connect to b and c in this
diagram but c wouldn't be able to
communicate with b unless they were
directly paired
also vpcs with overlapping cidrs cannot
be paired so in this diagram you can see
they all have different ip ranges which
is fine but if they had the same ipo
ranges they wouldn't be able to be
paired
and finally for this section
if you delete the default vpc you have
to contact aws support to get it back
again
so be careful with it and only delete it
if you have good reason to do so and
know what you're doing
this is a demonstration of how to create
a custom vpc
so here we are back at the amazon web
services management console and this
time we're going to go down to the
bottom left where the networking section
is i'm going to click on the pc
and the vpc dashboard will load up now
there's a couple of ways you can create
a custom vpc there's something called
the vpc wizard
which
will build vpcs on your behalf from a
selection of different configurations
for example a vpc with a single public
subnet or a bpc with public and private
subnets
now this is great because you click a
button type in a few details and it does
the work for you however you're not
going to learn much or pass the exam if
this is how you do it so
we'll cancel that and we'll go to your
vpcs
and we'll click on create a vpc
and we're presented with the create the
vpc window
so let's give our vpc a name
i'm going to call that simply learn
underscore vpc
and this is the kind of naming
convention i'll be using throughout this
course
next we need to give it the cidr block
or the classless interdomain routing
block
so we're going to give it a very simple
one 10.0.0
and then we need to give it the subnet
mask so you're not allowed to go larger
than 15. so if i try to put 15 in it
says no
not gonna happen
for reference subnet mask of 15 would
give you around 131 000 ip addresses
and
subnet 16 will give you 65
536 which is probably more than enough
for what we're going to do
next you get to choose the tenancy
there's two options default and
dedicated if you select dedicated then
your ec2 instances will reside on
hardware that's dedicated to you so your
performance is going to be great but
your cost is going to be significantly
higher
so i'm going to stick with default
and we just click on yes create
it'll take a couple of seconds
and then in our vpc dashboard we can see
our simply learn vpc has been created
now if we go down to the bottom here to
see the information about our new vpc we
can see it has a root table associated
with it
which is our default route table
so there it is and we can see that it's
only allowing local traffic at the
moment
we go back to the vpc again
we can see it's been given a default
network acl
and we'll click on that and have a look
and you can see this is very similar to
what we looked at in the lesson
so it's allowing all traffic from all
sources inbound and outbound
now if we go to the subnet section
and just
widen the vpc area here
you can see there's no subnets
associated with the vpc we just created
so that means we won't be able to launch
any instances into our vpc
and to prove it i'll just show you we'll
go to the ec2 section
so this is a glimpse into your future
this is what we'll be looking at in the
next lesson
and we'll just quickly try and launch an
instance we'll select any instance it
doesn't matter
any size not important so here the
network section
if i try and select simply learn vpc
it's saying
no subnets found this is not going to
work
so we basically need to create some
subnets in our vpc
and that is what we're going to look at
in the next lesson
now private ip addresses are ip
addresses that are not reachable over
the internet
and they're used for communication
between instances in the same network
when you launch a new instance is given
a private ip address and an internal dns
hostname that resolves to the private ip
address of the instance but if you want
to connect to this from the internet
it's not going to work
so then you'd need a public ip address
which is reachable from the internet you
can use public ip addresses for
communication between your instances and
the internet
each instance that receives a public ip
address is also given an external dns
hostname
public ip addresses are associated with
your instances from the amazon pool of
public ip addresses
when you stop or terminate your instance
the public i p address is released and a
new one is associated when the instance
starts
so if you want your instance to retain
this public ip address
you need to use something called an
elastic ip address
an elastic ip address is a static or
persistent public ip address that's
allocated to your account and can be
associated to and from your instances as
required
an elastic ip address remains in your
account until you choose to release it
there is a charge associated with an
elastic ip address if it's in your
account but not actually allocated to an
instance
this is a demonstration of how to create
an elastic ip address
so we're back at the amazon web services
management console we're going to head
back down to the networking vpc section
and we'll get to the vpc dashboard on
the left hand side we'll click on
elastic ips
now you'll see a list of any elastic ips
that you have associated in your account
and remember any the elastic ip address
that you're using that isn't allocated
to something you'll be charged for so i
have one available and that is allocated
to an instance currently so we want to
allocate a new address
and it reminds you that there's a charge
if you're not using it i'm saying yes
allocate
and it takes a couple of seconds
and there's our new elastic ip address
now we'll be using this ip address
to associate with the nat gateway when
we build that
aws defines a subnet as a range of ip
addresses in your bpc
you can launch aws resources into a
subnet that you select you can use a
public subnet for resources that must be
connected to the internet and a private
subnet for resources that won't be
connected to the internet
the netmask for the default subnet in
your vpc is always 20 which provides up
to 4096 addresses per subnet and a few
of them are reserved for aws use a vpc
can span multiple availability zones but
the subnet is always mapped to a single
availability zone this is important to
know
so here's our basic diagram which we're
now going to start adding to
so we can see the virtual private cloud
and you can see the availability zones
and now inside each availability zone
we've rated a subnet
now you won't be able to launch any
instances unless there are subnets in
your vpc
so it's good to spread them across
availability zones for redundancy and
failover purposes
there's two different types of subnet
public and private
you use a public subnet for resources
that must be connected to the internet
for example web servers
a public subnet is made public because
the main route table sends the subnets
traffic that is destined for the
internet to the internet gateway and
will touch on internet gateways next
private subnets are for resources that
don't need an internet connection or
that you want to protect from the
internet for example database instances
so in this demonstration we're going to
create some subnets a public and a
private subnet and we're going to put
them in our custom vpc in different
availability zones
so we'll head to networking and vpc
wait for the vpc dashboard to load up
we'll click on subnets
we'll go to create subnet
and i'm going to give the subnet a name
so it's good to give them meaningful
names
so i'm going to call this first one for
the public subnet 10.0.1.0
and i'm going to put this one in
the us east
one
b availability zone
and i'm going to call that simply learn
public
so it's quite a long name i understand
but at least it makes it clear for
what's going on in this example so we
need to choose a vpc so we obviously
want to put it in our simply learn vpc
and i said i wanted to put it in us east
1b i'm using the north virginia region
by the way
so we click on that then we need to give
it the cidr block
now as i mentioned earlier when i typed
in the name
that's the range i want to use and then
we need to give it the subnet mask
and we're going to go with 24
which should give us 251 addresses in
this range which obviously is going to
be more than enough if i try and put a
different value in that's unacceptable
to amazon it's going to say
it's going to give me an error and tell
me not to do that
let's go back to 24
and click on the cut and paste this by
the way just because i need to type
something very similar for the next one
click create
and it takes a few seconds
okay so there's our new subnet and i
just widen this
you can see so that's
the ip range
that's the availability zone it's for
simply learn and it's public
so now we want to create
the private
so put the name in i'm going to give the
private the ip address block
of
that i'm going to put this one in usd 1c
and it's going to be the private
subnet
obviously i want it to be in the same
vpc
where the bit is the zone of us east 1c
and we're going to give it
10.0.2.0.
24.
and we'll click yes create
again it takes a few seconds
okay
so we sort by name
so there we are we can see now we've got
our private subnet and our public server
let me just type in simply then there we
are so now you can see them both there
and you can see they're both in the same
vpc
simply learn vpc
now if we go down to the bottom you can
see the root table associated with these
vpcs
and you can see that they can
communicate with each other internally
but there's no internet access so that's
what we need to do next in the next
lesson you're going to learn about
internet gateways and how we can make
these subnets have internet access
welcome to the networking section
in this section we're going to take a
look at internet gateways root tables
and nat devices
and we'll have a demonstration on how to
create each of these aws vpc items
so to allow your vpc the ability to
connect to the internet you need to
attach an internet gateway
and you can only attach one internet
gateway per vpc
so attaching an internet gateway is the
first stage in permitting internet
access to instances in your vpc now
here's our diagram again and now we've
added the internet gateway which is
providing the connection to the internet
to your vpc
but before you can configure internet
correctly there's a couple more steps
for an ec2 instance to be internet
connected you have to adhere to the
following rules
firstly you have to attach an internet
gateway to your vpc which we just
discussed
then you need to ensure that your
instances have public ip addresses or
elastic ip addresses
so they're able to connect to the
internet
then you need to ensure that your
subnet's root table points to the
internet gateway
and you need to ensure that your network
access control and security group rules
allow relevant traffic to flow to and
from your instance so you need to allow
the rules to let in the traffic you want
for example http traffic
after the demonstration for this section
we're going to look at how route tables
access control lists and security groups
are used
in this demonstration we're going to
create an internet gateway and attach it
to our custom vpc
so let's go to networking bpc
bring up the vpc dashboard
and on the left hand side we click on
internet gateways
so here's a couple of internet gateways
i have already
but i need to create a new one so create
internet gateway
i'll give it a name which is going to be
simply learn
internet gateway igw and i'm going to
click create so this is an internet
gateway which will connect a vpc to the
internet because at the moment our
custom vpc has no internet access
so there is created
simply then i gw
but this state is detached because it's
not attached to anything so let me try
and attach it to a vpc
and it gives me an option of all the
vpcs that have no
internet gateway attached to them
currently
so i only have one which is simply then
bpc
yes attach
now you can see our vpc has internet
attached and you can see that down here
so let's click on that and it will take
us to our vpc
but before any instances in our vpc can
access the internet we need to ensure
that our subnet root table points to the
internet gateway
and we don't want to change the main
route table we want to create a custom
route table and that's what you're going
to learn about next
a route table determines where network
traffic is directed
it does this by defining a set of rules
every subnet has to be associated with a
route table and a subnet can only be
associated with one route table
however multiple subnets can be
associated with the same route table
every vpc has a default route table and
it's good practice to leave this in its
original state and create a new route
table to customize the network traffic
routes associated with your vpc
so here's our example
and we've added two route tables the
main route table and the custom route
table
the new route table or the custom route
table will tell the internet gateway to
direct internet traffic to the public
subnet
but the private subnet is still
associated to the default route table
the main route table which does not
allow internet traffic to it
all traffic inside the private subnet is
just remaining local
in this demonstration we're going to
create a custom route table
associated with our internet gateway and
associate our public subnet with it
so let's go to networking and vpc
the dashboard will load and we're going
to go to
route tables
now our vpc only has its main route
table at the moment the default one it
was given at the time it was created
so we want to create a new route table
and we want to give it a name so we're
going to call it simplylearn
i'm going to call it root table rtb for
sure
and then we get to pick which vpc we
want to put it in so obviously we want
to use simplylearn vpc
so we click create
which will take a couple of seconds and
here you are here's our new route table
so what we need to do now
is change its route so that it points to
the internet gateway so if we go down
here to roots
at a minute you can see it's just like
our main route table it just has local
access
so we want to click on edit
and we want to add another route
so the destination is
the internet which is all the zeros
and our target and we click on this it
gives us the option of our internet
gateway which we want to do
so now we have internet access to the
subnet sorry to this route table
and we click on save
save was successful so now we can see
that as well as local access we have
internet access
now at the moment if we click on subnet
associations
you do not have any subnet associations
so basically both both our subnets the
public and private subnets are
associated with the main route table
which doesn't have internet access
so we want to change this we'll click on
edit
and we want our public subnet to be
associated
with this root table let's click on save
so it's just saving that
so now we can see that our public subnet
is associated with this route table
and this route table
is associated with the internet gateway
so now anything we launch into the
public subnet will have internet access
but what if we wanted our instances in
the private subnet to have internet
access
well there's a way of doing that with a
nat device and that's what we're going
to look at in the next lecture
you can use a nat device to enable
instances in a private subnet to connect
to the internet or other aws services
but prevent the internet from initiating
connections with the instances in the
private subnet
so we talked earlier about public and
private subnets to protect your assets
from being directly connected to the
internet
for example your web server would sit in
the public subnet in your database in
the private subnet which has no internet
connectivity
however your private subnet database
instance might still need internet
access or the ability to connect to
other aws resources
if so you can use a network address
translation device for a nat device to
do this
and that device forwards traffic from
your private subnet to the internet or
other aws services and then sends the
response back to the instances
when traffic goes to the internet the
source ip address of your instance is
replaced with the nat device address and
when the internet traffic comes back
again then that device translates the
address to your instance's private ip
address
so here's our diagram which is getting
ever more complicated and if you look in
the public subnet you can see we've now
added and that device and you have to
put that devices in the public subnet so
that they get internet connectivity
aws provides two kinds of nat devices
and that gateway and a nat instance
aws recommends a nat gateway as it's a
managed service that provides better
availability and bandwidth than that
instances
each nat gateway is created in a
specific availability zone and is
implemented with redundancy in that zone
and that instance is launched from a nat
ami and amazon machine image and runs as
an instance in your vpc so it's
something else you have to look after
whereas in that gateway being a fully
managed service means once it's
installed you can pretty much forget
about it
and that gateway must be launched into a
public subnet because it needs internet
connectivity
it also needs an elastic ip address
which you can select at the time of
launch
once created you need to update the
route table associated with your private
subnet to point internet bound traffic
to the nat gateway this way the
instances in your private subnets can
communicate with the internet
so if you remember back to the diagram
when we had the custom route table which
was pointed to the internet gateway
now we're pointing our main
route table to the nat gateway so the
private subnet also gets internet access
but in a more secure manner
welcome to the create a nat gateway
demonstration where we're going to
create a nat gateway so that the
instances in our private subnet can get
internet access
so we'll start by going to networking
and vpc
and the first thing we're going to do is
take a look at our subnets
and you'll see why shortly so here are
our simply learned subnets so this is
the private subnet that we want to give
internet access but if you remember from
the section
that gateways need to be placed in
public subnets so i'm just going to copy
the name of this subnet id
for the public subnet and you'll see why
in a moment
so then we go to nat gateways on the
left hand side
and we want to create a new nat gateway
so we have to put a subnet in there so
we want to choose our public subnet as
you can see
it truncates a lot of the subnet names
on this option so it's a bit confusing
so we know that we want to put it in our
simply learn vpc
in the public subnet but you can see
it's truncated so it's actually this one
at the bottom but what i'm going to do
is just paste in
the subnet id which i copied earlier
so there's no confusion
then we need to give it an elastic ip
address now if you remember from the
earlier demonstration we created one so
let's select that but if you hadn't
allocated one you could click on the
create new eip button
so
we'll do that
okay so it's telling me my nat gateway
has been created and in order to use
your netgateway ensure that you edit
your route table to include a route with
a target of and then on that gateway id
so it's given us the option to click on
our edit route tables so we'll go
straight there
now here's our here's our route tables
now
here's the custom route table that we
created earlier
and this is the default the main
routeover which was created when we
launched our when we created our vpc
so we should probably give this a name
so that we know what it is so let me
just call this simplylearn
rtb
main
so now we know that's our main route
table
so if you take a look at the main route
and the subnet associations
you can see that our private subnet is
associated with this table
so what we need to do is put a route in
here that points to the nat gateway so
if we click on routes and edit
and we want to add another route
and we want to say that all traffic
can
either go to the simply then internet
gateway which we don't want to do we
want to point it to our nat instance
which is this nat id here
and we click save
so now any instances launched in our
private subnet will be able to get
internet access via on that gateway
welcome to the using security groups and
network acl section
in this section we're going to take a
look at security groups and network acls
and we're going to have a demonstration
on how we create both of these items in
the amazon web services console
a security group acts as a virtual
firewall that controls the traffic for
one or more instances
you add rules to each security group
that about traffic to or from its
associated instances
basically a security group controls the
inbound and outbound traffic for one or
more ec2 instances
security groups can be found on both the
ec2 and vpc dashboards in the aws web
management console we're going to cover
them here in this section and you'll see
them crop up again in the ec2 lesson
and here is our diagram and you can see
we've now added security groups to it
and you can see that ec2 instances are
sitting inside the security groups and
the security groups will control what
traffic flows in and out
so let's take a look at some examples
and we'll start with a security group
for a web server
now obviously a web server needs http
and https traffic as a minimum to be
able to access it
so here is an example of the security
group table
and you can see we're allowing http and
https
the ports that are associated with those
two
and the sources and we're allowing it
from the internet we're basically
allowing all traffic to those ports
and that means any other traffic that
comes in on different ports would be
unable to reach the security group and
the instances inside it
let's take a look at an example for a
database server security group
now imagine you have a sql server
database
then you would need to open up the sql
server port so that people can access it
and which is port 1433 by default so
we've added that to the table and we've
allowed the source to come from the
internet now because it's a windows
machine you might want rdp access so you
can log on and do some administration
so we've also added rdp access to the
security group now you could leave it
open to the internet but that would mean
anyone could try and hack their way into
your box so in this example we've added
a source ip address of
10.0.0.0 so only ipa ranges from that
address
can rdp to the instance
now there's a few rules associated with
security groups
by default security groups allow all
outbound traffic so if you want to
tighten that down you can do so in a
similar way to you can define the
inbound traffic
security group rules are always
permissive
you can't create rules that deny access
so you're allowing access rather than
denying it
security groups are stateful so if you
send a request from your instance the
response traffic for that request is
allowed to flow in regardless of the
inbound security group rules
and you can modify the rules of a
security group at any time and the rules
are applied immediately
welcome to the create security group
demonstration where we're going to
create two security groups one the host
db servers and one the host web servers
now if you remember from the best
practices section it said it was always
a good idea to tear your applications
into security groups and that's exactly
what we're going to do
so we go to networking and vpc to bring
up the vpc dashboard
on the left hand side under security we
click on security groups
now you can also get to security groups
from the ec2 dashboard as well
so here's a list of my existing security
groups but we want to create
a new security group and we're going to
call it
simply learn
web server
sg security group and we'll give the
group name as the same and our
description is going to be simply learn
web servers
security groups
okay and then we need to select our vpc
now it defaults to the default vpc but
obviously we want to put it in our
simply learn vpc so we click yes create
takes a couple of seconds
and there it is there's our new security
group
now if we go down to the
rules the inbound rules
you can see there are none so by default
a new security group has no inbound
rules
but what about outbound rules
if you remember from the lesson
a new security group by default allows
all traffic to be outbound
and there you are all traffic
has destination of everywhere so all
traffic is allowed we're going to add
some rules so let's click on inbound
rules
click on edit
now this is going to be a web server so
if we click on the drop down
we need to give it http
so you can either choose custom tcp rule
and type in your own port ranges or you
can just use the ones they have for you
so http
this pre-populates the port range and
then here you can add the source
now if i click on it it's giving me the
option of saying
allow
access from different security groups
so you could create a security group and
say i only accept traffic from a
different security group which is a nice
way of securing things down you could
also put in here just your ip address so
that only you could do http requests to
the instance but because it's a web
server we want
people to be able to see our website
otherwise it's not going to be much use
so we're going to say all traffic so all
source
traffic can access our instance on port
http 80.
i want to add another rule because we
also want to do https
which is
hiding from me
there we are
and again we want to do
the same
and also because this is going to be a
linux instance we want to be able to
connect to the linux instance to do some
work and configuration so we need to
give it ssh access
and again it would be good practice to
tie it down to your specific ip or an ip
range but we're just going to do all for
now and then we click on save
and there we are there we have our
ranges
so now we want to create our security
group for our db servers so let's click
create security group
and then we'll go through and give it a
similar name
simply learn
db servers
sg
and
the description is going to be simply
learn db servers security group
and our vpc is obviously going to be
simply learn vpc
so let's click yes create wait a few
seconds
and here's our new security group as you
can see it has no inbound rules by
default and outbound rules allow all
traffic
so this is going to be a sql server
database server
and so we need to allow sql server
traffic into the instance
so we need to give
it microsoft sql port access now the
default port for microsoft sql server is
1433.
now in reality i'd probably change the
port the sql server was running on to
make it more secure
but we'll go over this for now and then
the source so we could choose the ipa
ranges again but what we want to do is
place the db server in the private
subnet and allow
the traffic to come from the web server
so the web server will accept traffic
and the web server will then go to the
database to get the information it needs
to display on its web on the website or
if people are entering information into
the website we want the information to
be stored in our db server so basically
we want to say that this the db servers
can only accept sql server traffic from
the web server security group
so we can select the simply then web
server security group as the source
traffic
for microsoft sql server data
so we'll select that now our sql server
is obviously going to be a windows
instance
so from time to time we might not we
might need to log in
and configure it so we want to give rdp
access
now again you would probably put a
specific ip range in there
we're just going to do all traffic for
now
then we click save
and there we are so now we have two
security groups
db servers and web servers
a network acl is a network access
control list
and it's an optional layer of security
for your vpc that acts as a firewall for
controlling traffic in and out of one or
more of your subnets
you might set up network acls with rules
similar to your security groups in order
to add an additional layer of security
to your vpc
here is our network diagram and we've
added network acls to the mix now you
can see they sit somewhere between the
root tables and the subnets
this diagram makes it a little bit
clearer and you can see that a network
acl sits in between a root table and a
subnet
and also you can see an example of the
default network acl
which is configured to allow all traffic
to flow in and out of the subnets to
which is associated
each network acl includes a whose rule
number is an asterisk
this rule ensures that if a packet
doesn't match any of the other numbered
rules it's denied
you can't modify or remove this rule
so if you take a look at this table you
can see on the inbound some traffic
would come in and it would look for the
first rule which is 100 and that's
saying i'm allowing all traffic from all
sources
so that's fine the traffic comes in
if that rule 100 wasn't there it would
go to the asterix rule and the aztecs
rule is saying
traffic from all sources is denied
let's take a look at the network acl
rules
each subnet in your vpc must be
associated with an acl
if you don't assign it to a custom acl
it will automatically be associated to
your default acl
a subnet can only be associated with one
acl however an acl can be associated
with multiple subnets
an acl contains a list of numbered rules
which are evaluated in order starting
with the lowest
as soon as a rule matches traffic it's
applied regardless of any higher
numbered rules that may contradict it
aws recommends incrementing your rules
by a factor of 100
so there's plenty of room to implement
new rules at a later date
unlike security groups acls are
stateless
responses to allowed inbound traffic are
subject to the rules for outbound
traffic
welcome to the network acl demonstration
where we're just going to have an
overview of ocls where they are in the
dashboard
now you don't need to know a huge amount
about them for the exam you just need to
know how they work and where they are
so let's go to networking and vpc
and on when the dashboard loads on the
left hand side under security there's
network acls so let's click on that
now you can see some acls that are in my
my aws account so we want the one that's
associated with our simply learn vpc so
if we extend this vpc
column
that's our network acl simply then vpc
now let's give it a name because
it's not very clear to see otherwise
also i'm kind of an obsessive tagger so
let's call it simply learn acl and click
on the tick so there we are so now it's
much easier to see
so we click on inbound rules so this is
exactly what we showed you in the lesson
the rule is 100 so that's the first rule
that's going to get evaluated and it's
saying allow all traffic from all
sources and the outbound rules are the
same
so if you wanted to
tighten down the new rule you could
click edit
we would give it a new rule number say
which would be 200
so you should always increment them in
100 so that means if you had 99 more
rules you needed to put in place you'd
have space to put them in in between
these two
and then you could do whatever you
wanted you could say
you know we are allowing http access
from
all traffic
and we're allowing or you could say
actually you know what we're going to
deny it so this is the way of
blacklisting traffic into your vpc
now i'm not going to save that because
we don't need it
but this is where network acls sit and
this is where you would make any changes
it's also worth having a look at the
subnet associations with your acl
so we have two subnets in our simply
learn vpc so we would expect to see both
of them associated with this network acl
because it's the default
and there they are this both are public
and our private subnets are associated
and you can also see up here on the
on the dashboard it says default so this
is telling us this is our default acl
if you did want to create a new network
acl you would click create network acl
you'd give it a name
just say new acl
and then you would associate it with
your vpc so we would say simply learn
dpc
takes a few seconds
and there we are there we have our new
one now you can see this one says
default no because it obviously isn't
the default acl for our simply learn vpc
and it has no subnets associated with it
so let's just delete that because we
don't need it but there you are there's
a very brief overview of network acls
welcome to the amazon vpc best practices
and costs
where we're going to take a look at the
best practices and the costs associated
with the amazon virtual private cloud
always use public and private subnets
you should use private subnets to secure
resources that don't need to be
available to the internet such as
database services
to provide secure internet access to the
instances that reside in your private
subnets you should provide a nap device
when using that devices you should use a
nat gateway over nat instances because
they're a managed service and require
less administration effort
you should choose your cidr blocks
carefully
amazon vpc can contain from 16 to 65
536 ip addresses so you should choose
your cidr block according to how many
instances you think you'll need
you should also create separate amazon
vpcs for development staging test and
production or create one amazon vpc with
separate subnets with a subnet each for
production development staging and test
you should understand the amazon vpc
limits there are various limitations on
the vpc components for example you're
allowed 5 vpcs per region
200 subnets per vpc
200 root tables per vpc
500 security groups per vpc
50 in and outbound rules per vpc
however some of these rules can be
increased by raising a ticket with aws
support
you should use security groups and
network acls to secure the traffic
coming in and out of your vpc amazon
advises to use security groups for white
listing traffic and network acls for
blacklisting traffic
amazon recommends tiering your security
groups
you should create different security
groups for different tiers of your
infrastructure architecture inside vpc
if you have web tiers and db tiers you
should create different security groups
for each of them
creating tier-wise security groups will
increase the infrastructure security
inside the amazon vpc
so if you launch all your web servers in
the web server security group that means
they'll automatically all have http and
https open
conversely the database security group
will have sql server ports already open
you should also standardize your
security group naming conventions
following a security group naming
convention allows amazon vpc operation
and management for large-scale
deployments to become much easier
always span your amazon vpc across
multiple subnets in multiple
availability zones inside a region
this helps in architecting high
availability inside your vpc
if you choose to create a hardware vpn
connection to your vpc using virtual
private gateway you are charged for each
vpn connection hour that your vpn
connection is provisioned and available
each partial vpn connection hour
consumed is billed as a full hour
you'll also incur standard aws data
transfer charges for all data
transferred via the vpn connection
if you choose to create a nat gateway in
your vpc you are charged for each nat
gateway hour that your nat gateway is
provisioned and available
data processing charges apply for each
gigabyte processed through the net
gateway each partial nat gateway hour
consumed is billed as a full hour
this is the practice assignment for
designing a custom vpc where you'll
create a custom vpc using the concepts
learnt in this lesson
using the concepts learnt in this lesson
recreate the custom vpc as shown in the
demonstrations
the vpc name should be simply learn vpc
the cidr block should be 10.0.0.0.16
there should be two subnets one public
with a range of 10.0.1.0
and one private with a range of 10.0.2.0
and they should be placed in separate
availability zones
there should be one internet gateway and
one that gateway and also one custom
route table for the public subnet
also create two security groups simply
learn web server security group and
simply learn db server security group
so let's review the key takeaways from
this lesson
amazon virtual private cloud or vpc
enables you to launch aws resources into
a virtual network that you've defined
this virtual network closely resembles a
traditional network that you'd operate
in your own data center but with the
benefits of using scalable
infrastructure of aws
there are three types of ip address in
aws
a private ip address this is an ip
address that's not reachable over the
internet
and it's used for communication between
instances in the same network
a public ip address is reachable from
the internet which you can use for
communication between your instances and
the internet
and there's an elastic ip address this
is a static public persistent ip address
that persists after an instance restarts
whereas a public ip address is raised
associated after each restart
amazon defines a subnet as a range of ip
addresses in your bpc
you can launch aws resources into a
subnet that you select and a subnet is
always mapped to a single availability
zone
use a public subnet for resources that
must be connected to the internet and a
private subnet for resources that won't
be connected to the internet
to allow your vpc the ability to connect
to the internet you need to attach an
internet gateway to it and you can only
attach one internet gateway per vpc
a root table determines where network
traffic is directed it does this by
defining a set of rules
every subnet has to be associated with a
root table and a subnet can only have an
association with one root table however
multiple subnets can be associated to
the same root table
and you can use a nat device to enable
instances in a private subnet to connect
to the internet or other aws services
but and that device will prevent the
internet from initiating connections
with instances inside your private
subnet
a security group acts as a virtual
firewall that controls the traffic for
one or more instances
you add rules to each security group
that allow traffic to or from its
associated instances
a network access control list or network
acl is an optional layer of security for
your vpc that acts as a firewall for
controlling traffic in and out of one or
more of your subnets
today's session is on aws sagemaker
let's look into what we have in our
today's session
so what's in it for you we would be
covering what is aws
why do we need aws sage maker
what is aws sage maker services
what are the benefits of using the aws
sagemaker
machine learning with aws sagemaker how
to train a model with aws stage
sagemaker how to validate a model with
aws
and the companies that are using aws
shmaker along with that we will be
covering up one live demo on the aws
platform
now let's understand what is aws
so
what is aws it's an amazon web services
it's a largest
or
most widely used public cloud platform
offered by amazon it provides services
over the internet
aws services can be used to build
monitor
and deploy any type of application in
the cloud
aws also uses the subscription pricing
model that means you only pay for
whatever the services you use for
now why do we need aws sagemaker let's
look into it so
let's consider an example of one of the
company that is proquest
now before aws sh maker
the proquest is a global information
content and technology company
that provides valuable content such as
ebooks newspapers etc to the users
before awschmaker
the proquest requirement was to have a
better user experience maximum relevant
search results now after aws sh maker
they were able to achieve those
results
so they achieved more appealing media
user experience they achieved more
relevant search results for the users
now what do we mean by aws age maker why
this service is primarily used
so
amazon sage maker is a cloud machine
learning platform
that helps users in building training
tuning and deploying machine learning
models in a production ready hosted
environment
so it's kind of a machine learning
service which is already hosted on the
aws platform now what are the benefits
of using aws sagemaker
uh the key benefits of using aws
sagemaker are
it reduces machine learning data cost so
you can do the cost optimization
while running
this particular service on the aws
all ml components are stored in a
particular place in a dashboard so they
can be managed together
highly scalable so it can be scalable on
you can scale
this particular service on the fly
it trains the models quite faster
maintains the uptime so you can be
assured that your workloads will be
running all the time it will be
available all the time
high data security so security becomes a
major concern on the cloud platforms and
it ensures that you have the high data
security along with that can do a data
transfer to different aws services like
s3 bucket and all
with these simple data transfer
techniques
now machine learning with aws sagemaker
let us look into it
so machine learning with aws sagemaker
is a three step function
so one is to build second is to test and
tune the model and third is to deploy
the model now with the build it provides
more than 15 widely used ml algorithms
for training purpose
now to build a model you can collect and
prepare training data or you can select
from the amazon s3 bucket also choose
and optimize the required algorithm so
some of the algorithms that you can
select are k means linear regressions
logistic regression sagemaker helps
developers to customize ml instances
with the jupyter notebook interface
in the test and tune you have to setup
and manage the environment for training
so you would need some sample data to
train the model
so train and tune a model
with the amazon sagemaker
sagemaker implements hyperparameter
tuning
by adding a suitable combination of
algorithm parameters also it divides the
training data and stores that in the
amazon s3 s3 is a simple storage service
which is primarily used for storing the
objects and the data hence it is used
for storing and recovering data over the
internet and
below you can see that aws sagemaker
uses amazon s3 to store data as it's
safe and secure also it divides the
training data and stores in amazon s3
where the training algorithm code is
stored in the ecr ecr stands for elastic
container registry which is primarily
used for containers and dockers ecr
helps users to save monitor and deploy
docker and the containers later maker
sets up a cluster for the input data
trains it and stores it in the amazon s3
itself so this is done by the sagemaker
itself after that you need to deploy it
so suppose you want to predict limited
data at a time
you use amazon sage maker hosting
services for that okay but if you want
to get prediction for an entire data set
prefer using amazon sage maker batch
transform now the last step that is to
deploy the model
so once tuning is done models can be
deployed to sagemaker endpoints
and in the end point real time
prediction is performed so you would
have some data
which you would reserve and
validate your model whether it is
working correctly or not now evaluate
your model and determine whether you
have achieved your business goals
now the
other aspect is how we can train a model
with aws stage maker
so this is basically a flow
diagram which shows you how to train a
model with the aws sagemaker and
here we have used couple of services of
an aws to get that done
so model training in aws age maker is
done on machine learning compute
instances
and here we can see there are two
machine learning compute instances used
as helper code and the training code
along with that we are using 2s3 buckets
and the ecr for the container registry
now let's look into what are the ways to
train the model as per the slides
so below are the following requirements
to train a model so here in the diagram
you can see these are the following
requirements to train a model
the url of an amazon s3 bucket where the
training data is stored that is
mentioned
the compute resources on machine
learning compute instances so these are
all your machine learning compute
instances
then the url of an amazon s3 bucket
where the output will be stored
and the path of aws elastic container
registry
where the code data is safe the
inference code image lies in the
elastic container registry now what are
these calls these are called as the
training jobs
now when a user trains a model in amazon
sage maker he she creates a training job
so we need to first create a training
job and then the input data is fetched
from the specified amazon s3 bucket
once the training job is built amazon
sage maker launches the ml compute
instances so these compute instances
will be launched once the training job
is built then it trains the model with
the training code and the data set and
it shows the output and model rt crafts
in the aws s3 bucket so this is done
automatically now here the helper code
performs a task when the training code
fails the interference code which is in
the elastic container registry
consists of
multiple linear sequence containers
that process the request for inference
on data
the ec2 container registry is a
container registry that helps users to
save monitor and deploy container images
whereas container images are the ready
applications
once the data is trained the output is
stored in the specified amazon s3 bucket
so here you can see the output will be
stored here to prevent your algorithm
being deleted save the data in amazon
sagemaker critical system
which can process you on your ml compute
instances now how to validate a model
let's look into it so you can evaluate
your model
using offline or using the historical
data so first thing is that you can do
the offline testing to validate a model
you can do an online testing with the
live data so if you have a live data
coming or real time streams coming you
can validate a model from there itself
you can validate using a hold out set
and also you can validate using the
k-fold validation now use historical
data to send requests to the model
through the jupyter notebook in amazon
sagemaker for the evaluation online
testing with live data deploys multiple
models into the endpoints of amazon
sagemaker and directs live traffic to
the model for
validation validating using a holdout
set
is part of the data is set aside
where which is called holdout set so
the part of the data is left
which is basically called as the holdout
set
this data is not used for the model
training
so later when the model is trained
with the remaining input data and
generalize the data based on what is
learnt initially so whatever the data
which is left out
will be used for validating a model
because we have not used the data
while training a model the k-fold
validation
is
the input data is split into two parts
one part is called k
which is the validation data for testing
the model and the other part is k minus
which is used as a training data
now based on the input data the machine
learning model evaluates the
final output now
the companies that are using aws
sagemaker one is the adp so you must be
knowing about adb zelando
dow jones which is on the stock market
proquest
and the intuit
now let's look into the demo that how we
can actually run the aws sagemaker
so we'll use the r algorithm and then
package the algorithm as a container for
building training and deploying a model
we are going to use the jupyter notebook
for that for model building for model
training for model deployment
and the code for the demo is in the
below link so you can see here that from
this link you can get the code for the
demo
let's try to
do a demo on the aws
now i would be using a link which is
provided by amazon to build train and
deploy the machine learning model on the
sage maker as you can see on my screen
and in this tutorial you would have some
steps where you can put those steps and
the code python codes into your
awschmaker jupiter lab
so in this tutorial you will learn how
to use amazon sagemaker to build train
and deploy a machine learning model and
for that we will use the popular xt
boost ml algorithm for this exercise
so first of all what you need to do is
you have to go to the aws console and
there you have to create a notebook
instance
so in this tutorial you will be creating
a notebook instance you will prepare the
data train the model to learn from the
data
deploy the model evaluate your ml
model's performance and once all those
activities are done then we will see how
we can actually remove all the resources
in order to prevent the extra costing
now the first step is we have to enter
to the amazon sage maker console so here
you can see i'm already logged in into
the sagemaker console you can click on
the services
search for the sagemaker here
and here you get the amazon sagemaker
service
now the next step is
that we have to create a notebook
instance so
we will select the notebook instance
from the sagemaker service
and then
after the notebook instance is selected
we'll put a name to our instance and
we'll create a new im role for that
so let's wait for the sagemaker studio
to open
so here you can see the studio is open
and you just have to click on the
notebook instances
and here you have to create a notebook
instance so here you can see couple of
notebook instances have already been
created one of them is in service so
this is the notebook instance that we
are going to use for
creating the
demo model
i'll show you how you can create a
notebook instance you just have to click
on create notebook instance button
and put your notebook instance name so
you can put something like demo dash
sage maker 987 or we can put it as model
we'll go with notebook instance type as
default which is mlt2.medium
and in the permission and encryptions
under the im rule we will click on
create a new im role
now why we are creating a new im rule so
that we can allow the sage maker
to access any s3 bucket that has been
created on our account
just click on create a role and here you
would see
that the new im role will be created
with the set of permissions
then rest of the things will keep it as
default and then you just have to click
on create a notebook instance
the notebook instance creation takes
some time so you just have to wait for a
couple of minutes to get that in service
we already have one of the notebook
instance that has been created so we
will be using
that to create a demo
now going back to the steps so these are
the steps that we have already performed
now once the notebook instance is
created then we have to prepare the data
so
in this step we will be using the
sagemaker notebook instance to
pre-process the data that would require
to train the machine learning model
and for that we would be opening up the
jupiter notebook
and then we have to select an
environment a kernel environment in the
jupyter notebook that would be conda
underscore python 3.
so let's
follow these steps
go back to the sage maker click on the
notebook instances
select the running notebook instance and
here you would select the open jupiter
lab
now here you would see that the
sagemaker would try to open up the
jupiter notepad
and we would be performing all our
inputs into that jupiter notebook
and executing the results there itself
so just wait for the notebook to open
now here you can see the jupiter lab
notebook has been open so i would be
selecting one of the notebook that has
been created
so this one so likewise you can create
your own notebook also
how you can do
that first of all let me select the
kernel environment so i would be
selecting corner underscore python 3
and just click on select
so how you can create your own notebook
just have to click on file click on new
and here you can select the notebook
just name your notebook select the
environment conda underscore python 3 to
run this demo
so i have my notebook open so in the
tabs i would be putting up the python
codes and i would be executing those
codes to get the output directly
so the next step is
to prepare the data train the ml model
and deploy it we will need to import
some libraries
and define a few environment variables
in the jupyter notebook environment
so i would be copying this code
which you can see that would try to
import numpy pandas these are all
required to run the
python
syntax
so just
copy this code
and paste it into your
notebook
right so once you do that execute your
code
and here you can see
that
you get the output which is
that it has imported all the necessary
libraries that have been defined in the
code
now the next step is we would create an
s3 bucket
into the s3 service
and for that you have to copy this
python code
just that you have to edit it so you
have to specify this
bucket name that you want to get created
so here i would
provide the bucket name which should be
unique
should not overlap
so something like sage maker
dash
demo
is the name that i have selected for the
bucket and now you have to execute that
code it says that the s3 bucket has been
created successfully with the name sage
maker dash demo 9876 so this is
something which you can verify so you
can go to the s3 service and there you
can verify whether the bucket has been
created or not
now the next task is that we need to
download the data
to the aws sagemaker instance and load
it into the data frame and for that we
have to
follow this url so from this url
which is
built train deploy machine learning
model would have a data in the form of
bank underscore clean.csv
and this will be deployed onto our
sagemaker instance
we'll copy this code
and paste it here
and execute the code
so it says that it has successfully
downloaded bank underscore clean.csv
which is which has the data inside it
and that has to be loaded into the
sagemaker data frame successfully
now we have a data to
build and
train our machine learning model
so what we are going to do we are going
to shuffle the data and we are going to
split it one into the training data set
and the other one into test data set
so for the training data set we are
going to use 70 of the customers that
are listed in the csv file and 30 of the
customers in the csv file data we will
be using it as a test data to train the
model
so we'll copy the following code into a
new code cell and then we are going to
run that
code cell
so i'll just
copy it
for training the data so that we can
segregate
the data model 70
for building the model and
30 for
testing the data so click on
run the execution and here you can see
that we got the output successfully
now
we have to train the model from that
data so how we are going to train that
model and for that we will use sage
maker pre-built xg boost model which is
an algorithm
so you will need to reformat the header
and first column of the training data
and load the data from the s3 bucket so
what i'll do is i'll copy
this syntax
and paste it
in the note cell
so it has the trained data it would
train
the model
click on run execution
now it is
changing the s3 input class which will
be renamed to training input because now
we are training the model with the
training data
so we just have to wait for some time
till it gets executed completely
now the next thing is that we need to
set up the amazon sage maker session to
create an instance of the xgboost model
so here we are going to create this
sagemaker session say we are going to
create an instance of the xt boost model
which is an estimator
so just copy that
copy that code
and paste it here
execute it
and here you can see that
it will start it has basically changed
the parameter image name to the
image underscore uri in this sagemaker
python sdk v2
now we will follow the next step that is
with the data loaded in the xt boost
estimator we will set up train the model
using gradient optimization
and
we'll copy the following code and that
would actually start the training of
the model
so copy
this code
and
this would actually
start training the model
using our input data that we have
reserved 70 of that data that we have
reserved for training the model
so just copy that
again initiate the execution and it will
start the training job
now we'll deploy the model and for that
i would copy the deploy code put that in
the cell
and execute it
so
it says parameter image will be renamed
to image uri and using already existing
model so hd boost was deployed already
uh if you have not done that
if you're doing it the first time so it
will initiate another xd boost instance
so where you can find your xt boost
endpoints created you just have to
scroll down and here under the
inference
click on the end points
and you should find the xg boost
endpoints defined here
so here you can see that today i have
created one xt boost
endpoint
and that is now in process of
creating so just refresh it
so it is
still created it is going to take some
time to get that in service
now our endpoint is in service state so
now we can use it so
going forward with the next steps we'll
try to predict whether the customer in
the test data enroll for the bank
product or not for that we are going to
copy this code put that in the jupyter
cell function and execute it
so here it gives you the output that it
has actually evaluated and the same
output we got in the screenshot
of the demo as well now we are going to
evaluate the model performance so what
we are going to do we are going to get
the prediction done so based on the
prediction we can conclude that you
predicted a customer that will enroll
for a certificate of deposit accurately
for 90 of the customers in the test data
with the precision of 65 percent for
enrolled and 90
which are which haven't enrolled for it
so for that we are going to copy this
code
and executed here in the cell
so if it is predicted correctly that
means our model is working absolutely
fine so here you can say the overall
classification rate is 89.5 percent and
there is the accurate
prediction that has been made by the
model and that's what the output we can
see here
in the screenshot of a model so that
means our model is absolutely working
fine it has been built deployed and
trained correctly
now the next thing is that once you are
done with that you terminate your
resources and for that you just have to
copy
this code and put that in the cell
function so that the additional
resources and the endpoints and the
buckets that have been created by the
jupiter notepad should be
terminated so that you would not be
incurred with the extra costing so just
execute it and here you would see that
it has tried to it would try to
terminate all the additional resources
that we have created from the jupiter
today's tutorial is on aws cloudfront
let's look into what we have today in
the cloud front
so what's in it for you
we would be covering up the concept of
what is aws
what was earlier uh before aws
cloudfront after aws cloudfront what
were the services that were introduced
how it benefited what do we mean by aws
cloudfront benefits of the using aws
cloudfront and how aws cloudfront
actually is known as a content delivery
service the name of the companies that
are using aws cloudfront and we would be
covering up one live demo
now aws is the amazon web services it's
a cloud service provider that basically
offers a multiple services variety of
services such as
compute power database storage
networking and other resources so that
you can
create your solutions on the cloud and
help the business grow now with aws you
only pay for whatever the services you
use so for example if you are using a
service for a couple of hours then you
pay for only that many hours that you
have used that service
before aws cloud front so there is an
example that we are going to talk and
that is you must be aware of an
application called spotify so when you
used to access spotify and
when you click on it it kept on loading
and at the end you used to get the error
and the error was that the connection
failed and why you received that error
because of a latency issue probably a
network error right so how you can solve
these kind of a latency issues and that
is also going to these kind of an issues
are also going to impact the performance
of an application
so
with the introduction of aws cloud from
this problem of loading the application
got resolved so after aws cloud front
with the help of idle base cloud front
spotify gives the facility of updating
new features access to million songs
that you can access instantly
so with the use of aws cloud front or
the latency issues were solved and
successfully you can
basically access your application
now
what we mean by aws cloudfront so aws
cloudfront is a globally distributed
network that is offered by aws amazon
web services which securely delivers
content to the end users across any
geography
with a higher transfer speed and an
improve or a low latency now what are
the benefits of aws cloudfront there are
multiple benefits one is the cost
effective so
it helps you to do the cost optimization
when you use the cloud front it is time
saving so
it is implemented easily
and also a lot of issues with respect to
accessing the application
with respect to latency and all can be
resolved
content privacy so
the content is placed to the end users
and also to
the cloudfront servers
in a secured manner in a secured way
it is highly programmable and you can
make the changes amend the changes on
the fly
and you can target any location any
geography across the globe along with
that it helps you to
get the content deliver quickly
now how aws cloudfront delivers the
content let's look into the architecture
so
this is a flow and the flow is with
respect to how the user is going to get
a content from the cloud front now the
client first accesses a website by
typing a url on the browser
and in the step one it acts tries to
access the application
then the client requests when the
website is open the client request for
an object to download such as for
example a particular file
now
at that time the dns
routes user request to download that
file to aws cloudfront
the aws cloud front connects to the
nearest edge locations edge locations
are basically the servers
where it caches
the files documents and the web codes
aws cloud front connects to its nearest
edge location in order to serve the user
the request
at edge location
aws crowdfund looks for its requested
cache file
once the file is found let's say if the
file is available in the cache of an
edge location
aws cloudfront then sends the file
to the user
otherwise if the file is not found in
the cache memory of an edge location
ews cloud front compares the requirement
with the specification and share it with
a respected server that means a web
server or a server where the file is
actually available the server the web
server responds
to the edge location by sending the file
back to the cloud front edge location
and then as soon as the aws cloud front
receives the file
it shares with the client also adds the
file to the cache of an edge location
for a future reference this is how the
flow of a cloud front is now
the name of the companies that are using
the aws cloud front
so one of them is jio7
app which is which is a very popular app
so it uses amazon cloudfront to deliver
15 petabytes of audio and video to its
subscribers globally which is a huge
data sky news it uses the service in
order to unify the content for faster
distribution to scrub
subscribers or the discovery
communications
also uses the cloud front it uses the
service for delivering api
static asset and also the dynamic
content
and then
the tv one eu streaming europe is
basically also uses
the cloudfront service that helps in
improving latency and performance
that results in fastest delivery of
content
now let's look into the demo how to use
cloudfront to serve
private s3 bucket as a website
now i'm going to
run a cloudfront distribution demo on
the aws console
and
we'll basically try to deliver the
content from a private s3 bucket
and then map that with the domain name
using the root 53 service
so what we need for this demo we would
need
a domain url we would need
a route 53 service we would need
cloud front uh we have to create a cloud
front distribution
and that will be linked with our s3
bucket the private s3 bucket
right
and in the s3 bucket we would have
one html file the index.html file
so let's uh move into aws console
so right now i have opened up the
cloudfront distribution
and here you can see
that couple of distributions have
already been created so what i'm going
to do i'm going to create a distribution
now there are two types of delivery
method for your content one is the web
distribution and the other one is
rtmp
rtmp stands for real time
audio or video distribution
it's basically
used for
distribution of a media content or a
media file which are available in the s3
bucket
here
we are going to select a web
distribution because primarily we will
be using files which uses protocols http
or the https
so you have to click on get started
and
in the origin domain name you have to
specify
the bucket where your code is available
so
i have a bucket already created
here you can see
and what you need to do is you have to
create a bucket
with the url name or the domain name
which you would be mapping with the
route 53 service
so this is a bucket that has already
been created let me show you in a new
tab
so
here you have to go to the storage under
the storage
you have to select the s3 bucket
let's open the link in the new tab and
let's look into
how we can create the s3 buckets
now here are a couple of buckets already
created i have created one bucket with
the domain name that i'm going to use
and map it with the route 53 service
so that is basically mapped to a region
which is in ohio
and if you open up this bucket
here you will find an html webpage the
index.html has been
already added
right so similarly you have to create a
bucket with a domain and an index.html
page needs to be uploaded there
now again we'll go to the cloud front we
will try to create a distribution
just have to click on create
distribution
select a web delivery method
select an origin domain which is
sunshinelearning.n
and origin path you don't have to
specify origin id is this one
so basically when you define an origin
domain name automatically the origin id
appears
you can customize this origin id as per
your requirement also
so rest of the things primarily we keep
it as a default settings only until and
unless if we require some customized
settings to be done
so let's say if you have to change the
cache behavior settings you can do that
otherwise we'll keep it as default
now in the distribution setting you can
either
select use all edge locations for the
best performance so what does aws
basically do here
it uses all the edge locations
which are associated with aws across the
globe
otherwise you can specify based on the
regions also right
apart from that if you want to enable
firewalls or the access control list you
can specify here
and then
what you need to do is in the default
root object here you have to specify
your index.html
page which is in the s3 bucket
the distribution state has to be enabled
and if you want to use ipv6 as well you
need to enable it
click on create distribution
now you you can see here
a distribution has been created it's in
progress and it is enabled
and it takes around 15 to 20 minutes to
get that distribution
completed the reason is that the web
codes the web pages will be
distributed across all the edge
locations across the globe so hence it
takes time to get that done
right now let's move on to root 53
service
and let's create the hosted zones
so we'll type root 53 here scalable dns
and domain name registration
and what we are going to do here is
we are going to map our url the domains
pointed to
[Music]
the name servers that will be provided
by the route 53 so we have to create a
hosted zone
let's wait for it
so now
the route 53 dashboard is open and you
can see one hosted zone is already
created so just click on the hosted
zones
and in order to point the traffic from
the external domains towards the aws
you have to first point the domain's
traffic to the
hosted zone in the route 53.
so
i'll click on create hosted zone but
before that i will
first delete the existing one
and then i'll
create another record another hosted
zone
right
put your domain name let's say i put as
sunshine learning dot in
and it is acting as a public hosted zone
rest of the things will be default click
on create hosted zone
now it gives you four name servers and
these four name servers has to be
updated
in the domain so you have to update
these name servers in a platform from
where you have purchased the domain
right so this is half of the work done
then what you need to do is you have to
go and create records
now in the records you can select a
routing policy so right now what we are
targeting we are targeting basically
that the traffic from the domain should
be pointed directly towards the
cloudfront distribution
hence we are going with a simple routing
right now
click on
next
here you have to specify the record sets
so we are going to create the records
uh just click on default simple record
put here as world wide web
and you have to select an end point so
end point we are selecting for the
cloudfront distribution so we have to
specify
alias for the cloudfront distribution
now here we are going to put
the cloudfront distribution url
and then we are going to define the
simple report set
so what we need is we need a cloudfront
distribution url
which you can find it uh
from the cloudfront service itself and
you can find the domain name here itself
you just have to copy that
and then
paste it here in the distribution
just click on define simple records
again click on create records
and here you can see
the record set has been updated
now this domain is basically
pointed towards these name servers which
are further pointed
towards the cloud front distribution
right now the only thing which is left
is that
within the domain from wherever you have
purchased the domain
you should update these phone name
servers and
then you can see the live traffic coming
on this domain
will have an output from the cloud front
distribution
today's topic is on aws auto scaling so
this is akil i would be taking up a
tutorial on the auto scaling
let's begin with our tutorial and let's
look into what we have in today's
session
so
i would be covering up
why we require aws auto scaling
what is aws auto scaling
what are the benefits
of using the scaling service
how this auto scaling works
the different scaling plans we have
what is the difference between the
snapshot and the ami
what is the load balancer and how many
types of load balancers we have and
along with that i would be covering up a
real life demo on the aws
let's begin with why we require aws auto
scaling
now before aws cloud scaling there was a
question in the mind of enterprises that
they were spending a lot of
money on the purchase of the
infrastructure
if they have to set up some kind of a
solution so they have to purchase an
infrastructure and one time cost was
required
so that was a burden for them in terms
of procuring a server hardware software
and then
having a team of experts to manage all
those infrastructure
so they used to think that no longer
they require these resources
if there was a cost efficient solution
for their project that was the project
manager used to think
now after the aws cloud scaling that was
introduced
automatically the auto scaling maintains
the application performance
based on the user requirements at the
lowest possible price
so what does the auto scaling does is
that whenever there is a scalability
required it manages it automatically
and hence the cost optimization became
possible
now what is aws auto scaling let's look
into deep so aws auto scaling is a
service that helps users to monitor
their applications and the servers
and automatically adjust the capacity of
their infrastructure
to maintain the steadiness so they can
increase the capacity they can even
decrease the capacity also for the cost
optimization
and also predictable performance at the
lowest possible cost
now what are the benefits of auto
scaling
it gave the better fault tolerance
applications you can get the servers
created and you can have a clone copy of
the servers so that you don't have to
deploy the applications again and again
better cost management because the
scalability is decided by the aws
automatically based on some threshold
parameters
it was a reliable service and
whenever the scaling is created or
initiated you can get the notifications
onto your mail ids or to your cell
phones
scalability as i mentioned is always
there in the auto scaling it can scale
up it can scale down as well
and it has the flexibility the
flexibility in terms of whenever you
want to schedule it if you want to stop
it if you want to keep the size of the
servers at a fixed number
uh you can always make the changes on
the fly and the better availability
now
with the use of the auto scaling we come
around with the terminology called
snapshot and the ami let's look into the
difference between the snapshots and the
ami
snapshots versus ami
so in a company there was one of the
employee that was facing an issue with
launching the virtual machines
so he asked his colleague a question
is it possible to launch multiple
virtual machines with a minimum amount
of time because it takes a lot of time
in terms of creating the virtual
machines
the other colleague said that yes it is
possible to launch multiple ec2 instance
and that can be done at a lesser time
and with the same configuration
and this can be done either you use a
snapshot or the ami on the aws
then the colleague said that what are
the differences between the snapshot and
ami
let's look into the difference now the
snapshots basically kind of a backup of
a single abs volume
which is just like a virtual hard drive
that is attached to the ec2 instance
whereas the ami it is basically used as
a backup of an ec2 instance only
the snapshots
opts for this when the instance contain
multiple static ebs when you opt for the
snapshot whenever the instance contains
multiple static evs volumes
ami this is widely used to replace the
failed
ec2 instance
in the snapshots here you pay only for
the storage of the modified data
whereas with the ami you pay only for
the storage that you use
the snapshots are non-bootable images on
ebs volume
whereas ami are bootable images on the
ec2 instance
however creating an ami image will also
create the evs snapshots
now how does aws auto scaling work let's
look into it
so for the aws auto scaling to work you
have to configure single unified scaling
policy for application resource
and this scaling policy with that you
can explore the applications also
and then
select the service you want to scale
also for the optimization select do you
want to optimize cost or do you want to
optimize the performance
and then keep track of scaling by
monitoring or getting the notifications
now what are the different scaling plans
we have
so
in the auto scaling a scaling plan
basically helps a user to configure a
set of instructions
for scaling based on
the particular software requirement
the scaling strategy basically guides
the service of aws auto scaling on how
to optimize resources in a particular
application so it's basically a kind of
the parameters that you set it up so
that how the resource optimization can
be achieved in the auto scaling
with the scaling strategies users can
create their own strategy based on their
required metrics and thresholds and this
can be changed on the fly as well
what are the two types of scaling
policies we have so there are basically
dynamic scaling and the predictive
scaling
now what is dynamic scaling it basically
guides the service of aws auto scaling
on how to optimize the resources
and it is helpful in optimizing
resources for availability and
particular price
now with scaling strategies users can
create their plan based on the required
metrics and thresholds so a metric can
be like let's say a network in network
out or it can be a cpu utilization
memory utilization likewise
now in the predictive scaling its
objective is to predict future workload
based on daily and weekly trends and
regular forecast future network traffic
so it is kind of a forecast that happens
based on the previous past experiences
it uses a machine learning technique for
analyzing that network graphic and this
scaling is like how weather forecast
works
right
it provides schedule scaling actions to
ensure the resource capacity is
available for application requirement
now
with the auto scaling you would need the
load balancers also because if there are
multiple instances that are created then
you would need a load balancer to
distribute
the load to those instances
so
let's understand what do we mean by a
load balancer
a load balancer basically acts as a
reverse proxy
and it is responsible for distributing
the network or the application traffic
across multiple
servers
with the help of a load balancer you can
achieve a reliability you can achieve a
fault tolerance of an application that
is basically it increases the fault
tolerance and the reliability
so for example
when there is a high network traffic
that is coming to your application and
if
that much traffic comes to your
application to the instances your
instances may crash
so how you can avoid that situation
so
you need to manage the network traffic
that is coming to your instances and
that can be done with the load balancer
so thanks to the aws load balancers
which helps in distributing network
traffic across backend servers
in a way that it increases performance
of an application
here in the image you can see the
traffic coming from a different
resources landing on to the ec2 instance
and the load balancer is actually
distributing that traffic to all the
three instances hence managing the
network traffic quite properly
now what are the types of load balancers
we have there are three types of load
balancers on the aws one is the classic
load balancer second is the application
load balancer and the third one is the
network load balancer
let's look into what we have in the
classic load manager
so the classic load balancer is the most
basic form of load balancing and we call
it as a primitive load balancer also and
it is widely used for the ec2 instances
it is based on the ip address and the
tcp port and it routes network traffic
between end users as well as in between
the backend servers
and it does not support host-based
routing and it results in low efficiency
of resources
let's look into what we have in the
application load balancer
this is one of the advanced forms of
load balancing it performs a task on the
application level in the osi model
it is used when there are http and https
traffic routing is required
and also it supports the host-based and
path-based routing and performs well
with the
services or the backend applications
the network load balancer performs the
task at layer 4 of the connection level
in the osi model
the prime role of the network load
balancer is to route the tcp traffic and
it can manage a massive amount of
traffic and is also suitable to manage
the low latencies
let's look into the demo
and see how practically we can
create the auto scale
guys let's look into the demo for how we
can create an auto scaling on the aws
console
so right now i'm logged in into the aws
console and i am in the mumbai region
what you need to do is you have to go to
the compute section and under that click
on the ec2 service
let's wait for the ec2 servers to come
now just scroll down
and under the load balancing there is an
option called auto scaling so there
first you have to create a launch
configuration and then after that you
have to create the auto scaling groups
so click on launch configuration
and then you have to click on create
launch configurations
so click on create launch configuration
now this launch configuration is
basically this set of parameters that
you define while launching and auto
scaling so that this uniformity is
maintained with all the instances
so that includes let's say if you select
a windows os or a linux os that
particular type of an operating system
will be implemented in all the instances
that will be part of an auto scaling
so there are certain set of parameters
that we have to specify during the
launch configuration so that we can have
a uniformity in terms of launching the
servers
so here i would select an amazon linux
ami
and then i would select the type of a
server which will be t2.micro
click on configure details
put the name to the launch configuration
let's say we put it as a demo
and the rest of the things we'll keep it
default
click on add storage
since it's a linux ami we can go with
the 8gb storage that should be fine
click on configure security group
let's create a new security group which
has the ssh port opened and that is open
for
anywhere which is basically source ipv4
and ipv6 ips any ip will be able to
access that
click on review
just review your launch configuration if
you want to make changes you can do that
otherwise click on create a launch
configuration
you would need the key pair and this key
pair will be a unique key pair which
will be used with all the instances that
are part of the auto scaling group
so we can select an existing key pair if
you have that otherwise you can create a
new key pair
so i have an existing key pair i'll go
with that acknowledge it and click on
create launch condition
now we have successfully launched the
configuration of an auto scaling the
next thing is to create an auto scaling
group
so click on create an auto scaling group
using this launch configuration
put a group name let's say we put
something like test
and the group size to start with uh it
says one instance so that means at least
a single instance will always be running
and it will be initiated and running 24
cross 7 till the auto scaling is
available
you can increase the size of the minimum
base instances also let's say you can
change it to 2 also so you would get at
least two servers running all the time
so we'll go with the one instance
the network would be the vpc default and
uh in the vpc particular region we can
select
the availability zones so let's say if i
select availability zone 1a
and then availability zone 1b so how the
instances will be launched so one
instance will be launched in one and the
other one in the one b the third one in
the one a fourth one and the one b
likewise
it will
be equally spreaded among the
vulnerability zones
next part is to configure the scaling
policies so click on it
if you want to keep this group at its
initial size let's say if you want to go
with only a single instance or two
instances and you don't want the scaling
to progress you can put it
keep this group at its initial size so
this is basically a way to hold the
scaling
but we will use the scaling policies to
adjust the capacity of this group so
click on it
and we would scale between let's say
minimum one instance that we have and
we'll scale it between one two
four instances
and
what condition on what basis these
instances will be scaled up or scaled
down would be defined in the scale group
size
so the scaling policies you can
implement
based on
a scale group size or using the simple
scaling policies using the steps
so in the scale group size you have
certain metrics you can use average cpu
utilization you can define a metric
related to average networking average
network out
or the load balancer request counts per
target
and if you create the simple scaling
policies using steps then you need to
create the alarms and there you can get
some more metrics that you can add up as
a parameter for the auto scaling
let's go with the scaling group size let
us go with the metric type as average
cpu utilization and the target value
here you have to specify what would be
the threshold that when the instance cpu
utilization is crossed then a new
instance should be initiated
so you can put a reasonable threshold
for that let's say we put something like
85 percent
and whenever the instance cpu
utilization is crossed 85 threshold you
will see that there will be a new
instance created
let's go to the next configure
notifications
and here you can add notifications so
let's say if there is a new instance
that is initiated and you want to
basically be notified so you can get
notifications over your email ids or you
can get it on the cell phones so for
that for adding the notification you
would need the sns service that is
called as a simple notification service
and
you have to create a topic there you
have to subscribe for the topic using
your email id and then you should get
the notifications
click on configure tags
the tags are not mandatory you can
basically
put a tag let's say if you want to
identify the instance for the purpose it
was created otherwise you can leave it
blank also click on review
and review your scaling policies
notification tags
as well as the scaling group details
click on create auto scaling group
and here you go your scaling has been
launched click on close
and you should get at least a single
instance initiated automatically by the
auto scaling
so let's wait for the details to appear
so here you can see
our launch configuration name demo
auto scaling group name
test minimum instance we want
one the maximum instances we want four
we have selected two availability zones
ap south one ap south 1b
and
the instance one has been initiated and
if you want to verify where exactly this
instance has been initiated just click
on the instances here
and here you will see
that
our single instance has been initiated
that is in service
and that has been initiated in ap south
1b
now once the threshold of this instance
crosses 85 percent that is what we have
defined in the scaling policies
then you should see that another
instance will be initiated
so likewise this is basically uh i have
created steps to
initiate a scaling policy that means to
increase the number of servers whenever
the threshold crosses likewise here
itself you can add another policy to
scale down the resources in case if the
cpu utilization goes to a
normal value
today we are going to discuss about
amazon redshift which is one of the data
warehouse service on the aws so let's
begin with amazon redshift and let's see
what we have for today's session so
what's in it for you today we'll see
what is aws uh why we require amazon
redshift what do we mean by amazon
redshift the advantages of amazon
redshift the architecture of amazon
redshift some of the additional concepts
associated with the redshift and the
companies that are using the amazon
redshift and finally uh we'll cover up
one demo which will show you the
practical example that how you can
actually use the redshift service now
what is aws as we know that aws stands
for amazon web service it's one of the
largest cloud providers in the market
and it's basically a secure cloud
service platform provided from the
amazon also on the aws you can create
and deploy the applications
using the aws service along with that
you can access the services provided by
the aws over the public network that is
over the internet they are accessible
plus you pay only whatever the service
you use for now let's understand why we
require amazon redshift so earlier
before amazon redshift what used to
happen that the people used to or the
developers used to fetch the data from
the data warehouse so data warehouse is
basically a terminology which is
basically represents the collection of
the data so a repository where the data
is stored is generally called as a data
warehouse now fetching data from the
data warehouse was a complicated task
because might be a possibility that the
developer is located at a different
geography and the data data warehouse is
at a different location and probably
there is not that much network
connectivity or
some networking challenges internet
connectivity challenges security
challenges might be and a lot of
maintenance was required uh to manage uh
the data warehouses so what are the cons
of the traditional data warehouse
services it was time consuming to
download or get the data from the data
warehouse maintenance cost was high and
there was the possibility of loss of
information in between the downloading
of the data and the data rigidity was an
issue now how these problems could
overcome and this was uh basically
solved with the introduction of amazon
redshift over the cloud platform now we
say that amazon redshift has solved
traditional data warehouse problems that
the developers were facing but how what
is amazon redshift actually is so what
is amazon redshift it is one of the
services over the aws amazon web
services which is called as a data
warehouse service so amazon redshift is
a cloud-based service or a data
warehouse service that is primarily used
for collecting and storing the large
chunk of data so it also helps you to
get or extract the data analyze the data
using some of the bi tools so business
intelligence tools you can use and get
the data from the redshift and process
that and hence it simplifies the process
of handling the large scale data sets so
this is the symbol for the amazon
redshift over the aws now let's discuss
about one of the use case so dna is
basically a telecommunication company
and they were facing an issue with
managing their website and also the
amazon s3 data which led down to slow
process of their applications now how
could they overcome this problem let's
say that so they overcome this issue by
using the amazon redshift and all the
company noticed that there was 52
increase in the application performance
now did you know that amazon redshift is
basically cost less to operate than any
other cloud data warehouse service
available on the cloud computing
platforms and also the performance of an
amazon redshift is the fastest data
warehouse we can say that that is
available as of now so in both cases one
is that it saves the cost as compared to
the traditional data warehouses and also
the performance of this red shift
service or a data warehouse service the
fastest available on the cloud platforms
and more than 15 000 customers primarily
presently they are using the amazon
redshift service now let's understand
some of the advantages of amazon
redshift first of all as we saw that it
is one of the fastest available data
warehouse service so it has the high
performance second is it is a low cost
service so you can have a large scale of
data warehouse or the databases combined
in a data warehouse at a very low cost
so whatever you use you pay for that
only scalability now in case if you
wanted to increase the nodes of the
databases in your redshift you can
actually increase that based on your
requirement and that is on the fly so
you don't have to wait for the
procurement of any kind of a hardware or
the infrastructure it is whenever you
require you can scale up or scale down
the resources so this scalability is
again one of the advantage of the amazon
redshift availability since it's
available across multiple availability
zones so it makes this service as a
highly available service security so
whenever you create whenever you access
redshift you create a clusters in the
redshift and the clusters are created in
the you can define a specific virtual
private cloud for your cluster and you
can create your own security groups and
attach it to your cluster so you can
design the security parameters based on
your requirement and you can get your
data warehouse or the data items in a
secured place flexibility and you can
remove the clusters you can create under
clusters if you are deleting a cluster
you can take a snapshot of it and you
can move those snapshots to different
regions so that much flexibility is
available on the aws for the service and
the other advantage is that it is
basically a very simple way to do a
database migration so if you're planning
that you wanted to migrate your
databases from the traditional data
center over the cloud on the redshift it
is basically uh very simple to do a
database migration you can have some of
the inbuilt tools available on the aws
access you can connect them with your
traditional data center and get that
data migrated directly to the redshift
now let's understand the architecture of
the amazon redshift so architecture of
an amazon redshift is basically it
combines of a cluster and that we call
it as a data warehouse cluster in this
picture you can see that this is a data
warehouse cluster and this is a
representation of a amazon redshift so
it has
some of the compute nodes which does the
data processing and a leader node which
gives the instructions to these compute
nodes and also the leader node basically
manages the client applications that
require the data from the redshift so
let's understand about the components of
the redshift the client application of
amazon redshift basically interact with
the leader node using jdbc or the odbc
now what is jdbc it's a java database
connectivity and the odbc stands for
open database connectivity the amazon
redshift service using a jdbc connector
can monitor the connections from the
other client applications so the leader
node can actually have a check on the
client applications using the jdbc
connections whereas the odbc allows a
leader node to have a direct interaction
or to have a live interaction with the
amazon redshift so odbc allows a user to
interact with live data of amazon
redshift so it has a direct connectivity
direct access of the applications as
well as the leader node can get the
information from the compute nodes now
what are these compute nodes these are
basically kind of a databases which does
the processing so amazon redshift has a
set of computing resources which we call
it as a nodes and the nodes when they
are combined together they are called it
as a clusters now a cluster a set of
computing resources which are called as
nodes and this gathers into a group
which we call it as a data warehouse
cluster so you can have a compute node
starting from 1 to n number of nodes and
that's why we call that the redshift is
a scalable service because we can scale
up the compute nodes whenever we require
now the data warehouse cluster or the
each cluster has one or more databases
in the form of a nodes now what is a
leader node this node basically manages
the interaction between the client
application and the compute node so it
acts as a bridge between the client
application and the compute nodes also
it analyzes and develop designs in order
to carry out any kind of a database
operations so leader node basically
sends out the instructions to the
compute nodes basically perform or
execute that instruction and give that
output to the leader node so that is
what we are going to see in the next
slide that the leader node runs the
program and assign the code to
individual compute nodes and the compute
nodes execute the program and share the
result back to the leader node for the
final aggregation and then it is
delivered to the client application for
analytics or whatever the client
application is created for so compute
nodes are basically categorized into
slices and each node slice is alerted
with specific memory space or you can
say a storage space where the data is
processed these node slices works in
parallel in order to finish their work
and hence when we talk about a redshift
as a fast faster processing capability
as compared to other data warehouses or
traditional data warehouses this is
because that these node sizes work in a
parallel operation that makes it more
faster now the additional concept
associated with amazon redshift is there
are two additional concepts associated
with the redshift one is called as the
column storage and the other one is
called as the compression let's see what
is the column storage as the name
suggests column storage is basically
kind of a data storage in the form of a
column so that whenever we run a query
it becomes easier to pull out the data
from the columns so column storage is an
essential factor in optimizing query
performance and resulting in quicker
output so one of the examples are
mentioned here so below example show how
database tables store record into disk
block by row so here you can see that if
we wanted to pull out some kind of an
information based on the city address
age we can basically create a filter and
from there we can put out the details
that we require and that is going to
fetch out the details based on the
column storage so that makes data more
structured more streamlined and it
becomes very easier to run a query and
get that output now the compression is
basically to save the column storage we
can use a compression as an attribute so
compression is a column level operation
which decreases the storage requirement
and hence it improves the query
performance and this is one of the
syntax for the column compression now
the companies that are using amazon
redshift one is lya the other one is
equinox the third one is the pfizer
which is one of the famous
pharmaceuticals company mcdonald's one
of the burger chains across the globe
and philips it's an electronic company
so these are one of the biggest
companies that are basically relying and
they're putting their data on the
redshift data warehouse service now in
another video we'll see the demo for
using the amazon redshift let's uh look
into the amazon redshift demo so these
are the steps that we need to follow for
creating the amazon redshift cluster and
in this demo what we will be doing is
that we will be creating an im rule for
the redshift so that the redshift can
call the services and specifically we'll
be using the s3 service so the role that
we'll be creating will be giving the
permission to redshift to have an access
of an s3 in the read-only format so in
the step one what we require we'll check
the prerequisites and what you need to
have is the aws credentials if you don't
have that you need to create your own
credentials and you can use your credit
and the debit card and then in the step
2 we'll proceed with the im role for the
amazon redshift once the role is created
we'll launch a sample amazon redshift
cluster mentioned in the step 3 and then
we'll assign a vpc security groups to
our cluster now you can create it in the
default vpc also you can create a
default security groups also otherwise
you can customize the security groups
based on your requirement now to connect
to the sample cluster you need to run
the queries and you can connect to your
cluster and run queries on the aws
management console query editor which
you will find it in the redshift only or
if you use the query editor you don't
have to download and set up a sql client
application separately and in the step 6
what you can do is you can copy the data
from the s3 and upload that in the
redshift because the redshift would have
an access a read-only access
for the s3 as that will be created in
the im role so let's see how we can
actually use the redshift on the aws so
i am already logged in into my account i
am in north virginia region i'll search
for redshift service and here i find
amazon redshift so just click on it
let's wait for the redshift to come now
this is a redshift dashboard and from
here itself you have to run the cluster
so to launch a cluster you just have to
click on this launch cluster and once
the cluster is created and if you wanted
to run queries you can open query editor
or you can basically create queries and
access the data from the red shift so
that's what it was mentioned in the
steps also that you don't require a
separate sql client application to get
the queries run on the data warehouse
now before creating a cluster we need to
create the role so what we'll do is
we'll click on the services and we'll
move to i am role section so i am role i
can find here under the security
identity and compliance so just click on
the identity access management and then
click on create roles so let's wait for
i am page to open so here in the im
dashboard you just have to click on the
rules i already have the role created so
what i'll do is i'll delete this role
and i'll create it separately so just
click on create role and under the aws
services you have to select for the
redshift because now the redshift will
be calling the other services and that's
why we are creating the role now which
other services that the redshift will be
having an access of s3 why because we'll
be putting up the data on the s3 and
that is something which needs to be
uploaded on the redshift so we'll just
search for the redshift service and
we can find it here so just click on it
and then click on red shift customizable
in the use case now click on next
permissions and here in the permissions
give the access to this role assign the
permissions to this role in the form of
an s3 read-only access so you can search
here for the s3 also let's wait for the
policies to come in here it is let's
type s3 and here we can find amazon s3
read-only access so just click on it and
assign the permissions to this role tags
you can leave them blank click on next
review put a name to your role let's put
my redshift role and click on a create
role now you can see that your role has
been created now the next step is that
we'll move to redchat service and we'll
create one cluster so click on the
services click on amazon redshift you
can find that in the history section
since we browsed it just now and from
here we are going to create a sample
cluster now to launch a cluster you just
have to click on launch this cluster
whatever the uncompressed data size you
want in the form of a gigabyte terabyte
or petabyte you can select that and
let's say if you select in the form of
gb how much db memory you want you can
define it here itself this also gives
you the information about the costing on
demand is basically pay as you use so
they are going to charge you 0.5 dollars
per r for using the two node slices so
let's click on launch this cluster and
this will be a dc2 dot large kind of an
instance that will be given to you it
would be in the form of a solid state
drive ssds which is one of the fastest
way of storing the information and the
nodes two are mentioned by default that
means there will be two node slices and
that will be created in a cluster you
can increase them also let's say if i
put three node slices so it is going to
give us 3 into 0.16 db per node storage
now here you have to define the master
username password for your redshift
cluster and you have to follow the
password instructions so i would put a
password to this cluster and if it
accepts that means it does not give you
any kind of a warning otherwise it is
going to tell you about you have to use
the ascii characters and all and here
you have to assign this cluster the role
that we created recently so in the
available im rules you just have to
click on my redshift role and then you
have to launch the cluster if you wanted
to change something in with respect to
the default settings let's say if you
wanted to change the vpc from default
vpc to your custom vpc and you wanted to
change the default security groups to
your own security groups so you can
switch to advanced settings and do that
modification now let's launch the
cluster and here you can see the
redshift cluster is being created now if
you wanted to run queries on this
redshift cluster so you don't require a
separate sql client you just have to
follow
the simple steps to run a query editor
and the query editor you will find it on
the dashboard so let's click on the
cluster and here you would see that the
red shift cluster would be created with
the three nodes in the us east 1b
availability zone so we have created the
redshift cluster
in the ohio region and now what we'll do
is we'll
see how we can create the tables inside
the redshift and we'll see how we can
use the copy command so that we can
directly move the data uploaded on the
s3 bucket to the redshift database
tables and then we'll query the results
of a table as well so how we can do that
first of all after creating the redshift
cluster we have to install the sql
workbench slash j
this is not a mysql which is managed by
oracle and you can find this
on the google you can download it from
there and
then you have to connect this client
with the redshift database how you can
do click on file click on connect window
and after connecting a window uh you
have to paste the url which is a jdbc
driver this driver link you can find it
onto the aws console so if you open up a
redshift cluster there you would find
the jdbc driver link let's wait for it
so this is our cluster created let's
open it and here you can find this jdbc
url and also make sure that in the
security groups of a redshift you have
the port 5439 open for the traffic
incoming traffic you also need to have
the amazon redshift driver and this is
the link where you can download the
driver and specify the path once you are
done with that you provide the username
and the password that you created while
creating the redshift cluster click on
ok so this connects with the database
and now the database connection is
almost completed now what we will be
doing in the sql workbench we'll be
first creating the sales table and then
in the sales table we'll be adding up
the entries copied from the s3 bucket
and then move it to the redshift
database and after that we'll query the
results in the sales table now whatever
the values you are creating in the table
the same values needs to be in the data
file and
i have taken up this sample data file
from this link which is
docs.aws.amazon.com redshift sample
database creation and here you can find
a download file ticketdb.zip file this
folder has basically multiple data files
sample data files which you can actually
use it
to practice uploading the data on the
redshift cluster so i have extracted one
of the files from this folder and then i
have uploaded that file in the s3 bucket
now we'll move into the s3 bucket let's
look for the file that has been uploaded
on the s3 bucket so this is the bucket
sample and sales underscore tab dot text
is the file that i have uploaded this
has the entries data entries that will
be uploaded using a copy command onto
the red shift cluster now after
executing after putting up the command
for creating up the table then
we'll use a copy command and
copy command we have to define the table
name the table name is sales and we have
to define the path from where the data
would be copied over to the sales table
in the red shift now path is the s3
bucket and this is the redshift bucket
sample and it has to look for the data
inside the sales underscore tab.text
file also we have to define the
role arn that was created previously and
once it is done then the third step is
to query the results inside the sales
table to check whether our data has been
uploaded correctly on the table or not
now what we'll do is we'll execute all
these three syntax it gives us the error
because we have to connect it again to
the database let's wait for it
execute it
it's again gives us the error let's look
into the name of the bucket it's
redshift bucket sample so we have two
t's mentioned here right
let's connect with the database again
and now execute it so table sales
created and we got the error the
specified bucket does not exist
uh redshift bucket sample let's view the
bucket name redshift bucket sample let's
copy that put it here connect to the
window connect back to the database
right and now execute it so table sales
created uh the data in the table has
been copied from the s3 bucket
to sales underscore tab.text to the
redshift and then the query of the
results now the results
from the table has been queried hi guys
i'm raul from simply learn and today i'd
like to welcome you all to the greatest
debate of the century today i'm joined
by two giants of the cloud computing
industry they'll be going head to head
with each other to decide who amongst
them is better it's going to be one
hello fight
now let's meet our candidates on my left
we have aws who's voiced by a picture hi
guys
and on my right we have microsoft azure
who's voiced by anjali hey there so
today we'll be deciding who's better on
the basis of their origin and the
features they provide their performance
on the present day and comparing them on
the basis of pricing market sharing
options free tier and instance
configuration
now let's listen to their opening
statements let's start with aws
launched in 2006 aws is one of the most
commonly used cloud computing platforms
across the world companies like adobe
netflix airbnb htc pinterest and spotify
have put their faith in aws for their
proper functioning it also dominates the
cloud computing domain with almost 40
percent of the entire market share so
far nobody's even gotten close to
beating that number aws also provides a
wide range of services that covers a
great number of domains domains like
compute networking storage migration and
so much more
now let's see what azure has to say
about that azure was launched in 2010
and is trusted by almost 80 percent of
all fortune 500 companies the best of
the best companies in the world choose
to work only with azure azure also
provides its services to more regions
than any other cloud service provider in
the world azure covers 42 regions
already and 12 more are being planned to
be made azure also provides more than
100 services spanning a variety of
domains now that the opening statements
are done let's have a look at the
current market status of each of our
competitors this is the performance
route here we have the stats for the
market share of aws azure and other
cloud service providers this is for the
early 2018 period amazon web services
takes up a whopping 40
of the market share closely followed by
sgr at 30
and other cloud services adding 30
this 40 indicates most organizations
clear interest in using aws we are
number one because of our years of
experience and trust we've created among
our users
sure you're the market leader but we are
not very far behind let me remind you
more than 80 percent of the fortune 500
companies trust azure with their cloud
computing needs so it's only a match of
time before azure takes the lead the
rest of the 30 person that is in aws or
azure accounts to the other cloud
service providers like google cloud
platform backspace ibm software and so
on now for our next round the comparison
route first we'll be comparing pricing
we'll be looking at the cost of a very
basic instance which is a virtual
machine of two virtual cpus and 8gbs of
ram for aws this will cost you
approximately
0.0928 us dollars per hour and for the
same instance in azure it will cost you
approximately 0.096 us dollars per hour
next up let's compare market share and
options as i mentioned before aws is the
undisputed market leader when it comes
to the cloud computing domain taking up
40 percent of the market share by 2020
aws is also expected to produce twice
its current revenue which comes close to
44 billion dollars not to mention aws is
constantly expanding its already strong
roadster of more than 100 services to
fulfill the shifting business
requirements of organizations all that
is great really good for you but the
research company gardner has released a
magic quadrant that you have to see you
see the competition is now neck-to-neck
between azure and aws it's only a matter
of time before azure can increase from
its 30 market share and surpass aws this
becomes more likely considering how all
companies are migrating from aws to
azure to help satisfy their business
needs azure is not far behind aws when
this comes to services as well azure
service offerings are constantly updated
and improved on to help users satisfy
their cloud computing requirement
now let's compare aws and azure's free
offerings aws provides a significant
number of services for free helping
users get hands-on experience with the
platform products and services the free
tier services fall under two categories
services that will remain free forever
and the others that are valid only for
one year the always free category offers
more than 20 services for example amazon
sms sqs cloudwatch etc and the valid
fourier category offers approximately 20
services for example amazon s3 ec2
elastic cache etc
both types of services have limits on
the usage for example storage number of
requests compute time etc but users are
only charged for using services that
fall under the valid for a year category
after a year of their usage
a shop provides a free tier as well it
also provides services that belong to
the categories of free for a year and
always free there are about 25 plus
always free services provided by azure
these include app service functions
container service active directory and
lots more and as of the valid for a year
there are eight services offered there's
linux or windows virtual machines glob
storage sql database and few more azure
also provides the users with credits of
200 us dollars to access all their
services for 30 days now this is a
unique feature that azure provides where
users can use their credits to utilize
any service of a choice for the entire
month now let's compare instance
configuration the largest instance that
aws offers is that of a whopping 256 gb
of ram and 16 virtual cpus the largest
that azure offers isn't very far behind
either 224 gbs of ram and 16 virtual
cpus and now for the final round now
each of our contestants will be shown
facts and they have to give explanations
for these facts we call it the rapid
fire round first we have features in
which aws is good and azure is better
aws does not cut down on the features it
offers its users however it requires
slightly more management on the user's
part azure goes slightly deeper with the
services that fall under certain
categories like platform as a service
and infrastructure as a service
next we have hybrid cloud where aws is
good and azure is better okay although
aws did not emphasize on hybrid cloud
earlier they are focusing more on
technology now azure has always
emphasized on hybrid cloud and has
features supporting it since the days of
its inception for developers aws is
better and azure is good of course it's
better because aws supports integration
with third-party applications well azure
provides access to data centers that
provide a scalable architecture for
pricing both aws and azure are at the
same level it's good for aws because it
provides a competitive and constantly
decreasing pricing model and in the case
of azure it provides offers that are
constantly experimented upon to provide
its users with the best experience
and that's it our contestants have
finished giving their statements now
let's see who won surprisingly nobody
each cloud computing platform has its
own pros and cons choosing the right one
is based entirely on your organization's
requirements
hi guys today we've got something very
special in store for you we're going to
talk about the best cloud computing
platform available amazon web services
uh rahul i think you said something
wrong here the best cloud computing
platform is obviously google cloud
platform no it isn't aws has more than
100 services that span a variety of
domains all right but google cloud
platform has cheaper instances what do
you have to say about that well i guess
there's only one place we can actually
discuss this a boxing ring so guys i'm
apexah and i will be google cloud
platform and i'm rahul i'll aws so
welcome to fight night this is aws
versus gcp
the winner will be chosen on the basis
of their origin and the features they
provide their performance in the present
day and comparing them on the basis of
pricing market share and options the
things they give you for free and
instance configuration now first let's
talk about aws aws was launched in 2004
and is a cloud service platform that
helps businesses grow and scale by
providing them services in a number of
different domains these domains include
compute database storage migration
networking and so on a very important
aspect about aws is its years of
experience now aws has been in the
market a lot longer than any other cloud
service platform which means they know
how businesses work and how they can
contribute to the business growing also
aws has over 5.1 billion dollars of
revenue in the last quarter this is a
clear indication of how much faith and
trust people have in aws they occupy
more than 40 of the market which is a
significant chunk of the cloud computing
market they have at least 100 services
that are available at the moment which
means just about every issue that you
have can be solved with an aws service
now that was great but now can we talk
about gcp i hope you know that gcp was
launched very recently in 2011 and it is
already helping businesses significantly
with a suite of intelligent secure and
flexible cloud computing services it
lets you build deploy and scale
applications websites services on the
same infrastructure as google the
intuitive user experience that gcp
provides with dashboards wizards is way
better in all the aspects tcp has just
stepped in the market and it is already
offering a modest number of services and
the number is rapidly increasing and the
cost for a cpu instance or regional
storage that gcp provides is a whole lot
cheaper and you also get a
multi-regional cloud storage now what do
you have to say on that i'm so glad you
asked let's look at present day in fact
let's look at the cloud market share of
the fourth quarter of 2017. this will
tell you once and for all that aws is
the leader when it comes to cloud
computing amazon web services
contributes 47 of the market share
others like rackspace or verizon cloud
contribute 36 microsoft azure
contributes 10 the google cloud platform
contributes 4 and ibm software
contributes 3
47 of the market share is contributed by
aws you need me to convince you any
wait wait wait all that is fine but we
only started a few years back and have
already grown so much in such a less
span of time haven't you heard the
latest news our revenue is already a
billion dollars per quarter wait for a
few more years and the world shall see
and aws makes 5.3 billion dollars per
quarter it's going to take a good long
time before you can even get close to us
yes yes we'll see now let's compare a
few things for starters let's compare
prices for aws a compute instance of two
cpus in 8gb ram costs approximately 68
us dollars now a computer instance is a
virtual machine in which you can specify
what operating system ram or storage you
want to have for cloud storage it costs
2.3 cents per gb per month with aws you
really want to do that because gcp wins
this hands down let's take the same
compute instance of two cpus with 8gb
ram it will cost approximately 50
dollars per month with gcp and as for my
calculations that's a 25 percent annual
cost reduction when compared to aws
talking about cloud storage costs it is
only 2 cents per gb per month with gcp
what else do you want me to say let's
talk about market share and options now
aws is the current market leader when it
comes to cloud computing now as you
remember we contribute at least 47
percent of the entire market share aws
also has at least 100 services available
at the moment which is a clear
indication of how well aws understands
businesses and helps them grow yeah
that's true but you should also know
that gcp is steadily growing we have
over 60 services that are up and running
as you can see here and a lot more to
come it's only a matter of time when we
will have as many services as you do
many companies have already started
adopting gcp as a cloud service provider
now let's talk about things you get for
free with aws you get access to almost
all the services for an entire year with
usage limits now these limits include an
hourly or by the minute basis for
example with amazon ec2 you get 750
hours per month you also have limits on
the number of requests to services for
example with aws lambda you have 1
million requests per month now after
these limits are crossed you get charged
standard rates with gcp you get access
to all cloud platform products like
firebase the google maps api and so on
you also get 300 in credit to spend over
a 12 month period on all the cloud
platform products and interestingly
after the free trial ends you won't be
charged unless you manually upgrade to a
paid account now there is also the
always free version for which you will
need an upgraded billing account here
you get to use a small instance for free
and 5gb of cloud storage any usage above
this always free usage limits will be
automatically billed at standard rates
now let's talk about how you can
configure instances with aws the largest
instance that's offered the 128 cpus and
40 views of ram now other than the on
demand method like i mentioned before
you can also use spot instances now
these are the situations where your
application is more fault tolerant and
can handle an interruption now you pay
for the spot price which is effective at
a particular r now these part prices do
fluctuate but are adjusted over a period
of time the largest instance offered
with google cloud is 160 cpus and 3.75
tbs ram like spot instances of aws
google cloud offers short lived compute
instances suitable for bad jobs and
fault tolerant workloads they are called
as preemptable instances so these
instances are available at eighty
percent off on on demand price hence
they reduce your compute engine costs
significantly and unlike aws these come
at a fixed price google cloud platform
is a lot more flexible when it comes to
instance configuration you simply choose
your cpu and ram combination of course
you can even create your own instance
types this way before we wrap it up
let's compare on some other things as
well telemetry it's a process of
automatically collecting periodic
measurements from remote devices for
example gps gcp is obviously better
because they have superior telemetry
tools which help in analyzing services
and providing more opportunities for
improvement when it comes to application
support aws is obviously better since
they have years of experience under
their bed aws provides the best support
that can be given to the customers
containers are better with gcp a
container is a virtual process running
in user space as kubernetes was
originally developed by google gcp has
full native support for the tools other
cloud services are just fine tuning a
way to provide kubernetes as a service
also the containers help with
abstracting applications from their
environment they originally run it the
applications can be deployed easily
regardless of their environment when it
comes to geographies aws is better since
they have a head start of a few years
aws in this span of time has been able
to cover a larger market share and
geographical locations now it's time for
the big decision so who's it going to be
yeah who is it going to be gcp or aws i
think i'm going to go for in cloud
computing the competition for leadership
is a quite tough three-way race
amazon web services
microsoft azure
and google cloud platform clearly are
the top cloud companies who are
commanding lead in the infrastructure as
a service and platform as service
markets
hey everyone i'm shamlee and i welcome
you all to this new video of simply
learn on aws versus azure versus gzp
in this video we will compare and
contrast aws azure and gcp based on a
few related concepts around these cloud
computing platforms
it will help us understand the
functioning of these top cloud platforms
and will also let us figure out the
individuality of each one of them
but before starting with the comparison
let's have a quick introduction of aws
versus assured versus gcp
so let's get started
amazon web services or aws is a cloud
computing platform
that manages and maintains hardware and
infrastructure reducing the expense and
complexity of purchasing and running
resources on site for businesses and
individuals
these resources are available for free
or for a fee per usage
microsoft azure is a cloud computing
service that it offers a collection of
cloud computing services for building
testing deploying and managing
application in the cloud including
remotely hosted and managed versions of
microsoft technology
google cloud platform offers a variety
of cloud computing services for building
deploying scaling monitoring and
operating a cloud
the services are identical to those that
power google products such as google
search gmail youtube
and google drive
now let's move on to the comparison
between aws assure and gcp
we will be comparing them based on few
major parameters like
origin
service integration
availability zone
cloud tools like compute
storage
networking
market share
pricing
and at last who uses them
now
let's move ahead and start with the
first comparison origin
in the year 2006 amazon web services aws
was introduced to the market
and in the year 2010 azure launched its
services
whereas on the other hand gcp was
established in the year 2008.
from the start aws has been supportive
of the open source concept but the open
source community has a tense
relationship with azure
on the other hand gcp similar to aws
provides google cloud with manage open
source services that are tightly linked
aws offers services on a large and
complex scale that can be manipulated
but azure support is comparatively low
quality
whereas gcp's monthly support price is
almost 150 dollars for the silver class
which is the most basic of services and
is quite expensive
now let's move on to the service
integration of these cloud platforms
service integration is a set of tools
and technology that connects different
applications
systems
repositories and data and process
interchange in real time
aws makes it simple for users to combine
services such as amazon ec2 amazon s3
beanstalk and others
on the other hand azure allows customers
to effortlessly combine azure vms
as your app service sql databases and
other services
whereas users can utilize gcp to combine
services such as compute engine cloud
storage and cloud sql
now that we know briefly about all these
cloud platforms let's have a look at the
availability zones of these platforms
because aws was the first in the cloud
domain they have had more time to build
and extend their network
but
azure and gcp both have various
locations around the world
but the distinction is in the amount of
availability zones they have
aws now offers 66 availability zones
with an additional 12 on the pipeline
close to it azure is available in 140
countries and is available in 54 regions
throughout the world
but google cloud platform is now
available in 20 global areas with three
more on the way
now let's move on to the next important
factor which is tools
now let's move ahead and have have a
look at the first feature
which is compute
elastic compute cloud or ec2 is aws
compute service which offers a wide
range of features including a large
number of instances
support for both windows and linux high
performance computing and more
as sure on the other hand
virtual machines is microsoft azure's
core cloud-based compute solution
it includes linux windows server and
other operating systems as well as
better security and microsoft program
integration
in comparison to its competitors
google's computing services catalog is
somewhat smaller
compute engine that companies principal
service offers custom and predefined
machine types
per second invoicing linux and windows
support and carbon neutral
infrastructure that uses half the energy
of traditional data centers
within the compute category amazon's
different containers services are
gaining prominence it has docker
kubernetes and it's also far gate
service
which automates server and cluster
management when using containers as well
as other alternatives
azure unlike aws uses virtual machine
scale sets of two container services
azure container service is based on
kubernetes
and container service
uses docker hub and azure container
registry for management
for enterprises interested in deploying
containers google offers the kubernetes
engine
it's also worth noting that google was
significantly involved in the kubernetes
project
providing it extensive knowledge in this
field
now let's move on to the next parameter
of comparison which is storage
simple storage service
for object storage elastic block storage
for persistent block storage and elastic
file system for file storage among aws
storage offerings
block storage for rest based object
storage of unstructured data queue
storage for a large volume workloads
file storage and disk storage are among
microsoft azure's core storage services
gcp offers an increasing number of
storage options its unified object
storage service cloud storage also has a
persistent disk option
relational database service or rds
dynamodb nosql database
elastic cache in memory data store
redshift data warehouse
neptune graph database and database
migration service are all sql compatible
databases
offered by amazon
the database choices in azure are
specially wide sql database mysql
database and postgre sql database are
the three sql based choices
when it comes to databases gcp offers
the sql based cloud sql and cloud
spanner a relational database built for
mission critical workloads
now the next parameter is networking
aws uses amazon virtual private cloud or
vpc
on the other hand azure uses
azure virtual network we net
and gcp uses cloud virtual network
now let's move on to the another factor
which is market share and pricing
all these cloud services are based on
comparative pricing strategy which means
you need to pay on the basis of its
usage
according to canalis the worldwide cloud
market rose 35
to 41.8 billion in the first quarter of
2021.
aws accounts for 32 of the market
with azure accounting for 19
and google accounting for 7
on one hand amazon charges on a yearly
basis and on the other hand microsoft
azure and google services charge on a
minute basis and also of them provide
you a standard price for you to access
these services
aws charges roughly 69 per month for a
very basic instance with two virtual
cpus and 8 gb of ram
and aws largest instance with 3.84 db of
ram and 128 vcpus
will set you back roughly 3.97
per hour
but in azure the same type of instance
one with two v cpus and 8gb of ram cost
roughly 70
us
per month
and asia's largest instance has 3.89 tb
of ram
and 128 virtual cpus
it costs about 6.79 per hour
compared to aws gcp will supply you with
the most basic instance which includes
two virtual cpus and eight gigabytes of
ram for 25 percent less as a result it
will set you back roughly
to 52 dollar every month and the largest
instance that include
is 3.75 db of ram and 160v cpus it will
cost you around 5.32
per hour
amazon other than this also provides
spot instances reserved instances and
dedicated hosts where you can look for
multiple offers and discounts
but for ensure it provides special
prices to developers based on situations
or even ensure hybrid benefit which
benefits your organization up to 40
percent if it uses microsoft software in
their data centers
whereas google offers quite a sorted
pricing to its customer compared to
other two
it gives you sustained use discounts
which activate if you use the same
instance for a month
the printable instance which is very
similar to amazon spot instances
but one thing is common in all three
cloud services which is they all offer
long-term discount
now let's have a look at the last
comparison which is companies using them
because aws is the oldest player in the
cloud business
it has the largest user base and
community support
as a result aws has a largest number of
high-profile and well-known clients
including netflix airbnb unilever bmw
samsung mi senga and others
with time azure is getting a large
number of high-profile customers azure
currently boasts around 80 percent of
fortune
500 forms as customers johnson controls
polycom
fujifilm hp honeywell apple and others
are among its key clients
google cloud on the other hand uses the
same infrastructure as google search and
youtube and as a result many high in
enterprises
trust google cloud hsbc paper
20th century fox bloomberg domino's and
other among google clouds many clients
hey guys this is chidanan from simply
learn and i welcome you to this short
tutorial and demo on kubernetes
kubernetes specific to aws cloud
platform so what's a part of this
tutorial and demo what's in store for
you at offset i would like to cover the
basics of orchestration tools as most of
you would know kubernetes is one of the
most popular orchestration tools in
recent times specifically for
applications which are cloud native and
deployed on some or the other types of
containers but what are these
organization tools why would one need to
use orchestration tools what are the
facilities or features provided by this
orchestration tools that's the first
thing that i'm going to cover after that
i will pick two orchestration tools
specific to container management docker
swarm versus kubernetes i'm going to
compare them with regard to the features
that they provide the use cases that
they cover what facilities that they
provide and when to use what after that
i will get into a little bit details of
the kuvurnis architecture what exactly
is required for setting up a kubernetes
cluster what runs in a control plane or
a master node what runs as a part of the
worker node after that i will end the
tutorial by running you by setting up a
three node kubernetes cluster on aws
platform i will use something called as
cops which is one of the admin tools for
setting up production grade kubernetes
cluster so i will use this to set up a
three note cluster on aws all right now
that we set the context right let me get
started so what are orchestration tools
the application development and the
lifecycle management from the time the
application is developed connecting the
source code to your continuous
integration to testing them all along
your development process and eventually
moving it down to production managing
your production servers the dependencies
that your software has
the requirement that it has in terms of
the hardware the features of fault
tolerance self-healing capabilities auto
scaling all this has complicated over
the last few years as a part of devops
one thing that everyone is interested in
is managing all this application
dependency or lifecycle management using
some or the other kind of a tool so
that's where these orchestration tools
have become very very popular so what
kind of features that they provide is
you'll have to just let them know what
are the kinds of tool sets that is
required what are the fault tolerance
mechanisms that it has to be adopted to
what kind of a self-healing capabilities
that application will have to need and
if at all there is any auto scaling
features that is required if at all you
can bake in all these specific
parameters into your tool your
organization tool becomes a one-stop
shop for all your deployment and
configuration management needs that's
where this orchestration tools have
become a very very popular and relevant
specifically these days when people are
more and more uh interested in adopting
devops practices all right so having
said that about orchestration tools
let's concentrate on two of these
orchestration tools specifically for
container management docker swarm and
kubernetes many of the applications that
are written for these kind of containers
are called or kind of fall into a
category of cloud native where the
application need not know much about the
underlying infrastructure or the
platform where these applications are
running so these two along with apache
missiles there are many other container
management systems but i'm going to pick
docker swarm and kubernetes for
comparing the features that is provided
by these two frameworks for the sake of
comparison i picked up docker swarm and
kubuntis just because of the reason that
both of them operate in the space of
container management they do something
very very similar to containers that's
the similarity that exists between these
two orchestration tools however there's
a big difference that exists when it
comes to the types of containers that
both of them cater to and also the
capacity of workloads they can be used
for docker swamp is a cluster management
solution that is provided by docker
container docker is one of the very very
popular containers of recent times and
in case you have your applications that
is totally powered by only docker
containers if you have a need where you
want to run a cluster of servers which
are running only docker containers
docker swarm should be your choice for
your orchestration tool kubernetes on
the other hand can cater to any other
types of containers other than docker
and including docker as well so in case
you have your applications which have
got docker in them which have got rkt in
them which they have got alex in them or
any other type of container kubernetes
should be your choice of orchestration
too a docker swarm can manage up to 40
50 or 60 max
nodes so in case your application is
totally written in docker containers and
the load or the expected cluster size is
about 50 60 nodes docker swarm should be
your choice of orchestration tool on the
other hand kubernetes is something that
was open sourced by google and the kind
of the scale of operations that
kubernetes can cater to is google scale
so if in case your applications are more
than a thousand nodes that is where
kubernetes comes into play that's the
big difference that exists between
docker swarm and kubernetes putting
those differences aside let me compare
docker swarm and kubernetes based upon
other features which are similar in
nature the first and important feature
that kubernetes provides is something
called as auto scaling if at all the
load on your cluster is too high your
application is experiencing more load so
kubernetes can add new nodes to your
cluster of course you'll have to
configure kubernetes in order to have
those capabilities where it can spin up
new vms or new nodes if at all you do
that configuration correctly kubernetes
has got the capacity or it has got the
feature where it can bring up a new node
and add it to the cluster on the fly
based upon the load that exist at that
moment on similar lines if at all the
load is not too high it can identify a
few of those nodes which have got less
number of
replicas or less number of application
containers running on it it can move
them to some other node and also scale
down by deleting few nodes from your
cluster so that is the powerfulness of
auto scaling which is provided by
kubernetes and this unfortunately does
not exist in docker swarm the other
feature of load balancing specifically
application node balancing so docker
swarm gives you an application level
auto load balancing however kubernetes
gives you the flexibility of manually
configuring any other type of load
balancer of your choice for application
load balancing installation as i
mentioned earlier docker swarm is a
loose cluster of containers which are
running on nodes it is very easy to spin
up a new node and then connect them to a
swarm and this can be done in a very
very loosely coupled way where you can
create swarms of your choice notes are
allowed to connect to swarms and quit or
leave the swamps on the fly so in and
all the installation is pretty easy and
fast kubernetes on the other hand the
configuration of kubernetes the way to
spin up a big cluster specifying the
size of the node how many masternodes
how many config planes that you want how
many nodes that you want it's a pretty
tough thing to bring up a kubernetes
scalability kubernetes strength is very
very strong they are very tightly
coupled and even they have the
capability where on the cluster size
things or the nodes can be increased on
the fly based upon the requirement on a
darkest form the cluster strength is
weak as compared to cobra days worker
notes can be added to a swarm worker
notes can be asked to levers form or can
be taken out of a swarm based upon the
requirement so this is kind of a loosely
coupled architecture for docker swarm
while kubernetes the cluster is very
tightly coupled since docker swarm runs
only docker containers containers find
it very easy to share data and lot of
other things with each other because
they all have the same signature they're
all from the same family so it's very
easy for them to share not just volumes
but a lot of other things however for
kubernetes since it manages containers
of different types if your application
has to share some data across different
containers there's a little bit of a
complexity in how you would want your
containers to share data also when it
comes to kubernetes kubernetes groups
containers in something called as pods
while a pod can have either one
container that's the preferred choice or
multiple containers and the idea of pod
is like each part can run in any other
node it's not guaranteed that you would
want to have two or three parts to be
running on the same note that makes data
sharing a little bit of a different
thing compared to docker's form uh gui
so there's not a good enough ui tool in
docker's form at least the ce edition of
it which will allow you to get to know
what is running on your containers what
is the size of the containers what is
the volume of the containers and all
that stuff there are some free and open
source tools like proteiner which gives
you a good visibility into your running
docker containers however there's
nothing at a swarm level that is
provided by docker kubernetes gives you
an out of the box dashboard which is
easy to configure and set up you can
also club it with some metrics services
and you can also get information about
the size of the cluster that is running
what is the load on the nodes and stuff
like that all this across your cluster
in a very beautiful dashboard
perspective so that way um this is
little bit of a good ui for kubernetes
while for docker's form there isn't
anything that is provided out of the box
let me spend some time in explaining a
little bit about the kubernetes
architecture what comprises of the
kubernetes cluster what resides in a
master or a control plane and what
resides in a worker node this is a very
high level uh depiction of a kubernetes
cluster so this is the master node which
has got something called as a cluster
store a controller a scheduler component
and an api server and these are the
bunch of nodes that are connected or
administered by the master node the
master node can be one three five
typically an odd number this is as per
the typical cluster management thing
where you would need the masternodes to
be in odd numbers so that whenever
there's any contention in terms of what
needs to be deployed where or where to
give the job to whom and stuff like that
all the masters would cast their vote
and they would decide on the outcome so
that's the master node and there are a
bunch of
nodes which can be connected and
administered by the master node cuba ctl
or the command from using which anybody
can assign some workloads to the cluster
can also be run either on the same node
or on a separate node so cubectl is the
command line tool that we will be
installing and using in order to fire up
our commands to our cluster so if at all
i have to put up a job on our cluster if
i have to give out any specific commands
to my cluster all this is done using
cuba ctl there's a bunch of rest apis
which is used by cuba ctl and cubectl
will talk to the api server and fire up
the commands specific to my cluster what
runs in the master node master node
without saying it's the most important
component of any of the cluster if at
all you're running
cluster with only one master node if
your master node goes down there's no
other way that you know you can or any
user can talk to the different nodes in
the cluster so master node is the most
vital component responsible for the
complete kubernetes cluster there's
always one node that should be running
as a master node that's the bare minimum
requirement for your cluster so what are
the other components in the master node
the most important one is called etcd so
this is nothing but a data store a value
of key value pair which is stored which
contains all information about your
cluster so all the configuration details
which
node is up which worker node is down all
this information is stored in the
cluster store so all the managers would
access this cluster store before they go
ahead and decide any other work item or
anything else that has to be done
specific to your cluster what's in the
controller as the name says controller
is something it's like a daemon server
that is running in a continuous loop all
the time it is responsible for
controlling the set of replicas the kind
of
workloads that is running based upon the
configuration that the user has set in
so if at all if you are aware of
something called as replication
controllers endpoint controllers
namespace controllers all these
controllers are managed by the
controller component if any user asked
for some three replicas of a particular
pod or a service to be running and if at
all any of the nodes goes down or the
part goes down for whatever reason the
controller is the one who wakes up and
assigns this particular job or the part
to some other available node by looking
up for the details using in the cluster
store that's the importance of the
control manager or the controller the
scheduler the scheduler assigns the
tasks based upon whoever is asked for
any job to be scheduled based upon a
time frame or based upon some criteria
it also tracks the working load as to
what what exactly is the load who is
running what and in the cluster and
places the workload on whoever is the
available resource at that time all
right api server this is one other
important component in in our kubernetes
cluster where how would the end user
deploy or give out any sort of a
workload onto your cluster all the
requests come to the api server so this
is an entry point for all your
requests that come into your cluster
anybody wants to deploy something
anybody want to scale up a controller
anybody who wants to bring down a few
services anybody wants to put in a
service all this will have to come in as
a part of a rest um api endpoint and api
server is the enter point in case you
don't want uh you know somebody to
access your cluster in case you want
only specific people or specific users
to be running some specific workloads
you can set all those role-based access
control for this apa server so this is
the entry point for anyone who wants to
submit any job to your cluster so that's
a quick overview about the master node
what what are the important components
of a master node now let's go over to
what runs in a worker or a slave node as
i mentioned earlier slave nodes are
something where the job that is
submitted to your cluster is eventually
run as a pod as a service as a container
so in kubernetes world there's something
called as a pod a pod is nothing but a
combination of a container it is a
wrapper around your running containers
so slave nodes or the worker nodes
typically run these parts so that is
where the whole workload typically gets
run but there are a bunch of other
components in the in the node which also
manages what runs in the pod who has to
have access to the pod what is the state
of the pod is it in a running state is
it going down for some reason and all
the stuff so let's quickly go over those
components that is there in the slave
node the most important component in my
opinion that should be on the on the
node should be the container runtime as
i mentioned earlier kubernetes can run
any different types of containers not
just docker so in case you want to have
a node which wants to have docker
running on it rkt running or lkc running
on it or any other container environment
that is running on it you have to ensure
that the specific container runtime
environment is available on that
specific node so that whenever a job is
submitted a description of what needs to
be run as a part of the pod what should
be the image with it should be powered
and what kind of a container to spin up
so that's what you know when the job is
finally assigned to this particular node
it would definitely need a container
runtime to be up and running so that
exists only if at all the container
runtime is installed and running on your
kubernetes worker node okay now that we
know what our kubernetes node can run
how would somebody assign a job to our
node that is using something called as a
cubelet as the name says cubelet or
cubelet is a small subset which talks to
the cube api server so any node which
has to run any kind of a pod all these
instructions are passed around by the
qbpa server to the cubelet and cubelet
is capable of processing whatever job
that is assigned to it and ensuring that
so many parts and so many services are
spun up based upon the requirement the
last component that exists in the worker
node is the cube proxy or kubernetes
proxy this plays a very very important
role acting as a load balancer and a
network proxy so what typically happens
is whenever the pods are running in
nodes the parts can be typically running
in any node there is no um
affinity towards any node on which these
parts are running because pods or
containers are something called as
ephemeral they can run anywhere so how
would somebody reach out to these
applications that is running in some pod
which is running in one container now
and running in probably another
container another node altogether
tomorrow so that is where your
kubernetes proxy contains a picture and
this component will ensure that any
container that is spun up or any pod
that is spun up it keeps track of all
these parts and kind of connects the end
points or acts like a dns server so that
it knows when somebody is trying to
reach out to this particular service
which is the part on which the service
is typically running so that plays a
very very important role by acting as a
load balancer and a network proxy now
that at a very high level we know what
are all the components that make up of
our kubernetes cluster let's go ahead
and create a small cluster and spin up
this cluster on aws platform finally we
get to the demo section of my tutorial
now that you guys are aware as to what
is kubernetes what is the use of
kubernetes you also know at a very very
high level what are the components of a
cluster what is a master node or a
control plane what are the components of
a master node and what should be
existing in a worker node you're
probably thinking that it's maybe pretty
hard to kind of set this up so let me
demystify that by running you with a
quick demo of how to set up a simple
pre-node kubernetes cluster using a tool
called cops and i will be doing this
whole setup on my aws cloud okay so what
is cops cops is nothing but a simple
tool this is an admin tool that allows
you to bring up production grade
kubernetes environments as i said
setting up a kubernetes cluster on a
bare metal is little challenging so that
is why i would use something called as a
cops and i will use this on my cluster
which i'll spin up on my aws instance so
i have an aws account and what i will do
first is i will first spin up an ec2
server i will power this with one of the
um linux amis and i will install cops on
it now this will be my starting point
from where i'm going to trigger running
up a big cluster in our case i'll try to
keep it little small i don't want too
many nodes in my cluster i'm going to
have one master node and two worker
nodes this whole operation would be done
programmatically by installing this cops
admin tool so as you may know aws is
little hard for me to programmatically
run other components or rather bring up
servers it's not pretty simple so what i
would do is i will create an iam rule
which will attach to my ec2 server so
that my ec2 server gets powered with all
the required role so that it can go
ahead and spin up cluster based upon my
configuration that i'm going to specify
all right so once i have my cluster set
up i will also install cuba ctl which uh
you would probably know by now is
nothing but a command line utility using
which i can kind of connect to my
cluster give it some jobs put some parts
and stuff like that so i will use cuba
ctl i will also have a pair of ssh keys
so that from this machine i would be
able to successfully get onto the master
node and submit jobs on my behalf so let
me begin by first logging into my aws
account all the steps that i will be
following to bring up my aws cluster
kubernetes cluster will be documented
and i'll be sharing you this document in
a github repository so that in case
anybody wants to try you'll be more than
happy to find all the required
instructions in one place okay now the
first thing that i would need is to
launch an aws ec2 instance now this is
an instance where i'm going to install
cops and i will use it as a base server
from where i'm going to find some
commands which will bring up my
kubernetes cluster so let me login to my
aws account and um let me stick to one
particular region and let me bring up
some one ec2 instance all right so let
me launch my instance let me choose um
doesn't matter in the ways but in case
you want to try it on your free tire i
would recommend choose free tire only
and choose an ami of your choice let me
choose
this instance i will make it t2 micro
that is good for me configuration
instance details all right i don't want
to change anything here that looks good
maybe i will change this 30 gig that's
good for me let me add a tag to my
instance i will name this as my cops
server all right i would need a bunch of
posts to be opened up so what i will do
is i will create a new security group uh
called open to
the word i would not recommend that you
do this since i don't want to it will
take a long time for me to specifically
uh to pick and choose um the ports that
has to be open for running my cluster i
don't want to do that i will open up all
the http and https ports so that it's
quicker so i will say all tcp i would
say from anywhere just to be on the
safer side also open http and https and
i will make this anywhere and anywhere
this is good for me i will say review
and launch all right so i chose a t2
micro instance just for the sake of
easiness i've opened up all the ports
and um the instant details are you've
seen what is that i've chosen all right
now important part is like i would need
a keyboard i need to create a new keypad
i will call this as simply learn keys i
will download this
keypair and then i will launch the
instance it will take some time for my
ec2 instance to come up in the meanwhile
what i'll do is i will convert i have
this pen file which is the pair of keys
the ssh keys with which i need to log
into my ec2 instance so i'll need to
convert this because i'm trying to
connect from my windows box i would need
to convert this into a ppk file so i
have puttygen i'm going to load my set
of keys here and convert that key into a
ppk key all right open all right i would
say save hang on save private key yes i
would say simply learn or simply learn
private private key and save this here
and that that's all so this is my public
key which is the pem file and this is my
tpk or my private key now using the
private key i will log into my ec2
instance okay now my ec2 instance is up
and running it is running in this ohio
region and this is the ip address of my
public ipads of my machine so let me
connect to it so i use a moba x term
which is nothing but an ssh emulator you
can use putty or any of these sessions
which allow you to do an ssh this is my
ip address of my machine and since i've
spun up an amazon ami the user this is
the default user i would need to specify
the private keys for my session and this
is the private key for my session say
okay i am in my
amazon ec2 instance so let me look at
what are the other things that i need to
do all right so as i said i just brought
up my ec2 instance but i would need my
ec2 instance to
run few things on my behalf so that it
can spin up easy to other ec2 instances
it can also talk to an s3 bucket where
i'm going to store the instant state of
my kubernetes cluster also some sort of
an auto scaling group because i want to
spin up more and more instances i also
want to have a private hosted zone using
my route 53 so i would need my ec2
instance to have all these sort of
permissions for my server so what i
would do is i will go and create a
permission a rule in the ec2 or rather
in the aws im role and i will attach
this i am role to my ec2 instance all
right so let me go to my iam which is
nothing but the identity and access
management i will create a role called
as possibly corpse role i will create a
role this role will be used by my ec2 so
i'm going to click on ec2 and say next
permissions they would need a lot of
permissions uh specific permissions to
be very honest and the permissions are
all listed out here s3 ec2 and all this
stuff just to keep it pretty simple what
i would do is i'll create a role with
the administrative access all right so i
don't want any tags i will review i'll
create a role name i will say cups fold
for ec2 all right so i'm going to create
a rule which has got administrative
access rules i'm going to create a rule
so this would ensure that my ec2
instance from which i'm going to run my
cluster would have all the prerequisite
permissions so that it can go and spin
up instances talk to us three buckets
and all that stuff all right now let us
have our running instance get powered by
this role so i will connect this role to
my running instance all right so this is
my
easy to instant that is running action
attach attach attach attach replace im
rules so there is no rule as of now i
would want my cops roll for easy this
row that i created so i want this new
role to be assigned to my ec2 all right
great now my ec2 instance which is my
cop server has got all the required
permissions so that he can create a
cluster on my behalf great now before
this let me do a sudo yum update iphone
y so that any of the because this is a
newly provisioned vm i just want to
ensure that all my library system
libraries are all updated so that when i
do install cop and cube ctl and all
those things none of them will fail
because of some dependency or package
issues so i'm just running a sudo update
iphone y so that all the libraries are
updated okay looks like it is done so
let me go ahead and install cops cups is
a pretty simple installation it is
available in a particular location i
have to just copy this and ensure that i
do a curl and i install this particular
stuff all right so it is fetching uh the
cops tool it's installing for me once it
is copied down let me change the mode so
that i can execute it and then also let
me move it to my user local bin so that
it is available for me in my path okay
that's pretty much the corpse
installation let me also do one other
thing let me install something called as
cuba ctl so this is what would be you
know a tool using which i'm going to be
firing my uh commands to my kubernetes
cluster once it comes up right this is a
pretty smaller executable so
ctl all right so i have cuba ctl as well
as cops installed on my ec2 server now
okay now what i'll do next is i'm going
to create an s3 bucket in aws so that
the equipment is a cluster state is
persisted in this bucket so let me
create a simple bucket with this name s3
bucket with this name so let me go to s3
and let me create a simple bucket with
this name i will just say create a
bucket okay so this simply learn
kubernetes is the bucket that i created
so this bucket will store all
information about my cluster let me now
uh go and create a dns entry or a dns
zone or aws route 53 hosted zone for my
cluster so this is required so that you
know i can give a cluster name for my
kubernetes cluster that i'm coming up so
i will create a private hosted zone and
possibility possibly i will call this as
simplylearn.n so this will be my name of
my private hosted zone in case you
already have any other public hosted
zones in your name you can always put a
route 53 hosted zone specific for your
domain name since i don't have anyone
i'm just going to create a simple
private hosted zone so let me head down
to route
53 click on any of these and you'll get
these hosted zones out here so i'm going
to create a hosted zone here i'm going
to create a hosted zone click on create
hosted zone um this would be simply
learn lot in i want to create a public
no i don't want public i want a private
hosted zone and i'm going to associate
my vpc id for this hosted zone since i'm
going to try out all my exercises in the
ohio region i will associate the vpc of
the ohio region for this all right so
this is the one that is specific to the
ohio region so i will say this one i'll
say create a hosted great now let me
come back to my ec2 box my ec2 is all
powered with whatever it needs in order
to go ahead with the installation of my
cluster only few things that i need to
take care of is that you know now that i
put a name for my cluster i also have an
s3 bucket that i've configured for my
cluster i will have to ensure that i
need to put in these two configurations
as a part of my cluster building
activity so i will open my bash rc file
and i'm going to export these two
variables if at all you remember well
these two variables are nothing but the
cluster name which is nothing but the
public sorry the private hosted zone
that i created and the s3 bucket where
i'm going to create or rather i'm going
to store my cluster state so let me copy
these two and open up my
bashrc file all right so i will just add
these two and copy these add export them
out as my variable i'm going to save
this here now let me ensure that this
gets picked up all right i've got these
two that have configured and i also
ensure that these environment variables
are set now let me create a pair of ssh
keys this is to ensure that i can log
into the box that i'm going to be
provisioning as a part of my cluster ssh
hyphen keygen i don't want to give any
parameters let it go to the home
directory with the default name and
without any passphrase all right so i
created a bunch of my keypair now i'm
all set to go ahead and run my cops now
cops will ensure that this will take
some time for the cluster to come up but
this is exactly how i would define my
corpse command i have copied here so
corpse create cluster the state of the
cluster will be stored in this
particular variable which is what i have
exported out the number of node count is
two node count is the worker node count
if at all i don't specify configuration
for specifying the master or the control
pane as well if i don't specify that the
default one is one so i'm going to
create
one primary or the master node and two
uh worker nodes uh size of my master
node size of the worker nodes uh what
are the zones where i want this to be
created and where do i store the cluster
information and uh okay i've already
added this master account this is
actually not required but this is the
command that i'm going to fire off so
that i bring up my cluster all right
that went off uh very fast but um this
actually did not create a cluster it is
just the definition of a cluster and
that's why this came out very fast
now that everything looks good with
whatever configuration that i specified
now let me go ahead and create the
cluster by saying corpse update cluster
iphone iphone 8 yes now this will take
some time a good five to ten minutes for
it to because this will actually start
provisioning the servers and as i
mentioned earlier based upon my
configuration i'm gonna come up with one
master server and uh two nodes or the
worker nodes all right so this is the
command for me to validate the cluster
and i'm gonna try it out first i'm
pretty sure that it will fail because
all my servers are not up yet it is
taking some time the validation
everything failed but let me try to look
at my ec2 instances and
see how many servers do i have running
as of now if you see i had only one
server that i had started which was my
cop server and automatically the other
three instances one is called not start
simply not in this these two are the
nodes and this is the master node so
these three got automatically
provisioned by the cops command that i
ran all right so this may take a while
for it to get validated a good 5 to 10
minutes so what i'll do is i'll pause
the video now and i'll come back once
the server the cluster is up and running
it's been a good uh eight to nine
minutes uh since i started my cluster so
let me validate now okay seems good so
there's a master node
minimum one max one some nodes which are
nothing but the slave nodes or the
worker nodes there are two of them due
to micro
subnet so my clusters seem to be up and
running and my cluster name is simply
learn.n so what i would want to do is
now let me just log into the master and
see if i can run some parts so let me
get back to my
installation steps here the validation
cluster is done so let me log into my
since my cluster name is simply non dot
and this is the way to log into my box
so let me get into my box so if you see
here uh this is the host name of the
machine that i'm currently in if you see
this this is nothing but our this cop
server this is a server now from here
i'm trying to get into the master box
all right so if you see the ip address
has changed i was in a different box i'm
in a different box now if i see host
name you'll find a different host name
so this is 153 which is nothing but the
master node yep it's 153 this is the
particular host so i'm getting into this
machine now so i started the cluster
from my cop server here it ran and
brought up three nodes so i'm actually
getting into my master node and see if i
can run some parts on it all right so
let me try kubectl uh get cluster info
try cube ctl get nodes all right so
there are three nodes here master node
and
one master node and two worker nodes so
let me see if i have some parts here
cubicle get pods so there's no port as
of now so what i'll try to do is let me
just pin up a very very simple part just
to check if my connections is everything
is correct or not correct i have a
simple uh node.js application that i've
built uh and i've got a container for
that this is already pushed to the
docker have registered is called simply
learn docker hub and the image name that
i have here is called my node app and i
will use this image to power one of my
parts that i will run so this is the way
in which i'm going to launch my pod let
me show you these commands cube ctl run
the name for my deployment that i'm
going to run hyphen iphone image and
this is the image that is going to be
powering my container so this is simply
learn docker rub forward slash my node
app hyphen f1 replicas equal to i want
two replicas to be running and the port
that i want to expose this particular
part is on eight zero eight zero so let
me run this as soon as this is run it
creates something called as a deployment
all right now let me just say um i'm not
really interested in the deployment i'm
interested in checking if all the parts
are up and running so i will say cube
ctl get both all right so that was
pretty fast so i have two parts that are
running here these are two replicas
because i asked for two replicas these
parts are running so i can run cube ctl
describe pod pickup all right i can pick
up any of the pod name and see what is
the pod what is the information does it
contain from what is the image that is
pulling what is the image image name id
this is actually running my pod which is
actually spinning up a container great
so far so good so in kubernetes the pods
can are ephemeral so they can be there
at any time cannot be read in time if i
need to expose my pod outside i will
have to create a service for my part so
what i'll do is i'll create a very very
simple
service by exposing this particular
deployment before that let me check cube
cdl get deployment so there's a
deployment that is created the
deployment name is simply run app so i
will expose my deployment simply learn
app as uh yeah i'll just expose this let
me see all right i am not specifying
what type and all i don't want to get
into the complications of uh what are
the different types of exposing the
service and all that stuff so if i don't
specify anything uh it gives me
something closer cluster ip so this is
where my pod is actually exposed so let
me just check if at all this part is up
and running i'll just try a simple curl
command curl http colon this is my
cluster ip and the port is 8080. if at
all i hit this it's actually hitting my
application and giving me uh whatever i
put a simple assist.out kind of a thing
where i'm just printing um the container
id of whatever pod is serving uh being
sold out of so i'm actually hitting my
container and i'm getting this output
from the content so everything looks
good my content is up and running uh so
let me just go and clean it up i'll say
equip ctl uh delete deployment simply
learn app this should get rid of all the
parts that i created cube ctl getpod all
right these parts are intimidating
things let me just check cubectl get
services there's one service i don't
want this service let me delete that
cubectl delete service i want this all
right that sounds good so let me come
back to my host my cop server from where
i'm running so i managed to successfully
verify this part see if everything is up
and running so what i'll do is i'll just
go ahead and complete this demo by going
and
getting rid of my cluster so corpse
delete cluster hyphen f1 yes all right
so this will ensure that it will clean
up my complete cluster that i created so
i had three or four running instances if
you see that all the three are shutting
down because you know the cop server
which had cops installed on it has now
got a mandate to go ahead and shut down
and clean up the whole instances and all
those things that are created as a part
of my deployment cloud computing is
becoming more prominent among tech
companies and organizations making this
skill in demand in the sector
cloud-based solutions are proven to be a
boom for company management around the
world because they provide convenience
at an inexpensive price
this means that if you want to work in
technology
a job dealing with cloud-based systems
could be a great fit
hey everyone i'm sharmly and i welcome
you all to this new video of simply
learn on how to become a cloud
engineer according to market and markets
the global cloud computing industry was
valued at
371.4 billion usd in 2020.
it has been predicted that cloud
engineer will be among the top 10 in
demand id jobs in 2021
therefore in this video we will come
across some of the very important
aspects needed to become a cloud
engineer
like
first of all we will understand what is
cloud computing
then we will understand who is a cloud
engineer
after that we will look into the
technical skills needed to become a
cloud engineer
after that we will understand what are
the roles and responsibilities of a
cloud engineer
then we will have a look into the
roadmap of becoming a cloud engineer
and what is the average salary of a
cloud engineer in both the usa and in
india
and at last we will look at the
companies hiring cloud engineers
if getting your learning started is half
the battle what if you could do that for
free visit skill up by simply learn
click on the link in the description to
know more
the first thing we will come across is
what is cloud computing
cloud computing is the distribution of
computing services via the internet
or the cloud
including servers storage databases
networking software analytics and
intelligence to provide faster
innovation more flexible resources and
economies of scale
you usually only pay for the cloud
services you use which helps you cut
costs run your infrastructure more
efficiently and scale as your business
pros
that brings us to who is a cloud
engineer
cloud engineers are the i.t experts in
charge of accessing an organization's
technology infrastructure and
transferring operations and procedures
to a cloud-based architecture
they assist with the migration of
critical corporate applications and
processes to private public and hybrid
cloud com environments
a cloud engineer's job is to access a
company's id infrastructure and migrate
certain processes and operations of the
cloud
public private and hybrid cloud
computing systems are among these
functions and operations
now that we know who a cloud engineer is
let's have a look at the skills required
to become one
cloud engineers must have a diverse set
of technical talents that they will use
in a variety of positions
several key skill sets that cloud
engineers need to be successful include
the ability to program and code
cloud-based applications and processes
the ability to troubleshoot technical
challenges through problem solving
the ability to plan and design software
and cloud applications using critical
and creative thinking
should also include data analysis skills
and should be able to strategically plan
and to fulfill projects using technical
resources
now let's have a look at the roles and
responsibilities of cloud engineer
there are three types of cloud engineers
in particular in a small business one
individual may be in charge of all three
roles
cloud architect
cloud software engineer and cloud
security engineer
cloud architect and organizations cloud
computing strategy include application
design management and monitoring
is overseen by a cloud architect
cloud architects connect various aspects
of cloud computing including data and
networks with tools and services
cloud software engineer a cloud software
engineer creates software for cloud
computing systems and is in charge of
managing their development and
maintenance
cloud security engineer
control based technologies and
procedures that enable regulatory
compliance regulations are included in
security
when dealing with the cloud the major
purpose is to protect information data
data applications and the infrastructure
now let's focus on the roadmap to become
a cloud engineer
cloud engineers generally begin their
careers with a four-year degree in
computer technology
and the steps below defined fundamental
part to becoming a cloud engineer
obtain a bachelor's degree
in software and systems infrastructure
computing or other technical areas
your bachelor's degree program should
emphasize software and system
infrastructure computing and other
technical courses
a bachelor's degree in a computer or
technology related field will also
qualify you for advanced degrees if you
choose to pursue them
learn programming languages python c
plus plus java and ruby for example are
great options to start with
aside from programming languages you'll
want to brush up on your knowledge and
skills with some of the most popular
cloud services including aws hadoop and
azure
it's important that you gain experience
in cloud
computing why internships and open
source projects
this will help you build a portfolio of
work that you can use to demonstrate
your competence in future job interviews
and it will also teach you vital skills
that you'll need to need on job
consider a master's degree
to enhance your cloud computing
abilities while also advancing your
career
because of their higher level of
education cloud engineers with a
master's degree in a tech subject may
have additional career prospects a
master's degree in software engineering
or system engineering for example will
help you develop more of these technical
abilities and expertise advancing your
career
get cloud computing certification
to demonstrate your understanding and
skill level in cloud engineering you can
also check out our official website for
cloud computing certification
it will help you enhance your knowledge
in this particular field
now that we know everything about cloud
computing and how to become a cloud
engineer
let's have a quick look at the average
salary of a cloud engineer in india and
in the usa
in india the average salary of a cloud
engineer is rupees
12 lakh 41 000 per annum
and in the usa the average salary of a
cloud engineer is
837 dollars per annum
now cloud engineers may earn a
substantial income with a national
average salary but it can vary though
depending on your location and how many
years you have been in the field
for example a cloud engineer with a
master's degree and several years of
experience may make more than a new
graduate with a four-year degree who's
just starting out in their career
now let's dive down and explore the
companies hiring cloud engineers
cloud computing is gradually
establishing itself as the industry
standard for data storage and
administration by 2022 according to ivc
over a million cloud computing jobs
would be generated in india
amazon ibm vipro infosys oracle cisco
these are the few top companies who are
some of the top recruiters in this field
every journey begins with a solitary
foundational level certification and for
aws that starting point is the aws
certified cloud practitioner
hello everyone i'm shanley and i welcome
you all to this new video of simply
learn on how to become an aws certified
cloud practitioner
the aws certified cloud practitioner
certification gives you a high level
overview of aws
it doesn't go into a great detail about
any one service instead focuses on the
overall structure of aws and a basic
understanding of what the various
servers accomplish
so
in this video i will take you through
the path of becoming
a successful aws certified cloud
practitioner
starting with what is an aws cloud
followed by the eligibility criteria for
the exam
then we will discuss the exam objectives
then we will look into the exam content
followed by how to prepare for the exam
then we will have a look at some of the
sample questions for your reference
and then we'll discuss
some tips you should remember while
taking the exam
so without any further delay let's get
started with the video
so what is an aws cloud practitioner
the aws certified cloud practitioner
certification is a foundational level
test designed for people who can
successfully show an overall
understanding of the aws cloud according
to amazon
the skills necessary for specific
employment types such as developers
administrators and solution architects
are not assessed by this certification
aws recommends that you have
at least six months of aws cloud
experience
now let's look into the eligibility
criteria for the exam to proceed further
anyone with a basic understanding of the
aws platform should take the exam
we recommend that you have the following
factors before taking this exam
first
six months of aws cloud experience
second understanding id services and how
they are used in the aws cloud platform
is a must
and third is basic understanding of aws
services and use cases invoicing and
pricing mechanisms security concepts and
how the cloud affects your organization
moving on let's have an overview of the
exam
the exam consists of 65 questions and
has a 90 minute time restriction
to pass the exam you must get at least
700 out of 1000 points that is 70
percent
the exam has multiple choice one write
response from four possibilities and
multiple response questions two correct
responses from five options
the cost of applying for the exam is
hundred dollars and the certification
needs to be renewed after every two
years
now that we know of the eligibility
criteria for the exam let's move ahead
and have a look at its objectives
it will enable you to articulate the
value preposition of aws cloud
next you will be able to define the aws
cloud and aws global infrastructure with
it
also it will help you understand and
explain the fundamental aws cloud
architectural ideas
it will enable you to describe the aws
platform's essential security and
compliance features as well as the
shared security model
you'll be able to define invoicing
account management and price models with
it
and it will also enable you to describe
the fundamental code properties of aws
cloud deployment and operation
now let's proceed further and have a
look at the content for the exam for
better and organized preparation for the
exam
the required knowledge is divided into
four domains for the exam these
are various objectives within each test
domain that broadly reflect the
knowledge and expertise required to pass
the exam
cloud concept
this domain makes up 28 percent of the
exam
security this domain makes up 24 of the
technology makes 36 percent of the exam
and billing and pricing makes up twelve
percent of the exam
the following three goals are included
in cloud concepts
they find the aws cloud and the value
proposition it provides recognize
characteristics of the aws cloud's
economics
and make a list of the various cloud
architecture design principles
you should be able to explain the
advantages of public cloud services and
define the services that are offered on
aws like
iaas eas and saas
you must comprehend the financial
benefits of cloud computing and the
distinction between
c a p e x and o p e x this relates to
item one
you should be familiar with cloud
architectural design principles such as
loose coupling scaling bootstrapping and
automation to mention a few
now comes security
you should be familiar with the aws
shared responsibility model which
specifies who is in charge of which
component of the technology stack from
the data center to servers firewall
rules and data encryption
aws offers tools and services for
deploying security evaluating your
security posture and creating alert and
compliance reports you must be
have a thorough understanding of these
services and tools in order to describe
their use and benefits now comes
technology
you must know what the basic aws
services are and how they are used
you usually don't need a thorough
understanding of a services specifics
but you do need to comprehend its goal
benefits and use cases ec2 ecs
lambda light sale
ebs efs s3 rds dynamodb
redshift elastic load balancing auto
scaling cloudfront root s3 cloudwatch
cloudtrail and sms are all core services
you should be familiar with the aws
cloud's worldwide infrastructure regions
availability zones and edge locations
are all part of this
then comes billing and pricing the
majority of aws services are available
on a pay-per-use basis
however there are also alternators to
save money by signing one or three year
contract with a variety of payment
options
you must comprehend these models and the
services to which they apply
make sure you know what aws will charge
you and what will be free inbound data
transport for example is free whereas
outbound data transfer is usually
expensive
vpc cloud formation and iam are all free
services but the resources you generate
with them may not be
you must be aware of the potential for
cause to arise
now let's have a look at how to prepare
for the exam
step 1
start with aws training classes
aws cloud practitioner essentials aws
cloud practitioner technical essentials
and cloud business essentials are a few
courses that will help you build your
knowledge in aws
step 2 go through exam guides for aws
certified loud practitioner
certification because they give you an
idea of important concepts to focus on
for the exam as well as give you an
overview of all the exam objectives
and the pattern of questions
step 3 get familiar with subject areas
before the exam analyze the important
subjects for the exam and keep polishing
your knowledge in that area by constant
revisions
step 4
self sadhu to build your strength self
study is ample to clear this exam just
go through the aws training go through
the study material available online and
keep revising
step 5 examine sample questions and take
a free practice test
practice sample papers from various
website present online to see where you
stand and how much you know and how much
time you take to keep a track of your
performance and improve yourself
and 6.
schedule the exam and get certified
once you feel you are ready prepared and
confident enroll for the exam choose a
center near you for the aws child
practitioner exam website and just
register yourself
so let me give you a glimpse of some
sample questions based on each domain
first question
which feature of aws allows you to
deploy a new application for which the
requirements may change over time
option 1 elasticity option 2
fault tolerance option 3 disposable
resources and option 4 high availability
the answer is option 1 you can deploy
your app without worrying about whether
it will require more or less resources
in the future thanks to elasticity
infrastructure can scale up and down on
demand thanks to elasticity
question 2
which ews service is used to enable
multi-factor authentication
option 1 amazon stf
option 2 aws iam
option 3 amazon ec2
and option 4 aws kms
well the answer is option 2
iam is used to manage multi-factor
authentication and to securely regulate
individual and group access to aws
resources
question three a company would like to
maximize their potential volume and
array discounts across multiple accounts
and also apply service control policies
on member accounts
what can they use to gain these benefits
option 1 aws budgets
option 2 aws cost explorer option 3 aws
iam
option 4 aws organizations
well the answer is
option 4
aws organizations allow you to create
groups of aws accounts and then
administer policies across all of them
from a single location
consolidated billing is available in
both features set of aws organizations
allowing you to set up a single payment
method in the organization master
account while still receiving invoices
for individual activity in each member
account
question 4
what advantages do you get from using
the aws cloud
you have to choose any two
option one trade capital expense for
variable expense option two stop
guessing about cap capacity
option three increase capital
expenditure
option four gain greater control of the
infrastructure layers and option five
comply with all local security
compliance programs
well the answer is option one and two
you may pay on a variable opex basis for
the resources you use and draw on demand
using public cloud services like aws
so you never have to guess how much
resources you need to deploy
question five
under the aws shared responsibility
model what is the customer responsible
for
choose to
option one physical security of the data
center option two replacement and
disposable of this driver
option three configuration of security
groups
option four
patch management of infrastructure and
option 5 encryption of customer data
the answer is option 3 and 5.
customers are responsible for creating
security groups network acls updating
their operating systems and encrypting
their data while aws is responsible for
the physical security of the dc the
replacement of obsolete disk drivers and
infrastructure patch management
question six
what are two ways an aws customer can
reduce their monthly spend
choose two
option one
turn off your resources that are not
being used
option two use more power efficient
instance
type
option three reserve capacity where
suitable option four be efficient with
the usage of security groups
and option five reduce the amount of
data in address charges
the answer is
option 1 and 3
turning of resources that aren't in use
can help you save money reserve
instances can also help you save money
on a monthly basis without committing to
a one or three year contract which is
ideal for predictable workloads
question 7
what are the advantages of availability
zones choose to option one they allow
regional disaster recovery
option two
they provide fault isolation
option three they enable the caching of
data for faster delivery to end users
option 4 they are connected by low
latency network connection
and option 5 they enable you to connect
your on-premises networks to aws to form
a hybrid cloud
the answer is option 2 and 4.
each aws region has numerous
availability zones which are unique
locations
each az is designed to be isolated from
other failures a data center is an az
and
in some situations an ez is made up of
numerous data centers
with an area az provides low cost low
latency network connectivity to other
zone within that region this allows you
to synchronizationly duplicate your data
between data centers allowing the
failover to be automated and visible to
your users
question 8
which aws support plans provide support
via email chat and phone
choose any two option 1 basic option to
business option 3 developer
option 4 global and option 5 enterprise
the answer is option 2 and 5. only the
business and enterprise programs offer
email chat and phone assistance
now that we have discussed all the
important aspects required for aws cloud
practitioner exam let me give you some
tips
you should remember while taking the
exam
first start by answering questions you
are familiar with to prevent spending
time on tough ones
it will give you confidence as well as
save you from wasting your time on
trying tough questions
second keep track of your time and learn
how to manage it in order to complete
all the questions distribute your time
according to the time available to the
number of questions so that you can work
on each question precisely
third analyze the question first then
respond as there may be traps in the
questions focus on keywords and try to
read them two to three times for better
understanding sometimes it is said that
answer lies in the question itself
fourth because there may be numerous
answers to a question
read and choose your answers carefully
if you feel there is a chance that
multiple answers are correct for one
question
then do go for it and analyze it wisely
before coming to that conclusion
well this was all about it today i'm
going to tell you how you can become an
aws solutions architect so who is an aw
solutions architect now the main role of
an aws solutions architect is to help
you deploy your applications on the aws
platform now this is nothing but a cloud
computing platform so it's not to say
that you can't deploy your applications
on the cloud computing platform yourself
it's just that when it comes to
organizations the applications that you
need to deploy become a whole lot more
complex that's where an aw solutions
architect can help ever since cloud
computing became a thing companies
around the world have started migrating
their physical infrastructure onto the
cloud that's what an aws solutions
architect does they help you migrate
your physical infrastructure onto the
aws cloud companies around the world
work on a budget an aws solutions
architect will help design a cloud
infrastructure based on the
organization's budget before that can be
done however an aw solutions architect
has to create a design with an intricate
and detailed blueprint of the cloud
infrastructure that they plan to set up
now aw solutions architects also have to
focus mainly on non-functional
requirements like usability reliability
scalability and performance of the cloud
infrastructure they're also responsible
when it comes to minimizing risks that
an organization can face when it comes
to cloud computing platforms now they
could face risks like security leaks
calculation mistakes and application
down times an aw solutions architect has
to ensure that these don't happen before
we can talk about how you can become an
aws solutions architect i have some
exciting news for you guys we've
launched our own youtube community
you'll get to see a lot of quizzes polls
offers and much more to make your
learning experience a whole lot more fun
you can find all of this on your
subscription feed or you can also click
on the top right corner right now to get
started and let's get back to how can
you become an aws solutions architect
now to become an ew certified solutions
architect you need to clear the aw
certified solutions architect associate
level examination now here's some
details about it the exam score ranges
from 100 to 1000 marks and the minimum
passing score is 720. however there's a
catch the passing marks are actually set
using statistical analysis so they can
be changed based on how difficult the
examination actually is the exam fee is
and you can also take a practice
examination which costs 20
now regardless of the examination you
take be it solutions architect sysops
administrator or developer any associate
level examination costs 150 dollars for
the professional level examination it's
now if you want to learn more about the
aws certifications i suggest you click
on the top right corner and watch our
video aws certifications in 10 minutes
to learn more now the exam duration is
of 130 minutes and you have two types of
questions multiple choice and multiple
answer now the multiple choice questions
have four options on which one of them
is right and you have multiple answer
where you have five options out of which
two of them are correct you can take the
examination in english japanese korean
and simplified chinese now let's talk
about how you can schedule an
examination
first let's go to google and search for
aws certifications
click on the first link
so on this page we can go to the bottom
and find the different certifications
aws provides
click on architect
and select the aws certified solutions
architect associate certification
click on register
now and here you need to click on the aw
certification account
you can sign in with your amazon account
or create a new one
i already have an amazon account that
i'll be using for signing in here in
case you don't you can click on the
create your amazon account button here
and create an account for yourself
now after that is done you can schedule
a new examination
and you can scroll down to the bottom
here aw certified solutions architect
associate level certification
click on schedule exam
press continue
and here you need to select your
language
which i'm assuming is english
i'm from india so i don't need to change
anything here but you can change your
country your time zone and other details
based on your requirement
and select your preferred month i want
to do it in october
now select search for exam center
select the one that's closest to
you i'm going to select this one
and here you can select the day that you
want to take your test and the time
available i want to do it on 15
select the time that i want
and press continue
now you can go through all the details
here
change them if you want to otherwise you
can press continue
after this is done
close
and here we have the final step which is
the face
you can enter your details here
and pay now to finish the process
now let's look at an outline of the exam
content now what you're going to see in
the exam are five major domains and here
you have each of the domains with their
respective weightages
first you have at 34
designing resilient architectures at 24
percent you have both defining
performant architectures and specifying
secure applications and architectures at
10 percent you have designing cost
optimized architectures and at six
percent you have defining operationally
excellent architectures now let's look
at each of these domains in detail now
the first domain or design resilient
architectures can be divided into four
parts firstly you need to know how you
can choose reliable or resilient storage
using services like aws s3 aws glacier
and aws ebs
then you have how you can design
decoupling mechanisms using aws services
now this is possible with the help of
aws sns now these aren't the only
services that enable this these are just
some of the services then how you can
design a multi-tier architecture
solution now this is important because
you need to know how you can create a
solution that involves several other
services then you need to know how you
can design highly available and fault
tolerant architectures now for the
second domain defining performance
architectures first you have how to
choose performance storages and
databases services that are used are aws
rds aws redshift and aws dynamodb the
second step is how you can apply caching
to improve performance a service that
can be used for this is aws elastic
cache third how you can design solutions
with elasticity and scalability you have
aws lambda aws cloudwatch and aws data
pipeline now for the third domain which
is specifying secure applications and
architectures you need to know how you
can secure applications using services
like aws inspector aws cloudtrail and
aws iam you need to know how to secure
data using cloud hsm and aws macy and
how you can define the networking
infrastructure using front vpc and
elastic load balancer for the fourth
domain you have designing cost optimized
architectures firstly you need to know
how you can design cost optimized
compute solutions you can use aws ec2
elastic bean stock lambda and aw slide
sale then you need to know how you can
design cost optimized storage solutions
using aws s3 glacier ebs and elastic
file system and the final domain to
define operationally excellent
architectures you need to set up design
features and solutions that enable
operational excellence now some of the
features are that you perform operations
as code you annotate documentation you
make frequent and small reversible
changes and anticipate and tackle
failures now let's have a look at the
job opportunities when it comes to aws
solutions architects now if you have a
look at this graph you can see that aws
has always provided a lot more job
postings as compared to the other two
giants in the cloud computing domain
which are microsoft azure and google
cloud platform now if you do a little
bit of research you'll find out that
there's a significant lacking of
experienced personnel when it comes to
aws so i would suggest this is the best
time for you to get certified in aws the
amazon web services cloud management
system now has over a million clients
and generates 10 billion dollar in
revenue annually
kellogg's samsung unilever nokia netflix
adobe are the majority of international
corporation
trust the platform
so hello everyone i'm shamley and i'm
going to take you through this new video
of simply learn on top 10 reasons to
choose aws
through the medium of this video i'm
going to give you top 10 reasons to
choose adapt learn and explore aws
but before moving ahead let me give you
an overview of the concept of aws for
your better understanding
amazon web services aws is a cloud
computing platform that manages and
maintains hardware and infrastructure
reducing the expense and complexity of
purchasing and running resources on site
for businesses and individuals
these resources are available for free
or for a fee per usage
it is a comprehensive and simple to use
computing platform offered by amazon
infrastructure as a service platform as
a service and packet software as a
service are all used to build the
platform
so let's move ahead and explore the top
10 reasons to choose aws starting with
the first one which is flexible pricing
options
the most popular motivation for learning
aws is because of its cost-effective
pricing alternatives
aws provides a year of free access to
the free tire
which is idle for novices who wish to
learn about aws technology for beginners
we believe this is plenty
aws is highly customizable with pay as
you go options to match any company need
flexible pricing is a great approach to
scale up or down the architecture as
needed
the aws tariffs are comparable to those
for water and electricity
second reason to proceed with is the
global architecture
one of the most appealing features of
aws is that it is offered in 24
different zones across 16 different
countries
you can connect to the server from any
country you may use all of the
advantages by hiring an aws developer
from anywhere
there are no restrictions on who can use
the servers based on the location
third is automated multi-region backups
aws offers a variety of backup options
including amis and ebs snapshots
aws's decentralized global reach makes
storing crucial data in several
geographical locations simple and cost
effective
as a result
if your main production environment is
brought down by a natural or man-made
calamity your backup data will be
unaffected
third-party solutions can also let
businesses automate backups between aws
sites without the need for internal
scripting
fourth reason that we will come across
is flexibility and scalability
one of the most valuable aws features is
its flexibility it lets you pick your
operating system programming language
web application platform database and
other services
aws provides a virtual environment in
which your application may load all of
the services it requires
it also makes data migration easier
when demand increases or drops auto
scaling and elastic load balancing
techniques are automatically scaled up
or down via aws
aws approaches are useful for dealing
with unpredictably high or unpredictable
loads
organizations gain from lower cost and
more user satisfaction as a result of
this
moving on fifth is streamlined recovery
even a small bit of downtime or data
loss might be disastrous for some
services for others the cost of downtime
data loss is not greater than the
expense of maintaining a multi-site
hot standby recovery strategy regardless
of your organization's resilience to
downtime or data loss aws adaptable
platform can provide you with the tools
you need to implement a disaster
recovery strategy
in the event of a disaster aws disaster
recovery restores your data fast across
several locations
sixth one is
pass offering
the most prevalent model is platform as
a service which has a market share of
roughly 32
and is likely to rise in the next few
years
a platform as a service solution
provides a platform for developers to
construct unique configurable software
and is a popular choice for enterprises
looking to create unique apps without
spending a fortune or shouldering all of
the responsibilities seventh reason i
will take you through is customization
customization for aws control car is a
solution that combines aws control
target other highly available trusted
aws services to assist customers
set up a secure multi-account aws
environment
faster and more efficiently using aws
best practices
customers must first have an aws control
tower landing zone set up in the account
before installing the solution
eighth one is scheduling
aws clients can start and stop services
at any moment
thanks to its service scheduling
feature you can keep track of your
assets pay for the service you use and
run them at a certain time
it enables you to create sample planners
to test consumers viability and schedule
services as required
consider elastic computing cloud ec2 and
relational database service as examples
of scheduling services
you are not required to conduct these
services on a daily basis
set the time table for the service based
on the day of the week you utilize it
ninth is security
aws provides the same level of
world-class security to small one
startups as well as enterprise size
behemoths
the commercial data center meets the
highest conceivable standards saving you
the trouble of needing to defend your
own data centers
aws also maintains a large number of
compliance processes in its
infrastructure as well as a large
security help network that may provide
real-time information about suspicious
stars and potential vulnerabilities and
the last one the 10th reason is third
party apis
either blues api implies that you can
manage your cloud-based facilities in a
variety of languages in line with the
platform's entire versatility
it also means that third-party solutions
such as yours
can take advantage of all of aws time
and cost savings feature
you can automate ordinary but necessary
aws processes without the use of coding
from automated backups to ec2 and rds
instances
well
this brings us to the end of this video
so how can simply learn help you with
your aws certifications now we are on
the sampling on home page
and here we have the awa solutions
architect course
on this course which is the aws
solutions architect certification
training course we have 36 hours of
instructor-led training 20 hours of
self-paced learning 16 live demos three
simulation exams three hands-on practice
projects and so much more here our main
emphasis is on making sure that you have
enough hands-on experience with the
services that you crack the examination
at your first attempt
so here we also go through some of the
more important services that you need to
learn like iam vpc ec2 s3 and so much
more we'll also talk about databases
application services security practices
disaster recovery and so on we even have
practice examinations to help you
prepare for the real one choose from
over 300 in-demand skills and get access
to 1 000 plus hours of video content for
free visit scale up by simply learn
click on the link in the description to
know more i'm here to walk you through
some of the aws interview questions
which we find are important and our hope
is that you would use this material in
your interview preparation and be able
to crack that cloud interview and step
into your dream cloud job by the way i'm
and cloud technical architect trainer
and an interview panelist for cloud
network and devops so as you progress in
watching you're going to see that these
questions are practical scenario-based
questions that tests the depth of the
knowledge of a person in a particular
aws product or in a particular aws
architecture so why wait let's move on
all right so in an interview you would
find yourself with a question that might
ask you define and explain the three
basic types of cloud services and the
aws products that are built based on
them see here it's a very
straightforward question just explain
three basic types of cloud service and
when we talk about basic type of cloud
service it's compute obviously that's a
very basic service storage obviously
because you need to store your data
somewhere and networking that actually
connects a couple of other services to
your application these basic will not
include monitoring these basic will not
include analytics because they are
considered as optional they are
considered as advanced services you
could choose a non-cloud service or a
product for monitoring of and for
analytics so they're not considered as
basic so when we talk about basics they
are compute storage and networking and
the second part of the questions is
explain some of the aws products that
are built based on them of course
compute ec2 is a major one that's that's
the major share of the compute resource
and then we have platform as a service
which is elastic bean stock and then
function as a service which is lambda
auto scaling and light cell are also
part of compute services
so the compute domain it really helps us
to run any application and the compute
service helps us in managing the scaling
and deployment of an application again
lambda is a compute server so the
compute service also helps in running
event initiated stateless applications
the next one was storage a lot of
emphasis is on storage these days
because if there's one thing that grows
in a network on a daily basis that
storage every new day we have new data
to store process manage so storage is
again a basic and an important cloud
service and the products that are built
based on the storage services are s3
object storage glacier for archiving ebs
elastic block storage as a drive
attachment for the ec2 instances and the
efs file share for the ec2 instances so
the storage domain helps in the
following aspects it holds all the
information that the application uses so
it's the application data and we can
also archive old data using storage
which would be glacier and any object
files and any requirement for block
storage can be met through elastic block
store and s3 which is again an object
storage talking about uh networks it's
just not important to answer the
question with the name of the services
and the name of the product it'll also
be good if you could go in depth and
explain how
they can be used right so that actually
proves you to be a person knowledgeable
enough in that particular service or
product so talking about networking
domain vpc networking can't imagine
networking without vpc in in the cloud
environment especially in aws cloud
environment and then we have route 53
for domain resolution or
for dns and then we have cloudfront
which is an edge caching service that
helps customers get our customers to
read their application with low latency
so networking domain helps with some of
the following use cases it controls and
manages the connectivity of the aws
services within our account and we can
also pick an ip address range
if you're a network engineer or if you
are somebody who works in networks or
are planning to work the network you
will soon realize the importance of
choosing your own ip address for easy
remembering
so having an option to have your own ip
address in the cloud on the range of ip
address in the cloud it really helps
really really helps in cloud networking
the other question that get asked would
be the difference between the
availability zone and the region
actually the question generally gets
asked
so to test how well you can actually
differentiate and also correlate the
availability zone and the region
relationship right so a region is a
separate geographic area like the us
west one i mean which represents north
california
or the ap south which represents mumbai
so regions are a separate geographic
area on the contrary availability zone
resides
inside the region you shouldn't stop
there you should go further and explain
about availability zones and
availability zones are isolated from
each other and some of the services will
replicate themselves within the
availability zone so availability zone
does replication within them but regions
they don't generally do replication
between them the other question you
could be asked is what is auto scaling
what do we achieve by auto scaling so in
short auto scaling it helps us to
automatically provision and launch new
instances whenever there is an demand it
not only helps us meeting the increasing
demand it also helps in reducing the
resource usage when there is low demand
so auto scaling also allows us to
decrease
the resources or resource capacity as
per the need of that particular r now
this helps business in not worrying
about putting more effort in managing or
continuously monitoring the server to
see if they have the needed resource or
not because auto scaling is going to
handle it for us so business does not
need to worry about it and auto scaling
is one big reason why people would want
to go and pick a cloud service
especially an aws service the ability to
increase and shrink based on the need of
that art that's how powerful is auto
scaling
the other question you could get asked
is what's your targeting in cloud front
now we know that cloudfront is caching
and it caches content globally in the
amazon caching service global wide the
whole point is to provide users
worldwide access to the data from a very
nearest server possible that's the whole
point in using or going for cloud front
then what do you mean by geo targeting
jio targeting is showing customer and
specific content based on language we
can customize the content based on
what's popular in that place we can
actually customize the content the url
is the same but we could actually change
the content a little bit not the whole
content otherwise it would be dynamic
but we can change the content a little
bit a specific a file or a picture or a
particular link in a website and show
customized content to users who will be
in different parts of the globe so how
does it happen cloudfront will detect
the country where the viewers are
located and it will forward the country
code to the origin server and once the
origin server gets the specialized or a
specific country code it will change the
content and it'll send to the caching
server and it get cached there forever
and the user gets to view a content
which is personalized for them for the
country they are in the other question
you could get asked is the steps
involved in using cloud formation or
creating a cloud formation or backing up
an environment within cloud formation
template we all know that if there is a
template we can simply run it and it
provisions the environment but there is
a lot more going into it so the first
step in moving towards infrastructure as
a code is to create the cloud formation
template which as of now supports json
and yaml file format so first create the
cloud formation template and then save
the code in an x3 bucket s3 bucket
serves as the repository for our code
and then from the cloud formation call
the file in the s3 bucket and create a
stack and now cloud formation uses the
file reads the file understands services
that are being called understands the
order understands how they are connected
with each other cloud formation is
actually an intelligent service it
understands the relation based on the
code it would understand the
relationship between the different
services and it would set an order for
itself and then would provision the
services one after the other let's say a
service has a dependency and the
dependent service the other service
which this service let's say service a
and b service b is dependent on service
a let's say cloud formation is an
intelligent service it would provision
the resource a first and then would
provision resource b what happens if we
inverse the order if we inverse the
order resource b first gets provision
and because it does not have dependency
chances that the cloud formation's
default behavior is that if something is
not provisioned properly something is
not healthy it could roll back chances
that the environment provisioning will
roll back so to avoid that cloud
formation first provisions all the
services that has or that's dependent on
that's depended by another service so it
provisions those service first and then
provisions the services that has
dependencies
and if you are being hired for
a devops or you know if the interviewer
wanted to test your skill on a systems
side this definitely would be a question
in his list how do you upgrade or
downgrade a system with near zero
downtime now everybody's moving towards
zero downtime or near zero downtime all
of them want their application to be
highly available so the question would
be how do you actually upgrade or
downgrade a system with near zero
downtime now we all know that i can
upgrade an ec2 instance to a better ec2
instance by changing the instance type
stopping and starting but stopping and
starting is going to cause a downtime
right so that's you should be answering
or you shouldn't be thinking in those
terms because that's the wrong answer
specifically the interviewer wants to
know how do you upgrade a system with
zero downtime so upgrading system with
zero downtime it includes launching
another system parallelly with the
bigger ec2 instance type over the bigger
capacity and install all that's needed
if you're going to use an ami of the old
machine well and good you don't have to
go through installing all the updates
and installing all the application from
the ami once you've launched it in a
bigger instance locally test the
application to see if it is working
don't put it on production yet test the
application to see if it is working and
if the application works we can actually
swap if your server is behind and
behind
route 53 let's say all that you could do
is go to rot 53 update the information
with the new ip address new ip address
of the new server and that's going to
send traffic to the new server now so
the cutover is handled or if you're
using static ip you can actually remove
the static ip from the old machine and
assign it to the new machine that's one
way of doing it or if you are using
elastic nic card you can actually remove
the new card from the old machine and
attach the new card to the new machine
so that way we would get near zero
downtime if you're hired for an
architect level
you should be worrying about cost as
well along with the technology and this
question would test how well you manage
cost so what are the tools and
techniques we can use in aws to identify
and correct identify and know that we
are paying the correct amount for the
resources that we are using or how do
you get the visibility of your aws
resources running one way is to check
the billing there is a place where you
can check the top services that were
utilized it could be free and it could
be paid service as well top services
that can be utilized it's actually in
the dashboard of the cost management
console so that table here shows the top
five most used services so looking at it
you can get it all right so i'm using a
lot of storage i'm using a lot of ec2
why is storage high you can go and try
to justify that and you will find if you
are storing things that should be
storing and then clean it up why is
compute capacity so high why is data
transfer so high so if you start
thinking in those levels you'll be able
to dig in and clean up unnecessary and
be able to save your bill and there are
cost explorer services available which
will help you to view your usage pattern
or view your spending for the past 13
months or so and it will also forecast
for the next three months now how much
will you be using if your pattern is
like this that will actually help and
will give you a visibility on how much
you have spent how much you will be
spending if the trend continues budgets
are another excellent a way to control
cost you can actually set up budget
alright this is how much i am willing to
spend for this application for this team
or for this month for this particular
resource so you can actually put a
budget mark and anytime it exceeds any
time it's nearing you would get an alarm
saying that well we're about to reach
the allocated budget amount stuff like
that that way you can go back and know
and you know that how much the bill is
going to be for that month or you can
take steps to control bill amount for
that particular month so aws budget is
another very good tool that you could
use cost allocation tags helps in
identifying which team or which resource
has spent more in that particular month
instead of looking at the bill as one
list with no specifications into it and
looking at it as an expenditure list you
can actually break it down and tag the
expenditure to the teams with cost
allocation tax the dev team has spent so
much the production team has spent so
much the training team has spent more
than the dev and the production team why
is that now you'll be able to you know
think in those levels only if you have
cost allocation tax now cost allocation
tax are nothing but the tags that you
would put when you create a resource so
for production services you would put as
a production tag you would create a
production tag and you would associate
that resources to it and at a later
point when you actually pull up your
bill that's going to show a detailed a
list of this is the owner this is the
group and this is how much they have
used in the last month and you can move
forward with your investigation and
encourage or stop users using more
services with the cost allocation tax
the other famous question is are there
any other tools or is there any other
way of accessing aws resource other than
the console console is gui right so in
other words other than gui how would you
use the aws resource and how familiar
are you with those tools and
technologies the other tools that are
available that we can leverage and
access the aws resource are of course
hoodie you can configure pudi to access
the aws resources like log into an ec2
instance and ec2 instance does not
always have to be logged in through the
console you could use putty to log into
an ec2 instance like the jump box like
the proxy machine
and like the gateway machine and from
there you can actually access the rest
of the resources so this is an
alternative to the console and of course
we have the aws cli in any of the linux
machines or windows machines we can
install so that's point two three and
four we can install aws cli for linux
windows also for mac so we can install
them and from there from your local
machine we can access run aws commands
and access provision monitor the aws
resources the other ones are we can
access the aws resource programmatically
using aws sdk and eclipse so these are a
bunch of options we have to use the aws
resource other than the console if
you're interviewed in a company or by a
company that focuses more on security
and want to use aws native services for
their security then you would come
across this question what services can
be used to create a centralized logging
solution the basic services we could use
our cloud watch logs store them in s3
and then use elasticsearch to visualize
them and use kinesis to move the data
from s3 to elasticsearch right so log
management it actually helps
organizations to track the relationship
between
operational and security changes and the
events that got triggered based on those
logs instead of logging into an instance
or instead of logging into the
environment and checking the resources
physically i can come to a fair
conclusion by just looking at the logs
every time there's a change the system
would scream and it gets tracked in the
cloud watch and then cloud watch pushes
it to s3 kinesis pushes the data from s3
to elasticsearch and i can do a
time-based filter and i would get an a
fair understanding of what was going on
in the environment for the past one or
whatever the time window that i wanted
to look at so it helps in getting a good
understanding of the infrastructure as a
whole all the logs are getting saved in
one place so all the infrastructure logs
are getting saved in one place so it's
easy for me to look at it in an
infrastructure perspective
so we know the services that can be used
and here are some of the services and
how they actually connect to each other
it could be logs that belongs to a one
account it could be logs that belongs to
multiple accounts it doesn't matter you
know those three services are gonna work
fairly good and they're gonna inject or
they're gonna like suck logs from the
other accounts put it in one place and
help us to monitor so as you see you
have cloud watch here that actually
tracks the metrics you can also use
cloud trail if you want to log api calls
as well push them in an s3 bucket so
there are different types of blog flow
logs are getting captured in an instance
application logs are getting captured
from the same vpc from a different vpc
from the same account from a different
account and all of them are analyzed
using elasticsearch using the kibana
client
so step one is to deploy the ecs cluster
step two is to restrict access to the
ecs cluster because it's valid data you
don't want anybody to put their hands
and access their data so resting access
to the ecs dashboard and we could use
lambda also to push the uh data from
cloudwatch to
the elasticsearch domain and then kibana
is actually the graphical tool that
helps us to visualize the logs instead
of looking at log as just statements or
in a bunch of characters a bunch of
files kibana helps us to analyze the
logs in a graphical or a chart or a bar
diagram format again in an interview the
interviewer is more concerned about
testing your knowledge on aw security
products especially on the logging
monitoring even management or incident
management then you could have a
question like this what are the native
aws security logging capabilities
now most of the services have their own
logging in them like have their own
logging like s3 s3 has its own login and
cloudfront has its own logging ds has
its own login vpc has its own logging in
additional there are account level
logins like a cloudtrail and aws config
services so there are variety of logging
options available in the aws like cloud
soil config cloudfront redshift logging
rds logging vpc flow logs s3 object
logging s3 access logging stuff like
that so we're going to look at two
servers in specific cloud trail now this
cloud trail the very first product in
that picture we just thought the cloud
trail provides an very high
level history of the api calls for all
the account and with that we can
actually perform a very good security
analysis a security analysis of our
account and these logs are actually
delivered to you can configure it they
can be delivered to s3 for long time
archivals and based on a particular
event it can also send an email
notification to us saying hey just got
this error thought i'll let you know
stuff like that the other one is config
service a config service helps us to
understand the configuration changes
that happened in our environment and we
can also set up notifications based on
the configuration changes so it records
the cumulative changes that are made in
a short period of time so if you want to
go through the lifetime of a particular
resource what are the things that
happened what are the things it went
through they can be looked at using aws
config
all right the other question you could
get asked is if
you know your role includes taking care
of cloud security as well then the other
question you could get asked is the
native services that amazon provides
to mitigate ddos which is denial of
service now not all companies would go
with amazon native services but there
are some companies which want to stick
with amazon native services just to save
them from the headache of managing the
other softwares or bringing in another
tool a third-party tool into managing
ddos they simply want to stick with
amazon proprietary amazon native
services and a lot of companies are
using amazon service to prevent ddos
denial of service now denial of service
is if you already know what denial of
service is well and good if you do not
know then let's know it now denial of
service is a user trying to or
maliciously making attempt to access a
website or an application the user would
actually create multiple sessions and he
would occupy all the sessions and he
would not let legitimate users access
the servers so he's in turn denying the
service for the user a quick picture
review of
what denial of services now look at it
these users instead of making one
connection they are making multiple
connections and there are cheap software
programs available that would actually
trigger connections from different
computers in the internet with different
mac addresses so everything kind of
looks legitimate for the server and it
would accept those connections and it
would keep the sessions open the actual
users won't be able to use them so
that's denying the service for the
actual users denial of service all right
and distributed denial of service is
generating attacks from multiple places
you know from a distributed environment
so that's distributed denial of service
so the tools the native tools that helps
us to prevent the denial of service
attacks in aws is cloud shield
and web access firewall aws now they are
the major ones they are designed to
mitigate a denial of service if your
website is often bothered by denial of
service then we should be using aws
shield or aws waff and there are a
couple of other tools that also does
when i say that also does denial of
service is not their primary job but you
could use them for denial of service
route 53's purpose is to provide dns
cloudfront is to provide caching elastic
load balancer elbs work is to provide
load balancing vpc is to create and
secure a virtual private environment but
they also support mitigating denial of
service but not to the extent you would
get in aws shield and aws web so aws
shield and waff are the primary ones but
the rest can also be used to mitigate
distributed denial of service the other
tricky question is
this actually will test your familiarity
with the region and the services
available in the region so when you're
trying to provision a service in a
particular region you're not seeing the
service in that region how do we go
about fixing it or how do we go about
using the service in the cloud it's a
tricky question and if you have not gone
through such situation you can totally
blow it away you really need to have a
good understanding on regions the
services available in those regions and
what if a particular service is not
available how to go about doing it the
answer is not all services are available
in all regions anytime amazon announces
a new service they don't immediately
publish them on all regions they start
small and as in when the traffic
increases as and when it becomes more
likeable to the customers they actually
move the service to different regions so
as you see in this picture within
america not virginia has more services
compared to ohio or compared to north
california so within not america itself
north virginia is the preferred one so
similarly there are preferred regions
within europe middle east and africa and
preferred regions within asia pacific so
anytime we don't see a service in a
particular region chances that the
service is not available in that region
yet we got to check the documentation
and find the nearest region that offers
that service and start using the service
from that region now you might think
well if i'm looking for a service in
asia let's say in mumbai and if it is
not available why not simply switch to
north virginia and start using it you
could but you know that's going to add
more latency to your application so
that's why we need to check for
application which is check for region
which is very near to the place where
you want to serve your customers and
find nearest region instead of always
going back to north virginia and
deploying an application in north
virginia again there's a place there's a
link in aws.com that you can go and look
for services available in different
region and that's exactly what you're
seeing here and if your service is not
available in a particular region switch
to the other region that provides your
service the nearest other region that
provides that service and start using
service from there
with the
coming up of cloud a lot of companies
have turned down their monitoring team
instead they want to go with the
monitorings that cloud provides you know
nobody wants to or at least many people
don't want to go through the hassle of
at least new startups and new companies
that are thinking of having a monitoring
environment that they don't want to go
with traditional knock monitoring
instead they would like to leverage aws
monitorings available because it
monitors a lot of stuff not just the
availability but it monitors a lot of
stuff like failures errors it also
triggers emails stuff like that so how
do you actually set up a monitor to
website how to set up a monitor to
monitor the website metrics in real time
in aws the simple way anytime you have a
question about monitoring cloudwatch
should strike your mind because
cloudwatch is meant for monitoring is
meant for collecting metrics is meant
for providing graphical representation
of what's going on in a particular
network at a particular point of time so
cloudwatch cloudwatch helps us to
monitor applications and using
cloudwatch we can monitor the state
changes not only the state changes the
auto scaling life cycle events anytime
there are there are more services added
there is a reduction in the number of
servers because of less usage and very
informative messages can be received
through cloud watch any cloud watch can
now support scheduled events if you want
to schedule anything cloudwatch has an
event that would schedule an action all
right schedule a trigger time based not
incident based you know anything
happening and then you get an action
happening that's incident based on the
other hand you can simply schedule few
things on time based so that's possible
with cloud watch so this cloud watch
integrates very well with a lot of other
services like notifications for
notifying the user or for notifying the
administrator about it and it can
integrate well with lambda so to trigger
an action anytime you're designing an
auto healing environment this cloud
watch can actually monitor and send an
email if we are integrating it with sns
simple notification service or this
cloud watch can monitor and
based on what's happening it can trigger
an event in lambda and that would in
turn run a function till the environment
comes back to normal so cloudwatch
integrates well with a lot of other aw
services
all right so cloudwatch has uh three
statuses green when everything is going
good yellow when the service is degraded
and red when the service is not
available green is good so we don't have
to do anything about it but anytime
there is an ello the picture that we're
looking at it's actually calling an
lambda function to debug the application
and to fix it and anytime there's a red
alert it immediately notifies the
owner of the application about well the
service is down and here is the report
that i have here is the metrics that
i've collected about the service stuff
like that if the job role requires you
to manage the servers as well there are
certain job roles which are on the
system side there are certain job roles
which is development plus system side
now you're responsible for the
application and the server as well so if
that's the case you might be tested with
some basic questions like the different
types of virtualization and aws and what
are the difference between them all
right the three major types of
virtualization are
hvm which is hardware virtual machine
the other one is pv para virtualization
and the third one is pv on hvm para
virtualization on hardware virtual
module
all right the difference between them or
actually describing them is actually the
difference between them hvm it's
actually a fully virtualized hardware
you know the whole hardware is
virtualized and all virtual machines act
separate from each other and these vms
are booted by executing master boot
record in the root block and when we
talk about para virtualization paragraph
is actually the special boot loader
which boots the pv amis and when we talk
about pv on hvm it's it's actually the
marriage between hvm and pv and this
para virtualization on hvm in other
words pv on hvm it actually helps
operating system take advantage in
storage and the network input output
available through the host
another good question is name some of
the services that are not region
specific now
you've been thought that all services
are within a region and some services
are within an availability zone for
example ec2 is within an availability
zone ebs is within an availability zone
s3 is region specific dynamodb is region
specific
stuff like that vpc is both availability
and
region specific meaning you know subnets
are availability zone specific and vpcs
region specific stuff like that so you
might have thought you might have
learned in that combination but there
could be some tricky questions that
tests you how well you have understood
the region non-region and availability
non-availability services i should say
there are services that are not region
specific that would be iam so we can't
have im for every availability zone and
for every region which means you know
users will have to use one username and
password for one region and anytime they
switch to another region they will have
to use another username and password
that that's more work and that's not a
good design as well authentication has
to be global so im is a global service
and which means it's not region specific
on the other hand route 53 is again a
regional specific so we can't have a
route 53 for every region route 53 is
not a region specific service it's a
global service and it's one application
users access from everywhere or from
every part of the world so we can't have
one url or one dns name for each region
if your application is a global
application and then web application
firewall works well with cloudfront then
cloudfront is a region based service so
the web application firewall it's not
region specific service it's a global
service and cloudfront is again a global
service though you can
you know cache content on a continent
and country basis it's still considered
a global service all right it's not
bound to any region so when you activate
cloud front you're activating it away
from region or availability zone so when
you're activating a web application
firewall because it's not a
region-specific service you're
activating it away from availability
zone and regions
so a quick recap i am users groups roles
and accounts they are global services
they can be used globally around 53
services are offered at edge locations
and they are global as well web
application firewall a service that
protects our web application from common
web exploits they are global service as
well cloudfront cloudfront is global
content delivery network cdn and they
are offered at edge locations which are
a global service in other words
non-region specific service or beyond
region service
all right this is another good question
as well in the project that you are
being interviewed if they really want to
secure their environment using nat or if
they are already securing their
environment using nat by any of these
two methods like nat gateway or nat
instances you can expect this question
what are the difference between and that
gateway and that instances now they both
saw the same thing right so they're not
two different services trying to achieve
two different things they both serve the
same thing but still they do have
differences in them right on a high
level they both achieve providing
netting for the service behind it but
the difference comes when we talk about
the availability of it nat gateway is a
managed service by amazon whereas nat
instance is managed by us now i'm
talking about the third point
maintenance here nat gateway is managed
by amazon that instance is managed by us
and availability of nat gateway is very
high and availability of that instance
is less compared to the nat gateway
because it's managed by us you know it's
on an ec2 instance which could actually
fail and if it fails we'll have to
relaunch it but if it is not gateway if
something happens to that service amazon
would take care of reprovisioning it and
talking about bandwidth it can burst up
to 75 gigabits now traffic through the
net gateway can burst up to 75 gigabits
but for that instance it actually
depends on the server that we launched
and if we are launching a t2 micro it
barely gets any bandwidth so there's a
difference there and the performance
because it's highly available because of
the bigger pipe 75 gigabits now the
performance of the night gateway is very
high but the performance of the nat
instance is going to be average again it
depends on the size of the nat instance
that we pick and billing a billing for
that gateway is the number of gateways
that we provision and the duration for
which we use the nat gateway but billing
for nat instance is number of instance
and the type of instance that we use of
course number of instance duration and
the type of instance that we use
security not gateway cannot be
assigned meaning it already comes with
full packed security but in that
instance security is a bit customizable
i can go and change the security because
it's a server managed by me or managed
by us i can always change the security
well allow this allow don't allow this
stuff like that size and load of the
night gateway is uniform but the size
and the load of the uh that instance
changes as per that gateway is a fixed
product but not instance can be small
instance can be a big instance so the
size and the load through it varies
right the other question you could get
asked is what are the difference between
stopping and terminating an ec2 instance
now you will be able to answer only if
you have worked on environments where
you have your instance stopped and where
you have your instance terminated if you
have only used lab and are attending the
interview chances are that you might you
always lost when answering this question
it might look like both are the same
well stopping and terminating both are
the same but there is a difference in it
so when you stop an instance it actually
performs a normal shutdown on the
instance and it simply moves the
instance to the stopped state but when
you actually terminate the instance the
instance is moved to this stop state the
evs volumes that are attached to it are
deleted and removed and we'll never be
able to recover them again so that's a
big difference between stopping and
terminating an instance if you're
thinking of using the instance again
along with the data in it you should
only be thinking of stopping the
instance but you should be terminating
the instance only if you want to get rid
of that instance forever
if you are being interviewed for an
architect level position or a junior
architect level position or even a cloud
consultant level position or even in an
engineering position this is a very
common question that gets asked what are
the different types of easy to instances
based on their cost or based on how we
pay them right they're all compute
capacity for example the different types
are on demand instances spot instances
and reserved instances it kind of looks
the same they all provide the compute
capacity they all provide the same type
of hardwares for us but if you're
looking at cost saving or optimizing
cost in our environment we got to be
very careful about which one are we
picking now we might think that well
i'll go with on-demand instance because
i pay on a per hour basis which is cheap
you know i can use them anytime i want
and anytime i don't want i can simply
get rid of it by terminating it you're
right but if the requirement is to use
the service for one year the requirement
is to use the service for three years
then you'll be wasting a lot of money
buying on-demand instances you'll be
wasting a lot of money paying on an
hourly basis instead we should be going
for reserved instance where we can
reserve the capacity for the complete
one year or complete three years and
save huge amount in buying reserved
instances all right so under man is
cheap to start with if you're only
planning to use it for a short while but
if you're planning to run it for a long
while then we should be going for
reserved instance that is what is cost
efficient so spot instance is cheaper
than on-demand instance and there are
different use cases for spot instance as
well so let's look at one after the
other the on-demand instance the
on-demand instance is purchased at a
fixed rate per r this is very short term
and irregular workloads and for testing
for development on demand instance is a
very good use case we should be using on
demand for production spot instance spot
instance allows users to purchase ec2 at
a reduced price and anytime we have more
instances we can always go and sell it
in spot instances i'm referring to
anytime we have more reserved instances
we can always sell them in spot instance
catalog and the way we buy spot instance
is we actually put a budget this is how
much i'm willing to pay all right would
you be able to give service within this
cost so anytime the price comes down and
meets the cost that we have put in will
be assigned an instance and anytime the
price shoots up the instance will be
taken away from us but in case of
on-demand instances we have bought that
instance for that particular r and it
stays with us but with spot instances it
varies based on the price if you meet
the price you get the instance if you
don't meet the price goes away to
somebody else and the spot instance
availability is actually based on supply
and demand in the market there's no
guarantee that you will get spot
instance at all time all right so that's
a caveat there you should be familiar
with that's a caveat that you should be
aware when you are proposing somebody
that we can go for spot instance and
save money it's not always going to be
available if you want your spot instance
to be available to you then we need to
carefully watch the history of the price
of the spot instance now how much was it
last month and how much was it how much
is it this month so how can i code or
how much can i code stuff like that so
you got to look at those history before
you propose somebody that well we're
going to save money using spot instance
on the other hand reserved instance
provide cost savings for the company we
can opt for reserved instances for you
know one year or three years there are
actually three types of reserved
instances light medium and heavy
reserved instances they are based on the
amount that we would be paying and cost
benefit also depends with reserved
instance the cost benefit also depends
based on are we doing all upfront or no
upfront or partial payment then split
the rest as monthly payments so there
are many purchase options available but
overall if you're looking at using an
application for the next one year and
three years you should not be going for
on-demand instance you should be going
for reserved instance and that's what
gives you the cost benefit
and in an error-based interview
sometimes you might be asked you know
how you interact with the aws
environment are you using cli are you
using console and depending on your
answer whether console or a cli the
panelist put a score okay this person is
cli specific this person is console
specific or this person has used aws
environment through the sdk stuff like
that so this question tests whether you
are a cli person or an console person
and the question goes like this how do
you set up ssh agent forwarding so that
you do not have to copy the key every
time you log in if you have used footy
anytime if you want to log into an ec2
instance you will have to put the ip and
the port number along with that you will
have to map or we will have to map the
key in the puri and this has to be done
every time that's what we would have
done in our lab environments right but
in production environment using the same
key or mapping the same key again and
again every time it's actually in hassle
it's considered as a blocker so you
might want to cache it you might want to
permanently add it in your putty session
so you can immediately log in and start
using it so here in the place where you
would actually map the private key
there's a quick button that actually
fixes or that actually binds your ssh to
your instance so we can enable ssh agent
forwarding that will actually bind our
key to the ssh and next time when we try
to log in you don't have to always go
through mapping the key and trying to
log in all right this question what are
solares and ax operating systems are
they available with aws that question
generally gets asked to test how
familiar are you with the
amis available how familiar are you with
ec2 how familiar are you with the ec2
hardwares available that basically test
that now the first question or the first
thought that comes to your mind is well
everything is available with aws i've
seen windows i've seen ubuntu i've seen
red hat i've seen amazon amis and if i
don't see my operating system there i
can always go to marketplace and try
them if i don't find a marketplace i can
always go to community and try them so a
lot of amis available that lot of
operating systems available i will be
able to find solaris and ax but that's
not the case solar s and ax are not
available with aws that's because
solaris uses a different and solaris
does not support the architecture does
not support public cloud currently the
same goes for ax as well and they run on
power cpu and not on intel and as of now
amazon does not provide power machines
this should not be confused with the hpc
which is a high performance computing
should not be confused with that now
these are different hardwares different
cpu itself that the cloud providers did
do not provide yet another question you
could get asked in organizations that
would want to automate their
infrastructure using amazon native
services would be how do you actually
recover an ec2 instance or auto recover
an ec2 instance when it fails well we
know that ec2 instances are considered
as immutable meaning irreparable we
don't spend time fixing
bugs in an os stuff like that you know
once an ec2 instance crashes like it
goes on a always panic or there are
various reasons why it would fail so we
don't have to really worry about fixing
it we can always relaunch that instance
and that would fix it but what if it
happens at two o'clock in the night what
if it happens that during a weekend when
nobody's in office
looking or monitoring those instances so
you would want to automate that not only
on a weekend or during midnights but
it's general practice good to automate
it so you could face this question how
do you actually automate an ec2 instance
once it fails and the answer to that
question is using cloud watch we can
recover the instance so as you see there
is an alarm threshold a set in cloud
watch and once the threshold is met
meaning if there is an error if there is
a failure if the ec2 instance is not
responding for a certain while we can
set an alarm and once the alarm is met
let's say the cpu utilization stayed
high for five minutes all right it's not
taking any new connections or the
instance is not pinging for five minutes
or in this case it's two minutes it's
not pinging so it's not going to respond
connection so in those cases you would
want to automatically recover that ec2
instance by rebooting the instance all
right now look at this the take this
action section under the action so there
we have a bunch of options like recover
this instance meaning reboot the
instance so that's how we would recover
the other two options are beyond the
scope of the question but still you can
go ahead and apply just like i'm gonna
do it so the other option is stop the
instance that's very useful when you
wanna stop instances that are having low
utilizations nobody's using the system
as of now you don't want them to be
running and wasting the cloud
expenditure so you can actually set an
alarm that stops the ec2 instance that's
having low utilization so somebody was
working in an instance and they left it
without or they forgot to shut down that
instance and it gets i mean they will
only use it again the next day morning
so in between there could be like 12
hours that the system is running idle
nobody's using it and you're paying for
it so you can identify such instances
and actually stop them when the cpu
utilization is low meaning nobody is
using it the other one is to terminate
let's say you want to give system to
somebody temporarily and you don't want
them to hand the system back to you all
right this is actually an idea in other
words this is actually the scenario so
you hand over a system to somebody and
when they're done they're done we can
actually terminate the system so you
could instruct the other person to
terminate the system when they're done
and they could forget and the instance
could be running forever or you can
monitor the system after the specified
time is over and you can terminate the
system or best part you can automate the
system termination so you assign a
system to somebody and then turn on this
cloud watch action to terminate the
instance when the cpu is low for like
two hours meaning they've already left
or cpu is low for 30 minutes meaning
they've already left stuff like that so
that's possible and if you're getting
hired for an system side architect or
even on the sysop site you could face
this question what are the common and
different types of ami designs there are
a lot of ami designs the question is the
common ones and the difference between
them so the common ones are the full
back a mice and the other one is just
enough os ami j e os ami and the other
one is hybrid type amis so let's look at
the difference between them the full
backed ami just like the name says it's
fully baked it's
ready to use ami
this is the simplest ami to deploy can
be a bit expensive it can be a bit
cumbersome because you'll have to do a
lot of work beforehand you could use the
ami so a lot of planning a lot of
thought process will go into it and the
ami is ready to use right you hand over
the ami to somebody and it's ready to
use or if you want to reuse the ami it's
already ready for you to use so that's
full baked ami the other one is just
enough operating system ami just like
the name says
it has
i mean as you can also see in the
diagram or in the picture it covers a
part of the os all bootstraps are
already packed properly and the security
monitoring logging and the other stuff
are configured at the time of deployment
or at the time you would be using it so
not much thought process will go in here
the only focus is on choosing the
operating system and what goes the
operating system specific agents or
bootstraps that goes into the operating
system that's all we worry about the
advantage of this is it's flexible
meaning you can choose to install
additional softwares at the time of
deploying but that's going to require an
additional expertise on the person who
will be using the ami so that's another
overhead there but the advantage is that
it's kind of flexible i can change the
configurations during the time of
deployment the other one is a hybrid ami
now the hybrid ami actually falls in
between
the fully baked ami and just enough
operating system options so these amis
have some features of the big type and
some features of the just enough os type
so as you see the security monitoring
logging
are
packed in that ami and the runtime
environments are installed during the
time of a deployment so this is where
the strict company policies would go
into the ami company policies like you
gotta log this you gotta monitor this
these are the ports that generally gets
open in all the systems stuff like that
so they strictly go into the ami and
sits in an ami form and during
deployment you have the flexibility of
choosing the different runtime and the
application that sits in an ec2 instance
another very famous question you would
face in an interview is how can you
recover login to an ec2 instance to
which you lost the key well we know that
if the key is lost we can't recover it
there are some organizations that
integrate their ec2 instances with an 80
that's different all right so you can go
and reset the password and the ad and
you will be able to log into the new
password but here the specific tricky
question is you are using a key to log
in and how do you recover if you have
lost the key generally companies would
have made a backup of the key so we can
pick from the backup but here the
specific question is we have lost the
key literally no backups on the key at
all so how can we log in and we know
that we can't log into the instance
without the key present with us so the
steps to recover is that make the
instance use another key and use that
key to log in once the key is lost it's
lost forever we won't be able to recover
it you can't raise the ticket with
amazon not possible they're not going to
help it's beyond the scope so make the
instance use another key it's only the
key that's the problem you still have
valid data in it you got to recover the
data it's just the key that's having the
problem so we can actually focus on the
key part alone and change the key and
that will allow us to log in so how do
we do it step by step procedure so first
verify the easy to config services
running in that instance if you want you
can actually beforehand install the easy
to config in that service or you can
actually make the easy to config run
through the console just a couple of
button clicks and that will make the
easy to configure run in that ec2
instance and then detach the root volume
for that instance of course it's going
to require a stop and start to detach
the root volume from the instance attach
the root volume to another instance as a
temporary volume or it could be a
temporary instance that you've launched
only to fix this issue and then login to
that instance and to that particular
volume and modify the configuration file
configuration file modify it to use the
new key and then move the root volume
back to its original position and
restart the instance and now the
instance is going to have the new key
and you also have the new key with which
you can log in so that's how we go ahead
and fix it now let's move on to some
product specific or s3 product specific
questions a general perception is s3 and
ebs can be used interchangeably and the
interviewer would want to test your
knowledge on s3 and evs well ebs uses s3
that's true but they can't be
interchangeably used so you might face
this question what are some key
differences between aws s3 and ebs well
the differences are s3 is an object
store meaning you can't install anything
in it you can store drive files but you
can't actually install in it it's not a
file system but ebs is a file system you
can install services i mean install
applications in it and that's going to
run stuff like that and talking about
performance s3 is much faster and ebs is
super faster when accessing from the
instance because from the instance if
you need to access s3 you'll actually
have to go out through the internet and
access the s3 or s3 is an external
service very external service you'll
have to go through or you'll have to go
outside of your vpc to access s3 s3 does
not come under a vpc but ebs comes under
a vpc it's on the same vpc so you would
be able to use it kind of locally
compared to s3 ebs is very local so that
way it's going to be faster and
redundancy talking about redundancy of
s3 and ebs s3 is
replicated the data in s3 is replicated
across the data centers but ebs is
replicated within the data center
meaning s3 is replicated across
availability zones ebs is within an
availability zone so that way the
redundancy is a bit less in ebs in other
words redundancy is higher in s3 than
eps and talking about security of s3 a
s3 can be made private as well as public
meaning anybody can access s3 from
anywhere in the internet that's possible
with s3 but ebs can only only be
accessed when attached to an ec2
instance right just one instance can
access it whereas s3 is publicly
directly accessible the other question
related to s3 security is how do you
allow access to a user to assert in a
user to a certain bucket which means
this user is not having access to s3 at
all but this user needs to be given
access to a certain bucket how do we do
it the same case applies to servers as
well in few cases there could be an
instance where a person is new to the
team and you actually don't want them to
access the production service now he's
in the production group and by default
he or she is granted access to that
server but you specifically want to deny
access to that production server till
the time he or she is matured enough to
access or understand the process
understand the do's and don'ts before
they can put their hands on the
production server so how do we go about
doing it so first we would categorize
our instances well these are critical
instances these are normal instances and
we would actually put a tag on them
that's how we categorize right so you
put attack on them put attacks saying
well they are highly critical they are
medium critical and they are not
critical at all still there in
production stuff like that and then you
would pick the users who wants to or who
should be or should not be given access
to a certain server and you would
actually allow the user to access or not
access servers based on a specific tag
in other words you can use actually tags
in in the previous step we put tags on
the critical server right so you would
define that this user is not going to
use this tag all right this user is not
allowed to use the resources with this
stack so that's how you would make your
step forward so you would allow or deny
based on the tags that you have put so
in this case he or she will not be
allowed to servers which are tagged
critical servers so that's how you allow
deny access to them and the same goes
for bucket as well
if an organization is excessively using
s3 for their data storage because of the
benefit that it provides the cost and
the
durability you might get asked this
question which is organizations would
replicate the data from one region to
another region for additional data
durability and for having data
redundancy not only for that they would
also do that for dr purposes for
disaster recovery if the whole region is
down you still have the data available
somewhere else and you can pick and use
it some organizations would store data
in different regions for compliance
reasons to provide low latency access to
their users who are local to that region
stuff like that so when companies do
replication how do you make sure that
there is consistency in the replication
how do you make sure that the
replication is not failing and the data
gets transferred for sure and there are
logs for that replication this is
something that the companies would use
where they're excessively using s3 and
they're fully relying on the replication
in running their business
and the way we could do it is we can set
up a replication monitor it's actually a
set of tools that we could use together
to make sure that the cloud replication
a region level replication is happening
properly so this is how it happens now
on this side on the left hand side we
have the region 1 and on the right hand
side we have region 2 and region 1 is
the source bucket and region 2 is the
destination bucket right so object is
put in the source bucket and it has to
go directly to the region to bucket or
or made a copy in the region to bucket
and the problem is sometimes it fails
and there is no consistency between them
so the way you would do it is connect
these services together and create and
cross replication or cross region
replication monitor that actually
monitors that actually monitors your
environment so there are cloud watts
that make sure that the data is uh moved
no data is failing again there's cloud
watch on the other end make sure that
the data is moving and then we have the
logs generated through cloudtrail and
that's actually written in dynamodb and
if there is an error if something is
failing you get notified through an sms
or you get notified through an email
using the sns service so that's how we
could leverage these tools and set up
and cross region replication monitor
that actually monitors your data
replication
some common issues that company
companies face in vpc is that we all
know that i can use route 53 to resolve
an ip address externally from the
internet but by default the servers
won't connect to the other servers using
our custom dns name that does not do
that by default so it's actually a
problem there are some additional things
that as an administrator or as an
architect or as a person who uses it you
will have to do and that's what we're
gonna discuss so the question could be a
vpc is not resolving the server through
the dns you can access it through the ip
but not through the dns name and what
could be the issue and how do you go
about fixing it and you will be able to
answer this question only if you have
done it already it's a quick and simple
step by default vpc does not allow
that's the default feature and we will
have to enable the
dns hostname resolution before
now this is for the custom dns not for
the default dns that comes along this is
for the custom dns so we will have to
enable the dns host name resolution so
our will have to enable dns hostname
resolution so they actually resolve
let's say i want to connect to a
server1.simplylearn.com by default it's
not allowed but if i enable this option
then i will be able to connect to
server1 simplylearn.com if a company has
vpcs in different regions and they have
a head office in a central place and the
rest of them are branch offices and they
are connecting to the head office for
access or you know for saving data or
for accessing certain files or certain
data or storing data all right so they
would actually mimic the hub and spoke
topology where you have the vpc which is
centrally in an accessible region a
centrally accessible region and then you
would have a local vpcs or branch
offices in different other regions and
they get connected to the vpc in the
central location and the question is how
do you actually connect the multiple
sites to a vpc and make communication
happen between them by default it does
not do that we know that vpcs they need
to be paired between them in order to
access the resources let's look at this
picture right so i have like a customer
network or branch offices in different
parts and they get connected to a vpc
that's fine so what we have achieved is
those different offices
the remote offices they are connecting
to the vpc and they're talking but they
can't connect or they can't talk to each
other that's what we have built but the
requirement is the traffic
needs to or they should be able to talk
to each other but they should not have
direct connection between them which
means that they will have to come and
hit the vpc and then
reach the other customer network which
is in los angeles or which is in new
york all right that's the requirement so
that's possible with some architecting
in the cloud so that's using vpn cloud
hub you look at this dotted lines which
actually allows customers or which
actually allows the
corporate networks to talk to each other
through the vpc again by default it
doesn't happen cloud hub is an
architecture that we should be using to
make this happen and what's the
advantage of it as a central office or
as the headquarters office which is in
the vpc or headquarters data center
which is in the vpc you have control or
the vpz has control on who talks to who
and what traffic can talk to i mean what
traffic can be routed to the other head
office stuff like that that centralized
control is on the vpc the other question
you could get asked is neyman explain
some security products and features
available in vpc well vpc itself is an
security service it provides security
service to the application but how do
you actually secure the vpc itself
that's the question and yes there are
products that can actually secure the
vpc or the vpc delivers those products
to secure the application
access to the vpc is restricted through
a network access control list right so
that's and security product in vpc and a
vpc has security groups that protects
the instances from unwanted inbound and
outbound traffic and network access
control list protects the subnets from
unwanted inbound and outbound access and
there are flow logs we can capture in
vpc
that captures incoming and outgoing
traffic through a vpc which will be used
for later analysis as in what's the
traffic pattern what's the behavior of
the traffic pattern and stuff like that
so there are some security products and
features available in vpc now how do you
monitor a vpc vpc is a very important
concept very important service as well
everything sits in a vpc most of the
service sits in a vpc except for lambda
and s3 and dynamodb and couple of other
services most of them sit in a vpc for
security reason so how do you monitor
your vpc how do you gain some visibility
on your vpc well we can gain visibility
on our vpc using vpc flow log that's the
basic service as you see it actually
captures what's allowed what's not
allowed stuff like that which ip's
allowed which ip is not allowed stuff
like that so we can gather it and we can
use that for analysis and the other one
is cloud watch and cloud watch logs the
data transfers that happen so this is
you know who gets allowed and who does
not get allowed i mean the flow logs is
who is allowed and who's not allowed
that kind of detail and cloud watch
gives information about the data
transfer how much data is getting
transferred we can actually pick unusual
data transfers if there is a certain
hike in the graph there's a sudden hike
and something happens at 12 on a regular
basis and you weren't expecting it
there's something suspicious it could be
valid backups it could be a malicious
activity as well so that's how you know
by looking at cloudwatch logs and
cloudwatch dashboard now let's talk
about multiple choice questions when
going for an interview you might
sometimes find yourself that the company
is conducting an online test based on
the score they can put you to a panelist
and then they would take it forward so
we thought we'll also include multiple
choice questions to help you better
handle such situation if you come across
all right when you find yourself in such
situation the key to clear them is to
understand the question properly read
between the lines that's what they say
you know there can be like a big
paragraph with three lines or ten lines
you really got to understand what the
question is about and then try to find
answer for that question so that's a
thumb rule number one and then the
second rule is try to compare and
contrast the services
mentioned or try to compare and contrast
the answers you can easily read out one
or two answers and then you will be left
with only two answers to decide from you
know so that also helps you with time
and that's all that also helps you with
some precision in your answer so number
one read between the lines number two
compare and contrast the services and
you'll be able to easily weed out the
wrong ones so let's try answering this
question suppose you are a game designer
and you want to develop a game with a
single digit millisecond latency which
of the following database services would
you choose so we know that the following
are database services are good enough
all right and it talks about millisecond
latency that's a key point and the third
thing is it's a game it could be a
mobile game it's a game that you are
trying to design and you need the
millisecond latency and it has to be a
database all right so let's talk about
the options available rds rds is a
database for sure is it good for
a game design we'll come back to that
neptune
neptune is a graph a database service in
amazon so that's kind of out of the
equation and snowball is actually a
storage right it's it's a transport
medium i would say so that's again out
of the equation so the tie is between
rds and dynamodb if we need to talk
about rds rds is an a platform as a
service it provides cost efficient
resizable capacity but it's an sql
database meaning the tables are kind of
strict you know it's good for banking
and other type of applications but not
really good for anything that has to do
with the gaming so the only option left
is dynamodb again it's the right answer
dynamodb is actually an fast and
flexible nosql database service and it
provides a single digit millisecond
latency at any scale and it's a database
at the same time it's a key value store
model database so the right answer is
dynamodb all right let's look at the
next question if you need to perform
real-time monitoring of aws services and
get actionable insights which service
would you use
all right let's list the services so it
talks about real-time monitoring a
firewall manager what does it provide
now firewall manager is not really a
monitor just like the name says it's a
manager it manages multiple firewalls
and aws guard duty is an threat
detection service it does monitoring it
does continuously monitor our
environment but it monitors for threats
all right only threats now let's talk
about cloud watch a cloud watch is a
service that helps to track metrics it's
a service that is used to
monitor the environment and give us a
system-wide visibility and also it helps
us to store logs so at the moment it
kind of looks like that could be the
right answer we don't know that yet but
i mean we have one more option left
that's uh ebs so what's ebs ebs is a
block storage elastic block store if we
abbreviate ebs it's elastic block store
so all three of them are easily out of
the question the first one is to manage
second one is to find threats
of course it does monitoring so there's
i mean if there is one relation between
cloud watch and god duty that's
monitoring so easily we can actually
find ourselves slipped towards picking
guard duty but know that guard duty is
only for gaining security inside but not
about gaining aws service
inside so cloudwatch is a service that
helps us to get a system wide or an aws
wide or an account wide and it has
number of metrics we can monitor and get
a very good insight of how a service is
performing be it cpu be it ram beat
network utilization beat
connection failures cloud watch is a
service that helps us perform a
real-time monitoring and get some
actionable insights on the services all
right let's talk about this 33rd
question as a web developer you are
developing an app especially for the
mobile platform all right there is a
mention that this is especially for the
mobile platform so a lot of services
gets filtered out mobile platform right
which of the following lets you add user
sign up sign in and access control to
your web and mobile app quickly and
easily all right so this is all about
signing in to your mobile app so if we
need to read between the lines that's
how we can read sign up or sign in into
an mobile platform all right so we have
like four options here uh shield aws
massey aws inspector amazon cognito so
let's try to weed out services which are
not relevant to it so what's aws shield
aws shield is actually a service that
provides a ddos mitigation or ddos
protection denial of service protection
it's a security feature let's talk about
the second option aws maxi is again a
security service that uses machine
learning to automatically discover and
classify
the data it again talks about
security and this security is all about
encrypting or saving the data does not
come close with signing up and mobile
platform all right let's talk about the
other one aws inspector now aws
inspector has something to do with apps
it definitely has something to do with
apps so kind of looks like that's
relevant as of now so it actually helps
with
improving the security and compliance of
the apps that we deploy in the cloud so
kind of looks like it could be because
it has to do with apps the last one
cognito now cognito is a service that
actually lets the administrator to have
control access over web and mobile apps
and it's a service that helps us to sign
up and
assign in to an mobile and web app so
that very much looks like we found the
answer so cognito is a service that
helps web app and mobile app for sign up
and signing in and also gives the
administrator to have control over who
has access control over the web and the
mobile app pretty much we found it so
it's cognito cognito is a service that
helps us to set up sign up sign in and
have access control over the users who
would be using our mobile and web app
all right how about this question you
are an ml engineer or a machine learning
engineer who is on the lookout for a
solution that will discover sensitive
information that your enterprise stores
in aws and then uses nlp to classify
that data and provide business related
insights which among the following
services would you choose so we have a
bunch of services that's going to help
us achieve or one of it is going to help
us achieve the about requirement so it's
a service that deals with machine
learning you're a machine learning
engineer who's looking for a service
that
will help you to discover information at
your enterprise store so we're talking
about storage discover information in
store and then classify
the data depending on severity the
sensitivity classify the data so which
service is that so firewall manager just
like the name says it's a manager and
the aws iam
if we abbreviate it it's a identity and
access management so it's identity and
access management nothing to do with
identifying sensitive data and managing
it so the first two is already out of
the equation then the aw is messy we
already had a quick definition
description for aws massey that it's
actually a security service that uses
machine learning kind of looks like it
could be it it's a security service that
uses machine learning and it discovers
and classifies the sensitive information
not only that it does not stop there it
goes beyond and protects the sensitive
data aws massey kind of looks like but
we still have one more option to look at
which is cloud hms cloud hms is also a
security service kind of looks like that
could be the answer as well and it
enables us to generate encryption keys
and save the data so kind of fifty
percent of it it's a security service it
encrypts helps us protect the data but
aws maxi is right on spot it's a machine
learning service it helps us to classify
the data and also to protect the data so
the answer for this question would be
aws messy so hope you kind of get it how
this is going so first we apply the
thumb rule identify the question that's
being asked read between the lines and
then try to find the service that meets
your requirement then finding the
servers is by first weeding out the
wrong ones recollect everything that
you've learned about the service and see
how well that matches with those hints
that you have picked up and if that
doesn't match weed that out then you'll
end up with two just to to decide from
at some point and then it becomes easy
for you to decide click on the question
submit it and then move on to the other
question in your interview alright so
how about this one you are a system
administrator in a company which is
running most of its infrastructure on
aws you are required to
track your users and keep a look on how
your users are being authenticated all
right so this is where the problem
statement starts right you need to keep
track of how your users are being
authenticated and you wish to create and
manage aws users and use permissions to
allow and deny their access to the aws
resources right so you are to give them
permission number one and then i mean if
we put them in the right order first
giving them permissions and then
tracking their usage let's see which of
the service will help us achieve it iam
is a service that
helps us to
looking at the permissions we can
actually predict whether the user or the
group will have servers or not so that
helps us to get a track of who is able
to use who's not able to use certain
servers and all that stuff so it kind of
looks like but we have other three
options left let's look at aws firewall
manager just like the name says it's
actually a firewall manager it helps us
to manage multiple firewalls simple as
that and shield is a service it's a
service that's used to protect denial of
service or distributed denial of service
an api gateway is a service that makes
it easy for developers to create publish
maintain and monitor and secure api so i
mean it's completely on the api side
very less on user and how you
authenticate your user we can get that
by looking at the name itself right if
you abbreviate it or if you if you try
to find a definition for the name api
gateway you would get it it has to do
with api but if you aggregate aws iam
its identity and access management
pretty much meets the requirement for
the problem statement about its aws
identity and access management that's
the right answer all right let's look at
this one if you want to allocate various
private and public ip address in order
to make them communicate
with the internet and other instances
you will use this service which of the
following is this service so it talks
about using public and private ip
address so this service uses ip address
and then this service helps us to
allow and deny connections to the
internet and to the other instances so
you get the question is it let's pick
the service that helps us achieve it
route 53 route 53 is actually a dns
service right so it's not a service
that's used to allow or deny no it does
not do that vpc vpc uses public and
private ip address yes so kind of looks
like a vpc helps us
to allow i mean the security in vpc the
security group the network access
control list in a vpc that outing table
in a vpc that actually helps us to allow
or deny a connection to a particular ip
address or to a particular service
within the vpc or outside of the vpc so
as of now it kind of looks like it could
be but let's look at the other services
what if if we find a service that
closely matches to the above requirement
than the amazon vpc
gateway api gateway we know that it's a
managed service that makes it easy for
developers to create publish maintain
and monitor apis and secure api so that
has completely do with api not with ip
cloudfront we know about cloudfront that
it's a content delivery network and it
provides global distribution of
servers where our content can be cached
it could be video or or bulk media or
anything else they can be cached locally
so users can easily access them and
download them easily right so that's
cloud front now at this point after
looking at all four it looks like vpc is
the right answer and in fact vpc is the
right answer vpc has public ip address
vpc can help us with a private ip
address vpc can be used to allow deny
connection based on the security group
access control list and the routing
table it has so that's right answer is
vpc all right how about this one this
platform as a service or platform as a
db service provides us with the cost
efficient and resizable capacity while
automating time consuming administrative
tasks so this question is very clear
it's a db service we got to look for and
it's a service that can provide
automating some of the time consuming
tasks it has to be resizable at the same
time so let's talk about
amazon rational database it's a database
kind of matches the requirement we can
resize it as and when needed
all right looks like it's a fit as of
now it actually automates some of the
time consuming work looks like it's a
fit as of now let's move on to elastic
cache and then try to see if
that matches the definition that we've
figured out about elastic cache it's
actually a caching service it's again an
in-memory data store which helps in
achieving high throughput and low
latency in memory data store so it's not
a full-blown database and it does not
come with
any amazon provisioned automation in it
for automating any of the administration
tasks no it does not come up with
anything like that yeah we can resize
the capacity as in when needed but
automation
it's not there yet and moreover it's not
a database so that's out of the equation
vpc is
not a recessible one you know once we
have designed vpc it's fixed it can't be
resized so that's out of the equation
and uh amazon glacier glacier is a
storage but not a database all right so
that's again of the equation so that tie
is kind of between amazon rational
database service and amazon elastic
cache because they both aid the database
service but elastic cache is not a
full-blown database it actually helps
database but it's not a full-blown
database so it's amazon relational
database that's the one which is a
platform as a service it's the one which
can be resized it's the one which
can be used to automate the
time consuming administrative tasks all
right let's talk about this one uh which
of the following is a means for
accessing human researchers or
consultants to help solve a problem on a
contractual or a temporary basis all
right let's read the question again
which of the following is a means for
accessing human researchers or
consultant to help solve problems on a
contractual or a temporary basis it's
like a signing task or hiring aws
experts for a temporary job so let's try
to find that kind of service in the four
services that are listed amazon elastic
mapreduce mapreduce is actually an
framework service that makes it easy and
cost effective to analyze large amount
of data but that has
nothing to do with accessing human
researchers all right let's talk about
mechanical term it's a web service that
provides
a human workforce that's the definition
for it for example automation is good
but not everything can be automated for
something to qualify for automation it
has to be and repeated tasks one time
task can't be automated or the time and
money that you would be spending in
automation is not worth it instead you
could have done it manually so that does
not qualify for automation and anything
that requires intelligence right
anything that's a special case right
automation can do repetitive tasks
automation can do precise work but it
has to be repeated tasks the scenario
you know it should have been there
already only then that can be executed
but if it's a new scenario and it
requires uh appropriate addressing then
it requires human thought so we could
hire researchers and consultants who can
help solve a problem using amazon
mechanical turk the other two are
already out of the equation now dev pay
is actually a payment system through
amazon and multi-factor authentication
as it says it's an authentication system
so the right answer is amazon mechanical
turk all right this sounds interesting
let's look at this one this service is
used to
make it easy to deploy manage and scale
containerized applications using
kubernetes on aws which of the following
is this aws service so it's a service to
deploy manage and scale containerized
applications so it deals with containers
it also should have the ability to use
kubernetes which is an container
orchestration service all right the
first one amazon elastic container
service kind of looks like it's the one
the name itself has the word and the
relation we're looking for elastic
container service so this container
service is an highly scalable high
performance container orchestration
service let's look at the other one aws
batch it's a service that enables id
professionals to schedule and execute
batch processing i mean the name itself
says that that's meant for batch
processing elastic bean stock that's
another service that helps us to deploy
manage and scale but it helps us with
ec2 instances not with containerized
instances so that's again out of the
equation would light scale be a good
time for elastic container service
what's light sale now light sale is a
service it's called as a virtual private
server without a vpc it's called as a
virtual private
server it comes with a predefined
compute storage networking capacity it's
actually a server not a container right
so at this point that also becomes out
of the equation so it's amazon elastic
container service that's the one that
helps us to easily deploy manage scale
container services and it helps us
orchestrate the containers using
kubernetes all right how about this one
all right this service lets us to run
code without provisioning or managing
servers so no servers run code select
the correct service from the below
option all right so no servers but we
should be able to run code amazon easy
to order scaling easy to auto scaling
ec2 is elastic compute cloud which is a
server and auto scaling is a service
that helps us to achieve scaling the
server so that's the definition for it
could be that's out of the equation aw
is lambda now lambda is a service it's
actually an event driven serverless
computing platform and lambda runs code
in response to the event that it
receives and it automatically manages
the compute resource that's required for
that code as long as we have uploaded a
code that's correct and set up events
correctly to map to that code it's going
to run seamlessly so that's about lambda
it kind of looks like it could be the
answer because lambda runs code we don't
have to manage servers it manages
servers by itself but we can't conclude
as of now we have other two servers to
talk about aws batch all right batch is
service that
enables id professionals to run batch
job we know that and about inspector
amazon inspector it's actually a service
that helps us to increase and identify
any security issues and align our
application with compliance well that's
not the requirement of the question the
requirement in the question was run code
without provisioning your server and
without any more space for confusion aws
lambda is a service or is the service
that runs code without provisioning and
managing services right the right one
would be aws lambda i'm very excited
that you're watching this video and i'm
equally glad that uh we were able to
provide you a second part in aws
interview questions all right let's get
started so in an environment where
there's a lot of automation
infrastructure automation you'll be
posted with this question how can you
add an existing instance to a new auto
scaling group now this is when you are
taking an instance away from the auto
scaling group to
troubleshoot to fix a problem you know
to look at logs or if you have suspended
the auto scaling you know you might need
to re-add that instance to the auto
scaling group only then it's going to
take part in it right only then the auto
scaling is going to count it as part of
it it's not a straight uh procedure you
know when you remove them you know it
doesn't get automatically re-added i've
had worked with some clients so when
their developers were managing their own
environment they had problems adding the
instance back to the auto scaling group
you know irrespective of what they tried
the instance was not getting added to
the auto scaling group and whatever they
fixed that they were provided or
whatever fix that they have provided
we're not you know getting encountered
in the auto scaling group so like i said
it's not a straight you know a click
button procedure there are ways we'll
have to do it so how can you add an
existing instance uh to the auto scaling
group there are a few steps that we need
to follow so the first one would be to
under the ec2 instance console right
under the uh instance under actions in
specific you know there's an option
called attach to auto skilling group
right if you have multiple auto scaling
groups in your account or in the region
that you're working in then you're going
to be posted with the different auto
scaling groups that you have in your
account let's say you have five auto
scaling groups for five different
application you know you're going to be
posted with five different auto scaling
groups and then you would select
the auto scaling the appropriate auto
scaling group and attach the instance to
that particular auto scaling group while
adding to the auto scaling group if you
want to change the instance type you
know that's possible as well sometimes
when you want to add the instance back
to the auto skilling group there would
be requirement that you change the
instance type to a better one to a
better family to the better instance
type you could do that at that time and
after that you are or you have
completely added the instance back to
the auto scaling group so it's actually
an seven step uh process adding an
instance back to the auto scaling group
in an environment where they're dealing
with migrating the instance or migrating
an application or migrating an instance
migrating and vm into the cloud you know
if the project that you're going to work
with deals with a lot of migrations you
could be posted this question what are
the factors you will consider while
migrating to amazon web services the
first one is cost is it worth a moving
the instance to the cloud given the
additional bills and vessels features
available in the cloud is this
application going to use all of them is
moving into the cloud beneficial to the
application in the first place you know
beneficial to the users who will be
using the application in the first place
so that's a factor to think of so this
actually includes no cost of the
infrastructure and the ability to match
the demand and supply transparency is
this application and high demand you
know is it going to be a big loss if the
application becomes unavailable for some
time so there are a few things that
needs to be considered before we move
the application to the cloud and then if
the application does the application
needs to be provisioned immediately is
there an urge is there an urge to
provision the application immediately
that's something that needs to be
considered if the
application requires to go online if the
application needs to hit the market
immediately then we would need to move
it to the cloud because in on premises
procuring buying an infrastructure
buying the bandwidth buying the
switchboard you know buying an instance
you know buying their softwares buying
the license related to it it's going to
take time at least like two weeks or so
before you can bring up an server and
launch an application in it right so the
application cannot wait you know waiting
means uh you know workforce productivity
loss is it so we would want to
immediately launch instances and put
application on top of it in those case
if your application is of that type if
there is urge in making the application
go online as soon as possible then
that's a candidate for moving to the
cloud and if the application or if the
the software or if the product that
you're launching it requires hardware it
requires an updated hardware all the
time that's not going to be possible in
on-premises we try to deal with legacy
infrastructure all the time in
on-premises but in the cloud they're
constantly upgrading their hardwares
only then they can keep themselves up
going in the market so they constantly
the cloud providers are constantly
updating their hardwares and if you want
to be benefited of your application
wants to be benefited by the constant
upgrading of the hardwares making sure
the hardware is as latest as possible
the software version the licensing is as
latest as possible then that's a
candidate to be moved to the cloud and
if the application does not want to go
through any risk if the application is
very sensitive to failures if the
application is very much stacked to the
revenue of the company and you don't
want to take a chance in
you know seeing the application fail and
you know seeing the revenue drop then
that's a candidate for moving to the
cloud and business agility you know
moving to
the cloud at least half of the
responsibility is now taken care by the
provider in this case it's amazon at
least half of the responsibility is
taken care by them like if the hardware
fails amazon makes sure that they're
fixing the hardware immediately and
notifications you know if something
happens you know there are immediate
notifications available that we can set
it up and make yourself aware that
something has broken and we can
immediately jump in and fix it so you
see there are the responsibility is now
being shared between amazon and us so if
you want to get that benefit for your
application for your organization for
the product that you're launching then
it needs to be moved to the cloud so you
can get that benefit from the cloud the
other question you could get asked is
what is rto and rpo in aws they are
essentially disaster recovery terms when
you're planning for disaster recovery
you cannot avoid planning disaster
recovery without talking about rto and
rpo now what's the rto what's the rpo in
your environment or how do you define
rto how do you define rpo or some
general questions that get asked rto is
recovery time objective rto stands for
the maximum time the company is willing
to wait for the recovery to happen or
for the recovery to finish
when and disaster strikes so rto is uh
in the future right how much time
is it going to take to fix and bring
everything to normal so that's rto on
the other hand rpo is recovery point
objective which is the maximum amount of
data laws your company is willing to
accept as measured in time rpo always
refers to the backups the number of
backups the the frequency of the backups
right because when an outage happens you
can always go back to the latest backup
right and if the latest backup was data
storage right so rpo is the acceptable
amount if the company wants
less rpo rpo is 1r then you should be
planning on taking backups every one
hour if rpo is 12 hours then you should
be planning on taking backups every 12
hours so that's how rpo and rto you know
helps disaster recovery the fourth
question you could get asked is if you
would like to transfer huge amount of
data which is the best option among
snowball snowball edge and snowmobile
again this is a question that get asked
if the company is dealing with a lot of
data transfer into the cloud or if the
company is dealing with the migrating
data into the cloud i'm talking about a
huge amount of data data in petabytes
snowball and all of the snowball series
deals with the petabyte-sized data
migrations so there are three options
available as of now aws snowball is an
data transport solution for moving high
volume of data into and out of a
specified aws region on the other hand
aws snowball edge adds additional
computing functions snowball is simple
storage and movement of data and
snowball edge has a compute function
attached to it snow mobile on the other
hand is an exabyte scale migration
service that allows us to transfer data
up to 100 petabytes that's like 100 000
terabytes so depending on the size of
data that we want to transfer from our
data center to the cloud we can hire we
can rent any of these three services
let's talk about some cloud formation
questions this is a classic question how
is aws cloud formation different from
aws elastic bean stock you know from the
surface they both look like the same you
know you don't go through the console
provisioning resources you don't you
know you don't go through cli and
provision resources both of them
provision resources through click button
right but underneath they are actually
different services they support they aid
different services so knowing that is
going to help you understand this
question a lot better let's talk about
the difference between them and this is
what you will be explaining to the
interviewer or the panelist so the cloud
formation the cloud formation service
helps you describe and provision all the
infrastructure resources in the cloud
environment on the other hand elastic
bean stock provides an simple
environment to which we can deploy and
run application cloud formation gives us
an infrastructure and elastic beanstalk
gives us an small contained environment
in which we can run our application and
the cloud formation supports the
infrastructure needs of many different
types of application like the
enterprise application the legacy
applications and any new modern
application that you want to have in the
cloud on the other hand the elastic bean
stock it's a combination of developer
tools they are tools that helps manage
the life cycle of a single application
so cloud formation in short is managing
the infrastructure as a whole and
elastic bean stock in short is managing
and running an application in the cloud
and if the company that you're getting
hired is using cloud formation to manage
their infrastructure using or if they're
using infrastructure or any of the
infrastructure as a code services then
you would definitely face this question
what are the elements of an aws cloud
formation template so it has
four or five basic
elements right and the template is in
the form of json or in yaml format right
so it has parameters it has
outputs it has data it has resources and
then the uh format or the format version
or the file format version for the cloud
formation template so parameter is
nothing but it actually lets you to
specify the type of ec2 instance
that you want the type of rds that you
want all right so ec2 is an umbrella rds
is an umbrella and parameters within
that ec2 and parameters within that rds
are the specific details of the ec2 or
the specific details of the rds service
so that's what parameters in a cloud
formation template and then the element
of the cloud formation template is
outputs for example if you want to
output the name of an s3 bucket that was
created if you want to output the name
of the ec2 instance if you want to
output the name of some resources that
have been created instead of looking
into the template instead of you know
navigating through in the console and
finding the name of the resource we can
actually have them outputted
in the result section so we can simply
go and look at all the resources created
through the template in the output
section and that's what output values or
output does in the cloud formation
template and then we have resources
resources are nothing but what defines
what are the cloud components or cloud
resources that will be created through
this cloud formation template now ec2 is
a resource rds is a resource and s3
bucket is a resource elastic load
balancer is a resource and nat gateway
is a resource vpc is a reserve so you
see all these components are the
resources and the resource section in
the cloud formation defines what are the
aws cloud resources that will be created
through this cloud formation template
and then we have version a version
actually identifies the capabilities of
the template you know we just need to
make sure that it is of the latest
version type and the latest version is
0 9 0 9
that's the latest version number you'll
be able to find that on the top of the
cloudformation template and that version
number defines the capabilities of the
cloudformation template so just need to
make sure that it's the latest all the
time still talking about cloud formation
this is another classic question what
happens when one of the resource in a
stack cannot be created successfully
well if
the resource in a stack cannot be
created the cloud formation
automatically rolls back and dominates
all the resources that was created using
the cloud formation template so whatever
resources that were created through the
cloud formation template from the
beginning let's say we have created like
10 resources and the 11th resource is
now failing cloud formation will roll
back and delete all the 10 resources
that were created previously and this is
very useful uh when the cloud formation
cannot you know go forward cloud
formation cannot create additional
resources because we have reached the
elastic
ip limits elastic ip limit per region is
five right and if you have already used
five ips and a cloud formation is trying
to buy three more ips you know we've hit
the soft limit till we fix that with
amazon cloudformation will not be able
to you know launch additional you know
resources and additional ips so it's
going to cancel and roll back everything
that's true with a missing ec2 ami as
well if an ami is included in the
template and but the ami is not actually
present then cloud formation is going to
search for the mi and because it's not
present it's going to roll back and
delete all the resources that it created
so that's what cloud formation does it
simply rolls back all the resources that
it created i mean if it sees a failure
it would simply roll back all the
resources that it created and this
feature actually simplifies the system
administration and layout solutions
built on top of aws cloud formation so
at any point we know that there are no
orphan resources in the in in our
environment you know because
something did not work or because there
was an you know cloud formation executed
some there are no orphan resources in
our account at any point we can be sure
that if cloud formation is launching a
resource and if it's going to fail and
it's going to come back and delete all
the resources it's created so there are
no orphan resources in our account now
let's talk about some questions in
elastic block store again if the
environment deals with a lot of
automation you could be thrown this
question how can you automate easy to
backup using ebs it's actually a six
step process to automate the ec2 backups
we'll need to write a script to automate
the below steps using aws api and these
are the steps that should be found in
the scripts first to get the list of
instances and then and then the script
that we are writing should be able to
connect to aws using the api and list
the amazon abs volumes that are attached
locally to the instance and then it
needs to list the snapshots of each
volume make sure the snapshots are
present and it needs to assign a
retention period for the snapshot
because over time the snapshots are
going to be
invalid right once you have some 10
latest
snapshots any snapshot that you have
taken before that 10 becomes invalid
because you have captured the latest and
10 snapshot coverage is enough for you
and then the fifth point is to create a
snapshot of each volume create a new
snapshot of each volume and then delete
the old snapshot anytime a new snapshot
gets created the oldest snapshot of the
list needs to go away so we need to
include options we need to include
scripts in our script lines in our
script that make sure that it's deleting
the older snapshots which are older than
the retention period that we are
mentioning another question that you
could see in the interview be it a
written interview beat online interview
or beat and telephonic or face-to-face
interview is what's the difference
between ebs and instant store let's talk
about ebs first ebs is kind of permanent
storage the data in it can be restored
at a later point when we save data in
ebs the data lives even after the
lifetime of the ec2 instance for example
we can stop the instance and the data is
still going to be present in ebs we can
move the ebs from one instance to
another instance and the data is simply
going to be present there so abs is kind
of permanent storage when compared to
instance on the other hand instance
store is a temporary storage and that
storage is actually physically attached
to the host of the machine ebs is an
external storage an instant store is
locally attached
to the instance or locally attached to
the host of the machine we cannot detach
an instant store from one instance and
attach it to another but we can do that
with eba so that's a big difference one
is permanent data and another one is ebs
is permanent instant store is a volatile
data and um instant store with instant
store we won't be able to detach the
storage and
attach it to another instance and
another feature of instant store is data
in an instant store is lost if the disk
fails or the instance is stopped or
terminated so instant store is only good
for storing cache data if you want to
store permanent data then we should
think of using ebs and not instant store
while talking about storage on the same
lines this is another classic question
how can you take backups of efs like ebs
and if you can take backup how do you
take that backup the answer is yes we
can take efs to efs backup solution efs
does not support snapshot like ebs efs
does not support snapshot snapshot is
not an option for efs elastic file
system right we can only take backup
from one efs to another efs and this
backup solution is to recover from
unintended changes or deletions of the
efs and this can be automated but any
data that we store in efs can be
automatically replicated to another efs
and once this efs goes down or gets
deleted or data gets deleted or you know
the whole ef is is for some reason
interrupted or deleted we can recover
the data from we can use the other efs
and bring the application to consistency
and to achieve this it's not an
one step configuration it's a cycle
there are series of steps that's
involved before we can achieve efs to
efs backup the first thing is to sign in
to the aws management console and under
efs or click on efs to efs restore
button from the services list and from
there we can use the region selector in
the console navigation bar to select the
actual region in which we want to work
on and from there ensure that we have
selected the
right template you know some of the
templates would be you know efs to efs
backup granular backups incremental
backups right so there are some
templates the kind of backups that you
want to take do you want to take grant
alert do you want to take increment
backups stuff like that and then create
a name to that solution the kind of
backup that we have created and finally
review all the configurations that you
have done and click on save and from
that point onwards the data is going to
be copied and from that point onwards
any additional data that you put is
going to copy it and replicate it now
you have an efs to efs backup this is
another classic question in companies
which deals with
a data management there are easy options
to create snapshots but deleting
snapshots is
not always an you know click button or
an single step configuration so you
might be facing a question like how do
you auto delete old snapshots and the
procedure is like this now as best
practice we will take snapshots of ebs
volume to s3 all snapshots get stored in
s3 we know that now and we can use aws
ops automator to automatically handle
all snapshots the ops automator service
it allows us to create copy delete ebs
snapshots so there are cloud formation
templates available for aws ops
automator and this automator template
will scan the environment and it would
take snapshots it would you know copy
the snapshot from one region to another
region if you want i know if you're
setting up a dr environment and not only
that based on the retention period that
we
create it's going to delete the
snapshots which are older than the
retention period so life or managing
snapshot is made a lot easier because of
this ops automator cloud formation
template moving into questions and
elastic load balancer this again could
be an a question in the interview what
are the different types of load
balancers in aws and what's their use
case what's the difference between them
and as of now as we speak there are
three types of load balancers which are
available in aws the first one being
application load balancer just like the
name says the application load balancer
works on the application layer and deals
with the http and https request and it
also supports part based routing for
example simplylearn.com slash some
webpage simplylearn.com slash another
website so it's going to direct the path
based on the slash value that you give
in the urls that's path based routing so
it supports that and not only that it
can support a port based port-based
colon 8080 colon 8081 or colon 8090 you
know based on that port also it can take
a routing decision and that's what
application load balancer does on the
other hand we have network load balancer
and the network load balancer makes
routing decisions at the transport level
it's faster because it has very less
thing to work on it works on lower osi
layer it works on a lower layer so it
has very less information to work with
than compared with application layers so
comparatively it's a lot faster and it
handles millions of requests per second
and after the load balancer receives the
connection it selects a target group for
the default rule using the flow hash
routing algorithm it does simple routing
right it does not do path-based or
port-based routing it does simple
routing and because of it it's faster
and then we have classic load balancer
which is kind of expiring as we speak
amazon is discouraging people using
classic load balancer but there are
companies which are still using classic
load balancer they are the ones who are
the first one to step into amazon when
classic load balancer was the first load
balancer or the only load balancer
available at that point so it supports
http https tcp ssl protocol and it has a
fixed relationship between a load
balance report and the container port so
initially we only have classic load
balancer and then at after some point
amazon said instead of having one load
balancer address all type of traffic
we're going to have two load balances
called as the child from the classic two
load balancer and one is going to
specifically address the application
requirement and one is going to
specifically address the network
requirement and let's call it as
application load balancer and network
load balancer so that's how now we have
two different load balancers talking
about load balancer another classic
question could be what are the different
uses of the various load balancer in aws
elastic load balancing there are three
types of load balancer we just spoke
about it application load balancer is
used if we need a flexible application
management and a tls termination and
network load balancer if we require
extreme performance and the load
balancing should happen on based on
static ips for the application and
classic load balancer is an old load
balancer which is for people who are
still running their environment from ec2
classic network now this is an older
version of vpc or this is what was
present before vpc was created easy to
classic network is what was present
before ec2 was created so they are the
three types and they are the use cases
of it let's talk about some of these
security related questions you would
face in the interview when talking about
security and firewall in aws we cannot
avoid discussion talking about waff web
application firewall and you would
definitely see yourself in this
situation where you've been asked how
can you use aws off in monitoring your
aws applications waf or web application
firewall protects our web application
from common web exploits and vaf helps
us control which traffic source your
application should be allowed or a block
which traffic from a certain source you
know which source or which traffic from
a certain source should be allowed or
blocked your application with waff we
can also create custom rules that blocks
common attack patterns you know if it is
a banking application it has a certain
type of attacks and if it is simple uh
data management data storage application
it has i mean content management
application it has a separate type of
attack so based on the application type
we can identify a pattern and create
rules that would actually block that
attack based on the rule that we create
and waff can be used for three cases you
know the first one is allow all requests
and then a block all request and count
all requests for a new policy so it's
also an monitoring and management
service which actually counts all the
policies or counts all the requests that
matches a particular policy that we
create and some of the characteristics
we can mention in awsof are the origin
ips and the strings that appear in the
request we can allow block based on
origin ip allow block based on strings
that appear in the request we can allow
block or count based on the origin
country length of the request yeah we
can block and count the presence of
malicious scripts in an connection now
we can count the request headers or we
can allow block a certain request header
and we can count the presence of a
malicious sql code in a connection that
we get and that want to reach our
application still talking about security
what are the different aws im categories
we can control using aws iam we can do
the following one is create and manage
iem users and once the user database
gets bigger and bigger we can create and
manage them in groups and in im we can
use it to manage the security
credentials kind of setting the
complexity of the password you know
setting additional authentications you
know like mfa and you know rotating the
passwords you know resetting the
password there are a few things we could
do with iam and finally we can create
policies that actually grants access to
aw services and resources another
question you will see is what are the
policies that you can set for your users
password so some of the policies that we
can set for the user password is at the
minimum length or you know the
complexity of the password by at least
having one number or one special
characters in the password so that's one
and then the requirement of a specific
character types including you know
uppercase lowercase number and
non-alphabetic characters so it becomes
very hard for somebody else to guess
what the password would be and and try
to hack them so we can set
the length of the password we can set
the complexity in the password and then
we can set an automatic expiration of
the password so after a certain time the
user is forced to create a new password
so the password is not stale old and
easy to guess in the environment and we
can also set settings like the user
should contact the admin i mean when the
password is about to expire so you know
you can get a hold of how the user is
setting their password is it having good
complexity in it is it meeting company
standards or there are a few things that
we can control and set for the users
when the users are setting or recreating
the password another question that could
be posted in an interview so to
understand your understanding of iem is
what's the difference between an iem
role and an im user let's talk about iem
user let's start small and then go big
or let's start simple and then talk
about the complex one the iem user has a
permanent long-term credential and it's
used to interact directly with aws
services and on the other hand iem role
is an iem entity that defines a set of
permissions for making aws service
request so iem user is an permanent
credential and role are temporary
credentials and iem user has full access
to all aws iem functionalities and with
role trusted entities such as iem users
application or aws services uh assume of
the role so when an iem user is given an
permission you know it sticks within the
iem user but with roles we can give
permissions to applications we can give
permissions to users in the same account
in a different account a corporate id we
can give permissions to ec2 s3 rds vpc
and lot more role is wide and im user is
is not so wide you know it's very
constrained only for that im user let's
talk about managed policies in aws
managed policies there are two types you
know customer managed and amazon managed
so manage policies are im resources that
express permissions using the iam policy
language we can create policies edit
them manage them manage them separately
from the im user group and roles which
they are attached to so they are
something that we can do to managed
policies if it is customer managed and
we can now update policy in one place
and the permissions automatically extend
to all the attached entries so i can
have like three services four services
point to a particular policy and if i
edit that particular policy it's gonna
reflect on those three or four services
so anything that i allow is going to be
allowed for those four services anything
that i denied is going to be denied for
uh the four services imagine what would
be without the i am managed policy will
have to go and specifically allow deny
on those different instances four or
five times depending on the number of
instances that we have so like i said
there are two types of managed policies
one is managed by us which is customer
managed policies and then the other is
managed by aws which is aws managed
policy this question can you give an
example of an iem policy and a policy
summary this is actually to test how
well versed are you with the aws console
the answer to that question is look at
the following policy this policy is used
to grant access to add update and delete
objects from a specific folder now in
this case name of the folder is
example folder and it's present in a
bucket called example bucket so this is
an iam policy on the other hand the
policy summary is a list of access level
resource and conditions for each service
defined in a policy so im policy is all
about one particular resource and the
policy summary is all about multiple
resources with iam policy it was only
talking about s3 bucket and one
particular s3 bucket here it talks about
cloud formation template cloud watch
logs ec2 elastic bean stock services
summary summary of resources and the
permissions and policies attached to
them that's what policy summary is all
about another question could be like
this what's the use case of iam and how
does im help your business two important
or primary work of im is to help us
manage iam users and their access it
provides a secure access to multiple
users uh to their appropriate aws
resources so that's one it does and the
second thing it does is manage access
for federated users federated users or
non iam users and through iam we can
actually allow and provide a secure
access to resources in our aws account
to our employees without the im user no
they could be authenticated using the
active directory they could be
authenticated using the facebook
credential google credential amazon
credential and a couple of other
credentials third party
identity management right so we could
actually trust them and we could give
them access to our account uh based on
the trust relationship that we have
built with the other identity of systems
right so two things one is manage users
and their access for manage iam user and
their access in our aws environment and
second is
manage access for federated users who
are non-iam users and more importantly
im is a free service and with that
will only be charged for the use of the
resources not for the im username and
password that we create all right let's
now talk about some of the questions in
route 53
one classic question that could be asked
in an interview is what is the
difference between latency based routing
and
geodns or jio based dns routing now the
jio based dns routing takes routing
decisions on the basis of the geographic
location of the request and on the other
hand the latency based routing utilizes
latency measurements between
networks and
data centers now latency based routing
is used where you want to give your
customers the lowest latency as possible
so that's when we would use latency
based routing and on the other hand the
geo-based routing is
when we want to direct customers to
different websites based on the country
they are browsing from you know you
could have you know two different or
three different websites for the same
url you know take amazon the shopping
website for example when we go to
amazon.com from in the us it directs us
to the u.s web page where the products
are different the currency is different
right and the flag and a couple of other
advertisements that shows up are
different and when we go to amazon.com
from india it gets directed to the
amazon.com indian site where again the
currency the product and the
advertisements they're all different
right so depending on the
country they're trying to browse if you
want to direct customers to two or three
different websites we would use a jio
based routing another use case of geo
based routing is if you have a
compliance that you should handle all
the dns requests sorry if you should
handle all the
requests you know from a country within
the country then you would do geo based
routing now you wouldn't direct the
customer to a server which is in another
country right you would direct the
customer to a server which is very local
to them that's another use case of jio
based routing and like i said for
latency based routing the whole goal or
aim is to achieve minimum end user
latency if you are hired for the
architect role and if that requires
working lot on the dns then you could be
posted with this question what is the
difference between domain and a hosted
zone a domain is actually a collection
of
data describing self-contained
administrative and technical unit on the
internet right so for example you know
simplylearn.com is actually a domain on
the other hand hosted zone is actually
an container that holds information
about how you want to route traffic on
the internet to a specific domain for
example
lms.simplylearn.com is an hosted zone
whereas simplylearn.com is a domain so
in other words in hosted zone you would
see the domain name plus and a prefix to
it lms is a prefix here ftp is a prefix
mail.simplylearn.com is a prefix so
that's how you would see a prefix in
hosted zones another question from
another classic question from route 53
would be how does amazon drop 53 provide
high availability and low latency the
way amazon ralph 53 provides high
availability and low latency is by
globally distributed dns servers amazon
is a global service and they have dna
services globally any customer doing a
query from different parts of the world
they get to reach an dns server which is
very local to them and that's how it
provides low latency now this is not
true with all the dns providers there
are dns providers who are very local to
a country who are very local to a
continent so they don't they generally
don't provide low latency service right
it's always high latency it's low
latency for local users but anybody
browsing from a different country or a
different continent it's going to be
high latency for them but that's not
again true with amazon amazon is a
globally distributed dns provider it has
dns servers global wide and like i said
it has optimal locations it has got
global servers or in other words it has
got servers around the globe different
parts in the globe and that's how they
are able to provide high availability
and because it's not running on just one
server but on many servers they provide
high availability and low latency if the
environment that you're going to work on
is going to take a lot of configuration
backups environmental backups then you
can expect questions in aws config a
classic question would be how does aws
config work along with aws cloudtrail
aws cloudtrail actually records user api
activity on the account and you know any
http https access or any any sort of
access you know that's made to the cloud
environment that's recorded in the cloud
trail in other words any api calls the
time is recorded the type of call is
recorded and what was the response given
was it a failure was it successful they
also get recorded in cloud trail it's
actually a log it actually records the
activity in your cloud environment on
the other hand config is an uh point in
time configuration details of your
resources for example at a given point
what are all the resources that were
present in my environment what are all
the resources or what are the
configuration in those resources at a
given point they get captured in aws
config right so with that information
you can always answer the question what
did my aws resource look like at a given
point in time that question gets
answered when we use aws config on the
other hand with cloudtrail you can
answer the question i mean by looking at
the cloud trail or with the help of
cloudtrail you can easily answer the
question who made an apa call to modify
this resource that's answered by
cloudtrail and with the cloud trail we
can detect if a security group was
incorrectly configured and who did that
configuration let's say there happened
to be a downtime and you want to
identify let's say there happen to be a
downtime and you want to identify who
made that uh change in the environment
you can simply look at cloudtrail and
find out who made the change and if you
want to look at how the environment
looks like before the change you can
always look at aws config can aws
configure or aws config aggregate data
across different aws accounts yes it can
now this question is actually to test
whether you have used aws config or not
i know some of the services are very
local is it some of these services are
availability zone specific some of them
are regional specific and some of them
are
global services and amazon and though
some of the services are region services
you still can do some changes you know
add some configuration to it and collect
regional data in it for example s3 is a
regional service but still you can
collect logs from all other regions into
an s3 bucket in one particular region
that's possible and cloud trail is and
cloud watch is an regional service but
still you can with some changes to it
with some adding permissions to it you
can always monitor the cloud watch that
belongs to cloudwatch logs that belongs
to other regions you know they're not
global by default but you can do some
changes and make it global similarly aws
config is a service that's a region
based service but still you can make it
act globally you can aggregate data
across a different region and different
accounts in an aws config and deliver
the updates from different accounts to
one s3 bucket and can access it from
there aws config also works or
integrates seamlessly with sns topic so
you know anytime there is a change
anytime a new data gets collected you
can always notify yourself or notify a
group of people about the new log or the
new config or new edit that happened in
the environment let's look at some of
the database questions you know database
should be running on reserved instances
so whether you know that fact or not the
interviewer wants to understand how well
you know that fact by asking this
question how are reserved instances
different from on-demand db instances
reserved instances and on-demand
instances are exactly the same when it
comes to their function but they only
differ based on how they are
built reserved instances are purchased
for one year or three year reservation
and in return we get a very low
per hour pricing because we're paying
upfront it's generally said that
reserved instance is 75 percentage
cheaper than on-demand instance and
amazon gives you that benefit because
you know you're committing for one year
and sometimes you're paying in advance
for the whole year on the other hand
on-demand instances are built on an
oddly early price talking about auto
scaling how will you understand the
different types of auto scaling the
interviewer might ask this question
which type of scaling would you
recommend for rds and y the two types of
scaling as you would know now are
vertical and horizontal and in vertical
scaling we can vertically scale up the
master database with a couple of clicks
all right so that's vertical scaling
vertical scaling is keeping the same
node and making it bigger and bigger if
previously it was running on t2 micro
now we would like to run it on m3 two
times large instance previously it had
one virtual cpu one gigabit now it's
going to have eight virtual cpu and 30
gigabit of ram so that's vertical
scaling on the other hand horizontal
scaling is adding more nodes to it
previously it was running on one vm now
it's going to run on 2 3 10 vms right
that's horizontal scaling so
database can only be scaled vertically
and there are 18 different types of
instances we can resize our rds to right
so this is true for rds mysql postgres
sql mariadb oracle microsoft sql servers
there are 18 type of instances we can
vertically scale up to on the other hand
horizontal scaling are good for replicas
so they are read only replicas we're not
going to touch the master
database we're not going to touch the
primary database but i can do horizontal
scaling only with amazon aurora and i
can add additional read replicas i can
add up to 15 uh read replicas for amazon
aurora and up to five read replicas for
rds mysql postgres sql and marie db rds
instances and when we add replica we are
horizontally scaling adding more nodes
right read-only nodes so that's
horizontal scaling so how do you really
decide between vertical and horizontal
scaling if you're looking in to increase
the storage and the processing capacity
we'll have to do a vertical scaling if
you're looking at increasing the
performance or of the read heavy
database we need to be
looking for horizontal scaling or we
need to be implementing horizontal
scaling in our environment still talking
about database this is another good
question you can expect in the interview
what is the maintenance window in amazon
rds will your db instance be available
during the maintenance event all right
so this is really to test how well you
have understood the sla how well you
have understood the amazon rdas uh the
failover mechanism of amazon rdas uh
stuff like that so
audio's maintenance window it lets you
decide when adb instance modification a
database engine upgrades or software
patching has to occur and you you
actually get to decide should it happen
at 12 in the night or should it happen
at afternoon should it happen early in
the morning should it happen in the
evening you actually get to decide an
automatic scheduling by amazon is done
only for patches that are security and
durability related sometimes amazon
takes down and does automatic scheduling
if you know if there is a need for a
patch update that deals with security
and durability and by default the
maintenance window is is for 30 minutes
and the important point is the db
instance will be available during that
event because you're going to have
primary and secondary write so when that
upgrade happens amazon would shift the
connection to the secondary do the
upgrade and then switch back to the
primary another classic question would
be what are the consistency models in
dynamodb in dynamodb there is eventual
consistency read this eventual
consistency model it actually maximizes
your read throughput and the best part
with eventual consistency is all copies
of data reach uh consistency within a
second and sometimes when you write and
when you're you know trying to read
immediately chances that you would still
be reading the old data that's eventual
consistency on the other hand there is
another consistency model called the
strong consistency or strongly
consistent lead where there is going to
be a delay in writing the data you know
making sure the data is written in all
places but it guarantees one thing that
is once you have done a write and then
you're trying to do a read it's going to
make sure that it's going to show you
the updated data not the old data now
you can be guaranteed of it that it is
going to show the updated data and not
the old data that's strongly consistent
still talking about database talking
about nosql dynamodb or nosql database
which is
dynamodb and amazon you could be asked
this question what kind of query
functionality does
dynamodb support dynamodb supports get
and put operation dynamodb supports or
dynamodb provides flexible querying by
letting you query on non-primary key
attributes using global secondary index
and local secondary indexes a primary
key can be either a single attribute
partition key or a composite
partition sort key in other words a
dynamodb indexes a composite partition
sort key as a partition key element and
a sort key element and by holding the
partition key you know when doing a
search or when doing a query by holding
the partition key element constant we
can search across the sort key element
to retrieve the other items in that
table and the composite partition sort
key should be a combination of user id
partition and a timestamp so that's what
the composite partition sort key is made
of let's look at some of the multiple
choice questions you know sometimes some
companies would have an uh written test
or an mcq type online test before they
call you for at the first level or
before they call you for the second
level so these are some classical
questions that companies asked or
companies ask in their multiple choice
online questions let's look at this
question as a developer using this
pay-per-use service you can send store
and receive messages between software
components which of the following is
being referred here let's look at it
right we have aws step functions amazon
mq amazon simple queue service amazon
simple notification service let's see
the question again as a developer using
this pay-per-use service so the service
that we are looking for is a
pay-per-view service you can send store
and retrieve messages between two
software components kind of like a queue
there so what would be the right answer
it would be amazon simple queue service
now amazon simple queue service is the
one that's used to decouple at the
environment it breaks the tight coupling
and then it introduces decoupling in
that environment by providing a cue or
by inserting a queue between two
software components let's look at this
other question if you would like to host
a real-time audio and video conferencing
application on aws it's an audio and
video conferencing application on aws
this service provides you with a secure
and easy to use application what is this
service let's look at the options they
are amazon
chime amazon workspace amazon mq amazon
app stream but you might tend to look at
amazon app stream because it's real time
and a video conference but it's actually
for a different purpose is actually
amazon chime that lets you create chat
and create a chat board and then
collaborate with the security of the aws
services so it lets you do the audio it
lets you do the video conference all
supported by aws security features it's
actually amazon china let's look at this
question as your company's aws solution
architect you are in charge of designing
thousands of individual jobs which are
similar which of the following service
best serves your requirement in earlier
ec2 auto scaling aws snowball aws
fargate aws badge let's read the
question again as your company's aws
solution architect you are in charge of
designing thousands of individual jobs
which are similar it looks like
it's batch service let's look at the
other options as well aw snowball is
actually an storage transport service
ec2 auto scaling is you know in
introducing scalability and elasticity
in the environment and aws fargate is
container services aws batch is the one
is being referred here that actually
runs thousands of individual jobs which
are similar aws batch it's the right
answer but let's look at the other one
you are a machine learning engineer and
you're looking for a service that helps
you build and train mission learning
models in aws which among the following
are we referring to so we have amazon
sage maker and aws deep lens amazon
comprehend aws device farm let's read
the question again you are a machine
learning engineer and you're looking for
a service that helps you build and train
machine learning models in aws which
among the following are referred here
the answer is sage maker it provides
every developer and data scientist with
the ability to build train and deploy
machine learning models quickly that's
what sagemaker does now for you to be
familiar with you know the the products
i would recommend you to you know simply
go through the
product description you know there's one
page available on amazon that explains
all the products are quick neat and
simple now that really helps you to be
very familiar with you know what the
product is all about and what it is
capable of you know is it a db service
is it a machine learning service or is
it a monitoring service is it a
developer service stuff like that so get
that information get that details before
you attend an interview and that should
really help to answer or face such
questions with a great confidence so the
answer is amazon sage maker because
that's the one that provides developers
and data scientists the ability to build
a train and deploy machine learning
models quickly as possible all right
let's look at this one let's say that
you are working for your company's id
team and you are designated to adjust
the capacity of the aws resource based
on the incoming application and network
traffic how do you do it so what's the
service that's actually helps us to
adjust the capacity of the aws resource
based on the incoming application let's
look at it amazon vpc amazon iam amazon
inspector amazon elastic load balancing
amazon vpc is a networking service
amazon iam is an username password
authentication amazon inspector is a
service that actually does security
audit in our environment and amazon
elastic load balancer is a service that
helps in scalability that's in one way
you know indirectly that helps in
increasing the availability of the
application right and monitoring it
monitoring you know how much requests
are coming in through the elastic load
balancer we can actually adjust the
environment that's running behind it so
the answer is going to be amazon elastic
load balancer all right let's look at
this question this cross-platform video
game development engine that supports pc
xbox playstation ios and android
platforms allows developers to build and
host their games on amazon's servers so
we have amazon game lift amazon green
grass amazon lumber yard amazon sumerian
let's read the question again this
cross-platform video game development
engine that supports pc xbox playstation
ios and android platforms allows
developers to build and host their games
on amazon servers the answer is amazon
lumberyard this lumber yard is an free
a gaming engine deeply integrated with
aws and twitch with full source this
lumbar yard provides a growing set of
tools that helps you create and highest
game quality applications and they
connect to a lot of games and vast
compute and storage in the cloud so it's
that service they are referring to let's
look at this question you are the
project manager of your company's cloud
architect team you are required to
visualize understand and manage your aws
cost and usage over time which of the
following service will be the best fit
for this we have aws budgets we have aws
cost explorer we have amazon work mail
we have amazon connect and the answer is
going to be cost explorer now cost
explorer is an option in the amazon
console that
helps you to visualize and understand
and even manage the aws cost over time
who's spending more who's spending less
and what is the trend what is the
projected cost for the coming month all
these can be visualized in aws cost
explorer let's look at this question you
are a chief cloud architect at your
company and how can you automatically
monitor and adjust computer resources to
ensure maximum performance and
efficiency of all scalable resources so
we have a cloud formation as a service
we have aws aurora as a solution we have
aws auto scaling and amazon api gateway
let's read the question again you're the
chief cloud architect at your company
how can you automatically monitor and
adjust computer resources how can you
automatically monitor and adjust
computer resources to ensure maximum
performance and efficiency of all
scalable resources this is an easy
question to answer the answer is
autoscaling right that's a basic service
and solution architect
course is it auto scaling is the service
that helps us to easily adjust monitor
and ensure the maximum performance and
efficiency of all scalable resources it
does that by automatically scaling the
environment to handle the inputs let's
look at this question as a database
administrator you will use a service
that is used to set up and manage
databases such as mysql maya db and
postgres sql which service are we
referring to amazon aurora amazon
elastic cache aws rds aws database
migration service amazon arora is
amazon's flavor of
the rds service and elastic cache is is
the caching service provided by amazon
they are not full-fledged database and
database migration service just like the
name says it helps to migrate the
database from on-premises to the cloud
and from one database flavor to another
database flavor amazon rds is the
service is the console is the service is
the umbrella service that helps us to
set up manage databases like mysql money
db and postgres sql it's amazon rds
let's look at this last question a part
of your marketing work requires you to
push messages to onto google facebook
windows and apple through apis or aws
management console you will use the
following service so the options are aws
cloudtrail aws config amazon chime aws
simple notification service it says a
part of your marketing work requires you
to push messages it's dealing with
pushing messages to google facebook
windows and apple through apis or aws
management console you will use the
following service it's simple
notification service simple notification
service is an message pushing a service
but sqs is pulling similarly sns is
pushing right here it talks about a
pushing system that pushes messages to
google facebook windows and apple
through api and it's going to be a
simple notification system or a simple
notification service
and with that we have come to the end of
this video on aws full course of 2022
i hope you found it useful and
entertaining
please ask any questions you have
concerning topics covered in this video
in the comment box below
our experts will assist you in
addressing your problems
thank you for watching stay safe and
keep learning
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn youtube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos to nerd up and get certified
click here
you